. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE IS- IF- WE'RE STILL
LACKING THE TWO MEMBERS THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO FORM A
QUORUM A SENATE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIAL COME TO WORK MORNING AS
WE CAN DO TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS
TO MANAGE ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN REST THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
TOR HEARING SINCE PROVIDE ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE TO STATION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SPENT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT. NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 IN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING IS CUSTOMER IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING OR SERVICE OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE ARE HOLDING
OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN-
THE- STREET BUILDING SOMETIMES
OF THE SWING SPACE- ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE COME AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE
CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM BEGINNER
HEARING- BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION OF BILLS. LET'S SEE
- THIS SENATOR LAYERED STILL
STANDING RIGHT OUTSIDE OKAY ALL
RIGHT WELL- WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO THAT IS WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN-
PRESENTATION IS A SPECIAL ORDER
- THAT- FOUR FOUR THIS MORNING-
BEGINNING NOW. IN THAT SPECIAL
ORDER IS S. B. ONE THREE THREE
EIGHT- AND I WILL ASK CENTER
BOARD IS IF HE WITH IT BECAUSE
IT IS UP JOIN THE AUTHORED BY.
CENTER EGGMAN IN ME M. S. UNDER
MORE JUST IF YOU WOULD ASSUME
THE RESPONSIBILITY SHARE. IT
WOULD BE MY HONOR SURE. THE
VILLAIN.
WE'RE ON SOME HOUSEKEEPING-
DISCLOSURES R. S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR BORCHERS I
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
IT WILL BE RESET FOR MAY THIRD.
SELL WE ARE NOW MOVING TO SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IT WILL BE
A JOINTLY PRESENTED BY SENATORS
AMBERG AND EGGMAN. THE LECTERN
IS YOURS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IN MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE WITH WITH JOIN AUTHOR US
SENATOR EGGMAN. I WANT TO THANK
ALL THOSE WHO WORKED SO
DILIGENTLY ON THIS BILL- AS WE
BEGIN. I'M SERIOUS AND
REMEMBERED- THERE WERE SOME
RECITALS THE NEARLY HAD TO BE.
PUT IN THE RECORD. AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- SO THIS
MORNING WE'RE TAKING UP S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AUTHORED
BY CENTER EGGMAN MYSELF OR TO ME
GENERAL BERG OUR FIRST WE'LL
HEAR FROM UP TO THREE PRIMARY
SUPPORT WITNESSES AFTER THREE
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES THE
PRIMERS WERE WITNESSES WILL HAVE
TEN MINUTES TO SPEAK THE PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL HAVE
TEN MINUTES TO SPEAK. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS RAN THE LENGTH OF
HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS OF CLEANING
PROTOCOLS I'VE INSTITUTED TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY AS ALREADY
NOTED THERE WILL BE A TO THREE
PRIMARY WITNESSES SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL THREE PRIMARY
WITNESS SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION
THIS BILL PRIMERS WERE WITNESSES
WILL BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK TOTAL
OF TEN MINUTES. PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL
RECEIVE EQUAL TIME BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR A TOTAL OF TEN MINUTES
ALL OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY
MUST LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS THEIR. NAME AFFILIATION POSITION ON
THE MEASURE. THERE ALSO BE A
TIME LIMIT OF TWO. MINUTES THESE
CALLS AND SUPPORT IN FIFTEEN.
FOR CALLS IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
NINE ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TODAY. THE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OUR FILE ITEM.
THREE FOUR EIGHT ELEVEN FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
NINE THIRTY- SINCE WE'RE
CONVENING AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
ODD I DON'T BELIEVE WE'RE IN A
POSITION TO MAKE A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SECOND
QUARTER RECITALS. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WELL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I- YOU DID A
BETTER JOB COVERING UP FOR ME
THAT I COULD HAVE DONE SO I
APPRECIATE. YOU MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING AND
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING-
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE GROUND RULES
ARE PARTICULARLY FOR SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT AS I WAS BEGINNING
A MOMENT AGO I WANT TO THANK-
THANK ALL THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
WORKING AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT IN PARTICULAR. ALISON
MERRILEES ON THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE STAFF- TODAY I'M HERE
WITH SENATOR EGGMAN AND I HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF PRESENTING SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH
CREATES THE COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
RECOVERY EMPOWERMENT. KNOWN AS
CARE PROGRAM. CARE COURT IS A
PROPOSED FRAMEWORK SPONSORED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM TO DELIVER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
THE MOST SEVERELY IMPAIRED
CALIFORNIANS- THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE LANGUISHING. HOMELESS OR
INCARCERATED AND THIS IMPACTS
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION SEVENTY TWO HOUR
HOLD HOMELESSNESS FAMILIES
LOOKING FOR LOVED ONES AND CAN'T
FIND THEM IS A FLICKED IT SO
MANY CALIFORNIA INCLUDING MY OWN
FAMILY- THIS PROGRAM IS A
RESPONSE TO THE URGENT NEED FOR
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUFFERING
WITH UNTREATED SCHIZOPHRENIA.
SPECTRUM IN PSYCHOTICDISORDERS
OFTEN ON HOUSE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN A BASE HIGH RISKS
FOR REPEATED HOSPITALIZATION
REPEAT INCARCERATION
INSTITUTIONALIZATION MENTAL
HEALTH CONSERVATORSHIP AND-
PREMATURE DEATH. COMPREHENSIVE
CARE MEDICATION AND HOUSING HAVE
BEEN CLINICALLY PROVEN TO
SUCCESSFULLY TREAT AND STABILIZE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. BUT ARE OFTEN
UNAVAILABLE THESE SERVICES ARE
OFTEN UNAVAILABLE AFTER ARRESTS
OR IN SECURE FACILITIES
THEREFORE SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT WILL CREATE A PROGRAM TO
CONNECT A PERSON IN CRISIS WITH
A COURT ORDERED CARE PLAN FOR UP
TO TWELVE MONTHS. WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF EXTENDING THAT
PLAN FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE
MONTHS THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
INDIVIDUALS WITH A CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY BASED SET
OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
COMPETENT THIS INCLUDES SHORT
TERM STABILIZATION MEDICATION
WELLNESS RECOVERY SUPPORT. AND
CONNECTIONS SOCIAL SERVICES
INCLUDING HOUSING AND SUPPORT
UNDERLYING INCLUDING HOUSING ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF GETTING PEOPLE
STABLE AND WELL AS PROVIDING
HOUSING AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT AS THIS BILL
PROGRESSES I HOPE. THE
LEGISLATURE. OUR CONCERN STATE
ANNOUNCES IMPORTANT AND WE WANT
TO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD. I WANNA MAKE
IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THE CARE COURT
CONCEPT IS NOT. IT IS NOT
CONSERVATIVE SHIP THERE IS NO
SUBSTITUTE FOR THE DECISION
MAKER- FOR THAT PERSON WHO MAY
BE- ILL CARE COURT DOES NOT
CREATE A PATH TO REST KERR COURT
IS A- IS IN. A CIVIL COURT IS
NOT A CRIMINAL COURT IT DOES NOT
ALLOW FOR FORCED INVOLUNTARY
MEDICATION. CARE COURT
PARTICIPANTS CANNOT BE FORCED TO
PARTICIPATE. LAW ENFORCEMENT
WILL NOT ARREST THEM IF THEY DO
NOT COME TO COURT CARE COURT
DOES NOT INVOLVE SECURITY
FACILITIES. FINALLY CARE COURT
DOES NOT TAKE AWAY RIGHTS. DUE
PROCESS IS PROTECTED SELF
pIT DOES DO IS OFFERS HOPE. AND A
PATH TO A BETTER LIFE FOR
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES-
AS I MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET I'M
PROUD TO BE HERE WITH UP. THE
SENATE. JOINT AUTHORS SENATORS
EGGMAN- SEN REGNANT IS GOING TO-
SAY A FEW WORDS AND THEN WE HAVE
AS WITNESSES- DR MARK GALLI WHO
IS PRESENT HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- JUDGE STEVE MANLEY SPEAR
COURT JUDGE IN SANTA CLARA. WHO
I BELIEVE WILL BE PARTICIPATING
BY- TELEPHONICALLY. IN UDAY CUP
POOR PRESIDENT OF NAMI- SANTA
CLARA- CENTER EGGMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AN ARMORED- THANK YOU
ALL FOR TAKING SOME TIME HERE
THIS TODAY. AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT I THINK PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT HOPEFULLY IS
GONNA BE ANOTHER TOOL IN OUR
TOOLBOX AND BEING ABLE TO HELP
THOSE WHO MOST DESPERATELY NEED
OUR HELP- WE KNOW THAT I'M-
LOOKING AT. THESE LAST TWO YEARS
COMING OUT THE PANDEMIC THE
PROBLEMS WE HAD BEFORE EXIST AND
EVEN MORE HEIGHTENED LEVEL AND
RIGHTLY SO I THINK THE PUBLIC IS
SAYING WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT
THIS WE CONTINUE TO TRY- DEPOSIT
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US AND I
HAVE BILLS IT'LL BE BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE LATER. TO IMPROVE OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. BUT WE NEED A
DIFFERENT ON RAMP THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING HAVE NOT
BEEN WORKING. INTO A TOTALITY-
THIS PLAN PUT FORWARD BY THE
GOVERNOR AND VERY PROUD TO
INTRODUCE WITH CENTER ON BURKE-
COMES OUT IN A DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT WAY A WAY THAT IS MORE
ENGAGING ON THE UP FRONT. AWAY
THAT INVITES PEOPLE INTO THE
PROCESS IN A WAY THAT
COLLABORATIVELY MAKES A PLAN
THAT MUST INCLUDE HOUSING
STABILIZATION AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT WE THINK ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- MY ROLE IN
THE SENATE IS AS THE- BUDGET SUB
CHAIR ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. IN SINCE I BEGAN THE
SENATE WE HAVE BEEN INVESTING
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS AND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM INTO OUR
HOMELESSNESS SYSTEM. AND I'M NOT
SAYING AND THIS WILL IMPACT
HOMELESSNESS ON A BROAD SCALE
BUT THIS BILL I BELIEVE THIS
LEGISLATION IS CARE COURT WILL
HELP THOSE WHO ARE SICKEST AND
MOST DESPERATELY NEED OUR HELP
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO SEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO A SYSTEM.
THAT IS NOT RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS THAT WE SEE EVERY DAY ON
THE STREETS- WE'VE GOT TO DO
BETTER I THINK THE ONE THING
THAT WE KNOW IS THAT WE CANNOT
KEEP DOING THE SAME THING. AND
EXPECTING DIFFERENT OUTCOMES IT
JUST HAS NOT BEEN EFFECTIVE- AND
WE'D THIS THIS IS A PROGRAM.
THAT WILL BE WILL BE FUNDED I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY'S BE NO
DISPUTING IT WILL WILL BE FUNDED
IT WILL COST MORE. AND IT WILL
BE A DIFFERENT ON RAMP- THE
DEALS WITH A CHRONIC ISSUE
VERSUS COMING AT IT FROM AN
ACUTE. SYSTEM AS WE HAVE NOW- SO
WITH THAT AT THE SYSTEM STATUS
QUO IS NOT OKAY WE NEED TO DO
BETTER- AND I WILL URGE YOU ALL
IN SUPPORTING THIS CONCEPT AS WE
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU- UP OUR
FIRST WITNESSES IS DOCTOR MARK
GALLI. GALLI ALL RIGHT I. AS IN
ROBERT INDICATED WE ARE MOVING
ON TO THOSE WISHING TESTIFIED
SUPPORT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARING
SIX KNOWLEDGE CONSIDERATIONS A
CLEANING PROTOCOLS TO THE CHAIR
IS TO TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
ALREADY NOTED NOW FOR THE THIRD
TIME THERE WILL BE THREE PRIMARY
WITNESSES SPEAKING SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN THREE
PRIMARY WITNESSES SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. PRIMERS
FOR WITNESSES WILL BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR A TOTAL OF TEN MINUTES
. THE PRIMARY OPPOSITION WILL
RECEIVE EQUAL TIME BE ALLOWED TO
SPEAK FOR A TOTAL OF TEN MINUTES
ALL OTHERS WISHING TEST WHY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. THERE WILL BE A- TIME
LIMIT OF FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
THESE CALLS IN SUPPORT. IN
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR CALLS IN
OPPOSITION. THAT'S A TOTAL OF
THIRTY. FIFTEEN FOR FIFTEEN
AGAINST. I AM FOR THOSE THAT
WILL BE CALLING IN ENEMY TO
FASHION- PLEASE. LIMIT YOUR
YOURSELF TO YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY
THIS IS HOW WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MANAGE THE LENGTH OF THE
HEARING- AND IT'S OKAY TO
STRICTLY REINFORCE. ARE THESE
PROCEDURES GIVEN THE TIME
CONSTRAINTS AS INTERIM AMBURGEY
EDUCATED WE HAVE THE HONORABLE
JUDGE STEPHEN V. MANLY AND IT
WOULD TAKE A POOR ON THE LINE
TEST FIND SUPPORT. DR MARK GALLI
IS HERE IN PERSON TO TESTIFY. I
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE. THANK YOU ARE
AND GOOD MORNING ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING
SENATOR EGGMAN OF SENATOR UMBERG
THANK YOU FOR. PRESENTING OUT
THIS BILL. TODAY YESTERDAY CAN
BE AND I BELIEVE WILL BE A
HISTORIC TO THE STORK BEGINNING.
THE FIERCE SCRUTINIZING FACE OF
HISTORY WELL I HOPE JUDGE TODAY
IS A DAY WHERE CALIFORNIA MOVED
DEEPER DOWN A ROAD OF COMPASSION
AND CARE. VERSUS INSISTING ON
STAYING MIRED IN A STALE AND
DEADLY YES DEADLY CONVERSATION
ABOUT HAVING NOT ENOUGH OF THIS
WERE NOT ENOUGH OF THAT. THAT'S
OUR EXCUSE TO NOT SERVE THE MOST
SICK VULNERABLE AND SADLY
OVERLOOKED CALIFORNIANS. THE
CARE CORPORATE PUZZLE IS A
PARADIGM SHIFT IN MOVES BEYOND
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES- FRAMEWORK
OF LPS. BY RECOGNIZING AND
ADVANCES IN OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND TREATMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
IT'S THE PERSON AT THE CENTER IT
IS COMMUNITY BASED IT DOES NOT
DEPEND ON CONFINEMENT. THE
RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO COUPLE
TREATMENT IN SUPPORT WITH
COMMUNITY BASED HOUSING
SOLUTIONS IN ORDER TO HASTEN
RECOVERY. IT SEEKS TO EMPOWER
PARTICIPANTS DURING AND AFTER
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT AND PROMOTES
THEIR MEANT OVERALL MENTAL AND
SOCIAL STABILITY. IT FOCUSES ON
SUPPORTING AN INDIVIDUAL TO
REGAIN INSIGHT TO MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS RATHER THAN HARDLY
WATCH IN INDIVIDUAL AND RAVEL IN
PLAIN SIGHT INTEL WE NOT THEM
FEEL LEGALLY COMFORTABLE
SUBSTITUTING THE DECISION MAKING
CAPACITY. WITH ADVANCES IN
TREATMENT MODELS THE NEW LONGER
ACTING ANTI PSYCHOTIC TREATMENTS
THE NOTION OF THE RIGHT CLINICAL
TEAM IN HOUSING PLAN INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE HISTORICALLY DIED ON
THE STREETS OR WALLING CARTS
RATED CAN BE SUCCESSFULLY
STABILIZED AND SUPPORTED IN
COMMUNITIES. CARE COURT AS
SENATOR ON BURKE SAID IS NOT FOR
EVERYONE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR WITH A MENTAL
ILLNESS BY FOCUSING ON A
NARROWER SET OF CONDITIONS THAT
ARE DEFINED BY IMPAIRMENT IN
INSIGHT AND JUDGMENT.
SCHIZOPHRENIA SPECTRUM WHEN
OTHER PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS THE
EVIDENCE THAT CARE COURT
INTERVENTIONS CAN HEAL AND
SUPPORT IS WELL DOCUMENTED. I
HAVE NOT ONLY SEEN THIS EVIDENCE
WITH MY OWN EYES I'VE BEEN A
PART OF TEAMS THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED AND STUDIED THESE
INTERVENTIONS FOR YEARS I HAVE
PHOTOS OF PARTICIPANTS ON FIELD
TRIPS TO A CONCERT OR THE BEACH
WHO JUST WEEKS EARLIER WERE
JAILED. AS A RALSTON'S ULTIMA
QUOTE CHARGE OFTEN A CHARGE OF
DESPERATION TO STAY WARM
NOURISHED OR SAY. WITHOUT THE
HEWING RECOVERY ORIENTED
ENVIRONMENT THEY FOUND THEIR WAY
INTO. BY CHANCE OR FORTUNE THEY
WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE SUFFERED
MORE GRAVELY AND DEEPLY WITH NO.
END IN SIGHT. WHERE HISTORICALLY
EITHER THE TREATMENT STAFF FOR
BEDS ARE SCARCE OR THE HOUSING
PLAN IS MISSING CARE COURT HOLDS
OUR PUBLIC SYSTEMS ACCOUNTABLE.
TO PRIORITIZE YES PRIORITIZE
DELIVERY OF THESE SERVICES
EFFECTIVELY TO THOSE WHO CAN
BENEFIT. CANACCORD SUIT SEEKS TO
SERVE A POPULATION THAT ISN'T AS
SOME SAY AT THE BACK OF THE LINE
WAITING FOR SERVICES I SAY
THEY'RE NOT IN THE LINE AT ALL.
THIS PER PROPOSAL NOT ONLY GETS
THEM IN THE LINE THE REQUIRES US
IN GOVERNMENT BROADLY SPEAKING.
TO PUT THEM TOWARDS THE FRONT.
WITH THE CLIENT CENTERED
APPROACH THE POSITIVE IMPACT
WILL NOT ONLY BE EXPERIENCED BY
INDIVIDUALS BUT BY THE
COMMUNITIES AT LARGE. BY
EMPHASIZING THE CREATION OF A
MENTAL HEALTH ADVANCE DIRECTIVE
BY AND FOR EACH CARE
PARTICIPANTS WHEN THEY ARE
STABLE AND POTENTIAL THE- TO
AVOID FUTURE EPISODES OF
PSYCHOSIS. AT IF THEY DO HAVE A
FUTURE EPISODE OF PSYCHOSIS I'M
NOT ALL THE GAINS ARE FULLY
UNRAVELED. ALTHOUGH HOMELESSNESS
HAS MANY FACES IN CALIFORNIA ONE
OF THE MOST TRAGIC YET TREATABLE
IS THAT EXPERIENCED BY THE
SICKEST OF THE SICK WHO OFTEN
NEED EFFECTIVE TREATMENT
SUPPORTS TO IDENTIFY THE ROAD TO
RECOVERY INSTABILITY. CARE COURT
WILL HELP THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WE ESTIMATE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN SEVEN TWELVE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY LIVE IN
TODAY TO FIND THAT ROAD. I HAVE
OVER THE WEEKS SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE
CARE COURT FRAMEWORK HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF MEETING WITH AND
LEARNING FROM. WAS THIS PROPOSAL
THERE FEEDBACK HAS LED TO SOME
IMPORTANT CHANGES IN THIS IN THE
PROPOSAL AND PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EARLIER
ENGAGEMENT AND PARTNERSHIP TO
CREATE A PLAN WITH ALL THE
COMPONENTS ARE A AND DEEPER
ENGAGEMENT EARLY THIS SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT PERIOD WAS NOT THERE
IN THE INITIAL FRAMEWORK WE
HEARD AND LISTEN THIS FEEDBACK.
AND IT JUST MAKES SENSE TO ADD
IT AND THAT'S WHY IT WAS ADDED
IN TODAY'S MODEL USUALLY WELL
DOWNSTREAM AFTER YEARS OF
INDIVIDUALS LANGUISHING ON THE
STREETS HARDLY ENGAGED IN
SERVICES THE SAME VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS END UP IN OUR COURTS
IN OUR JAILS AND IN IN A
CONSERVATORSHIP PROCESS SEES WE
CAN DO BETTER IN CALIFORNIA WE
MUST DO BETTER LET ME CLOSE BY
ADDRESSING THE PROFOUND INEQUITY
CARE COURT ALSO SEEKS TO ADDRESS
ALBEIT IMPERFECTLY. WE HAVE
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE NEEDED DEEP
SEATED TRANSFORMATION IN ORDER
TO AMELIORATE THESE RACIAL AND
SOCIAL INEQUITIES OUR RESOLVE TO
REPAIR THE SYSTEMS MUST MOVE IN
PARALLEL BUT NOT IN CONFLICT
WITH OUR INSISTENCE TO IMPLEMENT
NEW SOLUTIONS NEW PROGRAMS TO DO
THE MOST BASIC THING WE ARE
CALLED IN GOVERNMENT TO DO SERVE
OUR MOST VULNERABLE I AM HERE
SLEEVES ROLLED UP YEARS CLEAR TO
CONTINUE IN THIS CONVERSATION.
THANKS FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF YOUR
TIME I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
JUDGE STEVEN BAILEY FROM SANTA
CLARA THANK YOU AND THEN AND- TO
BE CONSISTENT- THAT- USED
APPROXIMATELY SIX MINUTES AND WE
HAVE- HONORABLE JUDGE- STEPHEN
MANLEY AND- WOULD DIE OUT A
COUPLE ORDER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
RESPECTIVELY LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO TWO MINUTES EACH. FOR A TOTAL
OF FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE A PHD BUT NOW PROPHETIC
COUNTY UPS. TODAY ONLY FOR
MYSELF I DO NOT SPEAK OF THE
REPRESENTATIVE COUNCIL. NOR THE
COURTS. I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
FAMILY- INDIVIDUALS IN THE COURT
SYSTEM. FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. THE CARE COURT PART THAT
THE ONE GROUP AT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
SOCIETY. MANY OF WHOM LIVE AND
FILE THE STREETS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT IN JAIL. I SEE THIS EVERY
DAY THEY CONTINUE TO SUFFER
TRAUMA POVERTY AND
DISCRIMINATION AND STIGMA. THESE
INDIVIDUALS LIBERAL REALITY
CANNOT MAKE RATIONAL DECISIONS
THEY FOLLOWED BELIEVES DELUSIONS
A REALTOR BAM. UNFORTUNATELY
THAT LEADS TO A WIDE THE BLUES
FROM THE STREET TO THE HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY ROOMS AND LEAD TO JAIL
FOR A NEW OFFENSE. AND I. YOU
THEY CARS. ALL RESULTS IN MARCH
. AND LONGER AND LOWER LONGER
STAYS IN CONSTANT. WHAT IS MOST
TRAGIC MY VIEW IS THE FACT THAT
AS WE HAVE REDUCE THE GENERAL
POPULATIONS ARE JAILS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE NUMBER AND
PROPORTION OF MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR PARTICIPATION IN
CARE COURT HAS ACTUALLY
INCREASED. DOCTOR FOSTER'S. NOT
PEROTIS. COURT SHOULD BE HERE TO
PROTECT AND SERVE THOSE WHO ARE
THE MOST VULNERABLE. MY
CHALLENGE THE CHALLENGE FOR ANY
JOB. IS TO FIND ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. BUT THIS GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
RATHER THE CONTINUE YEAR AFTER
YEAR WATCHING THE SAME CYCLE
REPEAT ITSELF. BUT THE CARE
COURT BILL MAKING THE CIVIL
PROCEEDINGS ARE NOT CRIMINAL IS
VERY IMPORTANT. BECAUSE WITH
THEIR OWN SUPPORTER ON THEIR OWN
JOURNEY IT'S A NEW ROLE OF
APPROACH WITH THE DEDICATION OF
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES FOR HOUSING
TREATMENT AND SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY. THEY DO NOT EXIST IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ONGOING COURT OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IMPORTANT. AND
WE SHOULD BE THERE TO PERFORM
THAT FUNCTION. I WOULD LIKE
THEIR OWN ROLES WITH A BRIEF
EXAMPLE THANK YOU IN THE
INTEREST IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
VERY MUCH THANK YOU YOUR HONOR-
I THINK- WE ARE GOING TO NOW
MOVE ON TO- WITH A COUPLE WERE
ON THE LINE- I BELIEVE YOU HAVE
ABOUT. A MINUTE AND FORTY FIVE
SECONDS. IT IS SO MUCH. FOR THE
PRIVILEGE OF ADDRESSING THIS
AUGUST BODY. AND I HAVE A SON
FORTY YEARS FOR FORTY FOUR YEARS
OLD WHO WAS GRAVELY DISABLED THE
SPECIFIC. FISCAL EFFECTIVE
DISORDER HAD WITH THE CORCORAN.
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITY. AND IS
IN TREATMENT AT THE RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY IN SAN JOSE IN FACT
WE'RE- GOVERNOR NEWSOM RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED THE CARE COURT
INITIATIVE. AND I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO MEET HIM AND
SECRETARY. AND I SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
A MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSIS-
INDIVIDUALS LIVING WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL ILLNESS CONTINUE TO COME
TO HARM REGARDLESS OF MULTIPLE
OUTREACH ATTEMPTS BY A CODE
PENSION SYSTEM. WITHOUT SOME
LEVEL OF INTERVENTION. THE END
UP ON OUR STREETS IN PRISON
HOMELESS OR DEAD. MANY FAMILIES
SO CONTACT NAMI SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. IN DESPERATION TRYING TO
FIND HELP FOR THE VERY ILL
FAMILY MEMBERS. FURTHER
SUBSTANTIATES THIS ASSERTION.
FOR THIS SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION SUFFERING FROM
SCHIZOPHRENIA AND RELATED
DISORDERS. THE CARE CORD MODEL
IS AN IMPORTANT OPTION. THAT CAN
PREVENT UNNECESSARY SUFFERING
NOT ONLY FOR THE PATIENTS BUT
ALSO FOR THE FAMILIES. NO ONE
SHOULD HAVE TO EXPERIENCE
MULTIPLE INVOLUNTARY
HOSPITALIZATIONS ARRESTS AND
JAIL TIME. OR YEARS OF
HOMELESSNESS IN ORDER TO ACCESS
NEEDED TREATMENT. AT THE LEVEL
THAT IS WARRANTED ROBUST
WRAPAROUND SERVICES AND
APPROPRIATE COMMUNITY BASED
PLACEMENT. THEN UNLOCK SETTING.
WELL THE CIVIL COURT IS A TOOL
USED IT IS A SHORT TERM
INTERVENTION THAT CAN HAVE
LASTING POSITIVE OUTCOMES. THE
PROGRAM THAT USES CIVIL COURT
COUNT ABILITY WITH COMMUNITY
BASED SOLUTIONS WITH EMPHASIS ON
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. IS
NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF NAMI SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND I. SUPPORT IT BUT
PROGRAM. FOR DOCTORS THANK YOU
MISTER KING WE'RE WELL I HAVE
BEEN A I WENT UP TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU THANK YOU- IN THE
INTEREST OF EQUITY WE WERE ADD
IT IS THIRTY. TO THE OPPOSITE
MOVING BACK SOMEHOW I. SHE CAN.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ENOUGH FOLKS
HERE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM CAN
WE DO A ROLL CALL TO ESTABLISH
OR FOR PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING
A QUORUM. AMBERG AMBERG HERE OR
JUST HI PRESIDENT BUSH IS
PRESENT. ABIERTO DRESSEL.
DRESSEL HERE GONZALEZ. BURKE
HEARD HERE JONES LAYERED. STERN
WAKE HEALTHY WEIGHT CASKEY HERE
WIENER. WIENER PRESENT YOU HAVE
A SIX PRESENT. AND A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED EXCELLENT THANK YOU
COUNSEL- ALL RIGHT MOVINGBACK
TO- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT IN THIS
ROOM ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF BY NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR CENTERS DOUG
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE A
TOP ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR
TODD GLORIA IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. MARGARET GLAD
SHE NEVER HAVE A CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOSH POND
IN BEHALF OF MY MOM WHO IS FIFTY
NINE YEARS A SCHIZOPHRENIC IN
SUPPORT BUT MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
THE HOUSING THAT STICKS. IT HAS
TO BE ORDERED BY THE COURT THANK
YOU JUST WON'T WORK THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
I'M GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
MACHEL COVETED I WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A SOMEWHAT OF A TWEENER
POSITION CONCERNS- BUT GENERALLY
WE AGREE THE STATUS QUO IS
INSUFFICIENT AND YET WITHOUT A
CERTAIN CHANGES TO THIS BILL
STATUS QUO IT IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
WILL GET. WE HAVE FIELD STAFF
BRINGING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS IN
SERVICES AS WE WANT TO LIMIT THE
COMMENTS J. REVIEW WIENER
POSITION YES THEY ARE YOU THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ENVIRONMENT THEY TEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS WE ARE IN BETWEEN- LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE A
CONCERN SORT OF IN BETWEEN
POSITION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH- THE AUTHORS AS
WELL AS THE ADMINISTRATION THANK
YOU. YOU THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE A
CONCERN POSITION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AUTHORED. ON
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SEEING NONE- MODERATOR
WE'RE OPENING UP THE TELEPHONE
LINES- IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY
FOLKS WISHING TO SUPPORT. S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WITH NAME.
I AND POSITION ONLY AND WE WILL
CAP IT AT FIFTEEN MINUTES.
MISTER MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES AND ALSO IDENTIFY
HOW MANY FOLKS MIGHT BE IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU MR- WE DO HAVE
FOR IN QUEUE AT THE MOMENT IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT. THIS
PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL START WITH LINE ONE OH TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALLOWED HER
AGAIN BY EARLY EVENING ON BEHALF
OF THE THANKS AGAIN SUPPORT THAT. NEXT ONE ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NINETY
FOR YEAR ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY IN LINE ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANNY OFFER
WITH THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO KNOWN AS NON
THE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO ROB LANGUAGE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEING ABOUT HEALTH AGENCIES WITH
THAT WATCH ADDITION. IN ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING HUNDREDS ON BEHALF
OF SEIU CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE
AN IN BETWEEN POSITION I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND AUTHORS
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. WELL
ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI TRICIA LANDFALLING BEGIN
ONLY FOR MYSELF AND MY FAMILY.
EXCUSE ME I HAVE BIPOLAR JUST AT
THE TIME OF THE GOVERNMENTAL
ALMOST SHE WAS FOR MANY. AND IS
NOW IN FULL QUITE HOUSING I AM
TAKING A POSITION OF WHY. THANK
YOU MA'AM BYE MODERATE PLEASE-
ROOM THE CALLING IN IT IS NAME
AND- AFFILIATION INTO ONLY. NOT
OP FOR NARRATIVE DISCUSSION
THANK YOU. IN MEXICO ONE ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME SHRINK FOLLOW
MEN AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
HARM REDUCTION. THANK YOU. IN
LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THIS IS JANE ADD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL THE COUNCIL HAS
THE CONCERN AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. JUST NOW WE
HAVE TWO MORE QUEUING UP. WE'LL
GO TO ONE SEVENTY THREE. HI
CALIBER MARYLAND COLD IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CHARACTERS CALIFORNIA CODE. IN
ORDER TO LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY EIGHT
YARD IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY THANKS WELL THERE YEAR THEY
ARE GOOD. YES THIS IS SHERIN AND
I AM TIS. EIGHT M. AGO TO ONE
FORTY ONE GO AHEAD. I'M FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON ONE FIFTY ONE
HE'S THE HEAD. ONE FIFTY ONE YOU
WANT IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOCTRINE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE HARM REDUCTION IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT. AND LINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS RICHARD GALLO SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY ASSETS IN BASTAR ****
CALIFORNIA. OPPOSING THANK YOU
AND- MODERATE COMPUTER REMIND
FOLKS CALLING IN THAT WE ARE
TAKING POSITIONS IN SUPPORT AT
THIS AT THIS MOMENT THOSE
WISHING TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
WILL BE GIVEN OPPORTUNITY- IN
THE NEXT PHASE. IN THIS YEAR WE
HAVE NO NOTHING TO AT THIS TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
WE'RE GOING TO FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM OPPOSITION.
I BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE BEEN
ANTI- IMPERATORE. ANDREA WAGNER
AND KARIS MERRICK- SOME OF WHOM
MAY BE IN PERSON MAYBE
TELEPHONICALLY AS WELL- AS WE
HAD EARLIER- THERE'S A TOTAL OF
TEN MINUTES. AND LEAVE IT UP TO
YOU YOUR BEST JUDGMENT HOW BEST
TO DIVIDE THAT OUT WILL BE TEN
MINUTES AND THIRTY SECONDS TO
BE. EXACT. THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
BETTER BORDERS ARE YOU READY FOR
ME. SO HI GOOD MORNING I'M IN
THE IMPERATA ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE. AND
I'M HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL BUT NOT IN OPPOSITION TO
THE UNDERLYING GOAL THAT I HEARD
ARTICULATED BY BY THE SENATORS
IN INTRODUCING THE BILL. WE HAVE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE
PEOPLE WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA AND
GET THEM SERVICES THAT CAN HELP
THEM GET ON A PATH TO RECOVERY.
AND I FEEL LIKE THAT'S THE REAL
QUESTION WITH THIS BILL IS USING
A COURT THE BEST WAY TO GET
PEOPLE ON A PATH TO RECOVERY-
I'M A PERSONAL LIVED EXPERIENCE
WITH BI POLAR DISORDER. THIRTY
TWO YEARS AGO I WAS A LAW
STUDENT HOW MY FIRST SERIES OF
SORT OF DEPRESSION AND I WAS
LUCKY AT THAT EARLY STAGE IN MY
EXPERIENCE WITH MY DISABILITY.
THAT I HAD JUST GOTTEN MARRIED
TO THE RIGHT PERSON WE'RE STILL
MARRIED SHE HELPED ME GET ON A
PATH TO RECOVERY AND I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE A CAREER AS AN
ATTORNEY. AT WHEN I WAS IN
WASHINGTON DC I WAS THE
DISABILITY POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
SENATOR TOM HARKIN ON THE U. S.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
EDUCATION LABOR AND PENSIONS.
AND I'VE RAISED TWO CHILDREN
WITH MY WIFE. NONE OF THIS
WOULD'VE BEEN POSSIBLE FOR ME IF
I DIDN'T LEARN EARLY HOW TO MAKE
DECISIONS FOR MYSELF HOW TO GET
CARE THAT WAS GOING TO WORK FOR
ME AND HOW TO MANAGE MY SYMPTOMS
SO THAT I COULD ACCOMPLISH MY
GOALS. SO THE QUESTION FOR
PEOPLE WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA
SPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE DONE WITH
THE NEW DIAGNOSIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO WORK BEST FOR THEM. WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT FORCED CARER
WORKS WELL FOR PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES AND
WE DON'T FEEL THAT THERE'S A
GOOD EVIDENCE BASE TO SUPPORT
IT. I HEARD SENATOR I'M BURKE
SAY THIS PROPOSAL DOES NOT
INVOLVE FORCED CARE SO THE
QUESTION THAT WE HAVE IN
OPPOSITION IS. HOW DO YOU HAVE A
COURT ORDERED CARE PLAN. WITHOUT
FORCE. AND END TO THEIR- THAT
ALL THAT HOW. IS THE BILL
EXPLAIN. SAYS YOU CAN ORDER
HOUSING. SO IF THE COURT CAN
ORDER HOUSING HOW ARE WE GOING
TO ENSURE. THAT THE HOUSING AND
PRIORITIZE THE LAST POINT I WANT
TO MAKE. THIS PEOPLE WHO ARE
AFRICAN AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. DIAGNOSED
WITH SCHIZOPHRENIA OFTENTIMES.
INCORRECTLY SO LET'S ALSO MAKE
SURE THERE'S NOT AN UNINTENDED.
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCE PROPERTY
FROM AFRICAN AMERICANS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HOMELESS. AND
DISPROPORTIONATE GAIN THESE
DIAGNOSES. AND NOW I'M GONNA
TURN OVER TO ANDREA WATSON. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH CARE RUN
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU ANDY AND
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND OUR SYSTEM EXCUSE
ME I'M HERE- I STATE INTERIM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR CAMPRO
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH PEER RUN
ORGANIZATIONS. AND I AM HERE-
FOR CAMPERS VISION THAT WE HAVE
HAVE ARDENTLY OVER MANY YEARS
BEEN OPPOSED TO FORCE TREATMENT
WE FEEL CARE QUARTERS IS IN LINE
WITH THAT VISION OF BEING
OPPOSED TO- FORCED TREATMENT WE
BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW IN
COMMUNITY VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES ARE REALLY.
THE ANSWER AND WE ENVISION A
SYSTEM WITHOUT
WELL AFTER MY LAST
HOSPITALIZATION IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AFTER MY SON DIED OF
BRAIN CANCER. THAT I FOUND-
WELLNESS CENTER WHILE I WAS
STAYING AT A HOMELESS SHELTER.
AND THAT EXPOSURE TO THE
WELLNESS CENTER OF A COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT AND EXPOSURE TO
PEER SUPPORT DID MORE FOR ME
THAN TWENTY YEARS OF
HOSPITALIZATION MEDICATION AND
BEING ON THE STREETS. AND I'M IN
THE LONGEST PHASE OF STABILITY
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE AND I'M ABOUT
TO GET MY MASTERS IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION OR PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION. M. I. IT WASN'T
THE FIRST TIME I HAD PEER
SUPPORT- BUT I DIDN'T KNOW THAT
MY SISTER AND MY OLDER SISTER
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH PARANOID
SCHIZOPHRENIA WHEN I WAS A
CHILD. SHE WAS NOT OUR FAMILIES
THE CRAZY ONE NOBODY WANTED TO
LISTEN TO HER BUT SHE WAS THE
ONLY ONE I COULD TALK TO YOU.
ABOUT MY OWN EXPERIENCE THE ONLY
ONE THAT HELPED ME AND REACHED
OUT AND HAVE COMPASSION AND
TAUGHT ME A LOT ABOUT. LIFE AB
SHE WENT THROUGH CYCLES OF
HOMELESSNESS AS WELL- AND SO I
COME NOT ONLY AS A FAMILY MEMBER
I'M NOT A MOTHER ALSO WITH
CHILDREN WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE
AND I HAVE OTHER SIBLINGS HAVE
SUFFERED WITH WARNING AND
CLATTERING AND ALCOHOL AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE SO IT IS ALL
AROUND ME- AFTER BEING
HOSPITALIZED I STARTED WORKING
WITH MY COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH- I WORKED IN CRISIS
SERVICES FOR OVER FIVE YEARS I%
WORKED FOR ME AS A PEER AND AS A
CRISIS COUNSELOR. AND I CAN TELL
YOU IS A REALLY ODD FEELING TO
SUDDENLY HAVE THE KEYS TO THE
UNIT I WAS ONCE LOCKED UP IN AND
JUST ONLY BE ABLE TO WRITE THE
HOLES THAT I WAS ONCE ON- DURING
THAT EXPERIENCE I ALSO
COORDINATED HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
I CAN TELL YOU THERE ARE MANY
HOLES IN THE SYSTEM AND I CAN
TELL YOU EXPERIENCE LEE AS BOTH
A PATIENT AND SOMEONE WHO'S DONE
HOSPITALIZATION THAT THAT DOES
NOT WORK FOR MOST PEOPLE- I
WANTED TO SEE THAT ALSO IS MY
EXPERIENCE WITH LEAD- OUR
PROGRAM A CAMPER WE HAVE DONE
OVER- THE FORTY LISTENING
SESSIONS IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
TWENTY SEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN OF
THEM IN THE LAST TWO TWO MONTHS
OR THREE MONTHS AND WE'VE TALKED
TO HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE ASKING THEM WHAT
THEIR NEEDS AND PRIORITIES ARE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH NOT ONE OF
THEM ASKED FOR MORE FORCED
TREATMENT FOR MORE MEDICATION
THEY WANTED SERVICES IN THEIR
COMMUNITY PLACES WHERE PEOPLE
COULD GO TO GET HELP WITH IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THEY
CAN HAVE NETWORKS OF SUPPORT AND
COMMUNITY OF A SOCIAL NETWORK OF
PEERS THAT UNDERSTOOD WHAT THEY
WERE GOING- MY FEAR WITH. AN OUR
FEAR AT CAMP ROAD IS THAT- YOU
KNOW. THIS REPORT IS GOING TO
FAST TRACK PEOPLE AROUND OPS IN
INTO CONSERVATORSHIP BECAUSE
THOSE COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
AREN'T FUNDED AND AREN'T THERE
IN THE LEVEL THAT THEY NEED TO
BE TO SUPPORT THIS PROCESS- WE
HAVE- AS A RESPONSES DEVELOPED A
WHOLE MENU OF VOLUNTARY OPTIONS.
THAT WE SUGGEST THAT YOU LOOK AT
AS ALTERNATIVES TO ANY KIND OF
FORCED A TREATMENT PROGRAM- AND
LOOK AT A ROBUSTLY FUNDING THOSE
INSTEAD OF PUTTING MONEY AWAY
FROM EXISTING PROGRAMS INTO A
FORCE OF SYSTEM- I WOULD LIKE
TO. JUST OFFER THAT AS- I HAVE A
COPY OF THOSE SOLUTIONS- WITH ME
IF YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE THEM AND
I'M OPEN TO ANY QUESTIONS MOST
OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH- KERIS-
MERRICK. ARE YOU IN THIS MATTER
YEAH ALL RIGHT YOU HAVE
ESSENTIALLY THREE MINUTES AND
THIRTY SECONDS BRING IT ALL HOME
WHERE IS OUR TIMER REMOTE
HOWEVER SO HIGH MY NAME IS
KARISHMA OKAY WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND ARMY NATIONAL
PEER LEADER I PREFER UP
PREVIOUSLY WITH THE L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
SAMPSON WAS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF MONEY NATIONAL. I'M
ALSO A PERSON WHO WAS GIVEN A
DIAGNOSIS OF SCHIZOPHRENIA. MY
FIRST THING WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM DURING A TIME OF
CRISIS. OCCURRED WHEN I WAS IN
MY THIRTIES HERE IN LA. AND THE
VOICES WERE RELENTLESSLY
WOULDN'T STOP AND NEXT THING YOU
KNOW. I WASN'T CODE SWITCHING
SAID SOMETHING. AND OUR THAT WAS
INTERPRETED AS ME BEING SINGLE
FINAL COACHING AS AND- USING YOU
KNOW MORE CULTURAL LANGUAGE THAT
WITH AN UNDERSTOOD BY THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE HELPING ME. SO HOW
BEING DEEMED GREATLY DISABLED
AND A DANGER TO MYSELF I WAS
HANDCUFFED AND TAKEN TO THE
POLICE STATION. AND THEN I WAS
HOSPITALIZED UNDER FIFTY ONE
FIFTY. MY MOTHER CAME FROM
PHILADELPHIA TO HELP ME FIND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING NONE WAS TO
BE FOUND. LONG WAITING LIST FOR
SECTION EGHT LEFT US WITH NO
CHOICE BUT FOR ME TO GIVE UP MY
HOUSING GIVE UP MY DOG. AND
MOVED TO PHILADELPHIA. I
TREATMENT THAT WITH- THE
CONSISTED OF CBT TO WHICH I CAN
PLAINTIFF WAS NOT HELPFUL BUT-
IF I DIDN'T PARTICIPATE I WAS
CALLED NON COMPLIANT. I FOUND
OUT WHAT MENTAL HEALTH CARE WAS
ALL ABOUT IT WAS NEEDING HELP
AND INSTEAD GETTING RIGHTS TAKEN
AWAY BEING HARMED PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY AND NOT GETTING MY
NEEDS MET. EVIDENCE HAS SHOWN
THAT CB TEA IS NOT AS EFFECTIVE
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS. FOR MANY
YEARS I WAS ON BILLING TO SEE
CARE THAT I NEEDED WHEN I NEEDED
IT MOST. AND I FELT THAT IT WAS
BROKEN AND SO BLACK IN AMERICA
THAT IN FACT I. DESERVED PATRICK
MCDERMOTT WAS GETTING. OVER 40%
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE HOMELESS OR
PLAQUE BUT WE ONLY MAKE UP SIX
POINT 5% OF THE POPULATION. FOR
DIAGNOSIS OF BLACK MEN WITH
SCHIZOPHRENIA IS WELL DOCUMENTED
AND THAT IS YET ANOTHER
DISPARITY. MY FEAR IS THAT CARE
COURT WILL PERPETUATE
DISPARITIES YOU'RE A COURT
PROCESS RATHER THAN ADDRESS THE
STRUCTURAL CAUSES. COURTS HAVE
NOT BEEN FAIR SAFE OR PLACE OF
CARE FOR BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE.
AS A CALIFORNIA AS A BLACK
INDIGENOUS CALIFORNIA I REALLY
WANT US TO HAVE ACCESS TO WE
WENT WITHOUT REACH ENGAGEMENT
SERVICES. PEER SUPPORT RESPITE
SUPPORTED HOUSING AND TREATMENT
THAT'S CULTURALLY ALIGNED AND
EFFECTIVE. THERE'S A LAKOTA
THING THAT. FORCE NO MATTER HOW
CONCEALED BECAUSE WE FIFTEENTH
WHEN FIFTEEN FAILED PEOPLE WE
CAN HELP PEOPLE TO THE VERY
BROKEN SYSTEMS RATHER THAN-
CREATING SYSTEMS THAT MEET THE
NEEDS OF ALL PEOPLE IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE WAY POSSIBLE.
EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT PEER
SUPPORT SERVICES INCREASE
ENGAGEMENT ACTIVATION
PARTICIPATION IN TREATMENT AS
WELL AS REDUCE HOSPITALIZATION
AND LONGER TENURE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND FAMILY SUPPORT
INCREASES CONFIDENCE IN KNOWING
HOW TO SUPPORT THEIR LOVED ONE
REDUCTION OF STIGMA AND
INCREASED SOCIAL INCLUSION. IT
IS NOT A MEDICAID STATE MIGHT
BENEFIT HERE BUT IT IS AN FORTY
EIGHT OTHER STATES. WE NEED
PEOPLE WHO LOOK LIKE US FROM THE
SAME CULTURE WHO SPEAK THE SAME
LANGUAGE AND HAVE BEEN THROUGH
SIMILAR MENTAL HEALTH STRUGGLES. TO AID IN RECOVERY JOURNEY.
AND MEET US HERE WE- TALKING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WELL I MUST
SAY GOT IT IN LIKE TEN MINUTES
AND TWENTY SECONDS THAT'S
AMAZING IT WAS PERFECT ALLOTMENT
OF TIME. ALRIGHT WE ARE MOVING
ON NOW TO OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WAITING- PHYSICALLY HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IF YOU COULD
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR NAME
YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE CARROLL OF WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW PROPERTY
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ONE BACK AS FOR
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. HELLO
EVERYBODY DAMASO JOHNSON FROM
BLACK MEN SPEAK WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA HARRIS AND I
WOULD ALAMEDA COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH AWARENESS NUMBER ONE THE
PUBLIC POLICY COMMITTEE AND I'M
OPPOSING TO THE CARE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FOR POSSUMS WITH THE
DEPRESSION AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL WE NEED MORE CARE NOT
MORE COURTS. I CAN MORNING DAN
AYKROYD ARMAAN BEHALF OF DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AND IN MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY AS AN ADVOCATE OF FOR A
LOVED ONE LIVING WITH PARANOID
SCHIZOPHRENIA. JEFF ROBERSON
FROM OAKLAND. BLACK MASS
RECORDING SESSION APOLLO.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING DON BEARD SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND MY FAMILY
WHO'S BEEN SYSTEM IMPACTED I AM
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU YOU. SEVEN DAVIS
MENTAL HEALTH CLIENT TOTALLY
AGAINST IT YOU CAN DO BETTER I
KNOW. GOOD MORNING KAREN IF YOU
CARRY ON MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK IN
OPPOSITION. NAY FULLER SEND THAT
WITH YOU KNOW THE WHOLE HEALTH
ALLIANCE IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
MORTY MATTHEW GALLAGHER COWBOYS
THIS IN OPPOSITION YOU. GOOD
MORNING I'M DOING CRYSTAL SANTA
CLARA COUNTY OF WITH THE PEER
PRESSURE MOVEMENT FOR FOLKS AND
LYFT INSTITUTIONS- I'M IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AS WRITTEN
IN THE PROBLEM IS- WE NEED A BIO
. PSYCHOLOGICAL SOCIAL MODEL
INSTEAD OF A MEDICAL MODEL THAT
SERVES THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY THANK YOU MADE A
PERMANENT DIAGNOSIS IS NOT THE
SOLUTION THANK YOU ANY OTHER-
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC WHICH NEED TO
MAKE COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
PHYSICALLY PRESENT TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SEEING NONE MODERATOR
GOING TO THE LINES FIVE I'D LIKE
TO REMIND FOLKS THAT MAY BE
CALLING IN. THAT YOU'RE LIMITED
TO YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION- A MODERATOR CAN YOU
MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE START THE
CLOCK IN AND- THIS PORTION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT AT FIFTEEN
MINUTES SHOULD WE GO THAT LONG.
THE COMMISSION CHAIR IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. ONE ZERO-
LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT TEN THANK YOU
AT THE MOMENT. IT WILL START OF
ONE ONE ZERO ONE ONE ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING THIS IS
SHERIN REPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NEXT
ONE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CAROLYN GOOSSEN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
OFFICE CALLING IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING YES GREEN COLORED ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN AGING AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. ONE ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MEAN EVEN IN CHILDREN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES WE HAVE A
CONCERNS POSITION THANK YOU. ONE
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD MORNING TYLER BRANDY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
ALCOHOLIC DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVE
WE HAVE THAT RESPECTFUL
CONSTRUCTIVE ACTION THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAIL ME ROMERO
THE CALIFORNIA BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS OLIVIA AND
SIGN WITH HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH AND
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION. IN ONE ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS THERESA PASQUINADE PROUD
MOM AND ADULT SON WHO LIVES
AEROBICALLY WITH THINKING IT'S
MENTAL ILLNESS AND IN. IN
SUPPORT. AND AGAIN YOUR MIND OR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. MILLION FILIATION OF
TRADITION FOUR ONE ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. STACEY
HERE A MODEL WITH RAMCO THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION WE OPPOSE. MY NUMBER SEVENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA CARE FIRST
START CAREFIRST CALIFORNIA
COALITION IS IN STRONG AFTER
THIS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
STEPHANIE AMOS I AM A SIBLING
OF AN INDIVIDUAL WITH SCHIZO
AFFECTIVE DISORDER AND I
RESPECTFULLY. ONE ONE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. PAUL BODIN WENT
UP WESTERN REGIONAL ADVOCACY
PROJECT AND WE ARE 1100% IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE
BECAUSE- HI MY NAME IS DEBRA
INGRAM I'M CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. THANK YOU A MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE WOULD
YOU AT THE TIME. THANK YOU. WELL
THAT CONCLUDES OUR- COMMENTS
BOTH IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
BRING IT BACK TO THE DAIS-
COLLEAGUES WILL START WITH THE
CENTER WINNER AND THEN CENTER
WHAT KASKY. I'M GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- IS CHAIRMAN- SO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND HAPPY TO
MOVE IT- THANK THE AUTHORS FOR
THEIR WORK I'M ALSO THRILLED
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
INVOLVED- WE WERE DOING- SOME OF
THIS WORK IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN- WE WERE SORT OF
IN A LOAN MAYOR. MAYOR BREED
WAS- WAS WITH MY PARTNER IN THAT
IT WAS BASICALLY JUST THE TWO OF
US- AND WE WENT THROUGH THE MEAT
GRINDER OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE- QUIBBLING COMMITTEE ON THE
ASSEMBLY- AND ENDED UP WITH A
MUCH NARROWER BILL. THAT WE
WOULD HAVE WANTED AND WE REALLY
HAD NO SUPPORT IN THAT- AND SO
IT- WE DON'T GO AS FAR AS WE
NEED TO SO I'M GLAD THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOW. I'VE
DECIDED TO PRIORITIZE THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE- OF STRUCTURAL REFORM-
OF OUR- OF OUR LAWS IN THIS AREA
WILL NEVER HAPPEN WITHOUT
LEADERSHIP- OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JUST TO- POLITICALLY
CHALLENGING. PINE ISSUE SOME
LIKE THRILLED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INVOLVEMENT WE
HAVE TWO STRONG AUTHORS ON THE
BILL- IT THIS IS ALWAYS AN
AWKWARD- SUBJECT FOR ME ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
OPPOSING A BILL OUR
MODERNISATIONS I WORK WITH ON A
VERY REGULAR BASIS THING AND
PARTNER WITH THINGS. CARRY BILLS
THEY SPONSOR TURNS EXPAND
EXPANDING ACCESS AND FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
ADDICTION- TREATMENT. AND SO
FORTH AND WE KNOW THAT FOR THE-
VERY LARGE ME. OF PEOPLE WERE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CHALLENGES-
THAT CONSERVATORSHIP ARE ARE NOT
THE ANSWER. TO THE VAST MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES THIS IS NOT. THE
ANSWER IT'S VOLUNTARY TREATMENT
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE IS A SMALL PERCENTAGE
OF PEOPLE WITH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES THAT VOLUNTARY
SERVICES IS NOT AND WILL NEVER-
SOLVE. THEIR PROBLEM I WILL
NEVER GET THEM HEALTHY I AND
THAT IS A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WITH BEHAVIORAL
CHALLENGES BUT IT IS VERY VERY
REAL- AND THERE IS A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO NEED.
EXTRA HELP- AND SOMETIMES FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME THEY NEED SOMEONE
TO MAKE DECISIONS FOR THEM TO
GET THEM HEALTHY SO THEY CAN RE
ENTER VOLUNTARY SERVICES. AND WE
SEE IT PLAYING OUT ON OUR
STREETS EVERYDAY- WITH PEOPLE
WHETHER IT'S YOUR FOLKS YOUR
SLEEPING IN THEIR OWN FECES
FOLKS WHO ARE RUNNING OUT IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE STREET SCREAMING-
CARS ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACTING
IN WAYS WHERE THEY'RE- THEY'RE
THEY'RE BASICALLY TRENDING
TOWARDS THAT. WE HAVE TO BE
CLEAR THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRENDING TOWARDS DEATH AND IT IS
TOTALLY UNDERSTANDABLE WHEN
PEOPLE WALK ON THE STREET AND
THEY SAY WHAT WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING. WHY ISN'T ANYONE
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THIS AND AN
OFFERING. EXCLUSIVELY VOLUNTARY
SERVICES TO SOMEONE WHO IS IN
THAT CONDITION IS NOT GOING TO
WORK. ON I KNOW THAT THIS BILL
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS I KNOW
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION TO IT-
YOU KNOW THERE THERE THERE ARE
CONCERNS ABOUT DIFFERENT- WAYS
IN WHICH IT'S IMPLEMENTED OR
STRUCTURED- THIS BILL ISN'T VERY
EARLY FORM AND I KNOW IT'S GOING
TO EVOLVE- SO THAT IT IS. A VERY
FOCUSED AND TIGHTLY CRAFTED-
BILL- AND I'VE CONFIDENCE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE- AND-
BUT THE STATUS QUO IS NOT OKAY
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR STE
CHANGES SAYS QUOTE THIS IS ONE
PIECE OF IT. BUT. THE OTHER
PIECE OF IT HAS TO BE EXPANDING
OUR ACCESS. ON ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH FUNDING WE
KNOW THERE'S NOT ENOUGH ACCESS
WE KNOW THAT EVEN IF YOU ARE
PRIVILEGED TO HAVE THE BEST
INSURANCE. EVEN THOSE PEOPLE
STRUGGLE TO ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS
BROKEN AND I THINK I AGREE I
AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION. WHY
NOT- THE FACT THAT PEOPLE WITH
GOOD INSURANCE CAN'T GET MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES DOES SPEAK
VOLUMES- AND WE'RE DOING THAT
WORK IN THE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE
BEEN FOR A FEW YEARS I AUTHORED
THE MENTAL HEALTH MENTAL PAIR
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY. ALL LAW
WHICH IS THE STRONGEST IN THE
COUNTRY- WE DONE WORK. TO
STRENGTHEN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT TO PROVIDE FOR
BILLION. DOLLARS IN FUNDING FOR
pBECAUSE WE HAVE BASICALLY AS A
SOCIETY JETTISONED ARE USED. TO
JUST DEAL WITH THEIR CHALLENGES
WITH GIVE AND GIVING THEM VERY
VERY FEW RESOURCES ON. BUT WITH
ALL THAT SAID AND WE HAVE TO
KEEP DOING THAT WORK AND DO
MORE- THERE THERE ARE. A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO NEED
EXTRA HELP THIS BILL IS A STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION I SUPPORT- AND
AGAIN HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SIR WHAT KASKY THEN
SENATOR RUSSELL. I THINK I HAVE
EITHER FOR. EITHER FOR THE- THE
CHAIR OR FOR JUDGE MANLEY
BECAUSE QUESTIONS. YOU KNOW THE
OPPOSITION IS ALL OVER EITHER
IT'S TOO OPPRESSIVE OR DOESN'T
DO ENOUGH AND IS THE COURTS THE
BEST VENUE OR ARE WE TAKING
WHITE PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS SO THERE'S THAT- BUT-
COLLABORATIVE COURTS I'M I'M I'M
WONDERING BECAUSE I WAS THINKING
ABOUT. CHAPTER NINE WHICH IS
ONLY BY WHITE HOUSE HE COULD
THINK ABOUT BANKRUPTCY MUNICIPAL
BANKRUPTCIES BECAUSE- THE REASON
IS THAT JUDGES CAN'T ORDER
ANYTHING. IF THEY CAN'T NOT
UNLIKE A CHAPTER SEVEN OR
THIRTEEN ELEVEN THEY CAN SAY YOU
DID OR DO THIS AND YOU CREDITORS
ARE FOUND IT'S ALL COLLABORATION
THEY HAVE TO HAVE AGREEMENT WITH
PEOPLE NIGHT AND I WAS THINKING.
THOSE COURTS DO THAT FOR
MUNICIPALITIES WHEN THEY COME IN
BEFORE THEM AND THEY TRY TO WORK
OUT THESE DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS ON
WHAT'S THE BEST PLAN FOR THAT
CITY TO REORGANIZE TO DEBTS AND
FOR CREDITORS TO TAKE A HAIR CUT
SO THE- JUDGE MANLEY SAID A
BUNCH OF WORK IN COLLABORATIVE
COURTS AND I'M WONDERING YOU
KNOW WHY WE- CAN'T ORDER.
HOUSING AND WE CAN'T ORDER
MEDICATION THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT HOUSING ADVOCATES AND THE
MEDICAL- FOLKS ARE THAT-
PSYCHIATRISTS ARE NOT IN THE
ROOM WHEN THESE DISCUSSIONS ARE
GOING ON AND I WAS WONDERING.
HOW DOES HE ENVISION THE
EFFECTIVENESS IF IT WERE IF THE
GOAL IS TO HIT SEVEN TO TWELVE
THOUSAND. EVEN THOUGH YOU CAN'T
ORDER PEOPLE TO THIS TREATMENT.
YES ORDER SET THEM UP WITH THE
DISCUSSION I GUESS I'M I DON'T
KNOW I'M NOT A JUDGE BUT I WAS
WONDERING IF THE JUDGE KIDS
COULD GIVE US SOME IDEA OF HOW
THIS MIGHT BE SUCCESSFUL HEARD
HOW IT MIGHT NOT BE SAFE FOR
MAYBE. THE CHAIR COULD TELL US
HOW BAD. LACK OF. POWER TO ORDER
SOMEBODY DO SOMETHING MIGHT
ACTUALLY PROVED TO BE EFFECTIVE
- I WILL LET THE EXPERTS ANSWER
THE QUESTION- MISTER DOCTOR
GALLEY IS HERE AND I THINK JUDGE
MANLEY IS STILL ON THE PHONE
BUT- THIS IS. THE A COUSIN TO
THE COLLABORATIVE COURTS- THE-
OUTCOME FOR THE RECORD IS THE
WORST CASE OUTCOME IS A
CONSERVATORSHIP WHERE'S AND
COLLABORATIVE COURTS YOU MAY END
UP BEING BACK IN A COUPLE
JUSTICE SYSTEM JUDICIAL COMMIT
JUST SYSTEM AND CAN POTENTIALLY
BE INCARCERATED THAT'S A
DIFFERENCE OF THE COURT CANNOT
AS I MENTIONED ORDER MEDICATION
THE COURT CANNOT ORDER
INCARCERATION BUT THE COURT CAN
FOR EXAMPLE- SUPERVISE IN ORDER
SOME OF THE ANCILLARY SERVICES
THAT SUPPORT. THE CARE COURTS SO
OUT I'LL NOW DEFERRED TO A JUDGE
MANLEY THAN TO- DOCTOR GALLEY
THEY WISH TO ADD. JUDGE'S ORDER
HONOR. MODERATOR IS THEN IT IS-
JUDGE FAMILY STILL ON THE LINE
CAN YOU CONFIRM. IT LOOKS LIKE
THE JUDGE DISCONNECTED CUT THAT
DR KELLY TO JEWISH DATING. WELL
THANK YOU DR KELLY THAT'S THE
FIRST TIME EVER ONCE ANYONE'S
EVER SAID THAT SINCE I'VE BEEN A
LEGISLATURE OF- I GUESS MY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS AGAIN IT'S
THIS. CONSTITUTIONAL QUESTION
THAT'S NOT REALLY FLESHED OUT IS
THAT IF SOMEBODY IS
INCAPACITATED AND THEY YOU KNOW
THEY- ASSUMING MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE HAVEN'T REACHED THAT
INCAPACITATION SO THERE- THERE
IF THEY BREACH IT THEN WE HAVE
SOME CONSTITUTIONAL TRIGGERS
THAT WILL GO IN BUT IF THEY
HAVEN'T HOW DOES THE COURT.
ORDER A TREATMENT PLAN AND HOW
TO HAVE IT WHAT'S THE FORCE OF
THE LAW TO DO THAT. I SO THE
COLLABORATION COMES FROM A CASE
MANAGER FROM UP A PROFESSIONAL
FROM THE SUPPORTER WITH THE
JUDGE IN THE AND THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER IT'S- IT SHOULD BE AS
IT'S REFERRED TO AS IT LIKE IT'S
AN AGREEMENT SO WHILE THE JUDGE
CAN'T ORDER THE PERSON THIS IN
IT WHAT THE SYSTEM THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS AN AFFECT WHAT
THE WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS
ASKING FOR MORE COLLABORATION
MORE TOUCHES TO THAT PORTION
MORE ENGAGEMENT WITH THAT PERSON
THAT YOU'RE NOT JUST BEFORE A
JUDGE WITH THE SENTENCE ARE
GOING TO BE. HELD AGAINST YOUR
WILL OR NOT IT IS A
COLLABORATION AND IF IT'S A IF
IT'S A FAMILY MEMBER THAT WANTS
TO BE THAT SUPPORTER THAT CAN
HAPPEN AS WELL AND IT MISS PAID
IF THEY IF THEY DO NOT GO ALONG
THAT WOULD BE A- A FAIRLY PER
PERHAPS AT THAT LEVEL OF
TREATMENT WHICH THEN THE PERSON
WOULD COULD POTENTIALLY COME IN
THROUGH A DIFFERENT DOOR AS I
SAID BEFORE THIS IS A DIFFERENT
ON RAMP TO OUR SYSTEM SO IN THIS
ONE THERE WAS MORE FRONT AND
COLLABORATION TO GET AGREEMENT
WITH THAT PERSON AND THEN FOLLOW
UP TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE ABLE TO
FOLLOW THROUGH. IF THE
OPPOSITION MOST OF WHAT THEY SAY
YOU NEED MORE ENGAGEMENT MORE
COLLABORATION IN FACT THIS IS
WHAT THIS IS TO KIND OF GET
PEOPLE THERE VERSUS JUST SAYING
DO IT AND THEN HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE FOR OUTCOMES THEY
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE ON
THEIR OWN. SENATOR AWESOME THANK
YOU- AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS AND EVERYBODY WHO'S PUT
IN THEIR TWO CENTS A TO FIGURE
THIS OUT AYE AYE I WISH WE ALL
HAD CLEARER ANSWERS WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR RIGHT
CLEAR CUT AND- IT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THERE ARE
THOSE WHO ARE. THE WINNERS.
BECAUSE THIS IS A TWEENER BILL.
IT IS NEITHER FORCING AS I
UNDERSTAND IT NEITHER COMPLETELY
FORCING NOR IS IT SORT OF
COMPLETELY. ALLOWING YOU- TO
CONTINUE THE BILL AND THE
CONDITIONS THAT YOU'RE IN SO
THAT REALLY MAKES IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT- SO I JUST HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS BUT- ONE IS. IF THE
TARGETED- MEN AND WOMEN THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. IF THEY LACK
MEDICAL DECISION MAKING IF THEY
LACK THE CAPACITY. HOW DO AT THE
SAME TIME- FIND THAT THEY'RE
CAPABLE OF AGREEING TO THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT OR A
TREATMENT PLAN. HI MAKE THAT
WORK THAT THE DOCTOR GOAL IS
GOING TO TAKE THAT. GREAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
ADDRESS THIS QUESTION FIRST-
FIRST OFF THE PROCESS THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED ALLOWS FOR- WIDE
ARRAY OF PETITIONERS INCLUDING
FAMILY MEMBERS CLINICIANS OTHER
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE TO REALLY
ALLOW US TO. HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE SUFFERING
DEEPLY MAYBE WHO DON'T HAVE A
FAMILY MEMBER AT THEIR SIDE
WHO'VE LOST THEIR COMMUNITY FOR
ONE REASON OR ANOTHER TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO
RECEIVE THE FULL SET OF SERVICES
AND I'LL REMIND YOU THE CARE
PLAN REALLY HAS THREE
COMPONENTS. IT'S A TREATMENT
TEAM. SO A GROUP OF PEOPLE
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES SHOW US
THAT GROUPS OF CLINICIANS THAT
COME TOGETHER TO WRAP THEMSELVES
AROUND. INDIVIDUALS WITH SEVERE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS TO
BETTER. SECOND PIECES
MEDICATIONS WE KNOW THAT OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF DECADES WE
HAVE DEVELOPED BETTER.
MEDICATIONS FOR EXACTLY THE
CONDITIONS THAT ARE PLANNED AND-
IDENTIFIED FOR CARE COURT AND
THOSE MEDICATIONS OFTEN. CAN BE
GIVEN AS SINGLE INJECTIONS FOR
OVER TWO WEEKS OR A ONE ONCE A
MONTH AND INJECTION THAT DON'T
REQUIRE YOU TO SEE. DIRECTLY
OBSERVED THERAPY OF DAILY
TREATMENTS AND LOCKS OR OTHER
CONFINED SETTINGS SO IT ALLOWS
US TO DO THE THIRD PIECE WHICH
IS FOCUSED ON THE HOUSING PLAN
RUN COMMUNITY BASED HOUSING THAT
CAN MEAN MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
COULD MEAN HI DONNA FIND A
FAMILY MEMBER A LOVED ONE WHO
FEELS MORE EMPOWERED MORE
SUPPORTED TO ALLOW SOMEBODY
WHO'S IN THE PROCESS OF RECOVERY
AND HEALING TO BE AT HOME OR IT
COULD BE A COMMUNITY BASED
SUPPORT OF HOUSING UNIT. IT
COULD BE IN CERTAIN HIGH QUALITY
BOARDING CARE UNITS IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE WE HOPE TO
SEE THE LEVEL OF HOUSING AND THE
AVAILABILITY INVESTMENTS THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS MADE THE
LEGISLATURE IS MADE OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS THAT IS
PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET. REALLY
ANCHOR AND BUILD THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THAT HOUSE SO THAT SUITE OF
SERVICES- BECAUSE OF IMPORTANT
FEEDBACK FROM EXACTLY THE
PARTNERS IN ADVOCATES WHO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH. THIS BILL HAS
A OUR ENGAGEMENT PERIOD IT'S
CALLED THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
PERIOD FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN
WHO DO NOT- DO NOT LACK SO OF
SUCH SIGNIFICANT CAPACITY AND
JUDGMENT CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
ABLE TO. PARTICIPATE IN THE
CREATION OF THE PLAN AND IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY ON
THE PARTICIPANT WE'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT THAT TODAY BUT THERE'S
A STRONG ETHICAL COUNT ABILITY
ON GOVERNMENT WHETHER THAT'S
LOCAL COUNTY GOVERNMENT WHETHER
THAT'S ON. CITIES AND OTHERS WHO
HAVE FOR I NEED FOR HOUSE. TO
COME TOGETHER AND DELIVER A PAIR
PLAN COMMITMENT IN THE CAN. OVER
TIME TO INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
SUFFERING SO THE FOCUS OF THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT PERIOD THAT
ENGAGEMENT PERIOD IS TO BRING-
BRING TOGETHER A CLIENT WITH THE
WHOLE SUITE OF GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES THAT SHOULD BE SERVING
THEM WITH. MEDICAID REIMBURSABLE
SERVICES HOUSING AND A
SUPPORTIVE SETTING SO THAT WE
HAVE THE PROMISE THAT WE SHOULD
BE MAKING TO THESE INDIVIDUALS
FOR YEARS BEFORE NOW. AND WE
HOPE TODAY IS THE BEGINNING OF
MAKING THAT COMMITMENT IN A
STRONG SOLID WAY IF IN THE END
THAT ENGAGEMENT SETTLEMENT
PERIOD IS NOT ENOUGH. THE COURT
WILL HAVE TO THE CORK CARE CORE
PROCESS MORE OUR ENGAGEMENT AND
OVERSIGHT OVER ENSURING BOTH
PARTIES MEET THE FULL GLORY OF
THAT PLAN OVER THE COURSE OF
THAT FULL YEAR WITH THE ELECTION
OF A SECOND YEAR IF THAT'S
APPROPRIATE. THANK ONE MORE SURE
BUT ONE MORE QUESTION IS- WHY
NOT OR IS THERE WAIT FOR SOMEONE
TO OFTEN. TO THIS ON THEIR OWN
WITHOUT BEING RIGHT HAVE YOUR
DISHES AMONG SOMEONE CANNOT THEM
I MEAN SOMEONE CAN FOR EXAMPLE
IN ESSENCE SELF REFER IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY DR KELLY
SHAKING HIS HEAD IN THE
AFFIRMATIVE YEAH OKAY OKAY SO
THEY THEY GOT CAN OKAY. AND I'M
SORRY JUST ONE MORE ON THE
HOUSING ISSUE THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP BY A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
I THINK DR KELLY STARTED TO TALK
ABOUT THAT- THAT THERE MAY BE
HOUSING OF A FAMILY MEMBER HAS.
COULD YOU JUST EXPLAIN THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT'S THAT CAME UP- BY
OPPOSITION A NUMBER OF TIMES AND
WE KNOW WE ARE WOEFULLY. YOU
KNOW BEHIND ON THE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE HOUSING SO- FIRST OFF
THE HOUSING PLAN COMPONENT. OF
CARE COURT IS MEANT TO BE BROAD
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE NEEDS OF
INDIVIDUALS IT'S THERE'S NO ONE
SIZE FITS ALL. SOMEBODY MIGHT
HAVE A VERY APPROPRIATE
ACCESSIBLE OUR ABILITY TO LIVE
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER WE DON'T
WANT TO TAKE THAT AWAY AND
SUGGEST A DIFFERENT OPTION IS
BETTER. BUT IN THAT CONTINUUM OF
HOUSING OPTIONS INCLUDES HOUSING
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER A COMMUNITY
MEMBER ALL THE WAY TO PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR MORE-
SERVICE ENRICHED HOUSING WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES IF
THAT IS WHAT'S APPROPRIATE. WHAT
IS CALLED IN THE PLAN AND WHAT
HAS BEEN BACKED BY RESOURCES
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
INCLUDING A PROPOSAL FOR ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION THIS YEAR.
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BRIDGE
HOUSING TO SUPPORT EXACTLY THE
POPULATION CARE COURT MIND. I
KNOW THAT WE TALK DAILY ABOUT
THE BREADTH AND DEPTH OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SEVEN
TO TWELVE THOUSAND OF THE MOST
AT RISK SIX CALIFORNIANS WE CAN
MEET THEIR HOUSING NEEDS WITH
THOSE RESOURCES IT'S GONNA TAKE
PRIORITIZATION. IT'S GONNA TAKE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE
APPROPRIATESENTENCE BUT WE CAN
DO IT WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SOLVING EVERY FACE OF THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT SOLVING ONE OF THE
MOST CURABLE- A HEARTBREAKING
FRANKLY COMPONENTS OF THIS
ISSUE. I WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ARE
SOME OF THE STORIES OF
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE CLEARLY LACK
SOME OF THE DECISION MAKING AN
INSIGHT CHALLENGES THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT AND WE CAN DO
BETTER. AND SO THE HOUSING
COMPONENT YES IT'S A CHALLENGE
TO HOUSE EVERY CALIFORNIA WE
KNOW THAT BUT SEVEN TO TWELVE
THOUSAND ESTIMATED ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM WE CAN DO THAT IN
THIS PROGRAM IS COMMITTED. TO
HELPING MAKE THAT. IF I COULD
HAVE THING WE REFER SOMETHING
FAMILY. BECAUSE MOST FOLKS SOME
KIND OF FAMILY IN IN THEIR LIFE
WHO HAVE HAD TO SET REAL LIMITS
OR BOUNDARIES AND YOU CAN'T
CONTINUE TO STAY HERE IF YOU
DON'T COMPLY SO HAVING THIS.
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS GIVES A
FAMILY MEMBER- MORE EASE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO TAKE THAT PERSON
AND KEEP THEM THERE AND HAVE
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
AND FORTH WITH- AND THEN JUST TO
THAT SEVEN TO TWELVE IT IS A
SMALL. DEMOGRAPHIC IT IS A SMALL
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE AND RIGHT NOW
WE'RE JUST ASKING THOSE WHO ARE
THE MOST SIX SUMMER STREET TO
GET IN LINE WITH EVERYBODY ELSE
FOR A SECTION EIGHT VOUCHER AND
THAT'S JUST NOT FAIR. I JUST
WANNA SAY. REALLY THE WITNESSES
YOUR YOUR WORK-AND DOCTOR
GALLEONS AND JUDGE MANLEY- THESE
ARE REALLY TOUGH DECISIONS THAT
WORLD BEING. YOU KNOW. ESTIMATE
AND- WE DON'T UNDERSTAND.
EXACTLY HOW EVERYTHING IS GOING
TO REALLY WORK OUT. RAST TO TAKE
A- LEAP OF FAITH HERE- WERE
ASKED TO- MAKE A DECISION THAT.
MIGHT VIOLATE WHAT WE ALWAYS
BELIEVE IT RIGHT THE FREEDOMS-
AND THE CIVIL LIBERTIES THAT WE
ALL BELIEVE IN- SO. I JUST WANNA
SAY IN MAKING THIS DECISION IT'S
TOUGH BUT IT'S TOUGHER TO SEE-
HUMAN BEANS ON THE STREET LIKE
THAT- BUT IT IS ASKING US TO
TAKE A LEAP OF FAITH AND I'M
GLAD THAT YOU HAVE EXPERT
WITNESSES. WHO CAN TALK ABOUT
THIS TO THE DEGREE THAT WE CAN
OKAY I'M I'M RIGHT HERE I'M IN
BETWEEN I'M BEING ASKED TO MAKE
THIS DECISION. THAT'S DIFFICULT
BUT- I'M GLAD WE HAVE THE
WITNESSES THAT WE CAN RELY ON TO
HELP WITH TILT IN THAT DIRECTION
SO- MORE THAN ANYTHING I
APPRECIATE ALL THE EFFORT THAT'S
GOING INTO IT SO. I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENEGAL'S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I ADD TO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO BOTH THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION AGAIN HAS BEEN STATED
MANY MANY TIMES BY MY COLLEAGUES
IS NOT AN EASY- DECISION TO MAKE
AND I TAKE- EVERYONE'S TESTIMONY
WITH- COMPLETE OF RESPECT AND I
ALSO JUST WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY AGAIN FOR. PROVIDING
THEIR COMMENTARY BECAUSE THIS IS
GOING TO BE A AS OF THE WORK IN
PROGRESS THAT I LOOK FOR TO
LEANING IN ON- REPRESENTING A
VERY LARGE CITY THE SECOND
LARGEST CITY IN L. A. COUNTY
LONG BEACH THAT HAS ITS OWN
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND ALSO- MANY
SOUTHEAST CITIES- IN AND AROUND
ONE LOS ANGELES. SO HAVE A QUICK
COUPLE OF QUICK QUESTIONS AND
THE ONE FIVE LOTS OF- OF COURSE
CONCERNS BROUGHT BROUGHT BY THE
OPPOSITION AND IN VARIOUS
DEGREES BUT WANTED OF WHICH IS
THE PRESUMPTION CONCERN ON NON
COMPLIANCE AND I JUST WANT TO
KNOW YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON THAT
AND THEN SECONDLY BROUGHT UP
ANOTHER VALID CONCERN NOT
NECESSARILY WITHIN THE- YOU KNOW
PER VIEW LET'S SAY OF THE
JUDICIARY BUT- THE RACIAL
INEQUITY CONCERNS BECAUSE THOSE
ARE JUST CONCERNS OBVIOUSLY-
UNFORTUNATELY THE DATA SHOWS
THAT. THERE MAY BE MORE
MISDIAGNOSIS- FOR SCHIZOPHRENIA-
PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS FOR FOLKS
THAT IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
HOW WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING
THROUGH THAT AND I THINK IT THE
LEAST THIS WOULD LIFT UP THOSE
ISSUES SO WE CAN DISCUSS THEM
GREATER- IN A GREATER. WAY DR
KELLY WILL TO THIS BUT I JUST
ALL. THE TO GO BACK TO THE ISSUE
OF THE DIAGNOSIS THAT'S ME
OFTENTIMES AT THIS LEVEL THE
GOAL IS IN AGAIN THE MONEY WE
PUT IN FOR- TO STAND UP A WHOLE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLATFORM FOR
CHILDREN ZERO TO TWENTY SIX TO
BE ABLE TO GET AN EVALUATION.
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WILL
ADDRESS THE LONG STANDING ISSUES
THE- OF RACIAL EQUITY THIS IS
NOT A NEW ISSUE THIS IS NOT AN
ISSUE THAT WE'RE SURPRISED THAT
WE SEE ON THE STREETS THIS IS AN
ISSUE OF ACCESS AND EQUITY OVER
GENERATIONS. AND SO THE EARLIER
THAT WE START INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENTS THE LESS OF THAT
DISPARITY THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE. YEAH- LET ME SAY A COUPLE
THINGS FIRST THANK YOU FOR
REALLY LIFTING UP THE WORK THAT
WE NEED TO DO FURTHER UPSTREAM
YOU CANNOT SEE CARE COURT IN
ISOLATION IF ALL OF THE OTHER
WORK. THAT IS HAPPENING LARGELY
BY PEOPLE THAT WERE WORKING
CLOSELY WITHIN COMMUNITIES. THE
FUNDING COMES THROUGH THE STATE
THE LEGISLATURE ME TO SAY OTHER
FUNDING FOR MEDIC. CADE SERVICES
REALIGNMENT DOLLARS THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT YET. WE
HAVE SUCH A CHALLENGE AND IT WAS
EXACERBATED DURING THE PANDEMIC
BUT IF YOU TRY. TO LOOK AT CARE
COURT IN ISOLATION OF EVERYTHING
YOU WILL GET A COMPLETE OR AN
INCOMPLETE PICTURE. IMMEDIATELY
THAT IS I THINK ONE POINT. THE
SECOND THING IS MY EXPERIENCE IN
THE SPACE AND L. A. COUNTY. OUR
TEAM. ARE LARGELY THROUGH
WORKING WITH DIVERSION PROGRAMS
WORKING WITH COURTS. THAT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
SYSTEM WE HAVE IN THE COMMUNITY.
HAS BECOME THE PLACE WHERE SO
MANY PEOPLE WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS GET. YOURS AGO WHEN I
MET JUDGES AND ONLY. THEY WOULD
SAY A FULL 30% OF MY DOCKET. IS
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BUT THAT WAS WIDESPREAD
EVERY COURT THROUGHOUT THAT
LARGE COUNTY I'M SURE THAT
SHARED ACROSS THE STATE. JUDGE
MERELY WE'RE HERE IF OU COULD
VERIFY THAT BUT THE EXPECTATION.
THAT ARE SO MANY INDIVIDUALS
TODAY. WHO ARE EITHER
MISDIAGNOSED MISLABELED OR A
PROPERLY DIAGNOSED ONLY AFTER
THEY ENCOUNTER THE CRIMINAL
SYSTEM. END UP IN OUR JAILS AND
PRISONS AND TO GO UPSTREAM FOR
THAT POPULATION. OFFERS
SOMETHING LIKE THE CHARACTER
MODEL CIVIL PROCESS ONE THAT
LOOKS AT ENGAGEMENT FIRST LOOKS
AT. REALLY BUILDING A
COLLABORATIVE CARE PLAN
INITIALLY. BUT WE KNOW THAT
ISN'T GOING TO WORK FOR
EVERYONE. AND SOME PEOPLE WILL
NEED THE SUPPORT NOT JUST FOR
THEM BUT TO MAKE SURE THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
FUNDED TO SUPPORT THEM. ARE ABLE
TO COLLABORATE AND COMPLETE A
PLAN. THERE ARE DEEP INEQUITIES
IN OUR SYSTEM. WE ARE AWARE OF
THOSE WE DO A LOT IN CALIFORNIA
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THEM YET WE
SEE THEM PERSISTING. CONTINUE WE
NEED A NEW WAY. CARE CORD ISN'T
IGN TO THOSE THERE WILL BE
INVESTMENTS IN EVALUATION AND A
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THAT WE PAY
ATTENTION TO THOSE ISSUES BUT
THE PRESENCE OF THOSE ISSUES.
CANNOT BECOME OUR EXCUSE TO NOT
TO TRY TO DO MORE WE NEED TO DO
BUT- THEY ARE NOT INDEPENDENT WE
NEED TO WORK ON IMPROVING THOSE
ISSUES ADDRESSING THEM. THROUGH
THE INVESTMENTS I MENTIONED IN
MAKING SURE. THAT THE SUPPORTER
ROLE WHICH IS A KEY COMPONENT OF
THIS PLAN. REFLECTS AND SUPPORTS
THE INDIVIDUAL WHOEVER THEY MAY
BE. AND UNDERSTANDS THEIR WISHES
OVERTIME AND COMMUNICATES THOSE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE PART
OF THE CARE PLAN SO I THINK
THOSE PIECES NEVER A PERFECT
ANSWER. BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
WORKING PROGRESS ON THIS BUT I
THINK CALIFORNIA. IN THIS BILL-
ARE KEEPS A FRIEND OF MINE IT
WILL MAKE AND CONTINUE TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH LARGE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE. MANY HERE TODAY MANY OUT
AROUND OUR STATE TO MAKE SURE WE
DO THAT THE RIGHT WAY. THANK YOU
. THANK YOU AND THEN JUST THE
LAST FEW SOME PRESUMPTION AND-
SORRY DR KELLY THANK YOU. I'M
THE PEACE AROUND PRESUMPTION SO
ARE THE BELIEF IS THAT THROUGH
THE CARE CORE PROCESS LEAD OVER
THE COURSE OF OUR MAMA INDEED
NOT AGGRESSIVE BUT CERTAINLY
CONSISTENT ENGAGEMENT THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BRING PEOPLE
FORWARD AND A COMMITMENT TO
DELIVER A FULL SUITE OF SERVICES
THAT WE KNOW ARE EVIDENCE BASED
AND CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE. I
WOULD THAT OUR IS NOT ENOUGH WE
KNOW THAT INDIVIDUALS WILL
RETURN TO SETTINGS WHERE THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO SUFFER AND
DECOMPENSATED AND THAT IDEA THAT
THE EXPERIENCE IN THE CARE COURT
MODEL IF NOT EFFECTIVE SHOULDN'T
BE IGNORED AND SHOULD BE USED IN
THE CASE THAT SOMEBODY COMES
AGAIN TO THE HOSPITAL OR IS IN
ANOTHER SETTING AND THIS IDEA
THAT- WE HAVE TO START FROM
SCRATCH EVERY IME. DOESN'T
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND THEN WE
HAVE O TAKE INTO ACCOUNT PRIOR
ATTEMPTS IN PRIOR WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT IF IT'S APPROPRIATE TO
GO DOWN A CONSERVATORSHIP
PATHWAY THE BIG CARE COURT
EXPERIENCES AT LEAST ACCOUNTED
FOR SO THAT PRESUMPTION IS
REALLY ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE
TAKE WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IN THE
PROCESS THERE WERE HONEST AND
TRUE ABOUT THAT BUT THERE WE ARE
DON'T FORGET IT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD TO TRY TO DELIVER AND
SERVE INDIVIDUALS. AND OTHER
SETTINGS IF THAT'S. THE ONLY
TOOLS THAT WE HAVE LEFT FOR US.
WELL FOR YOU OF THE THREE OF YOU
FOR- THIS DIALOGUE AND I KNOW
WILL CONTINUE TO DISCUSS EVEN
WARNED WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT- SEEING NO
OTHER- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO COMMENT ON SANDERS
NUMBER EGGMAN WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. BOB THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF THE FIRST WELL THANK
YOU TO THE PROPONENTS THANK YOU
DR KELLY THE TICKET THANKS TO MY
JOINT AUTHORS CENTER EGGMAN WHO
IS THE ACKNOWLEDGED CHAMPION
WITH RESPECT TO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BASED ON EXPERIENCE IN
AND PASSION HERE SO THANK YOU
CENTER EGGMAN UP A COUPLE OF THE
POINTS LET ME LET ME JUST SPEAK
TO THE OPPONENTS YOUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE IS VERY IMPORTANT- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- YOUR LIVED
EXPERIENCE WILL HELP TO INFORM
THIS PROCESS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
YOUR LIVED EXPERIENCE IN THE
LIVED EXPERIENCES SO MANY
FAMILIES. IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ADDRESS IT IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THE
CONCERN ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
NEW SOMETHING BOLD SOMETHING
DIFFERENT IS LEGITIMATE AND WE
AS WE MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
WE'RE GONNA LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU- BUT OUR GOAL
IS THE SAME WE HAVE THE SAME
GOAL THAT YOU HAVE- AND I THINK
WE'RE GONNA GET THERE TOGETHER
SO WITH THAT I'D ORIGINAL VOTE
SORRY OKAY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
WE HAD A- EARLY MOTION BY
SENATOR WIENER BONTA ON S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND
BELIEVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH CHIEF
COUNSEL IN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATORS EGGMAN AND-
BURKE. WITH A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER THE MOTION AS STATED TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AMBERG.
UMBERG I BOARD YES. CABALLERO
THE RUSSELL THE RUSSELL I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES AYARD STERN WAKE HOUSEKI
WIENER SAFARI OF THREE DESIRO
ALL RIGHT WE WILL PUT THIS BILL
ON CALL BECAUSE IT'S ONE OF
THOSE LEGISLATIVE DAYS. ALL
RIGHT MOVING ON TO THE NEXT-
MATTERS JUST TO GIVE A PREVIEW
PREVIEW WE WILL NEXT TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN GO OUT
OF ORDER TO FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
S. B. EIGHT FOUR SEVEN BY
SENATOR HER TADO- SO LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. AS
THE CHAIR. TAKES OVER
RESPONSIBILITIES AGAIN.
THANK YOU- VICE CHAIR BOARD JUST
ALL RIGHT. OKAY TODAY IS A BUSY
LEGISLATIVE DAY SO AS YOU'LL
NOTE THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE THAT ARE MOVING IN AND
OUT- CENTER TITLES HERE BUT
BEFORE WE BEGIN CENTER DOT ORG A
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS S. B.
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO WAS PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR FROM TODAY'S AGENDA
SO IF YOU'RE WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN TWELVE EIGHTY TWO. THAT WILL
NOT BE HEARD TODAY S. B. ONE ONE
ONE EIGHT ELEVEN EIGHTEEN HAS
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA IT WILL BE SET
FOR MAY THE THIRD I BELIEVE THAT
SENATOR BOARD THIS IS BILL- AND
THEN- LET'S MOVE TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS THERE BEEN A MOTION. BOB
MOVED BY CENTER BORDERS. MANAGE
ACCOUNTS OF YOUR CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR UMBERG I
AM BURKE I BORGIAS OR JUST AYE
CABALLERO DRESSEL THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES LAYERED STERN WHITE HOUSE
SKI WINNER YOU HAVE FORTY ZERO
SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL NOW CENTER TOTAL ONE
LAST HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCED
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM CENTER TITLE
IS THAT AT NOON TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO BREAK FOR NINETY
MINUTES AND WE WILL RECONVENE AT
ONE THIRTY AM FOR YOU MILITARY
TYPES AS THIRTEEN THIRTY ALL
RIGHT. CENTER HER TADO THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING- I THINK IT'S MY FIRST
BILL INTRODUCTION AND THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE LAST THREE AND
A HALF YEARS BUT ANYWAYS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY I WOULD
LIKE TO FIRST A START BY SIFTING
AMENDMENTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH OUR
OFFICE. AND AS OF JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MORE THAN ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION HOMEOWNERS WERE
BEHIND ON THEIR MORTGAGES MANY
OF THESE HOMEOWNERS OWN RENTAL
PROPERTY WHEN FEDERAL MORTGAGE
FOR BANDS AND THEY MAY BE FORCED
TO REMOVE THE RENTAL UNTS FROM
THE MARKET SELL THEM IN ORDER TO
AVOID FORECLOSURE SB EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN ESTABLISHES A GRANT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THAT
ALLOWS FOR DISTRIBUTION OF
FUNDS. TO HOMEOWNERS APPLICANTS. UPON APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE. THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE PROGRAM USES FEDERAL
HOMEOWNER ASSISTANCE FUNDS TO
HELP HOME HOMEOWNERS GET. CAUGHT
UP ON THEIR HOUSING PAYMENTS BUT
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE HOMEOWNERS
WHO HAVE RENTAL PROPERTIES. THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM PROVIDED FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION TO CALIFORNIA
TO PAY RENT FOR SOME LOW INCOME
TENANTS WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PAY THE RENT DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. BUT IT DOES NOT
INCLUDE ALL RENTERS. WE DO HAVE
TENANTS IN CALIFORNIA WERE
BEHIND ON THEIR RENT BUT WILL
NOT RECEIVE GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE BECAUSE WHAT. THEY
MAKE FALLS JUST ABOVE THE
EXISTING THRESHOLD FOR THOSE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM. THIS LEAVE THE OWNERS
OF THE RENTAL PROPERTY WHO
SOMETIMES ARE STILL PAYING OFF
THE MORTGAGE ON THAT PROPERTY
STRUGGLING THEMSELVES. SB EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT FOUR SEVEN CLOSES THE
GAP FOR TENANTS AND HOMEOWNERS
WHO HAVE APPLIED AND BEEN
REJECTED FROM THE STATE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. ENSURING
NEEDED RENTAL UNITS STAY IN THE
MARKET AND PEOPLE DO NOT LOSE
THE ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS. AND
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE THREE
WITNESSES. A JOINING US IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OUR FIRST ONE
IS ON THE SHOP. SMALL RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNER A SECOND
WITNESSES CHARLOTTE STONE A
NOTHER SMALL PROPERTY HOMEOWNER.
AND WE ALSO HAVE A WITNESS ONLY
HERE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND THAT'S DEBRA CARLTON WITH
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION. AMISHA
IF. GO AHEAD. THE SHOP CLOSURES
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS ON THE
SHINE I'M HERE WITH MY HUSBAND
OF NASHA. WE OWN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND HAD A
HORRENDOUS EXPERIENCE WITH
TENANTS WHO REFUSED TO PAY RENT
FOR NEARLY TWO YEARS WHY THEY
WERE SUBLETTING OUR PROPERTY ON
AIRBNB AGAINST THE LEASE
AGREEMENT. ALAMEDA COUNTY'S
LOCAL MORATORIUM PROHIBITED
EVERY ACTION EVEN WHEN TENANTS
HAVE BEEN DEFRAUDING THEIR
LANDLORDS AND THEY REFUSED- ANY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AS WELL. WE
ORIGINALLY PURCHASED OUR HOME TO
BE OUR PRIMARY RESIDENCE. WE
ONLY DECIDED TO RENT IT OUT Y.
V. WERE- COMPLETING OUR OWN
RENTAL OBLIGATION TO OUR LAND
LINE. OUR PLAN WAS TO MOVE INTO
OUR HOME RIGHT AFTER. TO OUR
HORRIFIC SURPRISE OUR TENANTS
CLEAN HARDSHIP STOPPING RENT-
EVEN THOUGH THEY WERE MAKING
MONEY OFF OUR PROPERTY BY
RENTING IT OUT ON AIRBNB. AS OF
THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH THE AIRBNB
GUESTS REFUSED TO MOVE OUT AND
THE ORDERS NO TENANTS IN P.
ABANDONED THE HOME AFTER A
DISPUTE WITH THE AIRBNB GUESS.
ALAMEDA COUNTY'S LOCAL
MORATORIUM PROHIBITED US FROM
EVICTING TENANTS AND THE AIRBNB
GUESTS AND EVEN IN THIS
SITUATION. BY THE TIME THE
AIRBNB GUEST ABANDONED OUR HOME
B. HAD BEEN FINANCIALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY DRAINED. WE ENDED UP
WITH NOT ONLY RENTAL LOSSES THAT
AMOUNT TO FIFTY K. BUT ALSO A
HOUSE THAT WAS COMPLETELY
TRASHED. IT COST AS AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY GET TO MAKE IT
HABITABLE. OUR FAMILY MY HUSBAND
AND I WE IMMIGRATED HERE WITH A
FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS WORKED VERY
HARD. SAVED UP FOR A FINANCIALLY
SECURE FUTURE FOR US AND OUR
KIDS. WOULD BE ENDED UP HOUSING
PEOPLE FOR FREE OF FOR OVER TWO
YEARS AND BEARING HUGE LOSSES
NORTH OF HUNDRED GATE WHY WE
CONTINUE TO PAY MORTGAGE AND
PROPERTY TAXES ON THE PROPERTY
WE COULDN'T EVEN. THIS IS THE
STORY OF MANY OTHER SMALL
LANDLORDS A MOM AND POP AND I
LOOKS LIKE US. PLEASE WAIT YES
TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MICHELLE I'M SORRY FOR YOUR
HARDSHIP. BOB ALL RIGHT- SHOWED
STONE IF. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CHARLOTTE STONE IN THEM
SINGLE OWNER OF PROPERTY LOS
ANGELES AFTER YEARS OF HARD WORK
I WAS ABLE TO PURCHASE A RENTAL
PROPERTY AS AN INVESTMENT IN MY
RETIREMENT AND WITH THE HOPES TO
ONE DAY ABLE TO CARE FOR MY
AGING PARENTS. MY TENANT HAS NOT
PAID RENT FOR RENT FOR OVER TWO
YEARS AND AS OF TODAY OWES
OVERSIGHT SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
AND RENTS. THE LAW THE LOS
ANGELES PROHIBITS ME FROM FILING
AN EVICTION AGAINST HIM DURING
THIS TIME I'VE CONTINUE TO PAY
MORTGAGE MY MORTGAGE PAYMENTS
AND PROPERTY TAXES BUT THIS
BECOME A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. AS
SOON AS THE HOUSING IS KEY.
PROGRAM WAS UP OPERATIONAL I
APPLIED FOR RENT RELIEF DOLLARS
AFTER MANY FORMAL WRITTEN
NOTICES TO THE TENANTS ASKING
THAT HE APPLY I RECEIVED NO
RESPONSE HE DID EVENTUALLY APPLY
BUT I WAS UNAWARE OF HIS
APPLICATION BECAUSE HE FAILED TO
INFORM ME. AND THE HOUSING IS
KEY SYSTEM DID NOT LINK OUR
APPLICATIONS. WHEN I WAS FINALLY
ABLE TO SPEAK TO A HOUSING IS
KEY ADMINISTRATOR I WAS INFORMED
THAT THE HOUSING IS KEY- PROCESS
HAD SENT A CHECK DIRECTLY.
DIRECTLY TO THE- OR FORTY ONE.
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
THAT HAPPENED ON OCTOBER TWENTY
NINTH. TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AS OF
TODAY THE TENANT HAS NOT PAID
THOSE DOLLARS TO ME AS REQUIRED
BY LAW. I REPORTED THIS TO THE
FRAUD UNIT AND IT IS CURRENTLY
UNDER INVESTIGATION. THE FRAUD
UNIT AT. THE FRAUD UNIT IT IS
HAS NOT I HAVE NOT HEARD FROM
THEM NOR HAVE I HEARD FROM THE
TENANT. WHO CONTINUES TO LIVE IN
THE PROPERTY AND NOT PAY RENT.
THE TENANT IS THE SUCCESSFUL
SCREENPLAY WRITER FILMMAKER
DIRECTOR PRODUCER AND LECTURER.
HIS MOVIES HAVE TAKEN IN OVER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN THEIR
OPENING WEEKS. HE HAS ENOUGH
MONEY TO HIRE AN ATTORNEY WHO
HAS CLAIMED THAT MY FORMAL
WRITTEN A REQUEST FOR PAYMENT OF
RENT IS HARASSMENT. LET ME BE
CLEAR I HAD NOT CALLED HIM AT
ODD HOURS I HAVEN'T KNOCKED ON
HIS DOOR HAVE NOT ACCOSTED HIM
ON THE STREET. I SIMPLY HAVE
ASKED TO THE FORMAL STATE
REQUIRED NOTICE PROCESS THAT HE
FILED FOR RATE RELIEF AND PAY
THOSE DOLLARS TO ME. HE HAS
REFUSED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU VOTE AYE ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISSED ON. ALL RIGHT
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT SB EIGHT FOUR SEVEN OR
HERE IN THE ROOM IF YOU APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. I SEE. MISS TOP
BY SEA. GO AHEAD. A DIFFICULT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MORAN. MISTER
MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH THEIR ARENA
SO SEATS REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SINGH KNOWN APPROACHING
MICROPHONE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
FEW OF THOSE IN SUPPORT. OF S.
B. EIGHT FOUR SEVEN THEIR NAME
THEIR AFFILIATION. AND THEIR
POSITION. OF COURSE MY OPINION
IF YOU ARE AT THE CORE OF THIS
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THE
FIRST SUPPORT COMES FROM LINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING REBECA GONZALEZ OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
COMES FROM A LINE OF ONE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NUMBER THE PERFECT.
MURDER ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF CULTURE. THANK YOU ALL THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT COMES FROM A LINE
OF ONE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
THIS IS EDWIN FOR BONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF ONTARIO AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ENTERNEXT COME FROM LINE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRS CHRIS WORKING
WITH THE LOFT FIVE WITH BUSINESS
FEDERATION- IF SUPPORTERS S. B.
THE FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU. YEAH
THEY'RE CURRENTLY NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE ALL RIGHT NOW LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION I HAVE LISTED
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BRIAN AUGUSTA AND TINO SALAS MR
GUSTER. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS BY A GUEST ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YEAR OF OUR OUR CONCERNS ON THIS
BILL. FIRST ONE OUR KNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE DESCRIBED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND- IT SOUNDS LIKE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS ARE
FORTHCOMING FROM THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND SO I WILL NEED TO. WE
NEED TO REVIEW THOSE AND REVIEW
OUR POSITION IN LIGHT OF THAT
SIZE THAT STANDS NOW OUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND PRINT
IS THAT WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS ALL
EXPLAIN AND I ONE OF KNOWLEDGE.
OF THE HARDSHIP THAT THE TWO
PRIOR WITNESSES HAVE DESCRIBED I
THINK THE REAL QUESTION HERE IS
WHAT PROGRAM ARE WE GONNA CREATE
THE STATE LEVEL. THAT THAT
ADDRESSES. AND THAT'S IN THE
CONTEXT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE
JUST TO. OR SO WEEKS AGO THIS
COMMITTEE HEARD AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE AND THAT'S MISTER
GRAYSON AND BUSYWORK SPELL WHICH
ESSENTIALLY SIGNAL THE END OF-
THE STATE'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
RENTAL HOUSING- ASSISTANCE- THE
RAFT PROGRAM THAT WE'RE BRINGING
THAT PROGRAM TO AN END AND
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION IN
THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THAT THERE IS
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS. OF A OF A
BUREAUCRACY THAT IS HANDING OUT
HOURS AND WE HAVE NOT SOLVED THE
MANY BUREAUCRATIC HEADACHES
ABOUT TENANTS AND LANDLORDS ARE
EXPERIENCING. AND WE ALSO HAVE A
LOT OF IMPLICATIONS NUMBERS ARE
UP ON THE HIGHEST NOW DISCUSSED
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS FOR
VULNERABLE TENANTS WHO ARE GOING
TO BE LEFT BEHIND WE HAVE
DISPROPORTION OVER SPANISH
SPEAKING. ARE FOLKS WHO NEVER
GOT THROUGH THE DOOR AND THE
PROGRAM IS NOW CLOSER OF
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
ELDERLY FOLKS WHO NEVER GOT
THROUGH THE DOOR WE HAVE A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN LEFT BEHIND
BUT THE STATE HAS SIGNALED THAT
THEY'RE GETTING OUT OF THAT
PROGRAM. AND WE HAD ARGUED AS
MANY OF YOU HAVE THAT WE SHOULD
EXTEND THAT PROGRAM WHICH EXTEND
ITS PROTECTIONS WE SHOULD PUT
MORE STATE MONEY BEHIND IT AND
WE SHOULD CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THAT ASSISTANCE BUT- FOR TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE WITH THE ANSWER
THAT AND WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT SO
NOW TODAY WE'RE HERE TALKING
ABOUT STANDING UP A NEW PROGRAM
RELY ON THAT SAME BROKEN. I
SHOULD SAY TROUBLED. RECEIVE
THAT STRUGGLING AUGUST YOU'D GO
WRAP IT UP. THE USER. I WILL
JUST- NOTIFY THAT. ARE WE FEEL
LIKE THIS IN. WE INTERNAL OF
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL EVERY AT
VOTE DON'T ANSWER QUESTION FOR
TENANTS TO EXPERT. HARDSHIP AND
IS THIS WHERE WE WERE FOCUS.
THOSE ALL- I WILL WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO ON SOME OF THE
OTHER POINT. THAT I. AT THE
MOMENT WE REMAIN OPPOSED THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CUSTOM. ALL RIGHT. OF THIS
RESULT. NOW I'M NOT GONNA TAKE
THIS OFFICE GETS STUCK IN MY
HEARING. WELL I HAD THE PLEASURE
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING TRI
MEMBERS TO NORTH DALLAS WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY
RESPECTFULLY HAVE TO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. WE WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
BRAIN ACOSTA AND I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO EXTEND MY SYMPATHIES IN
MY EMPATHY IS. TO BE LANDLORDS
HERE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED THOSE
PARTICULAR HARDSHIPS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL THAT'S CURRENTLY
IN PRINT BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT BRAND REYES BUT ALSO
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE- YOUR
TECHNICAL ISSUES THAT WE'RE
SEEING SOME OF WHICH INCLUDE.
EXPANDING AN UNSPECIFIED AMOUNT
OF STATE RESOURCES. TO MAKE THE
LANDLORDS HOLD WHILE NOT. GOING
WITH THE GOAL OF THE EMERGENCY
RENTAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH
IS TO STABILIZE AND KEEP PENDANT
HOUSE. WE ALSO HAVE- SOME
CONCERNS WITH- SOME OF THE MEANS
TEST THAT I BELIEVE ARE GOING TO
BE ADDRESSED AND SOME OF THE
COMMENTS AND SO WE'LL HAVE TO
TAKE A STRONGER LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS TO SEE IF THEY ALIGN-
BUT REALLY THE GOAL WITH THE
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM THAT THIS BODY HAS
ALREADY DISCUSSED WAS TO KEEP
TENANTS HOUSE WHILE ALSO.
PROVIDING THE ASSISTANCE FOR THE
MOM AND POP LANDLORDS THAT
ACTUALLY NEED THE ASSISTANCE THE
CURRENT WAY THAT THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN IT DOES NOT HAVE THAT
SAME GOAL IN MIND. AND SO WITH
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
pOPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN OR PRESENT HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE. ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN. AND IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB EIGHT
FOUR SEVEN PLEASE GIVE YOUR NAME
FILIATION OF POSITION. IN THIS
CHAIR LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THE MOMENT. JUST NOW WILL
GET THE LINE NUMBERS. YEAH
THAT'S ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT. IT WILL START WITH LINE
ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD-
THIS BILL. GO THANK YOU. IT WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEANETTE
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. WE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN ALSO
KEEP. ALREADY THANK YOU MUCH- IS
A HOUSEKEEPING MATTER WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS HERE AT NOON BUT
IF CENTER LEYVA IS AVAILABLE WE
CAN TAKE UP HER MATTER- BEFORE
WE RECESS AT NOON ALL RIGHT
LET'S RETURN HERE TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENTER GONZALEZ. INSULAR
DRAW SO YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THINK YOU- CENTER HER
TADO FOR PRESENTATION- JUST A
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS- I
UNDERSTAND YOU TO TAKE AN
AMENDMENT THE LAST POINT OF THE
AMENDMENT IN THE ANALYSIS THE
STATE'S THAT. PREVENTS THE
RECIPIENT OF A GRANT UNDER THE
PROGRAM FOR A PERIOD TO BE
DETERMINED FROM PROCEEDING TO
EVICT THE TENANT WITHOUT AN OUT
FAULTS. BECAUSE IT'S IT DOESN'T
SEEM LIKE THAT'S- MAYBE THERE
CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT THAT THAT'S
SUFFICIENT ENOUGH FOR THE
OPPOSITION BUT- CAN YOU TELL ME
WHERE THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE AND-
WHERE WE'RE AT WE'RE OUT WITH
THAT SPECIFIC. AMENDMENT AND
WHAT ELSE MIGHT BE TO COME. IN
AND CHECK. YES THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE BUT THE REAL
QUESTION AND I'LL JUST SAY THAT-
TO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE-
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE- WORKED
WITH THIS COMMITTEE IT TO
ADDRESS THE- CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION- BUT I WILL. ALLOW
OUR EXPERT WITNESS TO COME UP TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENT
ON. THANK YOU. DISCOVER THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION I THINK
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS TO
FIND A AN APPROPRIATE TIME
PERIOD IN WHICH THE LANDLORD
WOULD NOT A VET. IF THEY HAVE
RECEIVED GRANT DOLLARS- WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS JUST A FEW
DAYS BEFORE THE ANALYSIS NEED TO
BE COMPLETE SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO SEE WHAT.
AMOUNT OF TIME IS FAIR WITH
OBVIOUSLY THE SITUATION HERE WE
HAVE A TENANT WHO ABSOLUTELY
REFUSED TO PARTICIPATE- DIDN'T
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT HIS ABILITY
SO WE HAD A LITTLE BIT OF A
DISAGREEMENT ON HOW LONG THAT
CAN CONTINUE TO STAY. SO WE WILL
WORK OUT THAT TIME PERIOD THOUGH
AND THAT IS PART OF THE-
COMMITMENT GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU Q. AND THEN- ANOTHER
QUESTION ON THE STATE DAHLER
ASKED BECAUSE I DON'T SEE AN
APPROPRIATION HERE BUT WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE AT THIS POINT-
WITH. THE DISCUSSIONS BEEN
AROUND THAT- THE DISCUSSIONS
HAVE BEEN AROUND OBVIOUSLY WOULD
BE A BUDGET REQUEST- WE HAVE
DONE SOME INTERNAL POLLING JUST
AMONGST OUR MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT
WERE ABOUT. A HUNDRED MILLION-
FROM OWNERS AND THESE ARE SMALL
LANDLORDS BECAUSE THEY WILL BE
PRIORITIZED WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
PAID- I THINK THE CHALLENGE FOR
US IS. THAT THE STATE MADE IT
VERY EASY FOR INDIVIDUALS TO
STATE THAT THEY COULDN'T PAY THE
TENANTS COULDN'T PAID SO.
LEGISLATION OR THE LOSS SAID
SIMPLY TELL US YOU CAN'T PAY AND
THAT'S WHAT HAS HAPPENED NOW
THAT THE TENANTS HAVE TO.
DEMONSTRATE THEIR INABILITY OF
PAY WE'RE FINDING OUT THEY
CAN'T. SO FOR WHAT- SO WE ARE
WORKING. I KNOW WITH THE SENATOR
ON A BUDGET ASK- I WILL SEE WHAT
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. WILL ALLOW
THANK YOU MISS CARP ALL RIGHT.
THE QUESTIONS SENT SERVICE ALSO
SERVED- SENATOR RUSSELL THANK
YOU- MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS
ABOUT. SOME AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES SAID- WE ENDED THE
RENTAL HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND THAT WAS FOR. OUR
LOWER INCOME- INDIVIDUALS- WE
ENDED IT AND THEY'RE STILL OUT
IN OUR STATE. PROBABLY THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE FOR LOW INCOME WHO
JUST CANNOT PAY THE OUTSTANDING
RENT- A DEBT- IN HERE WE'RE
BEING ASKED TO FULLY REIMBURSE-
A JUDGMENT AGAINST A TENANT. WHO
HAS THE ABILITY TO PAY- AND
USING DOLLARS YOU KNOW OUR FUND
DOLLARS TO PAY THE JUDGMENT
AGAINST SOMEONE WHO HAS THE
ABILITY TO PAY IT'S NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE LOW INCOME. SO EITHER
HOW YOU RESPOND TO THAT BUT
THAT'S MY ONE OF MY BIGGEST
CONCERNS OF COURSE UP THE WAY
THAT I SEE IT IS THAT WE HAVE
SMALL A RENTAL PROPERTY OWNERS
THAT. OUTSIDE OF THEIR CONTROL
THAT'S THAT REALLY IT'S NOT
THEIR FAULT THAT. THEY'RE IN THE
SITUATION WHERE THEY'RE
FINANCIALLY BURDEN COULD LOSE
THEIR HOMES OR THEIR RENTAL
PROPERTY WHERE THE TENANT COULD
END UP LOSING RIGHT OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S THERE SEEMS TO BE. AN
ISSUE HERE- IN THE STATE WHERE.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF. YOU KNOW PERHAPS
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE BEING PUT
OUT THERE AND THE TENANTS IN
NEED THE MOST HELP ARE NOT
GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY NEED%
AND THE LANDLORDS THAT NEEDS THE
HELP TO KEEP THE TENANTS THAT
NEED THE HELP OR THE NEED TO
HOUSING T STAY AND ARE NOT
GETTING THE HELP AND SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED. EITHER SO. I YOU
KNOW I SEE THAT IT I SEE THIS
AS- IF WE DON'T PROVIDE. SUPPORT
ODD TO THE SMALL LANDLORDS- IF
WE COULD CREATE OF A WORSE
SITUATION AND THE HOUSING MARKET
FOR TENANTS BECAUSE IF THEY LOSE
THE HOME WAS GONNA COME IN AND
PURCHASE THAT HOME IS IT GOING
TO BE SOME HEDGE FUND IS IT
GOING TO BE. AN INVESTOR THAT IS
JUST YOU KNOW WARSOP EITHER
PEOPLE BUT- INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THAT YOU'D- LIKE LIKE
MY PARENTS IMMIGRATED FROM
MEXICO OR HAVE A STORY THAT'S
THAT IT'S NOT ONE THAT'S
INVESTOR TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE SYSTEM THEY'RE STRUGGLING
JUST AS MUCH AS THE TENANTS ARE
BUT THE GO HEAD BIG IT'- THEIR
VERY MUCH INTERCONNECTED AND IF.
AND THEY'RE LOSING OUT BASED ON
ON A SYSTEM THAT HAS FAILED THEM
AND ALSO FAILED THE TENDED TO BE
AT THE MOST. ALL RIGHT OTHER
QUESTION SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS HERE FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- IS THERE MOTION. SET
SET HERTZBERG MOVES THE BILL ALL
RIGHT- BEFORE WE CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THIS THIS PROGRAM WHICH WAS
DESIGNED TO SUPPORT TENANTS WAS
NOT DESIGNED TO BASICALLY
PROVIDE TENANTS AN OPPORTUNE
RICH THEMSELVES OF THE EXPENSE
OF THE LANDLORD. MISS DON'T I
HOPE YOU WILL CONSIDER AT LEAST
EXPOSING THE PERSON WHO HAS IN
ESSENCE DEFRAUDED YOU ALL RIGHT
HAVING SAID THAT. SERTOLI COULD
CLOSE. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE-
YOU DID ACCEPT AMENDMENTS
CORRECT YES I DID ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT A MAN SHE
COUNTS OF YOU CALL THE ROLL. YES
THIS IS THAT SB EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR WITHOUT- WITH
THE MOTION BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBER. AMBER I
BURGESS WERE DECIDE CABALLERO
DID ASAL. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG AYE JONES.
LAYARD STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI
WIENER SO FAR YOU HAVE FORTY
ZERO RIGHT WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
CENTER LEYVA I SEE YOU HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU GOT
CALLED ON SHORT NOTICE TO COME
DOWN- HAPPY TO BE HERE YOU'RE
YOUR MEASURE IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN S. C. R. NINETY TWO. SIR
LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU SIR GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
MEMBERS AND MISTER CHAIR SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY TWO
SIMPLY AUTHORIZES A REQUEST THAT
THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
STUDY. A REVISION STUDY REPORT
AND PREPARE RECOMMENDATION
RECOMMENDED LEGISLATION TO
REVISE CALIFORNIA LAW TO REMEDY
ANY DEFECTS IN ITS LANGUAGE OR
IMPACT THAT DISCRIMINATE ON THE
BASIS OF SEX WELL IT IS LONG
OVERDUE FOR THE EQUAL RIGHTS
AMENDMENT TO BE VALIDATED. WE AS
A LEGISLATURE CAN AND MUST BE
ACTION TAKE ACTION TO NOW BY
PREPARING FOR IT TO BE CERTIFIED
AND MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
READY TO IMPLEMENT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE. MEMBERS I WOULD HOPE
THAT WE ALL AGREE THAT LAWS THAT
DISCRIMINATE ON THE BASIS OF SEX
ARE WRONG. S. C. R. NINETY TWO
WILL SIMPLY HELP TO SUGGEST
REMEDIES WITH ME HERE TODAY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARE KATHY SPILLAR
WITH THE FEMINIST MAJORITY AND
BETSY BUTLER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S LAW CENTER. MEMBERS WHEN
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABOUT. MR ARE YOU AVAILABLE
. YES I AM THANK FLOOR'S YOURS.
THANK YOU- THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN BURKETOWN CENTER LIKE
THAT AND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY WHICH IS A NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION WORKING FOR WOMEN'S
EQUALITY AND EMPOWERMENT WITH
OFFICES BOTH IN GREATER
WASHINGTON DC AND HERE IN LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS WHERE I AM
BASED OUR LEADERSHIP AND THE
FOREFRONT OF THE BATTLE FOR THE
COOL RIGHT TO MANAGEMENT. IN
MARCH OF THIS YEAR- WE MARK THE
FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
PROGRESSION OF PASSAGE OF THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT WITH
OVERWHELMING BOTH IN BOTH THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE AND IN THE
INTERVENING YEARS SECURE THREE
QUARTERS OF THE STATE- THIRTY
EIGHT STATES VOTING TO RATIFY
THE ERA. HOWEVER IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE TRUMP JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT BLOCKED THE ARCHIVIST
FROM CARRYING OUT HIS
MINISTERIAL DUTIES OF PUBLISHING
AND CERTIFYING THE AMENDMENT THE
LAST THREE STATE VOTED TO RATIFY
THE AMENDMENT HAVE SUBSEQUENTLY
SUED THE ARCHIVIST AND THE CASE
IS NOW BEFORE THE DC COURT OF
APPEALS. HOWEVER MANY OF THE
MOST PROMINENT CONSTITUTIONAL
LAW SCHOLARS IN THE UNITED
STATES INCLUDING KATHLEEN
SULLIVAN DOROTHY ROBERTS LARGE
TRIED KIMBERLY CRENSHAW AMONG
OTHERS INCLUDE THAT WHEN
VIRGINIA BECAME THE THIRTY EIGHT
STATES TO RATIFY THAT ALL
REQUIREMENTS FOR RATIFICATION AS
SET OUT UNDER ARTICLE FIVE OF
THE CONSTITUTION WERE MET AND
THE ERA SHOULD BE CONSIDERED TO
HAVE BECOME PART OF THE
CONSTITUTION. THE ERA STATE
SIMPLY THAT EQUALITY OF RIGHTS
UNDER THE LAW SHOULD NOT BE
DENIED OR ABRIDGED BY THE UNITED
STATES OR BY ANY STATE ON
ACCOUNT OF SEX AND SECTION THREE
OF THE AMENDMENT SPECIFIES THAT
IT WILL TAKE EFFECT TWO YEARS
AFTER THE DATE OF RATIFICATION.
THE CONGRESS STRUCTURE THAT TWO
YEAR DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION IN
ORDER TO GET THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA TIME TO REVIEW AND
REFORM THEIR LAWS AND POLICIES.
TO COMPLY WITH THE AND THEN. HE
AREAS THERE'S A- RESOLUTION AND
CON TO READY THE STAY. AS PART
OF. BUT WHETHER THROUGH CAN. ACT
OR- DECISION. HERE A REGULAR
THING YOU FOR CALLING. YEAH ARE
IN HERE THANK YOU- AND I BELIEVE
WE HAVE OF SOME WE MEMBER SEVEN.
BUTLER ON THE PHONE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUTLER. IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE. ALL RIGHT- IF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUTLER APPEARS
ON THE PHONE LINES WE'LL COME
BACK TO HER BUT THE MEANTIME
LET'S TAKE THOSE HERE IN ROOM
TWO TWENTY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO
ONE APPROACING THE MIKE FROM
THEN ON THE PHONE LINES THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINES IN SUPPORT OF S.
C. R. NINETY TWO. MODERATE FEUD
QUEUE THEM UP. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF IT. SB
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MR WE HAVE KNOWN IN CUBA
TALK ALL RIGHT. NOW OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION TO S. C. R. NINETY
TWO- I DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
LISTED- AS PRIMARY OPPONENTS THE
S. C. R. NINETY TWO. ANYONE HERE
IN THE ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSITION SCR. NINETY TWO IF
YOU PRODUCE A MICROPHONE SING
KNOWN APPROACH IN THE MICROPHONE
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATE IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION S. C. R. NINETY TWO.
IF YOU WANT YOU UP FOR
OPPOSITION OF. S. B. NINETY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THE OTHER
SIDE. SURE WE HAVE NO ENSURING
OF THE TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S
BRING IT BACK HERE QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS- CENTER
CONSULTS MOVES THE BILL- SEEING
NO OTHER QUESTIONS- SEVERAL A
WEEK AT A CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT VOTE ALL RIGHT BILLS THE
MOVE BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. MAN
CHIEF COUNSEL YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS A C. R. NINETY TWO
BY SENATOR LEYVA WITH THE MOTION
BY CENTER. THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED AMBERG MY NUMBER I BOARD
JUST. FORGES NO COVERAGE AT ALL
. THERE ARE. RUSSELL I GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I HEARD HERTZBERG I'D-
LAYERED STERN WAKE HEALTHY
WIENER YOU HAVE FORTY ONE SO FAR
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT ON CALL
WE'RE GOING TO RECESS NOW AND WE
HOPE TO START PROMPTLY AT ONE
THIRTY WITH CENTER EGGMAN'S BILL
CENTER EGGMAN HAS SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS. AND SO WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL HAVE US FISH
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE TO BEGIN
EXACTLY AT ONE THIRTY ALRIGHT
WE'RE IN RECESS THANK YOU.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RETURN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED GOOD AFTERNOON. BEFORE
WE GET STARTED WANT TO REMIND
EVERYONE OF OUR GROUND RULES FOR
WITNESSES EACH SIDE IS LED TO
WITNESSES WHO MAY SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES ALL OF HIS WISH TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMITTHEIR
COMMENTS TO. THE FOLLOWING THEIR
NAME. AFFILIATION POSITION ON
THE MEASURE THERE WILL ALSO BE.
TIME OF FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
CALLS AND SUPPORT AND FIFTEEN
MINUTES. OF FOR CALLS IN
OPPOSITION THAT'S THE CALL THE
FOLKS CALLED IN ON THE PHONE. IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
OVER THE PHONE FOR ANY OF THE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA THE
PHONE NUMBER IS AS FOLLOWS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO.
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. RESTRICTIONS
OF THE SENATE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITES ON HOW TO
USE THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
WRITTEN COMMENTS CAN ALSO BE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE BY
FOLLOWING THE INSTRUCTIONS ON
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. A CENTER EGGMAN IS NOW
WHO IS PRESENT WILL BEGIN WILL
WITH- I THINK IT'S YOUR DESIRE
WE BEGIN WITH THIS BILL FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN IS THAT RIGHT CENTER
EGGMAN- BUT WE WILL YES OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SIR EDMUND THE FLOOR'S
YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. FOR HEARING
THIS BILL TODAY AND FOR GETTING
THIS EXPEDITED SO ARE MY WITNESS
CAN STILL BE HERE- HERE THIS
BILL TODAY FOR MEN AS WELL AS A
FEW OTHERS- AND SO FAR THIS YEAR
COMMITTEES I'VE TRIED TO
PRESENT. A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEM CONTINUE OF CARE. PACKAGE
OF BILLS. SO AGAIN THIS CARE
THIS THIS BILL IS NOT IN
ISOLATION FROM ANY OF THE OTHER
BILLS. WE'VE BEEN PRESENTING WE
THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE CONTINUUM AND NOT JUST
LOOKING AT ONE COMPONENT IN
ISOLATION- THIS IS HAPPENING
ALSO IN HISTORIC BUDGET
INVESTMENT- JUST GIVE ME. A CALL
BECAUSE MAYBE WE TALK MORE ABOUT
INVESTMENT SHOULD BE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH IN. TRACTION WORK FORCE.
AS WELL AS HOUSING- AND I THINK
IT'S WE ALL AGREE THAT WERE IN
THE MIDST OF A CRISIS I DON'T
NEED TO KEEP ON HARPING ON THAT-
BUT WE ALSO KNOW IN IN THAT AND
THE ONE PART OF OUR SYSTEM THAT.
SOMETIMES IS MORE CONTROVERSIAL
THAN OTHERS IS THE- THE LPS. AND
I JOINED OUR SENATE COLLEAGUES
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY DID A- IT
WAS ON IT AND THEN- PRESENTATION
OF SAID AUDIT BY THE STATE
AUDITOR. AND I WAS ABLE TO-
ENGAGE IN THAT- INTO THINGS THAT
WE TOOK AWAY FROM THE STATE
AUDIT WAS. ONE WE NEED TO MORE
ABOUT HOW OUR SYSTEM IS WORKING.
AND YOU HEARD ME PRESENT A BILL
LOOKING AT DATA GATHERING A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO IN THIS
COMMITTEE. AND TO THERE APPEARS
TO BE A VARIATION FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY ON HOW WE TERM AND LOOK
AT. DANGEROUS AND. DANGEROUS
MISSING GRAVE DISABILITY. SO
WHEN CARE IS NOT AVAILABLE
PEOPLE ARE OFTEN. LOCKED UP IN
JAILS- DID. CORONER'S OFFICES-
ABUSED ON THE STREETS- AND END
UP IN OUR HOSPITAL ROOMS AND
TAKING UP. A LARGE AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
FIRST RESPONDERS WHO ARE OUT
THERE. RESPONDING SB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN WOULD ALLOW FOR
INVOLUNTARY CARE WITH ALL OF THE
EXISTING DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS
IS SOMEONE IS SO. MENTALLY ILL
AT THE POINT OF THEIR VALUE TO
THE CANNOT PROVIDE FOR THEIR OWN
MEDICAL CARE. TO THE POINT THAT
THEY ARE AT SUBSTANTIAL. RISK OF
BODILY HARM. DANGEROUS WORSENING
OF ANY RELATED SERIOUS PHYSICAL
ILLNESS. OR SIGNIFICANT
PSYCHIATRIC. DETERIORATION RIGHT
SO THESE ARE THE PEOPLE YOU SEE
SOMETIMES AND YOU THINK SOMEBODY
SHOULD DO SOMETHING. COULD BE
SITTING IN THEIR OWN FECES COULD
BE BANGING THEIR HEAD AGAINST
THE WALL COULD BE AS I'VE-
REGULARLY HAVE TO CALL NINE ONE
ONE ON MY WAY TO WORK DRIVING
THROUGH BOTH. DOWNTOWN STOCKTON
IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO THAT
SOMEBODY IS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
ROAD- NOT NOT FULLY CLOTHED- IN
CLEARLY TO SPEAKING TO SOMEBODY
OTHER THAN ANYBODY WHO'S AROUND
THEM IN TRAFFIC- IS THAT WHAT WE
WANT FOR PEOPLE AND I THINK THAT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO THAT IS. IS
THAT OKAY BECAUSE SOMEBODY CAN
SAY. I CAN SLEEP RIGHT HERE ON
THE SIDEWALK OR I'M NOT GOING TO
ACTIVELY KILL MYSELF RIGHT NOW
WE CLEARLY THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR OWN.
MEDICAL CARE. IS THIS BILL THE
SOLUTION. NO IT'S NOT- BUT IT IS
ANOTHER PART OF THE COMPONENT
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING VERY
NARROWLY- IN ADDITION TO FOOD
CLOTHING SHELTER. IF YOU ARE AT
THE RISK OF NOT BEING ABLE YOUR
ILLNESS NOT AND NOT JUST. YOU
KNOW YOUR LIFESTYLE OR- YOUR
POVERTY LEVEL OR NOTHING LIKE
THAT. BUT IF YOU'RE MENTAL
ILLNESS. IS SUCH THAT YOU CANNOT
PROVIDE FOR YOUR OWN MEDICAL.
CARE TO THE POINT THAT YOU ARE
AT RISK OF SUBSTANTIAL BODILY
HARM. DANGEROUS WORSENING OF ANY
RELATED SERIOUS PHYSICAL
ILLNESS. OR SIGNIFICANT
PSYCHIATRIC. DETERIORATION
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOLKS. THE OPS SYSTEM HAS
SIGNIFICANT GUARDRAILS THAT WE
PUT IN IS NOT INTENDED AS A TOOL
TO TARGET PEOPLE IN POVERTY AND
THE WHOLE POINT. IS TO PREVENT
THAT I KNOW THIS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE AND I KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TALKING ABOUT
THIS ABOUT FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOMS
AND WE ALL AGREE ON FUNDAMENTAL
FREEDOMS AND PART OF A WHO WE
ARE. BUT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
SOMEBODY'S MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION. PUTS THEM IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY ARE UNABLE
TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS IN A
SAFE. MANNER AND THEN WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING- TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THEM- WE ARE WORKING ON ALL OF
THE OF THE HOUSING.
INFRASTRUCTURE THE- WORK FORCE-
AS WE SPEAK AND THIS HAS TO BE
IN CONJUNCTION WITH IT. WITH ME
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
THE BILL IS DR ALEXIS SEGAN AND-
RANDALL HAGAR. ALL RIGHT- DR
SEGAN. DOCTOR SEASONS HERE THANK
YOU SEE GONZALES FONG YES- DR C.
CAN GO AHEAD. HI THANK YOU
SHERMAN ON BIRD AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TIME
DOCTOR LIKE BEGIN I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS. I'M ALSO AN
ASSISTANT CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE AND WORK ON THEIR
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC UNIT
THERE. SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN DOES
TWO IMPORTANT THINGS THE FIRST
EIGHTY EMPHASIZED THE IMPORTANCE
OF HOUSING AS A COMPONENT OF
GREAT DISABILITY HE CAN IN CASE
OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHO DESPITE
BEING IN THE MIDST OF A SEVERE
MANIC EPISODE BECAUSE SHE HAD
FUNDS AND STATED SHE COULD STAY
IN A HOTEL BUT SHALL NOTBE
GREATLY DISABLED. SHE LEFT THE
HOSPITAL FOR UP TO CONTINUE FOR
SEVERAL MONTHS ONLY ENDING WHEN
SHE WAS HOSPITALIZED IN ANOTHER
STATE WHOSE DEFINITION OF GREAT
DISABILITY IF THE MORE TO
WORKING PROPOSED HERE WHERE SHE
WON. TREATED AND DID RECEIVE
TREATMENT BUT NOT WITHOUT
BENDING HER STATING THAT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND BECOMING A
STRANGE. FOR HER FRIENDS AND
FAMILY IN THE PROCESS. ANOTHER
IMPORTANT THING TO ASK PEOPLE
SIXTEEN DOES. YOU CAN. THE
IMPACT ANOTHER ILLNESS COMO WITH
THE FACT. ILLNESS AFTER EXAMPLE
. FOR WITHIN THE- WITH YOU FEEL
WHO LOOK. TO OUR- MULTIPLE TIMES
A WEEK WHO WHEN HE STOPS WITH A
YOU AFTER. IS NOT ATTENTION
BALLOT WITNESS PLACING AT RISK
OF DEATH. HE HAD BEEN A PART.
AND WENT ON MEDICARE CAN QUITE
WHILE I. OF A- BUT HE CAN DO
QUITE WELL BUT I OF THE HOUSE.
QUICKLY STOPPED TAKING A
MEDICAID AND- STUFF THE CYCLE
PART AGAIN- HE WE RECEIVE NOTICE
TO. THAT USED HIS- HIS CONCERN
THAT IS NOT QUITE BE OF HELP YOU
GOT ENOUGH BE GREAT. STABLE.
SHALL NO AND A SIGNAL HE HAS THE
- WHICH PROVIDE. PEOPLE WHO CAN
BE CALLED ME. AWARE OF SEVERITY
ILLNESS I NEEDED TO COME. OF SAY
. THE DEATH OF GRAY DISABILITY
IF THEY GET AND- SENATE BILL.
SIX MARCH THAT THOSE WERE THE
TRUE BOTHERED WHICH TO HELP
NEED. A YOU. THANK YOU TO- NECK
- RANDALL. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE- SENATOR
EGGMAN THIS IS RIGHT HAGER- I
REPRESENT HELP THE SORRY IF I
GET VISITS ALIGN THE POWER. AND
I'M HERE TO THAT'S THE ON THIS
SCALE- YOU HEARD A LOT OF GOOD
PPL A CUP CASE RECORD HERE WE
CAUGHT UP TO A LITTLE BIT HIGHER
HERE FOR A FEW- WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT BE- DISPEL OF
PEOPLE WAS GETS. AND OTHERS
DISORDERS OF THE THAT WILL DIE
AND THEY HAVE A NEED FOR-
CONSERVATIVES SINCE END UP- IN
VERY BAD AND ARE HOSPITALS IN
SOMETIMES JAIL IN OUR OFF
SCOOPED UP HOW OF THE STREET TO.
EITHER THOSE OKAY BUT THE.
WALMART DOES GET. IS STILL OF
LOOSENING. AND PART OF THAT YOU
HEARD ABOUT ANALYSTS KNOWS THE-
IT'S A DISTURBANCE IN THE CLOUD
LOBE THE BRAIN WERE THERE IS. A
AN ABILITY TO RECOGNIZE THAT
YOUR SEX. SO THE PERSON- IN
ADDITION TO THAT COGNITIVE LEAVE
SO TECH SO I CAUGHT SYMPTOM OF
. THE FINAL OF THE- YOU GET
SOMEONE WHO WHO A VERY SERIOUS
WITH. MAKING AND THEY CAN BE SO
SEVERE. THAT YOU THAT IMPAIRED
THAT GET IMPACTS BOTH REFILL AND
A MENTAL. A GOOD EXAMPLE WOULD
BE A CYCLE IN THE WHO ALSO USES
MAC- THIS IS VERY. AS MEN OF YOU
KNOW ON ARTS- THIS IN TURN THIS
USE OF NAP AND LEAD TO WORSENING
PSYCHOSIS THAT THE SYMPTOMS BUT
THE LOSING DELUDE. AND
HALLUCINATIONS- WORKS AND BUT
ALSO LEADS TO THE BECAUSE
BECAUSE ON THE GLASS AND MORE.
FOR THE HEALTH BOB INCLUDING.
HEART ISSUE- WHICH AND MAYBE.
INFECTIOUS DISEASES- THAT OCCUR
AND THESE INDIVIDUALS AND UP AN
EMERGENCY ROOMS AND EMERGENCY
HOSPITALIZATIONS I CONSULTED IN
THESE REMARKS WITH. DR CAMERON
CARTER AT UC DAVIS HE IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LAB HEROUX HALL-
CENTER OF EXCELLENCE THERE ARE.
AND IS DOING RESEARCH AND IN
CRISIS- MOBILE CRISIS TEAM-
OUTCOMES AND- HE SAYS THAT EVERY
DAY AND EVERY DAY THEY SEE THESE
KINDS OF INDIVIDUALS. AT THE
MEDICAL CENTER AT UC DAVIS AND
THEY ARE IN THE MOST TERRIBLE
PHYSICAL AND- CONDITION. AND
THAT'S WHY THE CRITERIA IN IN
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY HELP US
HELP THEM AND THAT'S WHAT I
THINK AT THE END OF THE DAY WE
ALL WANT TO HAPPEN. TO HELP
THESE POOR INDIVIDUALS SO- LET
WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL WERE AT THE SPONSORS.
OF THE- EIGHT PACKAGE THAT
CENTER A MINUTES FOR ON THE
TABLE. ALL RIGHT YOUR ON THE
SECOND ENTIRE RIGHT YEAH IF YOU
GO HEAD WRAP UP. I AM DONE SIR
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
THOSE IN SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWENTY OF S. B. SIXTY.
NORTH STAR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER OF I'M MORE
TALK HERE ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
TODD GLORIA THIS OF SAN DIEGO
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND I'D
ALSO NOTE THAT- THERE HARRIS TO
DO OF THE CITY OF ANAHEIM IS A
MEMBER OF THE BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION WHICH IS- IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL CO SPONSOR A
POSITION ON THIS BILL. FINE
THANK YOU. MISTER MEMBERS PLAYER
WE HAVE THE CITY COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO MARYLAND A BREED ALSO
MEMBER THAT BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION IN SUPPORT THING
ALREADY THANK YOU. OTHERS HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWENTY. SHE'S ME-
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED ALL RIGHT.
SIGNAL ONE OF MODERATE IF YOU IF
YOU OF THOSE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN. IT WAS CHAIR AND ANYONE%
WISHING TO SPEAK ON SUPPORT OF
THIS THE FOURTEENTH SIXTEEN.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THANK TO
YOU AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO FAR
INTO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALLOWED HARD AGAIN BY
EASTON WITH THE FEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE ONE TWO FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAROL ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF STOCKTON SUPPORT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT- CANNELLA STIR THE
OPPOSITION I HAVE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION MATT
GALLAGHER AND COMPUTER- I SEE
MISS PETERSON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KIM PETERSON I AM AN
ATTORNEY AT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND I FOCUS ON LEGAL
ISSUES RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
US TO BE HERE TODAY I'M JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY BACKGROUND
BEFORE COMING TO THE R. C. I
SPENT TEN YEARS REPRESENTING ON
PEOPLE- WHO ARE INVOLUNTARILY
HELD ON FIFTY TO FIFTY HOLDS AND
THEIR CERTIFICATION REVIEW
HEARINGS SO. I AM VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE PROCESS OF LPS AND
EXACTLY WHAT THE LEGAL PROCESS
ENTAILS AND WHAT IT IS LIKE TO
BE. WHAT IT IS LIKE TO OBSERVE
PEOPLE BEING ON HOLD IN ACUTE
INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC UNITS. THE
AUTHORS AND SPONSOR THE OTHER
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL STATE THAT
EXPANDING THE DEFINITION OF
GRAVELY DISABLED AS NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE CARE AND DIGNITY TO THE
MOST DIFFICULT TO REACH
CALIFORNIANS. AND IN TURN STOP
THE CYCLE OF HOMELESSNESS
INCARCERATION AND
HOSPITALIZATION NOT SO MANY
PEOPLE FACE. HOWEVER EXPANDING
THE GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY TO
INVOLUNTARILY DETAIN PEOPLE WILL
DO NOTHING TO ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING SOCIETAL CAUSES OF
THIS CYCLE. WITHOUT REQUIRING
THE STATE AND THE COUNTY IS TO
ACTUALLY MAKE AVAILABLE HOUSING
AND INTENSIVE SERVICES THAT
PEOPLE NEED UPON DISCHARGE FROM
SHORT TERM LPS HOLDS AND
CONSERVATORSHIP. THE CYCLE WILL
PERSIST. AS DISCUSSED IN OUR
LETTER A RECENT UCLA STUDY
SHOWED THAT PLACING ON HOUSE
PEOPLE ON LPS HOLDS LEADS TO
LONGER HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOUSE AT THE TIME
THAT THEIR WHOLE BEGAN. AND ALSO
LEADS TO A GREATER THAN 50%
CHANCE THAT A PERSON WILL REMAIN
ON HOW IS THAT THE TIME OF
DISCHARGE. I HAVE SEEN THIS
FIRST HAND IN MY PREVIOUS WORK I
REPRESENTED DOZENS AND DOZENS
AND DOZENS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
HOW IS AND PLACED ON LPS HOLDS
WITH THE HOPE OF GETTING. WITH
SOMEONE HOPE OF GETTING THEM
INTO TREATMENT BUT THEY WIND UP
LINGERING IN THE HOSPITAL FOR
VERY LONG PERIODS OF TIME AND
THEN DISCHARGED BACK INTO
HOMELESSNESS. IN COMPARISON A
RECENT UCSF STUDY SHOWS THAT
LINKING ON HOUSE HIGH UTILIZE
THERE'S A PUBLIC SERVICES TO
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
WITH INTENSIVE CASE MANAGEMENT
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCES
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS AND INCREASES THE RATE OF
INCREASE OF OUTPATIENT MENTAL
HEALTH. VISITS AS WELL. THIS
STUDY SHOWS A VOLUNTARY
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS CAN KEEP SOME OF OUR
STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS HOUSING GAINS WITHOUT
RESTRICTING THEIR LIBERTY. THANK
YOU MISS PETERSON IF YOU COULD
WRAP UP YES- I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO NOTE THAT- CALIFORNIA AS WELL
DOES NOT HAVE THE DATA TO
SUPPORT EXPANDING INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT IN THE STATE AND ANY
EXPANSION. OF INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD
BE SUPPORTED BY DATA AND SHOULD
NOT HAPPEN UNTIL THAT DATA IS
AVAILABLE THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY. ODD NEXT MR GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATTHEW GALLAGHER ATTORNEY
FORMER PROSECUTOR. ON BEHALF OF
CAL VOICES. THE ISSUE BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY IS REALLY
OUTLINED ON PAGES THIRTEEN
THROUGH SIXTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH IS. IS SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
AS DRAFTED UNCONSTITUTIONALLY
VAGUE AND OVERBROAD. WE BELIEVE
IT IS. WE LOOK AT THE SPECIFIC
LANGUAGE IN THE STATUTE AS
DRAFTED. THE QUESTION IS WILL
PROPOSE CONSERVANCY BE ABLE TO
READ THE STATUTE AND UNDERSTAND
THAT. WE DON'T BELIEVE THEY
WILL. WE LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE.
SUBSTANTIAL BODILY HARM.
DANGEROUS WORSENING OF ANY
CONTINENT SERIOUS PHYSICAL
ILLNESS OR SIGNIFICANT
PSYCHIATRIC DETERIORATION. THESE
ARE NOT THE FINE WEAGLE
STANDARDS THEY'RE NOT DEFINED IN
THE STATUTE THEY'RE NOT DEFINED
ANY APPELLATE CASE LAW. IN QUITE
SIMPLY INDIVIDUAL SUBJECT
CONSERVATIVE CONSERVATORSHIP FOR
OPS HOLDS WILL NOT KNOW WHAT
THESE WHAT CONDUCT OR FOR
BEHAVIOR. THIS LANGUAGE
PROHIBITS OR ALLOWS. AND WHAT'S
MORE CONCERNING IS THAT JURORS
AND JUDGES WILL NOT KNOW HOW TO
APPLY THESE LEGAL STANDARDS. SO
ASSUMING AN INDIVIDUAL IS
SUBJECT TO HELP YES HOLD
EVENTUALLY MAKES HER WAY TO A
CONSERVATORSHIP AND THEY OFFER A
TRIAL YOUR WITH THE JUDGE OR
JURY. JUDGES INJURIES WILL NOT
KNOW HOW TO APPLY THESE LEGAL
STANDARDS IT'LL CREATE
INCONSISTENCIES. OF COMPLETE
LACK UNIFORMITY IN CASES WILL BE
DECIDED ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
WITHOUT ANY CONSISTENCY. THAT WE
BELIEVE RUNS A PHALLIC DUE
PROCESS AND CONSTANTLY
CONSTITUTIONALLY PRECISE SIZE
WELL SETTLED LEGAL PRECEDENT.
AND AS I CLOSED I AND WITH THIS
. PROCEDURALS PROTECTIONS OR A
COLD COMFORT. WHEN THE
UNDERLYING SUBSTANCE OF THE LAW
IS OVERBROAD. THANK YOU MR
GALLAGHER WE LOOK FORWARD YOUR
SUGGESTIONS AS TO HOW TO NARROW
THE LANGUAGE ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION WHO ARE PRESENT HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED GOOD
AFTERNOON GLENN BACKUS ON BEHALF
OF A CO YOU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU OTHERS HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
SEEING NONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN. WHICH IS PICKING UP TO
VERSION OF SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND YOUR AT
THIS TIME. MISCHIEVOUS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE IN QUEUE AT THE MOMENT.
MODEL ONE TWO FIFTY ONE. WHETHER
YOU'RE CHEWING UP. AS WELL TWO
FIFTY ONE GO AHEAD. HELLO
HELIOPOLIS COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH RECORDS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE A LITTLE LESS AMENDED THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YES MA'AM SHARE.
OKAY WILL POINT TO SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS TERRY HOW KOBE AND I AM IN
VIOLENT OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
I AM WITH PARENTS AGAINST DRUGS
ON THE STREET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE A SURFBOARD JUST
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SING GO
AHEAD. MAYBE JUST A- VETERAN OR
STANDING WHY THE HEARSAY- ISSUE
IS. INSURMOUNTABLE MEANING THAT
IF- THIRD PARTIES NEED TO BE
DRAWN INTO A- CONSERVATORSHIP-
SITUATION WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS
NOT BEING- ABLE TO TESTIFY IT
WILL BE SUBPOENAED TO PROVIDE
THEIR THEIR OPINIONS AND THEIR
EXPERIENCES OVER A PARTICULAR
PERSON. I'VE I BELIEVE YOU TALK
ABOUT ONE OF MY OTHER BILL
SENATOR CRACK IN IT IT IS ABOUT
HEARSAY LET ME JUST AND IT'S
ABOUT LOOKING AT A MEDICAL
RECORD. FORGIVE ME DIVIDE. I MAY
HAVE BEEN JUMPING AROUND. THE
PEOPLE OF THE COMMUNITY FACEBOOK
. BUT ALSO MY COMMENTS FOR THE
FOR THE FOR THE SECOND ONE I
APOLOGIZE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. I
JUST. ALL RIGHT- OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. RIGHT CETERA EGGMAN-
BACK TO YOU FOR YOUR BECAUSE
CLOSER MOTION. IF THERE'S NOT A
MOTION WE WILL AWAIT THE MORE
COMPLETE COMMITTEE- AND IT TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS IN TERMS OF
NARROWING. IF YOU WANT TO
DRESSES IN YOUR CLOTHES
CERTAINLY I CERTAINLY WE'VE WE
HAVE RUN A LOT OF BILLS THROUGH
THIS HOUSE IN THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AND WE NARROW AND WE NARAL
AND WE NARAL AND WE COME OUT
WITH BILLS THAT APPLY TO VERY
FEW PEOPLE- I CAN TELL YOU WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS NOT WORKING AND I
CAN THAT CERTAINLY AND BY THE
OPPOSITION TO CONTINUE TO. HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS- WE KNOW
THAT THIS DEFINITION IS IN THE
SAM'S A DEFINITION WE KNOW MOST
MANY OTHER STATES- USE AND EVEN-
MORE COMPREHENSIVE DEFINITION-
AND WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE
NARROWED TO BEING ABLE TO APPLY
FOR MEDICAL ISSUES AND AGAIN.
DETERIORATION THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO DIE ON THE STREETS
WITH THE RIGHT SIDE AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LEAVING THEM
OFTENTIMES TO DEAL WITH IS JUST
THEIR RIGHTS- AND NOT AND NOT
ANY ACCESS THIS PROVIDES. ACCESS
THIS WILL PROVIDE CARE AND AMEN
TO WHAT FOLKS ARE SAYING ABOUT
WE NEED MORE WE NEED MORE AND
YES AGAIN I'M DURING BUDGET SUB
THREE AND WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY CAN BUT
WE SHOULD NOT HOLD THEM THE
CRIMES OF THE PAST UNDERFUNDING
OF THINGS. TO ADD TO HOLD US
INCAPABLE OF MAKING POSITIVE
CHANGE TO CARE FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE I ASK FOR YOUR ITEM
THANK YOU SIR EGGMAN IS OUR
MOTION. TO MOVE THE BILL CYNICAL
YOU'RE ALMOST THE BILL AMOUNT
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL- YES. BILL FOURTEEN SIX
BY SENATOR EGGMAN WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR CAFIERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. NUMBER NUMBER
FIVE FORGES. VERY LITTLE. VERY
LITTLE I DID ASAL GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG JONES LAYERED STERN Y.
CASKEY WINNER YOU HAVE TO DO
ZERO SO FAR ALREADY I WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL. ON NEXT- S. B.
NINE SIX FIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EGGMAN ALSO YOUR PERCENT
NINE SIX FIVE WHICH WILL ENSURE
THAT ALL RELEVANT MEDICAL
HISTORY CONTAINED WITHIN THE
MEDICAL RECORD CAN BE USED
DURING A CONSERVATORSHIP
HEARING. LIMITED MEDICAL HISTORY
DETAILED DURING A CONSERVATIVE
PERSON PROCEEDINGS LEAVE US ME
JUST S. ARGUMENT IF YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS HI I AM
BILLS ON THIS WHEN I AM CARESS
OKAY. FINE THE- IN THIS IS THE
ISSUE THAT UNDER BORDERS WAS
ASKING ABOUT- PREVIOUSLY-
OFTENTIMES OF BEFORE YOU GO
BEFORE CONSERVATORSHIP- THE
ATTENDANCE IN THE PAST ARE NOT.
IN THE THAT HEARING AYE YOU'RE
USING A ASSEMBLY PRESENTING AND
YOUR DOCUMENT. THAT DOCUMENT AS
A MEDICAL RECORD- AND THAT WE
WERE SAYING THAT SHOULD BE AT
THAT. ADMITTED AND NOT AS
HEARSAY BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THE
MEDICAL RECORD. IT I THINK WE
WENT A LITTLE BIT OUT OF ORDER
WHICH COULD LEAD TO SOME
CONFUSION YES. YES BUT WHAT
WE'LL SEE IF WE CAN'T GET OKAY
BACK IN SYNC HERE OKAY I'LL ONLY
MAKE SURE THAT THE WITNESSES
THAT YOU HAVE LISTED HERE ARE
STILL SAME WITNESSES- DR SEGAN
AND- LOCAL. LEANNE DUMAS'S THAT
THIS ONE IS A DOCTOR ALEXIS EGAN
AGAIN AND YES AS DEPUTY ATTORNEY
BEGAN TO MAS FROM ARKANSAS. ALL
RIGHT- DR SEGAN IF YOU'RE
AVAILABLE. ALL OF. ALL RIGHT- MR
MAS. YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
DEPUTY CITY ATTORNEY LEE AND YOU
MUST FROM THE SEVENTH THE CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. ALREADY NAY
LAWYERS THANK YOU I AM APPEARING
TODAY IS A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
WITNESS AND I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF A
TECHNICAL NATURE- THAT MAYES
EXIST I HEARD THAT THERE WAS ONE
EARLIER SOME HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS NOW OR- WHEN THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU- CENTER BOARD JUST I THINK
THAT WAS YOUR QUESTION FROM A
PREVIOUS MATTER. DID YOU WISH TO
RAISE THAT ISSUE AGAIN WITH
RESPECT TO HEAR SAY- NO I'M
TRYING TO I'M TRYING TO MAKE MY
BINDER CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WORKS. WELL NO I CAN UNDERSTAND
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE A QUITE A
NUMBER OF MATTERS FOR US TODAY
SO- OKAY- I THINK WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT WE'VE TAKEN OPPOSITE WAY
NO WE HAVE NOT TAKEN A POSITION
YET HAVE NOT BUT BUT I BELIEVE
WE ALSO STILL HAVE. I THINK
RANDALL HAGAR WAS GOING TO FILL
IN FOR DR SEGAN. WHO HAD TO GO
SEE PATIENTS ALL RIGHT SO MR
HAGAR IF YOU'RE ON. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I AM- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND SENATOR EGGMAN
THANK YOU- AGAIN RENTAL ACRE FOR
THE PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS
ALLIANCE THE CALIFORNIA. I JUST
A COUPLE OF QUICK THINGS- WE DO
HAVE SKY INTERESTS AND IN
VARIOUS TREATMENT SETTINGS
ACTUALLY OUR FORENSIC
PSYCHIATRIST AND THEY ACTUALLY
DO FILL IN WORK FOR OTHER
ATTENDING STUDENT WHO- PROBABLY
DON'T HAVE QUITE THAT KIND OF
EXPERIENCE TO APPEAR IN COURT
AND TESTIFY AND- JULIA WITH. THE
PROCEEDINGS AND THE ROLES- BURKE
. IT'S A QUITE A VALUABLE THING
BECAUSE WHEN A PERSON LIKE A
CREDIT THIS HAS TO GO SAID IN-
COURT ROOM WAIT FOR THEIR TURN
TESTIFIED OKAY. AWAY FOR
PATIENTS AND SO THIS IS THE
IMPORTANT JUSTICE BILL DOES
BEING NO SUBSIDY TO OUR PULL
EVERY- D. A LOT OF AB NIGHT.
NOTE HEY BECAUSE IT. MADE NURSES
UNION. OUR CASE ON AND BASICALLY
SAY UP CAMP ADMITTED INTO. ONE
WANTS HER CLEAR THAT THERE IS A
- URGENT NEED FOR TO BE AN
ATTENTION TO SOMEONE WHO'S WAS A
TO MAKE. FOR CONSERVE THIS IS A
IMPORTANT I THANK AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO THAT WE NEED
TO LOT OF THESE. SETTINGS AND SO
HAVE SPONSORED COURT ROOM HAPPEN
OR A DAY WAITING TO TEST FOR ON
A SINGLE PAYER. IS NOT EFFECTIVE
USE OF THEIR TREATMENT SKILLS
AND SO THIS BILL WHAT I. HELP A
OF COMMON I TO THE- THAT THAT'S
A LOT. INDIVIDUALS TO BE- TO BE
CALLED IN COURT IN THEIR STATE
ARE REAL ON BY 8% AND BECAUSE
THIS BUT IT DOESN'T. ALLOW A
POSITION TO PRESENT THEM RECORD
THE NOTES- THAT DETAIL ABOUT
YOUR- AND MAKE THE CASE WHY B.
AND IT'S ALL. CALL I. GREATLY
DHISAY STATUS. YOUR SHIFT SO
THEY IS REALLY IMPORTANT- WE
COMMEND IT TO YOU WE ARE JUST
THANK YOU RT THANK YOU- I SEE
MISTER. WAS IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY HUNDRED. THANK YOU AGAIN
MR TERM AND MEMBERS MORE TALK
HERE ON THE- OF MERIT. THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GAMEST MEMBERS VOLUME
AMERILA BREED AND THANK YOU-
ANYONE ELSE HERE HERE IN ROOM TO
TWO HUNDRED C. NONE THE PHONE
LINE. MODERATOR FOR WOULD QUEUE
UP THOSE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. NINE SIX FIVE. IF
YOU'RE SPEAKING SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE SIX FIVE TWO SIX ONE ZERO.
GOLDLINE TWO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALLOWED HARD
NUMBER EASEMENT WITH THE TIME
BURDENS TO TEAR IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MR HAVE NO
ELSE NICK YOU ALL RIGHT NOW
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION- I
DON'T HAVE ANYONE LISTED HERE IN
PRIMARY UP OH I'M SORRY-
STEPHANIE REGULAR- ON THE LINE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION MISS
REGULAR ARE YOU AVAILABLE. I AM
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT GOT IT THANK
. BANK COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE REGULAR EVENT A
PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR TWENTY ONE
YEAR AND I'M GONNA FIND MY
OFFICE MENTAL HEALTH UNIT
REPRESENTING INDIVIDUALS
SUFFERING FROM SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS FOR THE PAST TEN YEARS.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS EDUCATION I
HAVE TO FIGHT IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE SIXTY FIVE. RIGHT THE
GREEN PART OF POP DECISION AND
BASED. HOUSE HAD LONG. THAT
ALLOWED ACT TO TALK TO. THE CASE
BUT HERE HEY IT WAS NOT ADMITTED
PURCHASE BUT ONLY IF BASIS FOR
THAT. OPINION AND FANTASTIC THE
SUPREME COURT REJECTED THE FRESH
. AND HELP THAT AN EXPERT CAN
NOT RELY ON YOUR FACE. AND THE
GUY THAT THEY ARE ADMITTED THE
TRUTH. THE COURT REASONED THAT
EXPERT HAS. ABOUT THE- FOR THEIR
- MUST BECOME FOR THE TRUTH AND
AT THAT POINTTHANK. I'M NOT
INDEPENDENT. PENDANT LIGHT AND
SUBJECT. TO PEOPLE BE SANCHEZ IS
A LOT OF STATE CRIMINAL OUT AT
AT THE P. M. ET AL AND YOU CASES
. AFTER NINE FIFTY FIVE TO PER
FROM. AS AS CREATE THE CASE LAW
A OPENING DOOR FOR A TO RELATE
CASE. HERE THANK TO THE JURY AND
BY ALLOW THE JURY TO CONSIDER
THAT HERE OF TRUE. AND TO ASK
NINE SIXTY FIVE THANK. EXISTENCE
UNLIKE THE MERIT FAMILY
THERAPIST. CAN DA. AN EVENT
STATEMENT OR OPINION. AND I
ENTER TO LATER BE INTRIGUED IN A
OUTCAST TRIBE AS EVIDENCE REGARD
OF. AND I THINK THE FIVE THE CAN
CAN CATCH THE RELIABILITY OF OUT
OF STATE I COULD BE I MEAN IF I
COULD THE FENCE FOR ON MY FOR
AND THAT'S HE MCCARTY NEPRA.
MEMORY BUT THE PETROL BY.
I'M EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE
EVIDENCE CODE IN LPS COMMITMENT
PROCEEDINGS. AND PERMITS THE
ADMISSION OF UNRELIABLE AND
OTHERWISE INADMISSIBLE EVIDENCE.
IN TRIAL FOR FUNDAMENTAL LIBERTY
INTERESTS ARE AT STAKE. TO THE
EXTENT THAT PROPONENTS OF THE
FALCON BUT I THINK NINE SIXTY
FIVE WILL NOT OPEN THE
FLOODGATES FOR THE IMPRESSION
I'M RELIABLE EVIDENCE. THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD BANKRUPT CHEN
WHAT PROBLEMS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
REMEDY. UNDER EXIST LAW
INCLUDING UNDER CHAD. MEDICAL
RECORDS MAYBE FIFTEEN AND IT
MADE THE END OF THE BUSINESS
RECORDS EXCEPTION WHEN PROPERLY
SUBPOENAED AND AUTHENTICATED.
AND EXISTING LAW HAVE TO FIND
MEDICAL EXPERTS WHO MEET WITH
THE CONSERVATIVE. MAKE HAVE TO
FIGHT TO DIAGNOSIS AND PROVIDE
AN OPINION THAT THE CONCERT.
RIGHT BASICALLY BOTH. ON THEIR
OWN OPERATION AT. A PROPERTY OF
THE MEDICAL RECORDS. IN THE CASE
CONSERVATIVE CASE THAT THE
WHETHER QUITE RELY. FIVE OUR-
PFK THANK YOU READY THANK YOU
FOR WRAP UP OKAY. THE BILL HAS
NO WOULD OF THE MANY WHERE
PUBLIC GUARDIANS STRUGGLE TO
HAVE ALTHEA BECAUSE TO STAY
BASED ON A LAW BUT COUNTY VEGAS
IRONY ME OF THIS CONSERVATIVE
AND POSSESSION THE STATE'S NOT
ALLOW ME ANDPOOR CONCEPT
PROTECTION ACCOMMODATE THE EARED
PACKED. TAKEN AWAY UP INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD NEITHER BE NOR EASY AND
WE HAVE THE FELT YEAH RT THING
YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION WHO ARE
IT AND ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
CHARACTER SET. KIM PETERSON FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. I AM
BACCHUS ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SEEING NONE ON THE PHONE
LINES THOSE IN OPPOSITION
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE THEM
UP PLEASE. IF YOU WISH WE CAN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINETY TWO FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. JUST
MOMENTS HERE TO JUST QUEUED UP.
HEY WE'RE GONNA WANT TO FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JEANETTE BELL AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. SURE WE
HAVE NO NIELSEN SHOULD THE TIME.
ALREADY THANK OU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK HERE
TO. THE HEARING ROOM QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- CENTER. SURFBOARDS.
SECOND TIME'S A CHARM SO. OF.
NINE SIX FIVE FIVE IT TENDS TO-
TO DECIDE TO ALLOW WHAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE HEARSAY AND I'M
JUST TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT
IS THE COMPELLING NEED FOR THESE
MEDICAL RECORDS TO BE TO BE
GIVEN THAT LEVEL OF PROTECTION.
WHY WHY CAN'T WHY CAN'T-
INDIVIDUALS BE BROUGHT IN- UNDER
OATH THURSDAY IN SOME OTHER
FASHION. THAT WOULD ALLOW THEIR
TESTIMONY TO BE AS FORMULAIC AS
ANY OTHER TESTIMONY. I CAN I CAN
MAKE IT BETTER I WAS I WAS A
MILITANT MR MAS ANSWER THAT. YES
HAPPY TO LEE AND YOU MUST HEAR-
FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO CITY
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE. SO THAT IS
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS A
REALLY ALIGNING THE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE WITH THE WAY THESE
HEARINGS ARE CONDUCTED AND WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT ALLOWING
PHYSICIAN EXPERT WITNESSES TO BE
ABLE TO EXPLAIN DURING THEIR
TESTIMONY WHAT THOSE POSITIONS
HAVE RELIED UPON IN MAKING THEIR
DECISION REGARDING SOMEONE'S
TREATMENT PLAN OR WHETHER
SOMEONE IS GRAVELY DISABLED. AND
E. EIGHTY PHYSICIAN IS RELYING
ON MEDICAL RECORDS REALLY HAVE
TO RELY ON MEDICAL RECORDS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE TREATMENT AND
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
EXPLAIN- THE INFORMATION THAT
THAT POSITION READS. AND THAT
THAT THAT POSITION IS RELYING ON
RIGHT NOW THAT IS NOT PERMITTED-
THAT- IS THE AFFECT POST- PEOPLE
B. SANCHEZ. SO YOU HAVE A DOCTOR
WHO'S RELYING ON VERY- CREDIBLE
AND- INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED AND DOCUMENTED WITH THE
UP MOST OF CARE BY OTHER MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND THAT DOCTORS
NOT ALLOWED. PLAINTIFF DOES. IN
COURT AND THE RESULT OF THAT IS-
YOU KNOW REALLY HAS THE EFFECT
OF THE COURT NOT HAVING THE
COMPLETE INFORMATION ABOUT AN
INDIVIDUAL'S CONDITION. THE
PROBLEM WITH THE- YEAH IT IS ONE
CLARIFY SO IMAGINE. AN EXPERT
WITNESSES HE'S CALLED IN TO
TESTIFY IN AN EXPERT WITNESS
IDENTIFIES- MAYBE YOU HEAR SHE
WAS PRESIDING POSITION IN SOME
CAPACITY. RELYING ON. THE
MEDICAL RECORDS TO EXPLAIN THEIR
INDIVIDUAL RATIONALE FOR HOW
THEY ENGAGE IN A COURSE OF
TREATMENT OR OVERSIGHT. THAT IS
WITHIN THEIR PURVIEW TO EXPLAIN
WHAT IN HOW AND WHY THEY WERE
DOING WHAT THEY WERE DOING BUT
IN MY UNDERSTANDING THAT. THEY
CAN TAKE THAT ONE STEP FURTHER
IN SAY THAT DR JONES WAS RELYING
ON DR SMITH'S- REPRESENTATION IN
THIS REPORT BECAUSE HE THAT
DOCTOR JONES BELIEVES THAT
DOCTOR SMITH WAS MAKING THE
FOLLOWING CONCLUSIONS BASED ON.
CERTAIN PRESUMPTIONS. IS THAT IS
THAT FAIR TO SAY. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS A SPECIFIC CASE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ABOUT
TREATMENT HISTORY FOR EXAMPLE OR
MEDICATION AND IF THERE WAS A
SAY AND OUTPATIENT PSYCHIATRIST
THIS WOULD BE THE MOST COMMON
EXAMPLE IN MY VIEW AN OUTPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIST THAT HAS BEEN
TREATING AN INDIVIDUAL FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME- TREATING THIS
INDIVIDUALS CHRONIC. ILLNESS AND
HAS BEEN CHARTING THE TRUE STORY
OF TREATMENT AND THE- HE AND
KIND OF THING THAT THE KERR
EITHER THE CURRENT TREATER WHO'S
TESTIFYING OR PERHAPS IT'S A
FORENSIC PSYCHIATRIST THAT'S
TESTIFYING THE NON TREAT- COULD
READ THE INFORMATION AND-
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION AS PART
OF. HIS OR HER TESTIMONY THEY'RE
NOT LISTING TO THE POOREST OF
THE AMAZED. IN THE RECORD THERE
SIMPLY ATTESTING TO WHAT THEY
RELIED UPON FROM THE RECORD.
THAT'S CORRECT. ALL RIGHT. WHAT
SEMI CASKEY PICKING UP ON WHAT-
CENTER BORCHERS JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE JURY OR THE JUDGE
STILL IS ABLE TO WEIGH THE
PROBATIVE VALUE OF THAT EVIDENCE
THE EVIDENCE ALL WE'RE DOING IS
SAYING THE EVIDENCE COMES IN BUT
THE PROBATIVE VALUE WHETHER
IT'S- ONE OR A HUNDRED. ARE YOU
. OKAY ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THE
YOU KNOW THE FACT FINDER IS
ALWAYS PERMITTED TO WAY SORT OF
THE CREDIBILITY OF THE EVIDENCE
BEING PROVIDED AND THE
CREDIBILITY OF THE EXPERT
WITNESS FOR THAT MATTER.ALL
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS SEEING NON. RIGHT SENT
SCISSOR MOTION SOME OF THE BILL
CYNICAL ALMOST THE BILL- WOULD
LIKE CLOTHES AND EVERYTHING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN INCIDENT
WE'RE JUST YOU FOR THIS WOULD BE
LIKE READ A DOCTOR'S GETTING
READY TO TREAT YOU THEY LOOK IN
YOUR RECORD. YOU CAN CHECK FOR
THE SAME THING FIVE TOP TIPS
YOU'VE HAD A SERIES OF
MEDICATION THAT HAS OR HAS NOT
BEEN A PIC HE WOULD WANT THAT
PERSON IT WILL TAKE THAT INTO.
ACCOUNT WHEN THEIR YOUR OWN TREE
PLAN WILL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE AS THE IN THE MAP READ. AS
AS THAT PERSON AND BEING ABLE
TO- PRESENT BUT ISN'T. WILL NOT
BE IN THE OFFICIAL REQUEST.
BEING ABLE TO YOU. SOMETHING
THAT THAT THE PERSON NOT WITNESS
THEM SO. WE'RE YOU CAN DO UPON
THAT TO MAKE YOUR CASE. BEFORE
THE JUDGE. YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE'S A THERE'S A COMMONSENSE
ELEMENT TO THIS THAT ARE LIKE-
I'D I JUST DIDN'T KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER MEANS BY
WHICH- THAT INFORMATION WOULD
HAVE BEEN. A BILLABLE TO THIS
LEGAL PROCESS. WITHOUT BREAKING
DOWN THE HEARSAY. PROTOCOLS MAY
I MAY I RESPOND SO LET ME LET ME
INTERVENE HERE JUST JUST TO
CLARIFY THINGS SO MR MAS- WHAT
WAS THE- QUESTION ONE WHAT WAS
THE STATE LAW BEFORE THE SANCHEZ
QUESTION. CASE AND QUESTION
NUMBER TWO IS THAT SO FOR
EXAMPLE FOR EXPERT WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN A IN A- A MEDICAL
EXPERT SAYS I NOTE WHICH PARTS
OF THE FOLLOWING SYMPTOMS WERE
NOTED ONE MORE THE GIRL. THAT
LEXPERT CAN SAY BASED ON MY
OBSERVATION AND BASED ON THE
MEDICAL RECORDS I CAN. OFFER THE
FOLLOWING OPINION WITHOUT
CALLING THE PERSON WHO
ORIGINALLY ANNOTATED THE MEDICAL
RECORDS A MONTH AGO- MISSED US
THE- QUESTIONS TO YOU. YES THOSE
THEY DON'T BOB PRIOR TO SANCHEZ
WAS THAT THE EVIDENCE WAS
ENTERED SUCH THAT EXPERT
WITNESSES COULD TESTIFY TO CASE
SPECIFIC FACTS THAT THEY GOT
FROM HERE SAY SO. IN THE EXAMPLE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN
EXPERT WITNESS POSITION COULD
SAY I READ X. Y. AND Z. IN THE
MEDICAL RECORD AND I ASKED IN
ADDITION TO MY OWN OBSERVATIONS
IS WHAT I READ RIGHT ON IN. MAKE
MY OPINION THAT THE- ISSUE WITH
IT DURING THE MONEY. SAN CHANGE
THAT AND MADE IT SO THAT THE
EXPERT WITNESS COULD NOT PROVIDE
ANY CASE SPECIFIC FACTS TO BACK
UP HIS OR HER OPINION OTHER THAN
THE ONE THAT. THE PHYSICIAN-
EXPERT WITNESS HAS ACTUALLY
PERSONALLY OBSERVE THAT THANK
YOU YOU MUST I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT YOU BUT- THE DUE TO A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT COMMITTEES
THAT ARE GOING RIGHT NOW. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO HAVE SENATOR
EGGMAN OF FINISH YOUR
PRESENTATION AND THEN IF THERE'S
A MOTION AND CALL FOR THE VOTE%
EXPECTED LAST YEAR I'VE OF ART
THANK YOU. OUR BARGAIN CENTER
MOVE THE BILL- CHIEF IF YOU
WOULD THE ROLL YEAH THIS IS
THAT'S B. NINE SIXTY BY SENATOR
EGGMAN WITH MY BY CENTER COVER
YEAH OF THE MOST IS TO PASS AS
THE- I'M BURKE. I'M BURKE I'D
BORJAS. WERE JUST I COME. I DID
I. GO HERTZBERG JONES WHERE'D-
WHERE'D I STERN WHITE HOUSE GAME
I LIKE AYE WIENER. ALL RIGHT
WE'LL SEE LATER EGGMAN CENTER
CORTESE'S HERE. SENATOR CORTESE
FILE ITEM NUMBER- NUMBER. TEN
SENATE CORTESE FILE NUMBER TEN.
S. B. EIGHT THREE ONE. GO AHEAD
CENTER CORTESE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME 2% S.
B. EIGHT THREE ONE TWO TODAY. IT
FOR US FOUR ON OCTOBER TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
TALENTED CINEMATOGRAPHER LUSTER
BIPV. ON THE SET OF THE MOVIE
GROSSED ONE REVOLVER LOADED WITH
A LIVE ROUND WENT OFF KILLING
HER. AND INJURING ANOTHER. OF
MOTHER WAS TAKEN IN A FAMILY
FOREVER CHANGED SB THIRTY ONE
BEGAN AS A RESPONSE TO THE
TRAGEDY OF THE ROSE SAID. IT HAS
EVOLVED THROUGH CISCO I HAVE HAD
WITH UNIONS AND GUILDS REPRESENT
WORKERS IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY. INTO THE GROUND
BREAKING LEGISLATION THAT
ADDRESSES THE BROADER ISSUE OF
OVERALL HEALTH AND SAFETY ON
SETS. THE MAGIC OF FILM AND
TELEVISION CAN OBSCURE THE
DANGERS OF WORKING IN MOTION
PICTURE. SHOULD IS OPEN OUTSIDE
THAT IS AMBER SHOOTING SUBJECT
TO ALL KINDS OF WEATHER AND
TERRAIN CONDITIONS. THAT WERE
WORKERS CAN BE INVOLVED IN
ANYTHING FROM STANCE COMPLEX
ELECTRICAL SET UP CAR CRASHES
EXPLOSIONS ALL WHILE WORKING ON
IN THE REGULAR HOURS. OTHER
INDUSTRIES ALSO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS IN THE
WORKPLACE. WE ALL KNOW THAT OF
THE VERY FEW HAVE AS MANY IT IS
VERY THREATS. AND ALL IN ONE
PLACE WHERE THE USE OF A FIREARM
IS JUST PART OF ANOTHER DAY AT
WORK. WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THE
TRAGIC INCIDENT SECURE WORKERS
BUT WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT THE
ACCIDENTS. THAT CAUSED SERIOUS
INJURIES AND CONSTANT NEAR
MISSES. THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY WIDE LABOR MANAGEMENT
SAFETY COMMITTEE HAS DEVELOP
SAFETY BOLTON'S FOR A BROAD
ARRAY OF POTENTIAL HAZARDS
INCLUDING USE OF FIREARMS AND
SETS. BUT THOSE BULLETINS ARE
NOT BINDING. WE'RE NOT BY ANY
LAWS OR REGULATIONS BUT ONLY
RECOMMENDED GUIDELINES MANY
RESPONSIBLE PRODUCTIONS FALL
THEM BUT MANY OTHERS PAY LIP
SERVICE OTHERS ARE BOUND BY THEM
AT ALL. THE ULTIMATE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SAFETY ON ANY
SAID BUYS EMPLOYER. ACCIDENTS
ARE PREVENTABLE IF SAFETY
MEASURES ARE PRIORITIZE FOLLOWED
AND ENFORCED. WORDSMITH A LACK
THERE OF IS WHAT SB THIRTY ONE
ADDRESSES BY TAKING A PROACTIVE
RATHER THAN REACTIVE APPROACH SB
THIRTY ONE A SERVICE A CLEAR
ENFORCEABLE SAFETY STANDARDS TO
PROTECT WORKERS ON FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTIONS. IT
RESTRICTS THE USE OF LIVE
AMMUNITION ON SET MANDATES
SUFFICIENT STAFFING OF QUALIFIED
PERSONNEL WITH FIREARMS BROWN
SAID IT REQUIRES ONLY. TWO
SPECIFIC TRAINING QUALIFICATIONS
MANAGE FIREARMS DURING
PRODUCTIONS MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
BILL RECOGNIZES THAT ENSURING
THE OVERALL HEALTH AND SAFETY ON
SETS REQUIRES ON THE GROUND
OVERSIGHT. THIS BILL REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS TO HAVE A TRAINED
QUALIFIED SAFETY SUPERVISOR ON
ALL PRODUCTIONS THE SAFETY
SUPERVISOR WILL BE TASKED WITH
CONDUCTING A PRE PRODUCTION RISK
ASSESSMENT. IT WILL BE. DEBT
EVERY DAY TO HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF CAST CREW AND EVERYONE
INVOLVED IN THE PRODUCTION. THE
CONCEPT OF A SAFETY SUPERVISOR
IS NOT SOMETHING NEW TO THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
PRODUCTIONS IN THE UK AUSTRALIA
AND NEW ZEALAND ALL HAVE SAFETY
OFFICER POSITIONS AND CONSULTANT
POSITIONS AND BOTH THE US
PRODUCERS IN UNION MEMBERS
WORKING IN THOSE COUNTRIES. ARE
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH THEM. THE
END INDUSTRY. CAME TOGETHER HERE
IN CALIFORNIA THANKS IS US WE
CREATED A COVERT NINETEEN PLAN.
THAT INCLUDED COMPLIANCE
SUPERVISORS ON THE SET FOCUS
SOLELY ON COVERT RELATED HEALTH
AND SAFETY TO ENSURE THE SAFE
RETURN. TO WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. SETS WERE NEVER THE
SOURCE OF WIDE COVERT SPREAD. SO
THE POINT IS. WE KNOW IT IS
POSSIBLE TO PRIORITIZE HEALTH
AND SAFETY YOU KNOW KEEP THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO MEET THAT
CHALLENGE IF THERE'S A WILL TO
DO IT. BY CODIFYING PROVEN
SAFETY MEASURES CREATED AN
APPROVED BY THE INDUSTRY. IN
REQUIRING A CRITICAL NEW SAFETY
POSITION SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
SETS UP A FIRST IN THE NATION
REGULATORY STRUCTURE FOR HER
SAKE. AND HOLD ACCOUNTABLE.
COLLEAGUES IT'S TO CALIFORNIA.
THE HOME OF THE FILM INDUSTRY TO
SET SRONG STANDARDS OF
PROTECTION SO THAT TRAGIC
ACCIDENTS LIKE WHAT HAPPENED IN
NEW MEXICO. NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN
AND SO THAT ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY CAN CONTINUE TO THRIVE
THIS BILL MOVES US ONE STEP
CLOSER. TOWARD THE SCHOOL. WITH
US TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY ONE. TAKE A RIDE
FROM THE NATIONAL. EXECUTIVE SHE
IS THE NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE INTERNATIONAL
CINEMATOGRAPHERS GUILD I OUT SEE
LOCAL SIX HUNDRED NGOS OF
READING FROM THE DIRECTORS GUILD
OF AMERICA- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
ALREADY THANK YOU- MISS ROBIN
ARE YOU ON THE PHONE. OR MISTER
READING EITHER OF THEM. HELLO
THIS IS JOSEPH FREE ALL RIGHT
MYSTERY TO GO AHEAD. I CHAIRMAN
NUMBERED FIVE SURE GORGEOUS AND
ANNUAL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK AT YOUR HEARING TODAY. HI
MY NAME IS JOE JOSEPH REIDY I'M
AN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WHO WORKS
ALL OVER THE WORLD I'M A MEMBER
OF THE DIRECTORS GUILD OF
AMERICA I AM ALSO ON THEIR
SAFETY COMMITTEE. I'VE WORKED AS
AN ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OR EIGHTY
ON MANY PROJECTS INVOLVES STUNTS
AND OTHER RISKY ACTIVITIES SUCH
AS THE FILM'S BEFORE THE FOURTH
OF JULY AGAINST NEW YORK THE
DEPARTED AND GOODFELLAS. AS AN
ASSISTANT DIRECTOR WITH WHICH IS
KIND OF LIKE WORKING AS A STAGE
MANAGER I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
ACHIEVING THE VISION OF THE
DIRECTOR MOVING THE PRODUCTION
FORWARD IT WILL MAKE THE STUDIO. SAFETY PROGRAM. THIS IS A FR
JOB AND IT'S- IS THAN A FULL
TIME JOB IS WE'RE ALL TO- TO
WORK. LONG HOURS. AND TO PROVIDE
A PERSONAL NOTE I EXPERIENCED
SOME HEARING LOSS FROM EXCESSIVE
BY AROUND A FELT. WHEN I WORKED
IN AUSTRALIA AND THE FILM
UNBROKEN. THE PRODUCTION WAS
SUPPORTED BY A FULL TIME SAFETY
SUPERVISOR WHOSE SOLE FOCUS WAS
SAFETY. IT OPENED MY EYES TO HOW
SAFETY CAN BE DONE BETTER AND
RELIEF TO BE APPOINTED BY BAKER
WERE EACH. I'LL SOON BE WORKING
WITH THE U. K. SAFETY SUPERVISOR
ON THE FILM AND SO FERRARI.
WHICH WILL BE FILLED THAT ITALY
. UNFORTUNATELY CITY SUPERVISORS
ARE NOT UTILIZED HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. DESPITE INDUSTRY
SHAKE PEOPLE UP IN STUDIO CITY
DEPARTMENTS IN THE BEST EFFORTS
OF A SHAKY CATCHES CREW
AFFORDABLE ACTION STILL OCCUR.
ASSISTANT DIRECTORS ARE ASKING
FOR KNOWLEDGE PROFESSIONAL WHO
CAN COORDINATE WITH US IN REAL
TIME I DAY TO DAY SAFETY ISSUES.
WE NEED AN EXPERT WHO CAN
PERFORM A SCRIPTED SPECIFIC RISK
ASSESSMENT IT SERVES AS A LIVING
DOCUMENT IDENTIFYING AND
MITIGATING DANGER. WHEN I CHECK
GAVE WORK HANDS ON WITH THE CREW
AND ALL THE DEPARTMENT HEADS AND
ARE DEVOTED TO SAFETY. WE NEED
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
TEMPORARILY PAUSE PRODUCTION AS
A LAST RESORT. WE NEED MORE THAN
THE STATUS QUO WHICH IS ASSIGNED
TO STUDIO REPRESENTATIVE WHO MAY
OR MAY NOT BE FOCUSED ON OUR
PROJECT. IT'S TIME CALIFORNIA
IMPORTS THIS LIFESAVING SHAKY
BOTTLE FROM OVERSEAS. THE
DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA FOR
THE SYSTEM AB TO VOTE HI I
RESPECTFULLY SHOULD. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. ALL RIGHT. MISS
RIVER RYAN IF YOUR BILL. MISS
RIGHT- ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
THOSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT THREE ONE. SEEING KNOWN
APPROACH I FROM LET'S GO THE
PHONE AND IF MISS RYAN- CHIMES
IN WILL GO TO HER BUT LET'S DO
THE FOLKS ON THE PHONE OR IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT THREE ONE
. AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT TO ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND YOUR AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
TO REACH YOU AT THE MOMENT HE
WILL START LINE TO NINETY FIVE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS
TOM THAT'S WHAT IT'S POLITICAL
DIRECTOR WITH AYE AFTER. ONE
TWENTY TWO HERE IN SAN DIEGO AND
WE ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF A
THIRTY ONE. THIRTY THANK YOU. I
AM GOING TO ONE TWO EIGHTEEN TO
GO AHEAD. NEW MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY MY NAME IS DURING THE
ASSOCIATE NATIONAL EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE OTHER DIRECTORS
GUILD ATSG LOCAL EIGHT HUNDRED
OPINION ON A VOTE IN STRONG WIND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NINE THREE
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DEB BONY ASSISTING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE COSTUME
DESIGNERS GUILD IOTTIE LOCAL
EIGHT NINE TWO IN SUPPORT. LINE
TO NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RANDY FAIR I'M THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE MAKE UP
ARTISTS AND HAIR STYLISTS GUILD
IATSE LOCAL SEVEN AFFECTS OUR
MEMBERS ARE ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. OKAY ONE
THREE OH TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SCOTT
BERNARD ON THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR IATSE LOCAL
SIX POINT FIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE THREE HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
BOB DENNY REPRESENTING LOCAL
SEVEN TWENTY NINE I A. T. IS THE
MOTION PICTURE SET PAINTERS AND
SIGN WRITERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE NUMBER THREE OH NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS TOM DAVIS
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA IF THE
COUNCIL INTERNATIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT. SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME OF COURSE
EVEN- MOVIE DIRECTOR AND CEO OF
BUILDING TABLE PRODUCTION AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. HELLO MICHIGAN
IMAGE JERRY HAVE NO ONE ELSE
NEEDS TO AT THE TIME. HELLO THEY
HAVE REBEKAH RYAN I'M ON ALL
RIGHT MISS RYAN GO AHEAD. THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE MIX UP CHAIRMAN NUMBER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU. MY NAME IS
REBECCA RHINE AND I'M SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IOTTIE COUNCIL I AM
THE NATIONAL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE INTERNATIONAL
CINEMATOGRAPHERS GUILD. HEY I
THINK LOCAL HUNDRED REPRESENTING
OVER TEN THOUSAND WOMEN AND MEN
WORKING IN THE FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND HOME CALL CALIFORNIA
HOME. THAT BY LOCAL HAS LOST
THREE MEMBERS TO AVOIDABLE
ACCIDENT. I STAND HERE TODAY
BECAUSE LOCAL SIX HUNDRED
MEMBERS BRENT HERSHMAN JERRY
JONES AND ALAYNA HUTCHINSON
CANNOT. ALL THE SAFETY IN THE
WORLD ALL THE WRITTEN OF PAPER
NOTHING IF THEY ARE NOT IN
SUPPORT ON THE GROUND. POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES ARE NOT ON SET
PROTECTING AN EXHAUSTED CREW IN
THE EARLY HOURS OF THE MORNING.
WHERE THERE WHEN A DANGEROUS
TEAM IS BEING SHOT. OR WHEN
WEATHER AND TERRAIN MEAT ALECTRA
CITY AND CRANE. REAL SAFETY IS
ONLY ACHIEVED SOMEONE IS PRESENT
IN THE PLACE WHERE THE ACCIDENT
HAPPENED. THE JUST RELEASED NEW
MEXICO OCEAN BUREAU REPORT ON
THE ROUTE SHOOTING UNDERSCORES
THIS POINT. IT STATES THAT THE
SHOOTING WAS A COMPLETE FAILURE
OF THE EMPLOYER TO FOLLOW
RECOGNIZED NATIONAL PROTOCOL.
THEY KEEP EMPLOYEES SAFE AT THE
QUOTE. NOW SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE
CAUGHT BY THE IMPORTANT ACTIONS
IN ORDER ALL. AT WORK IN OUR
INDUSTRY LATE AND DAY THE PEOPLE
ATTEND. THE PAIR REPORT UNDER
THE LAW HI TO ALL PRODUCTION SB
EIGHT THIRTY ONE ALSO WITH FIVE
EIGHT. FIVE THEIR- CONDUCT
DETAILED. AS REPRODUCTION RICH
THE STAFF AND TO BE ON EVERY
STEP AT ALL TIMES TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE CAST
AND CREW. CURRENTLY EACH
APARTMENT IS NARROWLY FOCUSED ON
ITS OWN WORK. WITH NOBODY ON
THAT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR LOOK AT
THE BIG PICTURE AND ASK THE MARY
AT ACTIVITIES THAT ALWAYS TAKE
PLACE SIMULTANEOUSLY AND MAY
POSE A THREAT. NOW SOMEONE WILL
BE. THE STATE PROVIDE OUR EIGHT
THIS IS. AS SENATOR CORTESE
NOTED IN OTHER COUNTRIES THERE
ARE EMPLOYERS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
PRODUCED CONTENT. IT CAN BE DONE
WITH THE PROVIDER IS THERE TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
EXPERTS WILL PROVIDE AN ADDED
LAYER OF PROTECTION. THAN SURE
THEIR VOICES ARE HEARD THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT. IN AN
INDUSTRY WHERE JOHN THERE BUT
RELATIONS. AND OUT MAKE YOUR
CHANCES. OF PEACE WORK SB EIGHT
THIRTY THANK YOU MAY. FORWARD
INTO TO THE WORKING MAN AND
WOMEN IN. WE FOR YOUR I. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS RIGHT ALL
RIGHT- I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE
OTHERS HERE IN THE CHAMBER IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THIRTY ONE-
THEY MAY APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
. THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JENNA SMELLY WITH A CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSION GUSMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE TEACHERS INSIDE
AFTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT I THINK WE'VE EXHAUSTED
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT IS THAT CORRECT
MODERATOR. SB THIRTY ONE. THIS
YEAR YES ALL RIGHT LET'S NOW
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
WITNESSES LISTED AS PRIMARY
OPPOSITION IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSITION IF THEY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NONE- TURN TO
THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR ARE
ARE THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS ON THE
LINE. IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
EIGHT THIRTY ONE. IF YOU WERE
SPEAKING OPPOSITION S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE THAT'S ONE ZERO.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SO I AM NOT IN
OPPOSITION DO YOU I AM OR EIGHT
THIRTY WHAT RIGHT OF ON EACH.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT. NINE
THREE TWENTY THREE GO AHEAD.
KATHY GOING TO TAKE FROM THE
ENTERTAINMENT UNION COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MICHELLE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE WOULD YOU AT
THE TIME ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
BACK COMMITTEE QUESTIONS CENTER
THERE ALSO BE QUESTION- ALL
RIGHT- ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
SEEING NONE IS THERE A MOTION.
SENATOR ALSO MOVES THE BILL. R.
ALL RIGHT. CYNICAL DAYS YOU
COULD CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER I WILL THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
THEN SHE COUNCIL IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL THIS IS SB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE BY CENTER CORTES A
WITH A- MOTION BY CENTER
DIRECTOR WITH THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG. I AM BURKE AYE BORJAS.
CABALLERO W. I. DRESSEL THE REST
SO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG JONES
WHERE'D WHERE'D I STERN WHITE
HOUSE HE- AYE KATHY AYE WIENER.
YEAH FIVE ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL ANOTHER HOUSEKEEPING-
ITEM- FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN S. B. 1276% OF THE RASO
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA BY CENTER THE RUSSELL-
OKAY. NEXT CENTER BRADFORD IS
HERE WHICH IS FILE ITEM. NUMBER. NINE THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE.
SB. ONE FOUR ZERO ONE. THANK YOU
SIR OKAY THANK YOU YOU'RE A
MEMBERSHIP SB ONE FOUR ZERO ONE
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE EXPLOITATION
AND UNDER COMPENSATION OF
STUDENT ATHLETES IN PARTICULAR
ATHLETES IN SPORTS TO GENERATE
LARGE AMOUNTS OF REVENUE FOR
THOSE UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES
THIS BILL CONTINUES TO BUILD ON
THE WORK AT CENTER SKINNER AND I
STARTED. FOUR YEARS AGO IT FIRST
SB TWO OH SIX FAIR PAY TO PLAY-
FOR NAME IMAGE AND LIKENESS IN-
UPDATING IT- LAST YEAR WITH SB
TWENTY SIX ARM FORTINO ONE LOOKS
AT SPORTS GENERATE LARGE AMOUNTS
OF REVENUE AND WHERE THE
ATHLETES RECEIVE ONLY THEIR
SCHOLARSHIP AND RETURN AND WHICH
AMOUNTS TO A SMALL FRACTION OF
THE TOTAL REVENUE THAT IS
GENERATED FROM THAT RESPECT TO
SUPPORT. COLLEGE FOOTBALL'S BOWL
. A SUBDIVISION FOOTBALL AND DID
VISION ONE MEN AND WOMEN
BASKETBALL PLAYERS ARE
PREDOMINATELY AFRICAN AMERICAN.
AND ARE THE ONLY COLLEGE
ATHLETES IN THE STATE WE DO NOT
RECEIVE AT LEAST 50% OF THE
REVENUE. THAT IS PRODUCED BY
THEIR SPORTS LAST YEAR THE
SUPREME COURT. ROAD UNANIMOUS
FROM UNANIMOUSLY. IN THE N. C.
A. A. VERSUS AUSTIN RULING THAT
TO IN SITU WAY. I WAS ACTING IN
VIOLATION OF THE ANTITRUST LAW
BY LIVE ANY EDUCATION RELATED
COMPENSATION THAT ATHLETES
RECEIVE. THE IN SITU A STILL
RESTRICTS COMPENSATION THAT
SCHOOLS CAN PROVIDE DIRECTLY TO
THEIR ATHLETES RELATED TO THEIR
EDUCATION. AND THIS CONCURRING
OPINION ON THIS CASE JUSTICE
CALVIN ALL STATED. THE IN SITU
ES AND ITS MEMBER COLLEGES ARE
SUPPRESSING THE PAY OF STUDENT
ATHLETES WHO COLLECTIVELY
COLLECTIVELY GENERATE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN REVENUES FOR
COLLEGES EACH YEAR. BUT TO
STUDENT ATHLETES WHO GENERATE
SALES REVENUES MANY OF WHOM ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND FROM LOWER
INCOME BACKGROUNDS END UP WITH
LITTLE OR NOTHING AT ALL THE
BILL IS SET UP A DEGREE
COMPLETION FONG TO ENSURE THAT
FIFTY FIFTY PERCENT. OF THE
REVENUES GENERATED IN THOSE
SPORTS GOES BACK TO THE ATHLETES
TO INCENTIVIZE GRADUATION A
SISTER COSTA LIVING DURING
COLLEGE AND GIVE BACK A FAIR
SHARE OF THE REVENUE THAT THEY
GENERATE. THE AMOUNT DEPOSITED
IN FOREIGN FUND IS CALCULATED BY
SUBTRACTING THE AMOUNT OF THE
GRANT. IN AID IN SCHOLARSHIP IN
THAT SPORT FROM 50% OF THE
REVENUE GENERATED BY THAT
SUPPORT THE DIFFERENCE IS THEN
DIVIDED AMONGST EACH ATHLETE IN
THAT RESPECT TO SUPPORT. AN
ATHLETE HAS IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
THE FUNDS UP TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER ACTED OUT
THE ACADEMIC YEAR AND SHALL
RECEIVE THE BALANCE OF THEIR
FUNDS WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF
GRADUATING. AS LONG AS THAT
DEGREE IS COMPLETED WITHIN SIX
YEARS WE ARE CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
UNIVERSE AND STAKEHOLDER NOT
SEVERED THESE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL SUCH AS WHAT CONSTITUTES
REVENUE. PROTECTING AGAINST
EXISTING SPORTS AN ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND DETERMINING HOW
MUCH AND WHEN IS APPROPRIATE FOR
AN ATHLETE TO WITHDRAW FROM
THEIR FUN WHILE STILL ENROLLED.
ULTIMATELY WE HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
DISAGREEMENT WITH ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT. AN ATHLETE SHOULD
CHEERING ANY OF THE- THE PRODUCE
BUT WE WANT- THIS BILL TO BE
IMPLEMENTED BY THE INSTITUTIONS
FAIR TO ATHLETES IN CAPTURING
ONLY THE REVENUE THEY GENERATE
AND NOT DETRIMENTAL TO ANY OTHER
SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT RELY ON
REVENUES GENERATED BY THESE-
OTHER MORE POPULAR SPORTS. TO
THAT END THE COMMITTEE HAS ALSO
RAISED A CONCERN ABOUT THE BILL
SIMPLY SIMPLE IMPLICATIONS
IMPLICATIONS WHAT CAN READ TODAY
AS IT PERTAINS TO A TITLE NINE
REQUIREMENTS NOT TO DISCRIMINATE
ON THE BASIS OF SEX WHILE WE
BELIEVE THAT- THAT THE WAY THIS
IS FUN OPERATE AS NO
DISCRIMINATORY- AND AIMS TO
PROVIDE ALL ATHLETES WITH 50% OF
THE REVENUE GENERATED I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING. ORDER.
PRESSES TO ENSURE TE BILL NOT-
MAKE UNIVERSITIES NOT. WITH
TITLE NINE TESTIFYING TODAY IS-
HOPE USAC IS NOT AVAILABLE TODAY
SO- AND WILL HAVE- ELIJAH
HIGGINS ALLEGED AGAINST US ALL
RIGHT MISTER HIGGINS YOU ON THE
PHONE FLOOR'S YOURS. MISTER
HIGGINS. FOR MR MOHAMMED IS A
MECHANIC- MISTER IS DOUBLE
HANDED ALISA STUDENT ATHLETES ON
BILL ALL RIGHT SO IS THAT
ZATVORENA MISTER BOHANNON IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S DO THIS LET'S SUB MR
MOHANAN IF YOU COME ON THE LINE
OR IF MR HIGGINS COMES ONLINE
WILL COME BACK TO THEM BUT IN
THE MEANTIME. LET'S SOME LET'S
GO TO OTHERS AND SUPPORT THAT
ARE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED- ANYONE WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN OH
ONE. IF YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE-
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD Q. OF
THOSE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. ONE FOUR ZERO
ONE. MOTIONS CAN SUPPORT THE
BEST BE. FORTINO ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND YOUR APPETITE. AND
BOTTOM LINE TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ARE AT THE
EVENTS AND I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT I AM A FAMILY MEMBER OF
AN ATHLETE. THANK YOU. YES MR AT
WALMART YOU.
IT WAS CHAIR WILL GO TO LINE
THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CENTER BROUGHT FOR
THIS IS BACK WHEN OF MY FAULT IS
FOR THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES.
ALL RIGHT MR BEHANAN GOING ON
HERE YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ZACH
BOHANNON AND I'M A FORMER A
DIVISION ONE BASKETBALL PLAYER
AND CURRENT ORGANIZER FOR THE
NATIONAL COLLEGE PLAYERS
ASSOCIATION OR UNDER ROUGH NOTES
THE NBN SHORT. I'M TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF THE NCPA WHICH IS THE
SPONSOR OF SB FIVE ONE FOUR ZERO
ONE AND I'M NOT THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE YEAH. UP
TO REITERATE SOME OF THE POINTS
THAT ADDRESS- MADE CALLS FOR THE
FIFTEEN GOING TO OUR YOUR
INDUSTRY THAT LEAVES MANY
ATHLETES WITHOUT THE GREASE. AND
ABOUT HALF OF PULLED OUT THE
BLOOD PRODUCTS SPORTS INJURIES
ALL COLLEGE ATHLETES SHOULD
RECEIVE. FAIR COMPENSATION. PAUL
CALIFORNIA. PAY ALMOST ALL
ATHLETES PREDOMINATE WHITE. A
FAIR MORE RATE WHAT THE NINE
THEIR MARKET FOR ALL ATHLETES
AND WITHOUT. BLACK FOR.
ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA
BLACKBALLED OUT THE CHEN. THIS
SHARE OF PUBLIC REVENUE AND
STUFF FOR THE WORSE GRADUATION
RATE. TOPPED CALLED UP PRO.
RECOUP PROBABLY BLOCK IN THE-
PROPERTY MANAGER. BUT THE FROM.
AS REGULAR BROKEN. AND FEDERAL
GRADUATION RATE AMONG. FOOTBALL
PLAYERS IS SIXTY PER. AND ONLY
43% OF BLACK MEN STOPS THE
PLAYERS. AT FIVE DIVISION ONE
HIT CALL FORTY COLLEGES. LIKE
BACHELOR GRADUATE AT A RATE OF
ZERO PERCENT. LAST SUMMER THE U.
S. SUPREME COURT UNANIMOUSLY
FOUND OUT THE COMPETITION. IF I
LIST OF ANTI TRUST LAWS.
CALIFORNIA CALLED. THE VIOLATE
ANTITRUST. BY LEGALLY COLLUDING
TO LIMIT OUT THE COMPETITION. WE
SUPPORT THEM BROWN LOOKS ONGOING
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE SB ONE FOUR
ZERO ONE. IS PAID FOR BY NEW
REVENUE. WALL LEAVING EXISTING
FUNDING LEVELS TO CONTINUE TO
PAY FOR ALL SPORTS. SB ONE FOUR
ZERO ONE WITH AND ECONOMIC
EXPLOITATION OF COLLEGE
ATHLETES. IT INCREASED
GRADUATION RATES WOLPER
RESERVING. ALLSPORT THANK YOU
QUE FOR YOUR YES VOTE. THANK MR
MOHANAN I'M AYE AYE TO LEAVE-
I'M GONNA TURN THE CHAIRED.
SENATOR BORJA BEFORE I GO SO
BREAD FOR YOU WOULD. I THINK ANY
OPENING BUT I WANT GO HEAD
UNDERLINED THE CONCERNS OF THE
VOTE AYE THE CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT TO TITLE NINE AND ITS
IMPACT ON WOMEN AND THEIR
ABILITY TO- PARTICIPATE IN THEIR
ABILITY MAKE SURE THAT SPORTS
ARE BOTH. FUNDED FOR WOMEN
ATHLETES AND AVAILABLE TO WOMEN
ATHLETES AND I KNOW YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS THE CASE IT IS OUR INTENTION
TO HAVE NO IMPACT ON TITLE NINE
WE WANT WOMEN TO. TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF EVERY OPPORTUNITY JUST LIKE
MAN JUST LIKE WE DID WITH- SB
TWO OH SIX A NAME IMAGE AND
LIKENESS RIGHT NOW WOMEN ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF MORE SO
THAN. A MALE ATHLETE SO FAR SO
NOW RT THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD- CENTER BORDERS THE FOR
THE CHAIRMANSHIP IS YOURS NOW.
FANTASTIC.
NOTICE OF DEPOSITION. ANDERSON.
ORANGE I'M NOT MISTAKEN NINE WE
HAVE- CONCLUDED OUR SUPPORT AND
MOVING INTO INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION FOR TO
HAVE ANY BOOKS ON RECORD WISHING
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION. NO. ANY
OF A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION IF YOU PLEASE
LIMITED TO YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
AND POSITION. ALL RIGHT ARE
MOVING TO MODERATOR MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE LET US KNOW IF
FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE. NOT TO
OPPOSE SB FOURTEEN OH ONE AND IF
SO HOW MANY THERE MIGHT BE. SURE
LOOKS LIKE WE RE IN THE MOMENT
ALL RIGHT LET ME JUST REMIND
FOLKS CALLING IN PLEASE LIMIT
YOUR- COMMENTS TO NAME.
OPPOSITION AFFILIATION AND
POSITION PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HELLO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. EXPRESSING SUPPORT
LIKE PS FINAL SUPPORT SB
FOURTEEN A ONE. ONE TWO FIFTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JEANETTE AND I WOULD
LIKE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. NINE THREE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON I
TELL OUR REGULAR BE AFTER THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA- WE DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL OPPOSE
POSITION AT THIS TIME- ON THE
BUILDING WILL BE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE IMPACT. THAT IT WILL
HAVE ON YOU SEE ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. BORDERLINE
THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS SANJAY FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY WE
ALSO DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION BUT HAVE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE THREE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CANNOT LOCATE YOUR CLEANING THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. AND WE'RE GOING
TO SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALEX GREAT THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES- AND R. EIGHTY
MEMBERS INCLUDING TEND TO
COMPETE AT THE DIVISION ONE
LEVEL- WE ARE- WITHIN MINUTES
RIGHT NOW MOVING. TO IN OPPOSE
POSITION. MISTER JERRY HAVE NO
ONE ELSE INTO IT. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK- TO
THE DAIS ANY- COLLEAGUES SIR
WHAT CASTING. I'M I'M ON PAGE
EIGHT OF THE STAFF ANALYSIS AND
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
OTHER ATHLETES THAT PARTICIPATE
IN. ALL KINDS OF ACTIVITY AND
WHAT THE STAFF REPORT TALKS
ABOUT IS THE TITLE NINE
SEPARATION OF YOU KNOW AN
EDUCATION PROGRAM ANY EDUCATION
PROGRAM SO IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
THAT THE UNIVERSITY WOULD HAVE
TO WHATEVER THE FOOTBALL PLAYERS
GOT. FOR TUTORING OR SOMETHING
MENTAL- EDUCATION TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN SCHOOL EVERY OTHER
PROGRAM HAD TO DO AND THEY MAYBE
THEY DO I DON'T KNOW BUT THEN IT
SAYS WERE. FOR ACTIVITY. AND
THAT ACTIVITY MAY BE THE TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT ARE
BE GIVE THAT WILL BE GIVEN TO
FOOTBALL PLAYERS AND BASKETBALL
PLAYERS IN THE SPORTS THAT RAISE
A LOT OF MONEY. CAN YOU ANSWERED
THAT IF HE SAID. HE SAID EACH
UNIVERSITY WOULD HAVE TO GIVE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
WHERE STUDENT WAS IN SCHOOL OR
GIVE THEM OPPORTUNITIES TO
GRADUATE WITHIN SIX YEARS SO
THERE WILL BE EQUAL WOULD
REQUIRE AGAIN. THE FIRM HERE IS
UNFOUNDED BECAUSE IF YOU'RE NOT
MAKING A PROFIT IS NO REVENUE TO
BE SHARED TO BE PUT INTO THIS
ACCOUNT FOR STUDENT ATHLETES TO
BENEFIT FROM ITS ONLY THOSE
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
SURE ACTIONS. ARE ARE MAKING A
PROFIT IF YOU'RE BREAKING EVEN
WITH YOUR SCHOLARSHIP AND HOW
WHAT YOU DO FOR ATHLETES WHETHER
YOU'RE A FEMALE ATHLETE OR MALE
ATHLETE WILL NOT BE IMPACTED AT
ALL IT'S ONLY FOR THOSE REVENUE
. IT'S A BEYOND. THAT PROFIT IF
IT'S NOT. IT'S NOTHING TO BE
SHE- IT'S A ZERO SUM GAIN IT'S
NO. OF NO PROFIT BY THESE
UNIVERSITIES BUT IF BUT IF 50%
OF THE PROFIT LET'S SAY LET'S
SAY THE THERE WAS. EVERYBODY
GREET THE DAY YOU HAD TO PROVIDE
WITH ALL THE ATHLETES. WITH
COMPENSATION TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IF THEY GOT. IF
YOU HAVE IF YOU REQUIRE. HALF OF
IT TO GO TO THE JUSTICE
STUDENTS- IN THE IN THAT
ACTIVITY IN THAT SPORT. THERE
MIGHT NOT BE ENOUGH AROUND. ON
WITHIN THE HIGH I WANT TO SEE
THE SPORTS BUDGET THAT'S NOT HOW
IT'S LOOK AT FOR YOU SEE. IF
THAT'S ENOUGH BUDGET TO GIVE
THOSE OTHER. OTHER STUDENTS THE
SAME TREATMENT. I MEAN I MEAN I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT YOU
WE HAVE THIS HARD RULE THAT IF
YOU'RE IN A SPORT AND THE
WRITTEN GET REVENUE LET'S SAY
IT'S IT THERE'S A NUMBER THERE
IF THAT REVENUE CAN'T BE SHARED
BECAUSE NOW THERE'S NEW
REQUIREMENTS MINUTES STUDENTS
NOBODY'S GETTING TWENTY FIVE
GRAND TO GET TO GO TO SCHOOL AND
BE IN ANY SPORT RIGHT IT MAY BE
THAT THIS IT MAYBE THAT'S A GOOD
OUTCOME- I JUST BROKEN. WITH
THAT IS AYE AYES AYE READ. THE
STAFF ANALYSIS ON TIELINE IN
SAYING. AND SAYING IT'S THESE
ACTIVITIES BESIDES JUST THE
EDUCATION BECAUSE- THEY HAVE TO.
YOU KNOW. HAVE TO TREAT THEM THE
SAME. I GET THAT AND I GET TO
CONCERNED ABOUT TITLE NINE I
HAVE FRIENDS AND FAMILY WERE.
FOR COACHES- WELL I HAVE A
COUSIN WHO'S A WOMAN'S
VOLLEYBALL COACH. AND THEY
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT
WOMEN'S SPORTS ARE NEGLECTED
MORE SO THAN ANY OTHER ONES BUT
AGAIN. THIS WILL NOT HAVE ANY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON. WOMEN'S
SPORTS ARE UNIVERSITIES IT WOULD
DO NOTHING TO THEM IF THERE'S-
EXTRA RECORD REVENUE THAT CAN BE
SHARED. THE ONLY STAND TO GAIN
FROM THIS PROGRAM. IF THERE IS
PROFITS TO BE MADE AND IT'S-
ABOVE AD BEYOND THE TWENTY
FIRST. I LET'S LET'S SEE EVERY
ATHLETE GOT. TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON THE FOOTBALL TEAM.
AND THEN WITH THE EXTERIOR.
STANDARD THOUSAND. LEFT OVER. WE
WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGES. FUND
ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES FOR
WOMEN'S SPORTS OR THOSE NON
REVENUE WHETHER IT'S WRESTLING.
OR BADMINTON WHAT WHATEVER I
MEAN THOSE SPORTS GENERATE NO
REVENUE- OFFER COLLEGES BUT
THESE ARE SCHOOL SCHOLARSHIP
ATHLETES NONE THE LESS. IS IT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING MISTER CHAIR
HE SAID. I MEAN I. SORT OF HAVE
GROWN UP. NOT THAT I'M GROWN UP
NOW BUT AS I WAS GROWING UP. HE
SAID THAT HE SAID. HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL
SUBSIDIZED ALL THESE OTHER
SPORTS I JUST SORT OF. ASSUMED
THAT THEY GENERATE MONEY. AND
NOBODY WENT TO A BASEBALL GAME
AND- THEY HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT
STUFF. SO YOU'RE- YOU. YOU'RE
TALKING PROFIT YOU'RE SAYING
THAT YOU PAY FOR THAT. THOSE
EXPERTS CURRENT EXPENSES THAT
YOU HAVE NOT YOU JUST.
SINGULARLY LOOK THAT ONLY.
EXPENSES FOR FOOTBALL. YEAH
WE'RE AGAIN WE'RE NOT AWAY ANY
OF CURRENT FUN THAT ACROSS THE
BOARD YOU WILL SEE FOR EXAMPLE
TOTAL SCHOLARSHIPS FOR ATHLETES
IT'S TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
AND COMPOSITION COACHES BUT
TWELVE OF TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. OUR PROGRAM WOULD NOT
TOUCH THAT IT WOULD ONLY ADD TO
THAT FOR THE ATHLETES BENEFIT
BUT USC GIVE ME A FANTASY TOUR
THE OTHER DAY. AND I ASSURE YOU
THERE PROGRAM RIVAL SOME
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS PROGRAMS AND
THEY WERE SHOWING ME WHY THIS
BILL WAS UNNECESSARY BUT I
WALKED AWAY SAYING THIS BILL IS
EVEN MORE SO I'M EVEN MORE SO
COMMITTED TO THIS BECAUSE I KNOW
THE MAJORITY OF COLLEGES DON'T
HAVE THOSE RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE AT USC YOU KNOW HOW THOSE
TYPE OF FACILITIES THEY DON'T
HAVE THE PSYCHIATRIST AT THE
INTRODUCED ME TO AN ALL BOYS AND
EVERY COLLEGE IS NOT BENEFITING
FROM THAT SO WE'RE SEEING. IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
THAT'S INCENTIVIZE THOSE
ATHLETES NOT ONLY TO STAND
SCHOOL BUT TO GRADUATE AND
THAT'S- WHAT ARE YOU SEE IF IT'S
NO PROPERTY BE SHARED IT'S NO
HARM HERE RIGHT I GUESS I'M-
LOOKING AT AND LOOKING AT. THE
FUNDS THAT ARE GIVEN TO THE
STUDENTS THAT SO THEY SUCCEED IN
COLLEGE AND WE USE THAT EXAMPLE
HERE IS TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT I WOULD THINK THAT
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO. GIVE THAT TO
ALL. STATE WHETHER THEY'RE ON
BADMINTON WRESTLING SO THAT THEY
SUCCEED ALSO SAID THAT HAVE
EQUAL TREATMENT THE ACTIVITY IS
THE SAME. I'M NOT TAKEN OPINION
NOT AND I GUESS I JUST SPOT THE
ISSUE GOT. SIR CABALLERO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR SO
FOR ME TO START OFF BY SAYING
THAT- RULES YOUR MIND THAT. THIS
IS A SCHOOL SET- UTILIZE STUDENT
ATHLETES AS PART OF THEIR
PROGRAM. THEY THEN DON'T
GRADUATE THOSE STUDENT ATHLETES
. I TO BE. FORECLOSED FROM
PARTICIPATING BEYOND KIND OF THE
REGULAR SEASON BECAUSE I FEEL
REALLY STRONGLY THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF UNIVERSITIES ON NOT
TOO MANY OF THEM CALIFORNIA BUT
BUT THERE ARE NUMBERED THEY
GRADUATE. THEIR ATHLETES RIGHT-
AND- IT'S PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC WHEN YOU CONSIDER
THAT THEIR ATHLETES OF COLOR ARE
EVEN WORSE OFF THAN THAT- SO I'M
SUPPORTING OF YOUR GOAL OF THE
BILL THE ISSUE I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A ALONG WITH- WHAT
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE SAID IS-
AS I UNDERSTAND THE BILL. IS
THAT THE SPORTS. IN THE SPORT
THAT GENERATES THE REVENUE. GETS
THE REVENUE FOR THEIR ATHLETES.
AND THAT'S THE SPLIT AND IF
YOU'RE IN A SPORT THAT IS A NON
REVENUE GENERATING SPORT- THEN
YOUR ATHLETES ARE NOT GONNA
BENEFIT BECAUSE THERE WON'T BE
MONEY THERE WILL BE REVENUE
THERE WON'T BE EXCESS REVENUES
IT'S HIM I AM AM I CORRECT
THAT'S THAT'S ACCURATE
ASSESSMENT I MEAN IT'S FOR THESE
ATHLETES WHO ARE GENERATING THE
REVENUE BUT- BENEFITING. SO
AGAIN. GREATER INCENTIVIZING
THEM BY SETTING MONEY ASIDE AND
HOPING THAT THEY GRADUATE
BECAUSE AGAIN THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO PUT -(*** IN SEATS WELCOME TO
A BATMAN GAME I'M SORRY WELL IN
FACT PART OF THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU RUN INTO QUITE FRANKLY IS
THAT WELL I SHOULD SAY NO ONE'S
PAYING THE TICKETS ARE FREE TO
THOSE GUYS YEAH WELL AND THAT
THIS GETS AT THE CRUX OF IT I'M
GONNA I'M GONNA SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY I I'VE GOTTEN A BUNCH
OF COMMENTS. IN OPPOSITION FROM
PEOPLE THAT- WORK IN THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM- AND I THINK
THE ISSUE REGARDING TITLE NINE
IS THAT- MANY OF THAT WOMEN'S
SPORTS PROGRAMS ARE FREE
TICKETS- AND THEY DON'T GENERATE
REVENUE AND THAT'S WHERE YOU GET
INTO THE AN EQUAL YOU KNOW-
ISSUE. IT'S GOING TO NEED TO BE
RESOLVED AT SOME POINT I JUST
THINK IT'S GOT TO BE RESOLVED
AND IT NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS.
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT. WERE
AND I REALLY LIKE WHERE YOU'RE
GOING WITH THIS I WENT I WENT
STUDENT ATHLETES TO GRADUATE-
AND I AND I WANT THERE TO BE A
COMMITMENT. TO THE PROGRAM. THAT
THEY THEY GET THEIR STUDENT
ATHLETES TO GRADUATE I MEAN I
THAT'S IT JUST IT'S- I THINK
IT'S FUNDAMENTAL WHERE WE WHERE
WHERE THE GOING TO COLLEGE THEN.
AND WE'RE IT WE'RE JUST USING
THEM AND THEN MOVING ON RIGHT.
AND I AND I GET IT BUT I BUT I
DO THINK THERE'S GONNA BE SOME.
SOME EQUITY ISSUES AND WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
THIS OUT AND I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER FOR IT LIKE I SAID I'M
GOING TO. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY BUT I DO THINK THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE- IF. WE
WHILE I DO WANT TO SUPPORT THEM
THE ATHLETES THAT ARE IN THE
REVENUE. GENERATING CATEGORY
ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT THEM THE
ATHLETES. THAT ARE NOT IN THE
REVENUE GENERATING PROGRAM
TONIGHT I THINK THE- FOR WOMEN
TO BE. EQUALLY TO MEN IN THE
PROFESSIONAL WORLD HAS BEEN
REALLY IMPORTANT. TERRIFIC TO
SEE THE WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM
FINALLY GET PAID FOR SOME STUFF
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THAT. THEY'VE
BEEN UNDER COMPENSATED SO WE'RE
JUST GONNA HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
SO- I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER- DRAWS A YEAH-
JUST TO REITERATE- THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT.
COULD IMPACT WOMEN AND- WE NEED
TO B. LOOK AHEAD AND NOT JUST
SORT OF REACT TO THAT SO- BUT
THAT WOULD THAT OF- COMINTERN'S
SUPPORT THANK YOU AREN'T ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
WISHING TO COMMENT SEEING NONE-
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. GOING TO
CLOSE ALL SORRY YES BY ALL
MEANS. AND IN ONE OF THOSE DAYS
MAN NO I APPRECIATE IT AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THAT ARE
MADE IN THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED IN IN IN THIS BY NO
MEANS WHAT ARE YOU CARRYING A
BILL THAT I THOUGHT WAS GONNA
HURT. ANY SPORTS ESPECIALLY
WOMEN'S SPORTS AGAIN I HAVE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE COACHING
WOMEN'S TEAMS SO I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS I'VE FOUGHT FOR
FUNDING AT A UNIVERSITY ERASED
DATA DID FUND RAISERS FOR
WOMEN'S BASKETBALL TEAM AT CAL
STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS WHO ARE
GRADUATED FROM SO I UNDERSTAND.
WORDS OF THIS. WORST TRYING TO
ACHIEVE HERE IS AGAIN A REVENUE
PULL FOR A PROFIT AND WHEN I
SAID BATMAN AND I'M IT NO ONE.
PIECE FOR BATMAN GAMES THOSE
GAMES ARE FREE THOSE ATHLETES
ARE ATHLETES ON THE LAST JUST AS
SERIOUS AS SOMEBODY ON THE
FOOTBALL FIELD. THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS NOBODY'S WILLING
TO PAY FIFTY DOLLARS YOU KNOW
AND ACTUALLY GIVE THOSE TICKETS
AWAY SO I'M SEEING THOSE ARE NOT
REVENUE GENERATING SPORTS BUT-
SPORTS NONETHELESS ATHLETES THAT
NEED TO BE RESPECTED AND
PROTECTED. AND AGAIN THE BILL
WILL HAPPEN IMPACT. STUDENTS ARE
WHETHER THEY'RE MALE OR FEMALE
AND AS I STATED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS WHAT WE'VE LEARNED SO
FAR IN A SHORT PERIOD. NAME INCH
IMAGE. BIT ENACTED THEIR WOMEN
ATHLETES WERE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE LOCAL
HOMETOWN HEROES AND- THE LOCAL
CAR DEALERSHIP FOR THE STORE
WANTS TO YOU KNOW SPONSOR THEM
OR HAVE THEM ADVERTISE. OUR
PRODUCTS SO THEY HAVE BENEFITTED
THEY HAVE SIGNED WHAT CONTRACTS
IN THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF
SINCE NAME AND MATURE- SO WE'RE
- MOVING FOR WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT. WE'RE GOING
LOOK AT- NINE. ONE THING THIS
BILL. MAY NOT DO IS HER TOP NOT
IT'S NOT GONNA TAKE ANYTHING
AWAY FROM WOMEN'S SPORTS IF
EVERYTHING WORKS WELL SB UPTICK
IN THOSE REVENUES COULD BE
SHARED ACROSS THE BOARDS ARE
RESPECT US WE ARE ABLE. ALL
RIGHT TO HAVE A MORE HONESTY
ROUTINE- WHAT KASKY MOVED BILL
THANK YOU IS TO PAY BUT FOR BE
RE. TO THE CAN ON APPROACH. TO
CANCEL CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS SB FOURTEEN ONE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD WITH THE MOTION
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI.
BURKE YES. CABALLERO CAREER- I
DID ALSO THE REST SO I.
HERTZBERG JONES LAYERED LAYERED
ICED WHITE HOUSE SKI WORKOUTS
SKI I WIENER YOU HAVE FOR TWO
ZERO SO FAR MY THANK LOOK BILL
ON CALL. ALL RIGHT WE ARE NOT
MOVING. BACK TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE
S. B. TWELVE TWO TWO SEVEN OR
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN CENTER
EGGMAN IS BACK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH REVOLVING TOWARDS TODAY-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS OF
MY TALKING POINTS OUT BUT I
THINK I CAN JUST DO THIS- I AM
HERE TO. AS SO RIGHT NOW
SOMEBODY GOES THROUGH A HOLD SO
CAN WE TALK ABOUT THE LPS IN THE
IN THE CONTINUUM OF TOOK
CONSERVATORSHIP HOPEFULLY NOT
GETTING THEIR THREE GOES THEY'RE
HELD AGAINST THEIR WILL THERE
THAT'S GOOD AND THEN COULD STAY
FOR UP TO JUDGE BACK WITH THE
JOB. AT THE END OF THAT. AND
AGAIN TO MY PEOPLE WHO ARE READY
TO GO TO GO HOME AND ON VACATION
FOR TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO IF
THEY'RE NOT. CONSERVATORSHIP SO
THIS WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY DAYS HAS BEEN AUTHORIZED
FOR PEOPLE TO TRY IN BETWEEN THE
TWO WE COLD ENOUGH POTENTIAL
CONSERVATORSHIP. THE GUARDIANS.
WITH THIS YEAR. IN ORDER TO ASK
FOR A LOT OF THINGS TO HELP THEM
OUT. I OFTENTIMES ARE THE ONES
WHO ARE WHO ARE- DEALING WITH
WITH PEOPLE WHO WHO WHO WHO NEED
EXTRA HELP UP TO ADD IN THE-
THIRTY TWO. BILLS DOESN'T TO BE
IN A- FEW DAYS THEY COULD.
THIRTY DAYS HREE COUNTS. ST RT
THIS A WAS A STATE IN THE MARINE
CARE. BEING ABLE TO USE THAT AS
AN- REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE.
MEMBERSHIPS THE IS.
INTO A CONSERVATORSHIP AND HERE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I HAVE
RENTAL HAGAR SHE SMOOTH SOUNDS
OF RANDALL HAGAR. HOW DO WE ALSO
ARE WE EXPECTING- DR ALEXIS C.
AND AS WELL SHE IS NOW SEEING
PATIENTS GOT IT GOT IT OKAY- MR
HAGAR. ARE YOU ON THE LINE AT
EIGHT. I AM INDEED THANK YOU
SENATOR EGGMAN COULD HAVE
INTRODUCTION- SIR. SO YOU KNOW I
THINK THE THING IS HERE THAT
THERE'S-SOME VERY ARMY FROM SKY
INTEREST PERCENT ACTIVE- AND LET
ME INTRODUCE MYSELF RENTAL ACRE
FOR THE PSYCHIATRIC VETERANS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA. I'M
THERE ARE SOME REALLY OBVIOUS
THINGS THAT THE CRISIS YOU MAY
NOT KNOW ABOUT- THAT THAT MEANS
THAT TREATMENT SOMETIMES OFTEN
TAKES LONGER THAN YOU EXPECT.
AND THEREFORE GOING A LITTLE BIT
MORE TIME ON THE BACK END AND
AVOIDING THE CONSERVATORSHIP OF
THAT THING- IF YOU CAN GET A LOT
MORE TIME TO TREAT. SO NOTE. MY
SECOND. ESPECIALLY WITH BEEN
PRACTICE A LONG TIME THAT
PATIENT SICK IN THEY HAVE BEEN.
OUR GENERATIONS AND THAT'S
BECAUSE OF A COUPLE OF THINGS-
THEY THEY OFTEN COME INTO
INPATIENT UNITS AND THEY START
WITH A FIFTY ONE. AND THEN THE
FOURTEENTH A HOLD ON THE THIRTY
DAY ALL- THEY'RE THEY'RE SICKER
BECAUSE THEY OFTEN HAVE-
PHYSICALLY ON- MORE. OPEN HOUSE
ISSUES ISSUE ON. AND THESE
THINGS CAN ALL TAKE LONGER TO-
BUT THEY'RE ALL OTHER. THAT COME
INTO THE- AND SO IT DOWN A THE-
CONTINUE WITHIN IN. SECTOR OF
THOSE THAT THE ARE YOU KNOW YOU
CAN OBTAIN MEDICATION ORDERS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE RESISTANT
TO MEDICATION AND SOMETIMES
SCHEDULING THOSE. GETTING
HEARINGS GOING. TAKES MORE
PLANNING DOWN THEN YOU KNOW I
MEAN THEIR STATUTORY STANDARDS
THEREBY. YOU KNOW. PICKING
SOMETIMES IT TAKES LONGER- AT
THE END AND IN EACH CASE SO LIKE
COURT DAY IN THE FOR ALL THEY
HAVE OR- ASIAN CREATURE THE SO.
THAT HEARINGS. AND THAT KIND OF
MINISTRY PROCESSES THEY HAD THE
TIME. TO TREAT BY THE UNTREATED
DURATION OF PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS
ON THE STREETS. IT'S NOTHING
LIKE WE'VE EVER SEEN BEFORE
PEOPLE AGAIN AFTER LONGER
THEY'RE SICKER AND THE MORE THEY
GO UNTREATED- THE LAST. YOU KNOW
ABLE IT IS FOR SIX HIGH INTEREST
TO BRING BACK BASELINE. AND THEY
STRUGGLE AND THEY AND THEY WORK
ON THAT AND THEN THEY GET HIM
BACK TO CASE ONE BUT IT TAKES A
LONG TIME. IT ALSO TAKES TIME TO
SELECT THE CORRECT MEDICATION-
THOSE TYPES OF DISCONTINUATION
BECAUSE MEDICAID ARE. MAYBE
JACKSON SO ALL OF YOUS TOGETHER
YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF COMBINED
TELL US THAT IF WE JUST OVER
MORE TIME ON IN SOME CASES
TOWARD YOU KNOW- THE END OF THAT
FOR THIRTY DAYS PERIOD YOU COULD
ADD. CHIEF SINGLE- IN
STABILIZING PATIENT. EXAM BOTH
STABLE HARVESTERS GO AND YOU
KNOW NEED TO GO CONSERVE FROM
WILL THAT THIS TO TREAT AND YOU
ON THE X. TIME. TO DO THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT BILL IS ABOUT FAMILY
OPERATE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MR HAGAR ALL RIGHT MOVING ON TO
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE. TO SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. PLEASE COME FORWARD
AND IDENTIFY YOUR NAME IS
AFFILIATION A POSITION PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS AGAIN WE WERE TOP HERE
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO MAYOR
TODD GLORIA AND HE IS A MEMBER
OF THAT- BIG CITY MAYORS
COALITION WHICH IS AGAIN IN. A
SUPPORT AND CO SPONSORSHIP OF
THE ENTIRE EGGMAN PACKAGE OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ALSO ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISHING
TO SPEAK SUPPORT. NON MODERATE
ONCE THE ISLANDS- AND IF YOU
COULD LET US KNOW THERE ARE
FOLKS IN THE QUEUE HOW MANY
THERE BE. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN. WE HAVE
THREE ARE IN QUEUE. IF YOU WISH
TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. WITH ONE THREE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY WELL ONE
TWO FIFTY ONE THE HEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KELLY O'DONNELL WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. OKAY JUST ONE MOMENT
SHARE. OKAY WE'LL GO ONE THREE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS PAUL
YOUR ON THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRISTS
AND SAM SISCO MARYLAND BREED IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND ONE THREE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CARE OFTEN BE OF THE CITY
STOCKTON IN SUPPORT. YOU SHOULD
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT
THE TIME ALL RIGHT FOLLOWING THE
SAME PROTOCOL DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PRESENT
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KIM PETERSON I AM
ATTORNEY AT DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND I FOCUS ON LEGAL
ISSUES RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY DRC OPPOSES THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE HAS NO
DATA UPON WHICH TO MAKE AN
INFORMED DECISION ABOUT WHETHER
EXTENDING THE FIFTY TO SEVENTY
HOLD FOR AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
DAYS. IS AN INTERVENTION THAT IS
LIKELY TO LEAD TO SUSTAINED
POSSIBLE. POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
PEOPLE SUCH THAT IT JUSTIFIES.
THE INCREASE TIME. ANY DECISION
TO ENACT LAWS THAT INFRINGE ON
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTIES SHOULD BE
DRIVEN BY CLEAR DATA AND NOT
PRESUMPTIONS. LAST WEEK DRC
AGREES WITH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WITHOUT WITHOUT DATA TO
SUPPORT THE NEED FOR AN EXTENDED
FIFTY TO SEVENTY HOLD THE STATE
CANNOT SHOW THAT THE
INFRINGEMENT OF LIBERTY IS
JUSTIFIED BY A COMPELLING
GOVERNMENT INTEREST. IN HOLD
SHOULD NOT BE AN ENTITLEMENT
TWENTY TWO JUDICIAL REVIEW. IN
CONCLUSION EXTENDING INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT DOES NOT RESOLVE THE
UNDERLYING SOCIAL CAUSES OF
REVOLVING DOOR HOSPITALIZATIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. THREATS GOOD AFTERNOON GOING
BACK AS FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IN OPPOSITION. OTHER THAN
ADEQUATE EVIDENCE THAT DETAINING
PEOPLE FOR AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
DAYS IS NARROWLY TAILORED AND
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE MEANS OF
ACCOMPLISHING A COMPELLING
GOVERNMENT INTEREST CONSISTENT
WITH DISTRICTS SCRUTINY TEST FOR
EVALUATING GOVERNMENT
RESTRICTIONS OF FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHTS. IMAGERY CONVENIENCE OF
AVOIDING A CONSERVER HEARING IS
INADEQUATE FOR JUSTIFYING AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY DAYS OF
INVOLUNTARY HOLDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU- MODERATE DO WE HAVE A
KIM PETERSON ON THE LINE. OR
EXCUSE ME. ALL RIGHT MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE PHONE
LINES- FOLKS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF THE COULD- PLEASE
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES BY NAME-
FILIATION IMPOSITION. ANALYSTS
KNOW HOW MANY ARE IN THE- DID
YOU WISH SPEAKING OPPOSITION OF
S. B. TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE SHOULD
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT BRING IT
BACK ON TO THE DAIS. SIR WHAT%
KASKY YOU'RE ONFIRE TODAY YOU
KNOW I WASN'T GOING TO GO UP ON
THIS BILL AND NOW. YOU'RE
WITNESSES HAVE TRIGGERED SOME
THOUGHTS IN MY MIND- BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE WE'RE LAWYERS AND WE
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF US
ARE LAWYERS TALK ABOUT NARROWLY
TAILORING TO LEAST RESTRICTIVE
TO THE DID AS A LAWYER TALK
THAT'S WE WANT. AND ONE OF YOUR
WITNESSES CAN'T BE HERE BECAUSE
SHE'S TREATING PATIENTS SO SHE
HAS THIS OTHER JOB OTHER THAN
GOING TO COURT AND TELLING US
WHAT THE TREATMENT PLAN IS BUT
YOUR OTHER WITNESS SAID THAT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GO TO COURT
FOR THE FOURTEEN DAY HOLD IN FOR
THE THIRTY DAY HOLD ITS THIS
OTHER THIS NEXT THIRTY DAY HOLD
ALSO GOING TO INCORPORATE GOING
TO. COURT SO THAT THE COURT FACT
DOES HAVE JUDICIAL REVIEW BEFORE
THEY AUTOMATICALLY GIVE YOU THE
THIRTY DAYS THE THAT IS CORRECT
THAT IS OUR INTENTION AND IF
THAT IS NOT CLEAR WE ARE GLAD TO
TAKE ANY AMENDMENT TO MAKE THAT
CLEAR THAT THE INTENTION OKAY SO
THIS IS NOT. THE END AND THE
COMPELLING STATE GOVERNMENT
INTEREST FOR HOLDING THESE
PEOPLE I THINK IT WAS
ARTICULATED IS THAT YOU WANT TO
AVOID CONSERVATORSHIP WHICH YOU
BELIEVE IS LESS RESTRICTIVE THAN
A SUCCESSFUL. MANAGEMENT
PSYCHIATRIC POINT WHERE BECAUSE
WHATEVER YOU PEOPLE CALL THAT ON
THAT IS THAT CORRECT THAT IS
CORRECT. OKAY WE BELIEVE AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY DAYS IS LESS
RESTRICTIVE THAN A FULL. SHIFT
SO. WHAT MIGHT THE YOUR WITNESS
WAS TALKING ABOUT. BEING THE
MEDICATION RIGHT I MEAN IS THERE
SOMETHING SPECIAL ABOUT FORTY
SEVEN DAYS THAT'S WHAT THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE NOW WHICH
I'M GUESSING WOULD ACTED. WE GOT
. FOURTEEN AND THIRTY GIVE YOU
FORTY SEVEN RIGHT YEAH AND I
FORTY THREE I THINK AS AS AS
WITH YOUR HAGAR TALKED ABOUT-
PEOPLE ARE COMING MORE ILL THAN
THEY USED TO. EXTEND INTO THEIR
THEIR THEIR THEIR BEHAVE HEALTH
ISSUES AND ALSO OFTENTIMES WITH
COMORBIDITY SUBSIDY USE ANOTHER
KIND OF MEDICAL ISSUES THAT THAT
NEED. TREATMENT AT THE SAME
TIME- I ARE YOU SUGGESTING THE
EXAMPLE OF WE ALL HAVE FAMILY
ISSUES WITH THIS RIGHT I HAD AN
AUNT WHO HAD SEVERE AND
PERSISTENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
MY COUSIN HAS FOR YEARS UNTIL
SHE DIED AS LEICESTER GOD REST
YOUR SOUL- SAID YOU KNOW MY MOM
WASN'T SICK ENOUGH FOR YOU TO
KEEP A FOR THIRTY DAYS. BUT SHE
WAS SICK ENOUGH TO GO OUT AND
GET RID. THE BE I. B. H. SO TO
MY IN AND OUT OF THE- MY BECAUSE
WOULD BAG PLEASE KEEPER OF THAT
ADDITIONAL TIME BECAUSE THEN SHE
CAN GET STABILIZED WHEN SHE CAN
GET STABILIZE ON THE MEDICATION
SHE CAN MAKE GOOD DECISIONS BUT
UNTIL THAT TIME. SHE WASN'T ABLE
TO AND SO THE REVOLVING DOOR OF
IN AND OUT IN AND OUT AND IN AND
OUT THIS GIVES A LITTLE BIT
EXTRA TIME TO GET PEOPLE
STABILIZE BECAUSE SOMETIMES A
MEDICATION MIX DOESN'T WORK EVEN
IF YOU HAVE HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
A. B. YOU MIGHT HAVE IT TAKES A
CERTAIN MEDICATION TO BE ABLE TO
TREAT YOUR YOUR SPECIFIC. THIS
MISTER WHAT TYPE OF IT MEANS TO
THE PSYCHIATRIST AND FOLKS IN
THIS FIELD SPEND IN COURT
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE I MEAN IF
YOU HAVE TO GO TO COURT FOR
FOURTEEN DAY HOLDING YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE COMING IN AND
THEN A THIRTY DAY HOLD YOU HAVE
TO GO IN AND YOU HAVE TO WRITE
THAT REPORT YOU HAVE TO DO IT
HOW MUCH OF THEIR TIME. IS SPENT
ON. PROVIDING NARROWLY TAILORED
EVIDENCE TO THE COURT ON THE
SPECIFIC TREATMENT PLAN THAT YOU
HAVE. VERSUS ACTUALLY. SEEING
THE PATIENT DOING THE TREATMENT
PLAN AND WE WILL HAVE PAPERWORK
MORE THAN ANYBODY WOULD LIKE.
RIGHT SO IT'S- BECAUSE- BECAUSE
THAT'S DATA SEWER WE WERE
WORRIED ABOUT THAT AT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE DATA. BUT IF WE KNEW
THAT THERE'S AND THEN. OF TOP
THAT SPENT ON. WELL THE BALANCE
OF TIME BETWEEN THE TREATMENT
AND WRITING IT AND THEN AND THEN
HOW THAT WHAT THAT THIRTY DAY
ADDITIONAL THIRTY GET A FULL
NOTE BEFORE I CAME HERE PSYCH
GET THE MEDICINES PRIDE PRIDE
BALANCE THAT PER BECAUSE IT
SEEMS THERE ARE. WAS THERE MORE
STE EARLY- PHYSICALLY OF A
SICKER OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE SICKER
THAT IS JUST NOT FORTY SEVEN
DAYS HIM AND WE'RE DONE- AND-
DAN THE GOAL WHICH IS NORMAL OF
AVOIDING THE- OF THAT SO. I FEEL
BETTER NOW. THEN THEN I WOULD
ALSO SUGGEST THAT PEOPLE OF SAID
THERE'S NOT ANY DATA AND YOU ALL
KNOW WHEN WE VOTED FOR LAST WEEK
AND LPS BUILT DATA AND ACTION
WHERE PEOPLE FALL OFF AND ON OF
OUR SYSTEM AND- WE ARE. HOPING
TO. ALSO DO KNOW THAT MARIE
COUNTY. DID A FIVE YEAR STUDY
THIRTY FIVE INDIVIDUALS USE
THIRTY DAY INTENSIVE TREATMENT
ONLY TWO HAD TO BE REFERRED TO A
MORE RESTRICTIVE-
CONSERVATORSHIP. OF THE PATIENTS
WHO WERE SUCCESSFULLY DISTRICT
FROM THURSDAY TO TREATMENT READ
- THE BOB GRAY THAT IS NO THREE
DATE WAS LESS STIGMATIZING AND
RESTRICTIVE FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES. AND THE PUBLIC GARDEN
IT GUARDIANS TO YOUR POINT MR
WHITE HOUSE KEY REPORTED CHANGE
THEIR WORKFLOWS ALLOWING THEM TO
FOCUS MORE ON CONSOLES THAT THAT
THAT TRULY. AND MORE EXTENDED
PLACEMENT AND EVERYBODY OF
COURSE. TO THE COST SAVING- FOR
THE FOR THE WHOLE SYSTEM CAN I
HAVE ONE FINAL QUESTION BECAUSE
ONE OF THINGS WE'RE CONCERNED
WITH IS COMPELLING GOVERNMENT.
MEMBER THAT COMPELLING
GOVERNMENT INTEREST WITH THAT IN
MIND. GIVING SOMEBODY'S
MEDICATION RIGHT THAT PSYCHOTIC
OR SCHIZOPHRENIC OR WHATEVER THE
THIS IS THE- IS THAT IMPORTANT
TO THE COMMUNITY- OR TO THE
GOVERNMENT TOURISTS THE STATE.
YOU'RE GOING TO REPORT TO A
PERSON'S WELL BEING. AND IF THE
STATE HAS ANY INTEREST IN IN A
PERSON'S WELL BEING- I MEAN I'M
NOT AN ATTORNEY I'M A SOCIAL
WORKER AND I COULD TELL YOU THAT
PEOPLE THINK THIS WOULD ADD. ONE
MORE LEVEL OF CARE. TO AGAIN
AVOID THE MORE RESTRICTIVE.
CONSERVATORSHIP. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU CENTER WORK ASKING CENTER
STERN. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I GUESS I WOULD JUST A
COMMENT TO ADD ON TO THE
CONVERSATION AND THEN I'D LOVE
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME- I THINK THE
OTHER DATA SET THAT WE WERE
LOOKING AT IS AN AUDIT THAT I
HELPED. UP HE IS BACK LOS
ANGELES SAN FRANCISCO AND I
THINK SHASTA COUNTY- AND WE DO
HAVE DATA ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
INVOLUNTARY FIFTY ONE FIFTY
HOLDS WITH NO THAT'S IN THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS IN COUNTY ABOUT THE
L. A. TEN THOUSANDS IN SALMON
TO. I'M THE CAN SHIP THE CURRENT
- CASE FOR GUARDIANS OUT THERE
IS WAY TOO HIGH AND SO FOR FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE THE OTHER
COMPELLING INTEREST HERE IS
ACTUALLY A LIBERTY INTEREST IF
WE CAN FIND A WAY TO DO MORE
TRUNCATED AND PRECISE. TEMPORARY
CONSERVATORSHIP STABILIZE PEOPLE
AND THEN NOT HAVE TO BURDEN THE
SYSTEM WITH THE LONGER TERM
PROCEEDINGS YOU MAY ACTUALLY
HAVE FEWER PEOPLE IN. BRITISH
FOR THE VISIT. SO IN THE NEAR
TERM. YOU MAY HAVE. SOMETHING
BEYOND WHAT IS YOUR THREE DAY
HOLD RIGHT NOW FRANK THAT THE
THOSE THREE HOLES THE EVIDENCE
WE'RE FINDING OF FIFTY ONE
FIFTIES INCREDIBLY DRAMATIC
FORCED HOSPITALIZATIONS WITH
PERSPIRATION. THOSE ARE NOT-
REPUDIATE INTERFACES WITH OUR
SYSTEM I THINK GO IN A MONTH
PERIOD WHERE YOU HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE ABILIFY WHERE YOU CAN IF
YOU IF YOU CONSENT TO IT OR OR
OR END UP YOU KNOW SIGN OFF. THE
ON A WEAK LONG. ACTING DOUBLE TO
GET YOU STABILIZE AND MAKE SOME
DECISIONS AND THEN YOU CAN START
TO LOOK AT HOUSING OPTIONS AND
ALL THE REST OF IT SO. I
APPRECIATE YOU WE INTO. UP
IMPORTANT AND TOUGH TERRITORY
AND OF FOR ALL THE WORK BEEN
DOING THIS YEAR I WOULD LOVE TO
BE ABLE A CO AUTHOR. WELL BUT I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL. OR ANY
OTHER FINAL COMMENTS SEEING NONE
ON SYRACUSE LOOKED CLOSE I WOULD
USE TENER STERN SPINE COMMENTS
AS MY CLOTHES AND ASK FOR YOUR
IDOL EXCELLENT RIGHT WE HAVE A-
WE HAVE LESS TWELVE TO SEVEN
MOVING MOVE. HE REFERRED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROACH. CHIEF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AMBERG.
PORTIS HI FOR JUST LIKE A HERO.
ZERO I DO WRESTLE. GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG JONES JONES I'VE
LAYERED STERN STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI WHAT HAS HE AYE
WIENER. YOU HAVE FIVE TO ZERO
WITH SOME MEMBERS MISSING KEEP
THAT ON CALL THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN DO WE HAVE ANYMORE ARE
YOU TODAY. IF ALL RIGHT MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWELVE PATIENCE
IS A VIRTUE CENTER GLAZER THANK
YOU. SB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU- THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS. I
THANK THE STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND FOR THEIR EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS. THANK YOU THIS BILL
WOULD CLEAR EXPAND THE AUTHORITY
OF BART'S INSPECTOR GENERAL GIVE
THE OFFICE MORE PROTECTION FROM
IMPROPER INTERFERENCE IN ITS
WORK. BAY AREA VOTERS CREATED
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS A PART OF A
BALLOT MEASURE. THAT ALSO GAVE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITIES THE POWER TO RAISE
BRIDGE TOLLS. TO FINANCE
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT OFFICE AN
OFFICE THAT GIVES THE PUBLIC IN
THE SYSTEM RIDERS AN INDEPENDENT
SET OF EYES AND EARS THE
MONITORS THE AGENCY SPENDING
OPERATIONS. WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
FORMER STATE AUDITOR ELAINE
HOWLE TO RESEARCHING CRAFT THIS
BILL. AND MOST OF WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING IS ALREADY BEING DONE
BY THE STATE AUDITOR. THE
CALTRANS INSPECTOR GENERAL THE
LOS ANGELES- METRO INSPECTOR
GENERAL THIS HOUSE SUPPORTS THE
BILL AS TO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSPECTOR
GENERALS. AND THE ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AUDITORS. ALL
THESE PEOPLE SUPPORT THE BILL
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THE BART
INSPECTOR GENERAL NEEDS THESE
CHANGES TO BE ABLE TO FULFILL
THE MISSION THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND THE VOTERS ASKED THEM TO DO.
BILL CLARIFIES THAT THE OFFICE
SHOULD HAVE THE INDEPENDENCE TO
CONDUCT ITS WORK IN CONFORMITY
WITH GOVERNMENT AUDITING
STANDARDS. PUBLISHED BY THE
COMPTROLLER GENERAL OF TH
UNITED STATES. AND WITH THE
PRINCIPLES AND STANDARDS FOR
OFFICES OF INSPECTOR GENERAL
PUBLISHED BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL GIVES THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL ACCESS TO
AGENCY DOCUMENTS AND THE RIGHT
TO INTERVIEW EMPLOYEES. IT ALSO
GIVES THE OFFICE THE ABILITY TO
HIRE STAFF TO PROTECT
CONFIDENTIAL COMPUTER FILES FROM
IMPROPER DISCLOSURE. FINALLY THE
BILL ALSO RAISES THE BAR FOR
FIRING AN INSPECTOR GENERAL
DURING THEIR FOUR YEAR TERM.
ENSURING THAT THEY WILL ONLY BE
DISMISSED FOR MALFEASANCE AND
NOT BECAUSE THEIR WORK IS AN
IRRITANT FOREIGN THERE SEEM TO
THE STAFF. OR BOARD OF THE
AGENCY. WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL- IS HARRIET
RICHARDSON PARTS CURRENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME EFFECTIVELY
ASTRONAUT ABOUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND AS YOU MENTIONED- WE
HAVE- ACCURATE RICHARDSON WILL
SERVE A DEBORAH ALAN ON THE LINE
I DON'T BELIEVE BECAUSE THE
SCHEDULING CHALLENGES OUT AT
LEAST SHE'S THERE SHE IS WE
WELCOME THE TESTIMONIES AREN'T-
MODERATE DO WE HAVE A HAIRY.
RICHARDSON ON THE LINE. ONE
MOMENT HERE. YOUR LIFE SHOULD BE
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TERRY RICHARDSON AND I
AM PART INSPECTOR GENERAL I'M
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT
THE SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT I PORTERFIELD THE
GOVERNMENT AUDITING AND
INDEPENDENT INSPECTOR GENERAL
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ENOUGH
SERVED AS THE FEDERAL. LOCAL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT AND SERVE
ON THE GOVERNMENT AUDITING
STANDARDS ADVISORY COUNCIL AN
APPOINTMENT MADE BY THE
COMPTROLLER GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES I AM ALSO AN
APPOINTED MEMBER OF THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTING STANDARDS
ADVISORY COUNCIL I'VE ALSO
SERVED ON OTHER NATIONAL BOARDS
AND COMMITTEES AND I AM
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED AS AN
EXPERT IN MY FIELD MY PROFESSION
IS GOVERNED BY AND REQUIRED TO
HEAR AND HEAR. PERSONAL
STANDARDS THOSE INCLUDE THE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING STANDARDS AND
THE PRINCIPLED STANDARD FOR
OFFICES INSPECTOR GENERAL SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
TENS THE AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT
OUR AUDITS AND INVESTIGATIONS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS AND
ENSURES THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO COMPLY WITH THE INDEPENDENCE
REQUIREMENTS IN THOSE STANDARDS
FOR FORTY EIGHT WOULD ALIGN THE
BARTON SPECTER. AUTHORITY WITH
THE RESPONSE OF AND THAT LEAST
OTHERS I DON'T OFFICE FIFTY CAL
. INCLUDING CALTRANS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND L.
A. AS WELL AS RESPONSIBLE. HE'S
THE STATE TO STOP. AND OFFICES
EVANS GENERAL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
. AUDIT OFFICE IN CAL. AND THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING THOSE Y. POR
IN THE- ADDITIONALLY BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
ONLINE OPTIONS TO FORTY WITH
BEST PRACTICES MODEL. CREATION
AS- NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE ASSOCIATION OF
INSPECTORS GENERAL AND THE
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AUDITORS PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE THAT THE
OFFICE OF THE PART INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
INDEPENDENTLY CARRY OUT THE
FUNCTIONS TYPICAL. OFFICE OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL BOTH IN THE
SHORT AND LONG TERM IT WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT AREA TAXPAYERS
REPEAT THE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
OF THEIR TAX DOLLARS THANK YOU
MA'AM IF YOU COULD READ ABOUT IT
REGIONAL BILL. YES I THANK YOU
AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE VOTE YES
ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OTHER
WITNESSES ALL BONE. OTHER
WITNESSES- HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SEEING KNOWN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ONE FOUR EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU NOT SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME I GUESS
ONE ZERO. EIGHT GIVE US JUST A
MOMENT.
OKAY.
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE.
WE DO I'M WAIT FOR OUR OUR-
PARTICIPANT. IN THE NUMBER HERE
GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT HERE.
OUR HEROES WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE TWENTY SIX BUT. AFTERNOON
THIS IS LIZ AMES I'M ELECTED
BURKE DIRECTOR AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WE GO TO
IN JUST A MOMENT HERE.
THREE TWENTY FOUR WOULD DEBRA
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH BEING
SHARED COMMITTEE MEMBER ENDEAVOR
ALLEN ONE OF NINE MEMBERS OF THE
PARK BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND I
SUPPORT SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL I BEGAN MY
CAREER AS A CPA AND AUDITOR IN
THE THIRTY YEARS IN FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT ROLES FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS ON APPOINTED AND
ELECTED LOCAL. BUT AS PART- I'VE
BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
FORMATION AND DEVELOPMENT OF THE
OFFICE OF PARTS INSPECTOR
GENERAL AS WELL AS IN THE HIRING
IN OVERSIGHT OF OUR CURRENT I.
G. I CARE VERY MUCH ABOUT
FURTHERING THE WORK OF THE
OFFICE. AS I BELIEVE IN MY
PROFESSIONAL OPINION. IT IS A
VERY NEEDED. BARRED HAVE BEEN
COMBINED. OPERATING AND CAPITAL
BUDGET OF TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS WITH ONE AND A HALF
BILLION OF THAT IN LARGE CAPITAL
PROJECTS. MOSTLY CONTRACTED TO
PRIVATE COMPANIES I'VE WATCHED
WITH SADNESS FOR ALMOST THREE
YEARS AS PART SENIOR MANAGEMENT
HAS WORKED TO UNDERMINE THE
AUTHORITY GIVEN TO THE I. G. BUT
IN THE LEGISLATURE AND BAY AREA
VOTER. WITH THE BILL. YEAH I IN
THE WHITE ACCEPTED INDUSTRY
STANDARDS THAT SHOULD RUN FOR
GOVERNOR IN HER WORK WILL BE
CLARIFIED. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
OFFICE TO FULFILL THE MISSION
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE VOTERS
INTENDED WHEN YOU PASSED SB FIVE
NINETY FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AND THE VOTERS
RATIFIED IT THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
PARTS TAXPAYERS RIDERS AND
WORKERS ALL DESERVE STRONG
OVERSIGHT AN INDEPENDENT
ASSURANCE BUT TAX DOLLARS ARE
BEING SPENT EFFICIENTLY AND
PROVIDE VALUE TO THE PUBLIC IN
FURTHERING BAY AREA TRANSIT.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PROVIDE THAT
PLEASE VOTE YES. THANK YOU MISS
ALLEN ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE FOUR EIGHT EIGHT. WHAT CARE
WILL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHT GO
AHEAD. BY DAVID SEAN BROWN
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS DEFENSE
AND EDUCATION FUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN A LINE
THREE FIFTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON- JASON BARRIS'S
ATTORNEY FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
LIKE WE HAVE ONE MORE HERE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES MY NAME IS
ANNA MARIE HOGAN I AM FORMERLY
THE ELECTED CITY AUDITOR FOR THE
CITY OF BERKELEY AND NOW THE
SENIOR ADVOCACY REPRESENTATIVE.
FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AUDITORS ALKA AND WE
S. ALGA SUPPORT. SB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. AND THEN
FROM THERE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT THE
STERN OPPOSITION- I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S UP. TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANOTHER PERSON ON THE
LINE FOR TECHNICAL CLASS- JANICE
LIE. GEN SLEEP. AND ROBERT
ROBERT. ARE ARE THE VIEW AND
YOU'RE LYING ON THE PHONE YES.
ALL RIGHT GOOD RETURN OKAY
MISTER RAYBURN GO HEAD IT UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR- BURKE IN
MEMBERSHIP MY NAME IS ROBERT
RETURN I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE PARK BOARD OF
DIRECTORS BUDGET QUOTED THE
CREATION OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT OF PARTS
FINANCIAL. MANAGER RATIONS.
TORPEY COMPLIANCE HOWEVER ON
APRIL FOURTEENTH THIS YEAR THE
PARK BOARD VOTED SIX TO THREE TO
OPPOSE FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
UNLESS DEMAND GIVEN SEVERAL
SEVERAL CONCERNS WITH. BILL IS
CURRENTLY PRESS. THE EXPANDED
OUT IN THE TOWARD GRANTED THE
AYE- WITH THE INDEPENDENT OF
EXISTING UP AND STEVE THAT PARTS
OF. ITS PARTS OFFICE THE
INDEPENDENT POLICE AUDITOR WHICH
ALSO HAS A LEGISLATIVE MANDATE
IN TOTAL INDEPENDENCE THE
CARRYING OUT OVERSIGHT OF PARTS
POLICE DEPARTMENT. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SHOULD BE CLARIFIED
THE EXPANDED DUTIES THE I. T.
COULD NOT INTERFERE WITH THE
INDEPENDENCE OUR PURVIEW A BIG
CITY PART ENTITIES SIMILARLY
CHARGED WITH CONDUCTING
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FUNCTION. FURTHER THE BILL
GRANTS THE I. T. UNFETTERED
ACCESS TO ALL DISTRICT RECORDS
OF THE PROPERTY. AUTHORITY COULD
CREATE CONFLICTS WITH EXISTING
PART ENTITIES MUST KEEP CERTAIN
RECORDS CONFIDENTIAL UNDER
FEDERAL OR STATE LAW. ONE AREA
WHERE PARK IN THE AUTHOR DO
AGREE IT'S THE I. T. SECURITY TO
ISSUE SUBPOENAS WE ACKNOWLEDGE
SUBPOENA AUTHORITY IS QUITE
COMMON FRIED CHEESE AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE BLANK WHICH TO
CLARIFY. HOUSE **** WILL BE
ENFORCED IT IS ALSO PUT
DISTRICTS PRIORITY TO FACILITATE
PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
BY CHEEK YEAH. PARTNERS THE I.
G.'S PLASTIC. INVOLVING
EMPLOYEES CAN BE A- AT THE
OFFICE RECOGNIZED THE RIGHTS
AFFORDED TO AN EMPLOYEE UNDER
THEIR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT IN ADDITION TO
WEINGART. IN CLOSING PARTIES
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE I. T. AMENDMENTS
TO SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THROUGH PRODUCTIVE
DIALOGUE WE HOPE REMOVED FOR
OPPOSITION MP IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THIS
COMMITTEE AND HAVE FAILED TO ON
THE PHONE RODLEY PARTS. OF
CENTRAL MANAGER OF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS HE CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISS IS IT LEADER LIE. NOT NOT AVAILABLE I FULLY
DIRECTOR LEVY HAD LEE ALL RIGHT-
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM YES SIR GO AHEAD. MISTER%
CHAIRMAN SENATORS TERRY BRENNAN
ON BEHALF OF S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA WE WERE IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE SAME REASONS THE BART
BOARD IS. THANK YOU THE SECOND.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION ALSO
OPPOSED THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED SEEING NONE ON THE
PHONE LINE THOSE OPPOSED
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE OPPOSED PLEASE. SB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU DO OPPOSE AT THIS TIME. IN
THE FIRST TO LINE THREE TWENTY
EIGHT. TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE TWO EIGHT. NEARLY
YEAH I CAN HEAR YOU. MY NAME IS
JOE CORCORAN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BAY AREA TRANSPORTATION
WORKING GROUP AND WE ARE VERY
STRONG IN FAVOR OF FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT ADDRESS. THANK YOU
. THOSE WHO ARE ALEJO'S
TELEPHONE LINE. AND THREE FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
BRIAN WILLIAMS WITH US HERE YOU
TEND ONE IN OPPOSITION. AND THEN
FURTHER AT THIS TIME ALREADY
THANK YOU ARE LET'S BRING BACK
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
ARE COMMON SEEING NONE ALL
RIGHT- IS THERE MOTION. MOVED BY
SENATOR JONES- CENTER BORJAS I
CAN'T TELL YOU GUYS APART. ALL
RIGHT. A MOVE BY SENATOR BUT
CERTAIN APPROVED BY SENATOR
VOYAGES- SENATE WAYS YOU COULD
CLOSE. I'LL BE BRIEF THEN- LAST
YEAR I HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE WHO WAS OUR
AUDITOR GENERAL HERE UP THE
LEGISLATURE AND I ASKED YOU TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THE POWERS OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL GIVE ME YOUR
PROFESSIONAL VIEW SHE WAS KIND
ENOUGH TO DO THAT. THIS BILL
REALLY CAN'T COMES OUT OF THAT
STUDY TO MAKE SURE WE ALIGN HER
POWER PUT THOSE THAT WE'VE
CREATED FOR OUR STATE FOR OUR
LOCALITIES- EXCEPT WHERE WE TALK
ABOUT OVERSIGHT ON SPENDING- YOU
KNOW WE LIKE TO TOUT THE
CREATION OF- THE COUNTER BILITY
THE OVERSIGHT OF INSPECTOR
GENERALS. IT'S OF THAT. WE HAVE
. IT PROPERLY- BUT BASED ON
THAT- OUR- THE GOLD STANDARD IN
THE INDUSTRY LISTEN I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE BART
BOARD WHO HAVE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS I THINK THEY CAN BE OF
MANY OF THEM AT ALL MANY OF THEM
CAN BE RESOLVED WE WANT TO
PROTECT THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF
RECORDS OF INVESTIGATIONS WE IF
THE EMPLOYEE- IS BEING
INTERVIEWED AS A PART OF THE
PATIENT. YEAH TO TWO OF THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT TO ASK FOR
REPRESENTATION ALONE INTERFERE
WITH THAT- SO I'M I'M HOPEFUL
THAT AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
WITH THOSE FOR TODAY THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
THAT SPACE I WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS. MOUNT YOU
CAN SEE CALL THE ROLL. THE IS
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR BOARD BOARD
YES THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
UMBERG. AMBERG I BORGIAS. FORGES
I CARRY IT ALL. EVERY AT ALL I
DID ASAL. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
JONES. JONES I LAYERED STERN
WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER AS A FOUR
YEAR FORTY ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT I'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL THINKCENTRE ALL RIGHT.
NEXT OF. SENATOR COM LONGER
SENATE COME LONGER IS ON HER WAY
I APOLOGIZE TO THOSE THAT ARE
LISTENING AND WATCHING- TODAY IS
AN INCREDIBLY BUSY DAY IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND SO NUMBER
OF OUR MEMBERS EITHER HAVE TO BE
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMITTEES ARE
ARE PRESENTING BILLS OF THE
COMMITTEES I SEE SENATOR COM
LONGER IS HERE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN SB. ONE TWO FOUR FIVE
SIR CALM WATER WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY THE FLOOR IS YOURS. AND.
GOOD AFTERNOON. TO YOU AND TO
MEMBERS I AM HERE TO PRESENT.
SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY FIVE L.
A. COUNTY ABORTION ACCESS SAFE
HAVEN PILOT PROGRAM. SB TWELVE
FORTY FIVE WILL SUPPORT A FUNDED
PILOT PROGRAM FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ONLY TO BUILD ON THE
STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE. THE PROGRAM WILL
HOUSE INNOVATIVE APPROACHES AND
PATIENT CENTERED COLLABORATIONS
TO SAFEGUARD ACCESS TO ABORTION
FOR PATIENTS COMING TO LOS
ANGELES COUNTY REGARDLESS OF
WHERE A PATIENT RESIDES. THIS
YEAR THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT IS REVIEWING A DIRECT
CHALLENGE TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION ESTABLISHED IN
ROE V. WADE SHOULD THE COURT
UPHOLD MISSISSIPPI'S BAN THEREBY
OVERTURNING ROE PEOPLE IN OVER
HALF THE STATES IN THE COUNTRY.
OVER THIRTY SIX MILLION WOMEN
AND OTHER PEOPLE THEY BECOME
PREGNANT WILL LOSE ACCESS TO
ABORTION CARE. AND IT IS ALREADY
HAPPENING PEOPLE IN TEXAS HAVE
BEEN DENIED PROTECTIONS UNDER
ROW SINCE THE STATE'S EXTREME
ABORTION BAN SB EIGHT WENT INTO
EFFECT LAST YEAR. ACCORDING TO A
REPORT RELEASED BY THE GUTMACHER
INSTITUTE THE NUMBER OF OUT OF
STATE PATIENTS WHO WOULD FIND
THEIR NEAREST ABORTION PROVIDER
IN CALIFORNIA FROM FORTY SIX
THOUSAND TO ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION AN INCREASE OF NEARLY
3000% L. A. COUNTY ACCOUNTS FOR
OVER A THIRD OF ALL ABORTIONS
THAT TAKE PLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE PREVALENCE OF ABORTION IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN PARTICULAR
LIKELY REFLECTS BETTER ACCESS IN
THE CITY THAN OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND QUITE FRANKLY
EVEN OTHER STATES IN THE NATION
. THIS PREVALENCE COUPLED WITH
THE COUNTY'S ROLE AS A MAJOR
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION HUB
WITH MULTIPLE AIRPORTS. MAKES
IT'S HIGHLY LIKELY THAT NON
RESIDENTS WILL COME TO L. A.
COUNTY FOR THE ABORTION CARE
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS.
HOME STATE OR COUNTY. CURRENTLY
L. A. COUNTY HAS ALREADY MADE
EVIDENT COMMITMENTS TO HEALTH
EQUITY THE COUNTY HAS A RECORD
OF SUCCESSFUL INNOVATIONS IN
CARE COORDINATION FOR PROGRAMS
SUCH AS MY HEALTH LA ECON SOLD
SYSTEM LANES HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE. AND THE WHOLE PERSON
CARE PILOT PROGRAMS WHICH ARE
NOW INFORMING CAL AIMS STATEWIDE
EFFORTS. BUILDING UPON THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
RESOLUTION OF BUILDING A COUNTY
WIDE RESPONSE TO THE POTENTIAL
OVERTURN OF ROE V. WADE. SB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WOULD FIND AND
SUPPORT A PILOT PROGRAM APPROACH
TO CARE THAT IS RESPONSIVE TO
THE IMPENDING NEEDS OF PEOPLE
SEEKING ABORTION CARE. HE
FUNDING AREAS FOR THE PILOT
PROGRAM WOULD INCLUDE SERVICES
THAT PRIORITIZE EFFORTS TO
ADVANCE AND IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES COMPREHENSIVE SEXUAL
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES
STREAMLINED AND SECURE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO COORDINATE
CARE AND OTHER PATIENTS
SERVICES. PATIENT ACCESS TO
TOOLS TO EMPOWER PATIENTS TO
OVERCOME BARRIERS TO CARE
MEDICALLY ACCURATE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TOOLS SPECIFIC TO
COMMUNITY NEEDS WITHIN THE
COUNTY. AND PATIENT COMMUNITY
OUT REACH TO ASSESS OUNTY
SERVICES. WHETHER MAURITIAN
RIGHTS ALREADY A ROADING IN
NUMEROUS STATES. IN THE FUTURE
OF ROE V. WADE HANGING IN THE
BALANCE NOW IS THE TIME TO PUT
FORWARD INNOVATIVE INVESTMENTS
IN ABORTION ACCESS WITH ME AND
SUPPORT AS THE LINDA VASQUEZ
CHIEF EXTERNAL OFFICER FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD LOS ANGELES
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU- IS VAZQUEZ
IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE FOR. THANK
YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AT AND THEN- COME UP
WITH THAT NINA THINKING THAT
VASQUEZ I AM TO KEEP EXTERNAL
THIRD TALK. LOS ANGELES. THIS
YEAR ALONE THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE
HUNDRED ABORTION RESTRICTIONS
RESTRICTIONS INTRODUCED IN FORTY
ONE STATES IN OUR COUNTRY. WITH
THREE ABORTION BANS BEING BACK
RECENTLY ENACTED IN ARIZONA
IDAHO AND WYOMING. FIVE AGAIN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS HOME TO
ALMOST 30% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION AND ACCOUNT FOR OVER
A THIRD OF ALL ABORTIONS THAT
TAKE PLACE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
FACT COUPLED WITH THE COUNTIES
WALL AT THE MAJOR METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION HUB WITH MULTIPLE
AIRPORT MAKES IT VERY HIGH WOULD
LIKELY THAT NON RESIDENTS WILL
COME TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR
PORTION SERVICES CAFE
DESPERATELY. NEED AND CANNOT
ACCESS IN THEIR HOME STATE. AT
PLANT HERE TO LOS ANGELES WE
HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE AT NUMBER
OF PATIENTS TRAVELING TO AND
FROM OUT OF STATE WITH THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF PATIENTS
COMING TO WATCH FROM TAX THAT-
IN FACT WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL
PATIENTS THAT HAVE EXPRESSED-
VARYING ISSUES FROM CHILD CARE
TO NOT HAVING ENOUGH FUNDS CAN'T
TRAVEL- ONE PATIENT HAD EVEN.
TRAVELED THE BROTHER FROM TEXAS
TO LOS ANGELES. IF YOU'RE NOT
YOU NEED TO LOS ANGELES BUT WITH
THE POPULATION AND- AND A 3000%
ARE PROJECTION FROM THE
GUTMACHER INSTITUTE WE KNOW THAT
MANY FOLKS WILL. COME TO GO AYE
FINANCIAL AS- I HERE TO. FOR
INFLUX OF. AT THE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IS EXPRESSING
THEIR COMMITMENT TO REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM AGAIN. BUILDING UPON
WHAT THE STATE HAS IS ALREADY
DEALING. THE BILL BEFORE YOU
TODAY ONCE LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS
PAIRED TO KEEP THAT COMMITMENT
TO BE A REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
HAVEN BY CREATING A PILOT
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT AND EXPAND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND EXPANDED
ACCESS TO ABORTION IN THE
COUNTY. WE ARE UNIQUELY SITUATED
HERE IN LOS ANGELES. THIS
PROGRAM WILL ENABLE THE COUNTY
TO TAKE MANY OF THE FACT
STATEWIDE AFRICA THEY SAID- AND
REALLY EXPAND ON WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS TRYING TO DO. WHY
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PRODUCTIVE JEFF THAT
IN THIS DIRE TIME IN PARTICULAR
WITH THE- FIRST CITY AND THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF OUR COUNTY. MORE
THAN EVER WE NEED LEGISLATION
LIKE SENATE BILL TWELVE FORTY
FIVE TO ENSURE THAT. EVEN THOUGH
NATIONALLY OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS ARE BEING. TAKEN AWAY WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ENSURE ACCESS
FOR ALL OF THE REASONS I URGE
YOU. TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE MEG ACT YES.
THANK YOU MS VASQUEZ ALL RIGHT
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE THOSE IN
SUPPORT HERE AND IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HOT EXCUSE ME AND- YES
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. YES HI LISA
MATSUBARA ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT- AS WELL
AS AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
DISTRICT NINE. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED ALL RIGHT LIST OF THE
FIE PHONE LINES THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE FORTY
FIVE MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE
THEM UP PLEASE. THANK YOU AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL FOR SCHOOLING TO
THIRTY FIVE. THEIR NUMBERS THIS
IS ERIN EVAN BOND BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS NEW CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU X. WE HAVE
THREE SIXTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MULTI YEN WITH THE CENTRAL
INSURANCE COURT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE. THREE SIXTY
ONE SIXTY THREE SIXTY ONE. I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD MASS THREE SIXTY
ONE TO HIT TWO ONE ZERO AGAIN
HERE. AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THERE ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ON YOUR MOBILE YEAH WITH
LACHLAN FOR WELLNESS AND BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. X. SINGLE LINE
THREE SEVENTY SIX. DELIVER
CANNER INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
GREENSTEIN IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHER THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S NOT TURN THE OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWELVE FORTY
FIVE- I BELIEVE WE HAVE FRAN
VOLLEY IS WELL AS SUSAN ARNELLE
MR NOW I'M ACTUALLY THERESA
BRENNAN ON BEHALF OF MISS
ARNELLE SHE WAS SICK SO I CAME
IN HER STEAD ALL RIGHT. MY NAME
IS THERESA BRENNAN. YOUR
ATTORNEY A THIRD GENERATION PRO
LIFE ACTIVIST. MOTHER OF FIVE
AND PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT TO
LIFE LEAGUE. AMERICA'S FIRST PRO
LIFE ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
FIFTY THREE PREGNANCY HEALTH
CLINICS CENTERS AND MATERNITY
HOMES IN EVERYONE OF YOUR
DISTRICT. AND TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF PRO LIFE VOTERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SB TWO
FORTY FIVE ALTHOUGH FACIALLY
NEUTRAL WILL DESPERATELY IMPACT
MINORITIES. LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS HOME 228% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION AND ALREADY ACCOUNTS
FOR MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF ALL
ABORTIONS IN CALIFORNIA. MOST
ABORTIONS IN LOS ANGELES ARE IN
LOW INCOME HIGH MINORITY AREAS.
AND NOT SURPRISINGLY GOOD MARKER
INSTITUTE STATISTICS SHOW THAT
BLACKS AND HISPANICS ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY THAN ANY OTHER RACE
OR ETHNIC ETHNICITY TO HAVE AN
ABORTION. WE AS A NATION CANNOT
AND SHOULD NOT IGNORE RACISM IN
OUR HISTORY. IT IS WIDELY
ACCEPTED THAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
FOUNDER MARGARET SANGER WITHIN
ADMITTED WHITE SUPREMACISTS HER
STATED PURPOSE WAS TO PROMOTE
BIRTH CONTROL AND ABORTION FOR
LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF COLOR.
CENTER REFERRED TO BLACK
AMERICANS IMMIGRANTS AND
INDIGENOUS AMERICANS AS AND I
QUOTE. HUMAN WEEDS RECKLESS
BREEDERS WHO ARE. HUMAN BEINGS
WHO SHOULD HAVE BEEN BORN. DO
NOT MISUNDERSTAND I AM NOT
SAYING AND DO NOT INTEND TO
IMPLY THAT THE AUTHORS OF PRO
ABOUT ABORT BILLS TRAVELING
THROUGH OUR LEGISLATURE ARE
RACIST NOR TO IMPLY THAT THEY
ARE INTENTIONALLY PROMOTING A
RACIST AGENDA. THANK YOU.
HOWEVER NO MATTER THE INTENTION
BY PLACING MORE ABORTION
FACILITIES AND LOW INCOME
NEIGHBORHOODS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
UNDENIABLY FOLLOWS PLANNED
PARENTHOOD'S EUGENIC ROOTS
MARGARET SANGER WOULD BE
THRILLED WITH THE ONSLAUGHT OF
PRO ABORT BILLS MAKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH ITS CAPITAL BECAUSE
THESE BILLS WILL WIPE OUT FAR
MORE BLACK AND HISPANIC CITIZENS
IN CALIFORNIA IN FACT MANY OF
THESE ABORTION BILLS EXPRESSLY
TARGET BLACK AND INDIGENOUS OF
COLOR FOR ABORTION SERVICES.
THESE ARE BOARDED PEOPLE WILL
NEVER BE BORN THANK YOU MISS
BROWN WE SHOULD JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION- I UNDERSTOOD THAT YOU
ARE NOT SUGGESTING THAT THOSE
WHO SUPPORTER AUTHORED THIS
MEASURES. ARE RACES BUT THE
QUOTES YOU YOU GAVE US FROM
MARGARET SANGER CLEARLY WERE
RACISM WONDERING WHAT WAS THE
PURPOSE THAT WELL THE GOOD
MARKER INSTITUTE SPECIFICALLY
STATES THAT ABORTION IN THE
UNITED STATES AS PRIMARILY-
RECEIVED BY PERSONS OF COLOR
HISPANICS AND BLACKS IN ADDITION
LOW INCOME. SO THE POINT IS THAT
THESE ARE NOT WOMEN WHO ARE
BEING OFFERED A CHOICE THEY'RE
BEING FORCED INTO A DECISION
THAT THEY OTHERWISE MIGHT NOT
HAVE CHOSEN AND THE FACT THAT
THESE. LOCATIONS ARE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES SPEAKS TO THE
FACT THAT WE ARE NOT PROVIDING
THE SERVICES TO THESE WOMEN THAT
WE SHOULD TO ENABLE THEM TO HAVE
A TRUE CHOICE RIGHT BUT I JUST
SPEAKING FOR MYSELF I JUST
INTERVIEWED THEM TO BE QUITE
RACES IS IMPLIES I'M GONNA VOTE
AYE ON THE BILL'S APPLIES AT
LEAST TO ME. I DOUBT READ MY
TESTIMONY WAS GOING TO CHANGE
YOUR MIND AT ANY RATE THANK YOU.
RIGHT OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. MISS
ARNELLE GOOD AFTERNOON. GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR- NUMBER
AGAIN MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FOR ANYBODY
I'M A LATINA A SINGLE MOTHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS AND AT THE AGE
OF. IN THE PMR IN THE INNER CITY
OF SOUTH CENTRAL LA. ALTHOUGH I
FOUND MYSELF UNEXPECTEDLY
PREGNANT I BECAME MORE
DETERMINED THAN EVER TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION. I ALMOST
BELIEVED THE LIE THAT OUR
SOCIETY PLACED ON MOTHERHOOD
THAT IT WOULD AND MY CHANCES OF
BEING SUCCESSFUL RESILIENT.
GOING TO COLLEGE OR HAVING A
CAREER. CHANGE IN EMBARRASSMENT.
YEAH MYSELF CORD. YEAH THE
DENTIST. I THANK BREAKING
THROUGH ALL THE KEY MOM OKAY I
GRAB HIGH SCHOOL WITH HONORS
THAT ACCEPTED TO UC RIVERSIDE
EVENTUALLY RECEIVED MY
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN BIOLOGY IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN SEVEN. THANK
NEVER ONCE DID I SAY OH MAN
SHOULD GOTTEN THE BALL. NOT I
WOULD SOCIETY BECAUSE I DOUBT IT
. WHY SUPPORT. THEY HAVE
GENUINELY OR SOME OF STUDENTS I
WOULD BE DESTINED TO FAIL.
GETTING AN ABORTION ONCE THE
ONLY SOLUTION FOR FIVE YEARS I
COMMUNITY COMMUTE IT FROM LA TO
RIVERSIDE AS I RELIED HEAVILY ON
MY PARENTS FOR CHILDCARE THEY
WORK HARD. YEAH THIS DIDN'T STOP
ME FROM PURSUING MY MASTERS
DEGREE LATER ON. A. B. TWELVE
FORTY FIVE ONLY BE THE IDEA THAT
WOMEN WE'RE NOT STRONG ENOUGH
MARTINEZ CAPABLE OF BEING A MOM
INTERESTED IN OUR CAREERS AND
GREEN. I YOU WORK IN THE STATE
COMMUNITY I WORK I GREW UP IN I
HAVE WORKED FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD I HAVE WORKED IN
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS AND
I CURRENTLY LIVE IN THE- FUTURE
ALL GIRLS HIGH SCHOOL. IN MY
EXPERIENCE IN LA HAVE TAUGHT ME
THAT ABORTION DOES NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM 50% OF WOMEN WHO GET
ABORTIONS. ALREADY HAVE
CHILDREN. AFTER THEIR ABORTION
SHE RETURNED TO THE SAME
CONDITION LIVING ON THE STREETS.
USE OR WITH HER ABUSIVE PARTNER
AND CARBON. THAT'S NOT THE
SOLUTION. I FAMILY HOUSING AND
CHILD CARE AND RESOURCES NOT
MORE ABORTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
CALIFORNIANS COMPLETELY FAILING
THE WOMEN IN MY COMMUNITY. ON
WANTED ABORTION IN OUR COMMUNITY
AMOUNTS TO COERCION MY
NEIGHBORHOOD HAD ELEVEN ABORTION
PROVIDERS WITHIN A FIVE MILE
THANK YOU MA'AM. WRAP UP. FOR
THESE REASONS I HAVE A VOTE I
ASKED NOBLE SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
PM THANK YOU ALL RIGHT OTHERS
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWELVE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
MALAYSIAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU- GREG BIRD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION THANK. A
PASTOR BRANDONCAMPBELL FAITH OF
THE CHURCH IN WHEATLAND AND WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CAPITOL
CONNECTION REPRESENTING BAPTIST
CHURCHES ACROSS THE STATE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. OTHERS
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSITION SAYING NO ONE ELSE
COMING FORWARD THOSE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. TWELVE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU DO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. YOU CAN GO FIRST TO LINE.
THREE SIXTY FOUR. ANY HEARING IN
EAGLE COUNTY STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWO FIFTY SEVEN. TWO FIVE SEVEN.
LET ME YEAH. MY NAME IS IN
ITSELF SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT THREE SIXTY THREE.
THREE SIX THREE. HELLO MY NAME
IS ROBERT BYRD I AM AN ACTIVIST
WITH PRO LIFE AND WANTS TO GO
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU. XS.
THREE SIXTY FIVE. HELLO JENNIFER
BARRON OF PLASTER COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION- STRONGLY OPPOSED NO
ON SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THREE SIXTY FIFTH. HELLO MY
NAME IS WHEN AT FULL SERVICE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
BUDGET FOR. YEAH THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND THREE ORTY EIGHT SO.
GLAZER. AND AND ROCK HARBOR
CHURCH WE ARE TO FOR LIFE AND I
AM A STRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS
THIS BILL ONE TWO FOUR FIVE SB.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO THREE THIRTY
FOUR. MY NAME IS IN OUR DAHLE
WITH THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE
AND I OPPOSE SB TWELVE FORTY
FIVE. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
THREE SIXTY SEVEN. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER MIGUEL DOWN ONE KING
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE S.
B. THE BILL. AND THEN FURTHER AT
THIS. ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE OF QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT-
IS THERE MOTION MOVE THE BILL
CENTER CABALLERO MOVES BILL-
CENTER COMMAGER CARE CLOSE. I'M
I JUST.
THE COUNTRY AND THE STATE ARE
FINDING THEIR WAY TO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF ALL OF THESE. BILLS
THAT ARE BEING PASSED INTO LAW
IN OTHER STATES- THIS IS ABOUT
CHOICE AND IF WE STOPPED
STIGMATIZING PREGNANCY AND
PREGNANCY OUT OF WEDLOCK IF WE
STOP SHAMING POVERTY- WE MIGHT
HAVE BETTER OPTIONS FOR FOLKS OF
ALL COLORS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE. I
TAKE OFFENSE WITH THE FACT THAT
ALL OF LOS ANGELES COUNTYIS LOW
INCOME- I TAKE OFFENSE TO THE
FACT THAT HEALTH CARE CLINICS
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
ACCESS IS ONLY AVAILABLE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES BECAUSE IN
FACT IT IS A- WHERE AND- BOMBS
ARE ACCESSING ABORTION. THERE
ARE IMMIGRANT WOMEN ON THE
BORDER IN TEXAS WHO ARE UNABLE
TO ACCESS CARE BECAUSE OF SB
EIGHT DESPERATELY TRYING TO FIND
THEIR WAY HERE THERE ARE AFGHAN
REFUGEES WHO'VE BEEN RAPED BY
THE TALIBAN WHO JUST HAD. ENDED
UP IN TEXAS AS REFUGEES TRYING
TO ACCESS ABORTION CARE AND ARE
UNABLE TO- YELP IS ACTUALLY
OFFERING AS A WORK FORCE
BENEFITS TO COVER THE COST OF
TRAVEL HERE SO THAT WOMEN CAN
ACCESS ABORTION CARE SO THIS IS
AN EIGHT. THAT WE SHOULD SEE
LATE THE RESULT OF THE GOVERNOR
AFFIRMING THIS IS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE AND I JUST WANT TO
CLOSE BY SAYING THIS IS A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND IF YOU DON'T CHOOSE BONTA.
IN ABORTION THEN YOU DON'T HAVE
TO FIND YOUR WAY TO ONE OF THESE
CLINICS WITH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ITEM ALL RIGHT- THERE'S A
MOTION BY CENTER CALERO. AND A
FEW COUNTS IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
CAN I'M XIN BY CENTER CAR IT ALL
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT
FIRST TO BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATION.
BURKE I BOARD THIS. BOARD IS NO
KARAPIRO. CALIENDO I THE
RUSSELL. THE RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG OWNS. JONES NO LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN. STERN EYEWEAR
KALECKI. WE KNOW. I HAVE FIVE
TWO SO FAR WITH MA'AM MISSING-
ARE- THANK YOU FOR THE BILL ON
CALL NEXT IS SO MALL- S. B.
SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF I WANT TO SEARCHES BY
REALLY THINKING YOU I KNOW THAT-
YOU WORK QUITE A BIT AS TO HELP
US. UNDERSTAND THAT WERE GOING
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THE THANK
YOU FOR THAT. I'M SURE. THANK
HOW WOMEN IN TWENTY TWENTY LOT
READS HELLO MOM ME JUST ASK YOU
YOU'RE EXCEPT THE MEASURE FOR. I
A- OPPOSE EN EL. THE ENTER RESET
L. OF PAYDAY THAT WOMEN INTO
TWENTY LAW FORTY BILL DUE TO THE
J. PAY AND PEOPLE OF IN THIS
LOST SIXTY ONE DO BASED PAGAN
THE WE JUST ACROSS IN THIS YOU
PATIENTS HANNAH SOME LEVEL EGGS
HEAVY FORM A PLAN WHEN BOTH. SO
ONLY THE PORT THE IS A WHOLE.
GIVE EMPLOYMENT THIS BILL WILL
NOT ELIMINATE THE GENDER AND
RACE PAY GAP BUT THIS BILL
ACCOMPLISHES TWO MAJOR POLICIES
THESE ACTIVE SERVERS AS TOOLS
FIRST IT WILL SERVE AS A TOOL TO
NARROW PAGE I REQUEST. AN SHOP
BILLABLE KERN EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING THE MINIMUM AND
MAXIMUM SALARIES ON JOB POSTING
PROVIDING JOB SEEKERS WITH THE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO NEGOTIATE
SALARIES BUSINESS FISHER HIGHER
RETAIN THE BEST AND THAT MET
THEIR NEEDS THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE FOURTEEN. THIS GAME. ANY
SALARY AND PROMOTION
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS BEFORE
THEY CAN BE SUED UNDER PAGA.
INSTEAD IT ALL IMPLEMENTATION
CONCERNS BY PROVIDING A
MECHANISM FOR EMPLOYERS TO A
DEBT ADDRESSED URGENT PERSONAL
VACANCIES ALLOWING FOR TEMP RE
AND IN. APPOINTMENTS SECOND LIEN
. EXISTING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SB NINE SEVEN
NINE SEVENTY THREE BY REQUIRING
COMPANIES TO PUBLICLY REPORT HE
TO CONDUCT BY RACE IF THE AND-
FOR BOTH DISTRICT DIRECTORS AND
EMPLOYEES HAVE. RT THINKING.
MANY MAJOR COME READY TO CLOSING
THERE WERE FOR STATE AS PART OF
THEIR COMMIT TO DEBORAH BUT HE
AND- BUT IF TOLL JEFF. THANK OF
THE TOP ONE HUNDRED PUBLICLY
TRADED IN THE U. S. TRANSPARENCY
IS. VALLAPUDUA LAST YEAR A STUDY
FROM JUST CAPITAL AND THE HARRIS
POLL FOUND THAT 73% OF AMERICANS
WANT COMPANIES TO POP THE DISC.
R. FOR COMPANIES THIRTY FIVE. WE
MUST DISCLOSE THEIR PAY THE PAY
GAP HAS SHRUNK BY 7% FOR THOSE
REPORTING AND IT'S THE SAME FOR
THE BENEATH THAT DIDN'T HAVE TO
REPORT. AMENDMENT PAGE LEVIN IN
TWELVE AND SUMMARIZED ON PAGE
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN PREVENT
PLAINTIFFS FROM PURSUING
LAWSUITS AGAINST EMPLOYERS BAY
ON THE- EMPLOYER. THE M. A AND
FEES IN THE OF PAY DATA TO
COMPANIES WITH TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OR MORE AND BY TWENTY SIX.
THIS WOULD ONLY AND- POINT 5%
AGAIN POINT 5% OF BUSINESSES AND
IT WOULD COVER 29% OF WORKERS
THIS APPROACH ALSO GIVES
EMPLOYERS TIME TO COME I AM AN
ANSWER BORDERS HAVE FOURTEEN
PROVIDE. AND FOR ME A COPY OF
THE PUBLIC OF THEIR PAPER TO
REPORT. WE MUST INCREASE PAY
TRANSPARENCY IN ORDER TO NARROW
THE GENDER AND RACIAL WAGE GAP
WHICH PREVENTS WHAT IN
PARTICULARLY WOMEN OF COLOR FROM
A CHEEKY ACHIEVING. THE ORTEGA.
HOW DID MEANINGFUL STEP TO
NARROW THE GENDER AND RACIAL PAY
GAP TODAY WE HAVE MARIE GO GET
YOUR HE YOSHIHARA CAL EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND HANNAH
HOLLOWAY WITH EXPECTED BE
TESTIFIED FOR THE BILL. SHE HARA
. THANK YOU OUR MEMBERS MORE SHE
HARLEM THE CAL PLAN OR IS THIS.
I ALSO FIRST ONE I THINK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR INTO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH US ON THIS
BILL I THINK WE ALL ARE THE SAME
. ULTIMATELY BUT- TAKING US LONG
DO IT IS BECAUSE WE AREN'T ALL
OF CONTRIBUTORS TO THE PAY GAP.
AND BECAUSE COME. SIMPLY NOT UP
STEPS ON THEIR OWN TO FIX THE
PROBLEM FAST ENOUGH ALL WOMEN
AND PEOPLE OF COLOR LOSING BILL.
DOLLARS THEIR CLOTHES. WE'VE GOT
IS NOT JUST ABOUT AND SHE EVEN
PAY FOR WORK IT IS ALSO ABOUT
ENSURING FAIR EQUITABLE FROM AND
PRACTICES WHICH IS WHAT THE BILL
WILL DEAL FOR EXAMPLE COME IN
AND LOOK AT. HOW MUCH THEIR- AND
FIND AND- REYES. GENDER THIRTIES
BUT IF YOU HAVE FORTY MALE
EXECUTIVES AND ONE FEMALE
EXECUTIVES YOU MIGHT NOT HAVE AN
EQUAL PAY VIOLATION BUT YOU
STILL HAVE A PROBLEM. IF A
COMPANY. PAINTER AND ASSESSES
THE MAKE SURE THAT MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S NO GENDER OR RACE
BASED PAID VERY YOU DON'T BY
LISTEN PUBLISHED WOMEN OF COLOR
ARE THE ONES DOING THE JOBS. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS ILL IS ABOUT
THE PURPOSE OF. HE GOT THESE ARE
BIG PICTURE REPORTS THAT ALLOW
YOU TO ASSESS WHERE WOMEN AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE CONCENTRATED
OR UNDER. SENATE IN. AB AND
CATEGORIES AND THIS IS BASED ON
AGGREGATE PAY DATA AND JOB
CLASSIFICATION AND LAST MONTH
THE DPH RELEASED FINDINGS BASED
ON THESE REPORTS WHICH IS IN
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AT PRESENT.
NOTED THAT. OVER A ENOUGH A BAND
HIGHER PAYING JOBS AND WOMEN
PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN THE LOWER LOWER
PAY BANDS OF THE LOWER PAYING
JOBS. AND THIS IS PART OF THE
PAY GAP THEY GETS FAR LESS
ATTENTION BUT IS JUST AS
IMPORTANT. AND LAST MONTH A FEW
TURNING. THE FIRM WHAT.
REQUIRING EMPLOYERS TO ACTUALLY
DISCLOSE THESE PAY DATA REPORTS
TO THEIR WORKERS BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT ACCOUNT OF. IN PEOPLE.
THANK YOU MISS YOSHIHARA FEUD
WRAP IT UP SURE I'M JUST ON THE
POINT OF LITIGATION I JUST WANNA
AGAIN ECHO THAT MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT YOU CANNOT FILE SUIT BASED
SOLELY ON HIS REPORT A CLEAR
RIGHT TO KEEP AND MOST OF THESE
WORKERS ARE. IN A THREE MAN
ANYWAY. WE CAN'T ARE IS MORE
JUST YOUR ALL RIGHT NEXT- WE
HAVE MISS HANNAH. YES HELLO
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HANNAH HOLLOWAY WITH TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE- AND PICKING UP ON
REQUESTED MENTAL JUST BE
SPEAKING TO THE INCLUSION OF
LABOR CONTRACTOR AND THERE ARE.
IN THE BILL THIS- GREAT.
RECESSION TEMPER IMPROVEMENT IN
SEVENTY FIVE. COMPARED 219% IN
TOTAL ONE POINT AND THAT
INCREASES MEANT THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS BROUGHT IN OVER THIRTY
FIVE BILLION. FOR THE SAKE
INDUSTRY AND- MONEY. RUNNING 28%
THE INDUSTRY'S NATIONAL SALES.
DESPITE DRIVING THESE REVENUES
FOR LARGE AND PROFITABLE
INDUSTRIES EMPLOYERS OF LABOUR
CONTRACTORS ARE CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE SAME OVERSIGHT
AS THE REST OF THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE. THE SECOND. THREE
HUNDRED LOOK AT THESE WERE. THIS
SECTION INCLUDING THE STATE OF
ILLINOIS NOW COLLECT AND PUBLISH
INFORMATION ON TEMPORARY
WORKERS- WE HAVE THE ILLINOIS
TRANSPARENCY BILL. ANY SEVENTEEN
THE STAFFING INDUSTRY HAS
INCREASED STATE REVENUE BY 32%
AND TOTAL EMPLOYMENT BY NEARLY
8% THE LION CLEANS YOU MIGHT
HEAR THAT TRANSFER EFFORT HIM.
GROWTH CAN HAVE. HER OUR
RESEARCH TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE THESE WORKERS
TEMPORARY WORKERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LIKELY TO BE
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR AND NON
BINARY COMPARED TO THE DIRECT
FOR BORIS. INTERNET OPTION HEY
EVEN THANK MORE ROLES- BY
COLLECTING ORDERS EVER GET WAGE
INFORMATION BUT HOW MANY WORKERS
AREN'T CERTAIN JOB CATEGORIES
THIS BILL CAN REVIEW WAGE.
PATTERNS IN. AND IT I AGREE WE
OFTEN IN THE RESEARCH BUT DON'T
YET HAVE CONSISTENT DATA- SO IN
CLOSING TO GET AN ACCURATE
PICTURE OF THE WORKFORCE SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO. REYES AND
WEBER. EMPATE AND I RESPECT
ENCOURAGE I BOTH THINK THANK YOU
MS HOLLOWAY ALL RIGHT I'M OTHERS
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
IN SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
BIRDS JESSICA STENDER ON BEHALF
OF THE GREAT ADVOCATES PROUD CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF STRONGER CALIFORNIA AS
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK. MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN
SENATORS JERRY BROWN HAVE S.
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY AIM ON BEHALF OF
WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER AND NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT
LAW PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED IN SUPPORT SEDONA TO
MICRO LET'S. SMART QUEUE UP
THOSE ON THE PHONE IT SB ELEVEN
THE TWO. AGAIN IT ONE AND THEN
GENERAL SUPPORT. WELL FIRST
CAROLINE THREE SEVENTY FOUR. HI
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KATHY VAN OFF AND ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT. THREE SEVENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ FOR
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THAT. THIRTY FIVE. MEMBERS ERIN
EVANS ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA PART THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THREE EIGHT FIVE. HI
EVAN MINTON WITH PLACES I THANK
AND FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU. TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANNY KENDALL
CRIES ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
LAWCENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. EIGHTY EIGHT. I CAN'T WAIT
FROM COMMUNICATIONS WORKERS OF
AMERICA AND IT SUPPORT THIS BILL
ALONG WITH OUR MEMBERS OF OUR
ORGANIZATION. THANK YOU. LINE
THREE SEVENTY THREE. HELLO NINE
EUROS AND BEHALF OF GREEN LINE
INSTITUTED SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THREE SEVENTY NINE YEAR OPEN.
HELLO AND OF YOUR MOMENT YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU. THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
KATHERINE HEDGES- SPLENDID
COLORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD LINE THREE SEVENTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON HOLLY MARQUEE
NEXT YEAR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS ALSO A CO
SPONSOR GRATEFUL TO THE AUTHOR
AND GRIFFIN ARE STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE SEVENTY
TWO. MORE ABOUT HEARING THE
COMMISSION ON THE STATUS OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN STRONG WORK.
THANK YOU. AND LINE TO SEVENTY
FOUR. HI MY NAME PREVENTIVE
PACKWOOD CAMP WORKER JOHN HAVE
BEEN CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
ELEVEN FIFTY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
EARLY NO. ALL RIGHT AND FOR THAT
THIS TIME OKAY LET'S NOT TURNED
OPPOSITION- ASHLEY HOFFMAN AND-
IS JAMIE HUFF. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACTUALLY
HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO IS ONE OF OUR JOB KILLER
BILLS I DO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHOR HER
STAFF AS WELL AS A SPONSOR.
WORKING WITH TO ADDRESS AND
CONCERT THE BILL. SUCH TWO AND
THREE I'M HOWEVER WE ARE STILL
DEEPLY CONCERN ABOUT. THE PAY
DATA IN SECTION ONE FOR US THERE
REALLY IS NO AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
UNLESS WE KEEP THOSE RECORDS IN
HANDS. YES H. AND WE HAVE DEEP
CONCERN. ASIAN WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES ATTEND
ADDRESSES SPACE REPORTER A LOAN
. TO STATE BECAUSE OF ACTION.
THIS OUR FEAR IS WILL HAVE NO
PRACTICAL- I USED TO GET LABOR
EMPLOY. CLAIM OR IF YOU. LOVE IF
YOU PLEASE LEAVE THEM. LEAVE TO
AMEND IT LEAST ONCE THEY ARE
BASICALLY REQUIRED TO DO SO AND
SECOND IT'S VERY EASY TO GET
AROUND ALL YOU REALLY NEED TO DO
TO GET OVER PLEADING HURDLE IS
TO ACT I KNOW PLAINTIFFS.
CONTENT CAN BELIEVE YOU FEEL
THAT YOU HAVE BEEN ON PAYER.
AGAIN IF THEY ARE YOU MEETING
HER ALL ALSO WE DON'T THINK OF
THE REALLY A FOR OF LITIGATION
AND DEMAND LETTERS THERE ARE A
LOT OF LAW FIRMS AND MAKE THEIR
ENTIRE PROFIT. LETTERS I TEND TO
THIS LETTER CAN ACTUALLY THE
WEBSITE LAST NIGHT AND WHAT THEY
DO IS THEY WILL POST THE NAME OF
A COMPANY AND THEY SAY SOMETHING
WELL HAVE YOU NOT PAID OVERTIME
YOU KNOW DO YOU KNOW YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO GET THIS. ASSIST AT
LEAST ONE WE CAN POST THESE KIND
OF ADVERTISEMENTS USING THESE
COMPANY NAMES AND WHEN YOU HAND
THEM FOURTEEN THOUSAND OF THESE
PAIDEIA REPORTS- HERE'S THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO.
AN ESSAY I ALL RIGHT. THE PORT
ST YOU'RE YOU KNOW YOU'RE-
AGAINST AN INTERVIEW WORKER BUT
I THINK THAT THE HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE HER TRADE AND I KNOW
YOU KNOW AUTHOR HAS A FOURTEEN
EIGHT THAT WOULD THAT LEAST AS
WHATEVER YOU AB PRINCE TREATMENT
. YOUR THANK BENEFITS BUT I'M
OUT EXACTLY WE IT NEEDS ARE NOT
ARE REALLY GIVING AN ACTOR
PICTURE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN A
AND GOING TO SEE FUTURE
LEGISLATION THAT TAKE AT NO AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT BECAUSE IT. I
ASSEMBLY BILL SIMILARLY IT WOULD
RANK COMPANIES YEAH THANK. THANK
YOU. OTHERS OTHERS AN OPPOSITE.
HI AFTERNOON A RESEARCHER
MEMBERS ANY HELP ON BEHALF OF C.
JOCK RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
BILL IN THE CURRENT FORM I WANT
TO ECHO MY CALL COM ABOUT THE
XIN HOW. IN THIS LINE WE
ACTUALLY ALL COMES A DATA CANNOT
TELL THE WHOLE. A CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES SHOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
TO LOS REPUTATIONAL CLASH.
REASONABLE PAY DIFFERENCES THAT
EXIST IN THE WORK FORCE I'M
SORRY. ANOTHER CAN BE
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS BILL IS THIS
IS A PUBLIC. WE WILL DO OUR PAY
DISCREPANCY. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER ON. AN APPLE OR UNLAWFUL
CONDUCT OCCURRED IN UNITED
KINGDOM FOR THIS TYPE OF DATA IS
PUBLISHED IN A GLIMPSE OF WHAT
THIS WOULD BE YES NEWS HEADLINES
WILL MINIMIZE BUSINESS. SAYS
EVEN BRIDGE. THAT ARE EXCEPT.
INDUSTRY YOU CAN ACTUALLY- LINE
THAT HAS FACED SEVERAL NEGATIVE
NEWS ARTICLES OVER THE
DIFFERENCES IN MEDIAN PAY WHICH
BETWEEN THE MALE AND THE FEMALE
PILOTS THE REASON FOR THE
DIFFERENCE IT BECAUSE THE PAY
DIFFERENCE. PILOTS REMEMBER HOW
SAY YOU HAVE TO START YOURSELF
YOU'VE ALREADY LOST WHICH IS YOU
KNOW BASED ON- WHERE OF IF YOUR
EX YOU'RE LOSING THE HEAD ALONE
CAN THE COMPANY A CALL PUT A-
THEIR.
SO THE FOREGOING REASONS- WE ASK
FOR YOU KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO. OTHERS HERE IN THE
IN THE OF- HEARING ROOM
OPPOSITION YES MISTER CHAIR
CHRIS MCNALLY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY
I LIVE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
Q. HYBRID ACCOUNT UP TO HALF OF
THE AMERICAN STAFFING
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA
STARTING FRESH ENOUGH. BECAUSE
TO THE I THINK. I THINK THE FACT
THAT MOST OF INDUSTRY SO IT'S
NOT ALL RIGHT COULD HAVE YOUR
VERY MUCH REASON MILLION OF DATE
THANK YOU. I MEMBERS. INSTRUCT
LAWYERS THE IS ASSOCIATION OF
THE LARGEST BUILT IN THE STATE
THANK YOU. ROBERT WILSON THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
HERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MARGARET LECCINUM I HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE TOP ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU OTHERS HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IN OPPOSITION
SAYING KNOWN APPROACHING MICHAEL
ON THE PHONE. YOU WOULD TURN TO
THE THANKS IN. THOSE TWO TWO
ELEVEN S. B. SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU AND TO HOLD THE ELEVEN FIFTY
TWO SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO FIRST WE'LL GO TO
LINE. SIXTY HELLO YOU ARE VERY
YES WE CAN. OKAY MY APOLOGIES-
I'M ACTUALLY CALLING IN SUPPORT-
I'M WITH WORK FACE MAINTAINING
PHASE AND I WAS CALLING TO
SUPPORT SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
MCCARTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE TAKING THOSE ON THE LINE
WHO DOES THE NEED. THERE FOR IN
THEIR POSITION RIGHT NOW TAKING
INTO STATE. THANK YOU ABOUT A
LINE EIGHT TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR KERRY MEMBERS TRICIA GERINGER
WITH CULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIANS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AT THE ELEVEN SIXTY
Q. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE PETER
WARD- WITH BIKE- THE BALLOT
VALLEY INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED THE OF IF
YOU YEAH THANK YOU. A LOT. THREE
EIGHTY NINE. HI THIS IS JAMIE
CON WITH THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. IN LINE FOR TWENTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MATTHEW ALLEN WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION- WE
ARE ALSO OPPOSED TO AT ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. HI WORKING
WITH. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN'T BUY. OKAY HI WITH YOU
FIGURE FEEL ITH THE CALIFORNIA
GROCERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THREE FORTY ONE. HI YES WITH THE
- HI YES THIS IS SUSAN REYES
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU. NOT
THREE SEVENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK THREE SEVENTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CINDY LEE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THREE
EIGHTY. WITH YOUR CURRENT
MEMBERS MIKE HELLO FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPLOYMENT LOG
COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND LASTLY
LINE THREE SEVENTY. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ROBERT WITH
THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION THE
UNITED CONTRACTORS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
CONFERENCE OF THE PLUMBING
HEATING PIPING INDUSTRY IN
OPPOSITION ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
FURTHER AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT
BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE
HEARING ROOM- QUESTIONS COMMENTS
ANNA CABALLERO. I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS AND I AM
GOING TO SAY- THAT I'VE YOU KNOW
I'VE HEARD ALL OF THAT SUPPORT
ME OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO
THINK- SYNERGY ONE FOR. FOR
TACKLING THIS THIS IS NOT AN
EASY AND EASY- BELT CRAFT A
SOLUTION FOR- THERE'S NO
QUESTION WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS
PAY EQUITY ISSUES- AND WE'VE
BEEN. TALKING ABOUT THESE EQUITY
ISSUES FOR THIRTY YEARS- AND THE
GAP DOESN'T GET ANY BETTER. DOES
IT YOU KNOW WE'VE WORKED ON IT
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE AND I
THINK WE'RE WE'RE GETTING THERE
BUT- BUT IT'S A PROCESS AND PART
OF THAT PROCESS IS SET. SHINING
SUNLIGHT ON. WHAT KIND OF WORK
PEOPLE ARE DOING. HOW MUCH
THEY'RE EARNING AND WHETHER
OTHER PEOPLE SIMILAR SIMILARLY
SITUATED ARE EARNING THE SAME
AND I THINK THERE'S THIS THIS
BELIEF IN THE COMMUNITY THAT MEN
NEED TO WORK MORE THAN WOMEN AND
SO THEY SHOULD GET PAID MORE AND
THAT'S JUST THAT'S NOT THE CASE
ANYMORE THAT MAY HAVE BEEN OUR
SOCIETY FIFTY YEARS AGO SIXTY
YEARS AGO BUT IT'S NOT NOW-
WOMEN NEED TO. WORK AT- MONEY
JUST LIKE MEN DO AND SO WHEN I
THINK YOU FOR TACKLING THIS- I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS. WITH THE OPPOSITION.
TECHNICAL FIXES. TO RELIEVE SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE- AT THE AMENDS
BECAUSE THEY ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED AND
I AND I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
AND WHAT. THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE MISTER CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO MOVE ABOUT. I THANK YOU
CYNICAL THANK YOU SEVERAL OTHER
QUESTIONS THE CENTER THE RUSSELL. YES I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GOING
WHATEVER YOU'RE GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL- YOU KNOW GETS HEARD AND
GETS VOTED ON- IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING TO SAY. **** ARE
COMPANIES GO TO BE PUBLICLY
SHAMED. WELL IF YOU THINK YOU'RE
GONNA BE PUBLICLY SHAMED AND FIX
THE PROBLEM- YOU KNOW JUST
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH WE- ALL AROUND
THE EDGES WE GO AROUND THE EDGES
AND THIS ISN'T EVEN REALLY
HITTING AT THE HEART OF THE
PROBLEM- BUSINESSES TO KEEP ON
ACTING THIS WAY WITH WOMEN. IT'S
SHAMEFUL. MAYBE THE BE SHAMED
PUBLICLY THIS IS NOT I KNOW THE
PURPOSE THE INTENTION I KNOW
THAT'S NOT WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
BUT I DON'T KNOW ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO OTHER
QUESTIONS OTHER COMMENTS SEEING
OF SIMILAR. I SHOULD'VE LET-
CENTER ROSS'S COMMENTS BE THE
CLOSE OF THE COMMITTEE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ONE THING YOU KNOW THE
ONE THING IS THE ONE THING IS
THAT- I JUST WANTED SOME CONTEXT
ARE BECAUSE I ACTUALLY WITH THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE MADE A THIS.
THAT'S CON START IN FULL. THE
WELCOME I'M- FROM THE COME. AND
THE ARE STILL. KANNST RAISED BY
OPPOSITION DO YOU THINK THERE
ARE STILL PLACES THAT YOU COULD
WORK TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE I
THINK TAKE COULD BE A MESS. IF
COMMITTEE ADDRESS. YOU THINK
KERR THE- THE CONCERNS THAT
AROUND SO I THINK THAT THE
AMENDMENTS I TUCK ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS BUT AS YOU HEARD
OPPOSITION SAY THAT THERE'S
NOTHING I CAN DO THERE ARE NO
AMENDMENTS. THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAVE. THAT NO I CONTINUE TO
LISTEN AND SEE IF THERE'S PLACES
WHERE WE CAN WORK BUT WHEN
OPPOSITION TELLS YOU AND YOU
KNOW GOES ON RECORD SAYING THERE
ARE NO AMENDMENTS AND THEY
WANTED DEAD I MEAN I HAVE TO
STAND UP THEIR POSITIONS OR THAT
WAS THE OUTLOOK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT- SO THE
COVER YOUR HIS MOVE THE BILL
WHICH LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU AND
AGAIN THANK TO THE AT U. S.
CENTER. KIND OF MET WHAT AN
AUTHOR. BUT I ALSO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEES GO THROUGH WHEN THEY
GET LOBBIED TO SIGNIFICANTLY ON
BOTH SIDES ON THESE DIFFERENT.
I'M THINK. AND I HAVE TO TELL
YOU I'VE ASKED MYSELF OVER AND
OVER AND OVER IF SHARING THE
TRUTH OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
THE ACT OF SHAMING AND I DON'T
BELIEVE IT IS GOING PUBLIC WHAT
THE REALITY IS I BELIEVE IS THE
ACT OF SHAMING I THINK THE ACT
OF SHAME COMES AND- I THINK THAT
. THE LATE THAT THAT INFORMATION
WILL NOT GO PUBLIC AND IT STARTS
AT A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES THEN
GOES DOWN TO EAT WE GET TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EMPLOYEES. HE
AT. A SENATOR I GET- MENTIONED
WE HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO DO THIS
BILL DOESN'T TELL SOMEONE TO PAY
SOMEONE A CERTAIN SALARY OR
CERTAIN WAGE THIS BILL IS ABOUT
. UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND WHAT OVER THREE OR FIVE
DECADES WE CONTINUE TO SEE THIS
PROBLEM AND THE MORE WE HIDE THE
DATA. THE HARDER GOING TO PRESS
TO ADDRESS THIS- AND SO
CERTAINLY I ALSO WANT TO RIP. A
LOT OF POSITION ROOM THERE ARE
COME NOW THAT ARE BE COMPANY
LIKE INTEL THAT IS OUR RELEASED
THIS INFORMATION THERE ARE
COMPANIES NATIONALLY AND IN THE
STATE WHO ARE DOING IT ON THEIR
OWN. BECAUSE THEY- AND THE-
PLEASE. ABLE TO. YOU KNOW THE
MAY- OF REALLY THEIR JOB IN
THEIR WORK FORCE BY BEING
TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW
DESPITE WHAT HAS BEEN SAID- AND
REFERENCING BILLS THAT ARE NOT
IN THIS COMMITTEE- OR IF THEY
HAVE EVEN MADE IT. TO LAW I
THINK IT'S ALSO IN INTO USE DATA
TO INFORM OUR DECISIONS I'M
SOMETIMES IN OUR WHERE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE SAY OH YOU SHOULD START
JUST YOU KNOW ASKING FOR. THERE
WERE AT AND IF THE JOB. RIGHT
IT'S LIKE OKAY WELL THERE'S NO
THERE'S NO REAL REGULATION
THERE- IT'S ALSO YOU KNOW
FASTENING IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE WHEAT THIS DATA
COMPANIES OF A HUNDRED OR MORE
EMPLOYEES ARE ALREADY REPORTING
THE STATE IT'S JUST NOT PUBLIC.
SO WE'RE NOT ASKING THEM. TO DO
SOMETHING THAT THEIR- NO. FIGURE
OUT HOW DO WE THIS AND WE ALSO
ARE LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW FOLKS
IN THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO BE
PARTNERS INSTEAD OF OPPOSING AND
YOU KNOW AGREEING WITH THE
STATUS QUO THAT WE DON'T WANT.
TO PAY A YOU KNOW IN THE SAME
LIGHT AT MEN AND WOMEN AND YOU
KNOW AFRICAN AMERICANS AND I
HAVE I FEEL LIKE IT'S JUST
INPUT. SAY LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND LET'S LOOK AT THE DATA
TOGETHER TO OUT HOW WE ADDRESS
THIS. ARE NOT AND IT SAYS. FOR
NINE AM I WANT. MY BILL ALONE
WON'T DO IT MY BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT HAVING INFORMATION SO THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND. WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH THESE COMPANIES.
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT NOT A FEW CUPS OF YOU CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR LEE
MARTIN. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR COVER YET ALL THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND IT. TO THE CAN
APPROPRIATE. NUMBER I BORGIAS.
BOARD IS NO AT ALL. VERY AT ALL
I RUSSELL. RUSSELL I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG JONES JONES NO LAYERED
LAYERED I STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI
WHITE HOUSE HE AYE WIENER YOU
HAVE THREE FIVE FIVE TWO TWO
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL THE NEXT
ASSEMBLY MON ITEM EIGHT SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU
TERRY MEMBERS S. ELEVEN SEVENTY
SEPARATE TO CONTINUE. NUMBER
ABOUT HOW WELL I FOR AND- ARE
SERVING COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WHO CAN. FROM HEALTHY
FINANCIAL PRODUCTS AND- I THINK
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS LIKE LO FI BANK
ACCOUNTS AND MORTGAGES OR SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS WITH FARE RATES
IT'S A POSITIVE THING FOR OUR
CONSTITUENTS. IT INTO MANY
PLACES ACROSS THE STATE
SPECIALLY IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
CONSTITUENTS NOT ENJOY. ACCESS
AS WEALTHIER AND MORE DENSELY
POPULATED AREAS BACK IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TRIED TO ADDRESS
THESE DISPARITIES BY PASSING THE
COMMUNITY REINVESTMENT ACT KNOWN
AS THE C. R. EIGHT WHICH-ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK TO
EVALUATE HOW WELL BANKS. ARE
MEETING THE FINANCIAL SERVICES
NEED TO THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
THEY DO BUSINESS. THE FEDERAL
CRA IS NOT PERFECT AND ONE OF
THE WAYS IF FALL SHORT IS THAT
IT COVERS ONLY BANKS THIS MAY
HAVE BEEN REASONABLE IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN BANKS
HOW MANY DID THE FINANCIAL.
TIMES BUT FAST FORWARD TO TODAY
HAVE A VARIETY OF FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE NOT
EVAPORATED FOR HOW WELL THEY ARE
SERVING UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING. YOUR NAME IN THE
RECORD COMPANY AND A GREAT. TECH
LENDERS. RECOGNIZING THIS GAP
SEVERAL STATES HAVE ENACTED
THEIR OWN FURY LAWS IN AN EFFORT
TO ENCOURAGE A BROADER SECTOR
FINANCE SERVICES JUST TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF. COMMITTEES FOR IS
. I RECKLESS. START A
CONVERSATION IT WEALTH GAP IS
SOME OF US ARE FROM IF WE UNDER
THE FINANCIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT GAP WHETHER IT BE LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE MONEY FOR A DOWN
PAYMENT ON THE HOUSE OR WHETHER
IT'S LIKELY TO HIGHER STUDENT
LOAN DEBT OR HIGH INTEREST
CREDIT CARD DEBT BUT THERE IS
ALSO THE THING THAT MUST ADDRESS
WHEN IT COMES TO INTERACTING
WITH FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS I IS
. TO TRY. OKAY KING AND BANKING
HEARING TO BE TREATED
DIFFERENTLY. DECADES OF BEING
OFFERED STEPS STANDARD PRODUCTS
IF ANY AT ALL. AND THOSE DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IS NOT JUST OUR
OWN GENERATION BUT ALSO THE
GENERATIONS THAT CAME BEFORE US.
ALL OF THAT EXPERIENCE CREEPS
ARE PREDICTIONS TODAY. THE
FEDERAL DID NOT EXT. FOR RAY. IN
AT THE- OF.
FINANCIAL SERVICES EVEN AS OUR
COUNTRY HAS MADE PROGRESS IN
NARROWING THE WAGE GAP THE GAP
IN HOME OWNERSHIP RATES. BETWEEN
BLACK AND WHITE AMERICANS IS NOT
THE SAME AS IT WAS BEFORE
PASSING THE FAIR HOUSING ACT IN
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. FEELING
TAKEN RACENET ANOTHER FOR GOLD
C. R. A. P. THEY STATED I
BELIEVE THAT WE MUST DO MORE
INFIGHTING THE REVERSE. FIRST
THE LADY COUNTY FOR ESTATE
REGULAR TO BE VALLEY HER STATE
LICENSE BY IS FOR HOW WELL THEY
ARE SERVING THE DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA WITH
THAT I DO THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
THOSE IN SUPPORT- OF A LEAH SHE
HE IS A LEADER SHE HEAT ON THE
PHONE. OR YEAH I WANT- EL HALABI
. YES THIS MONTH SHE HE'D- YES.
WE'VE GET ACCIDENT BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BEING
COALITION OR THE ARE THE FIRST
SHORT AND I'M CALLING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. ELEVEN SEVEN
SIX TODAY. WE REMAIN LEAST LIKE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO A BANK ACCOUNT
REFORM SMALL BUSINESS FROM AN
EARLY PRICE MORTGAGE. INSTEAD WE
ARE FORCED TO PAY MORE IN FEES
AND HAVE HIGHER INTEREST RATES
ON CREDIT CARDS CAR LOANS SMALL
BUSINESS CAPITAL AND EVEN
MORTGAGE LOAN THE- IS A MORE.
FOR BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE IN TANGLED IN A DEBT TRAP
AS A RESULT THERE'S A STRONG
DISTRUST OF THE INDUSTRY AND
IT'S BEEN THAT BUILDING WEALTH
OR EVEN LONG TERM FINANCIAL
STABILITY IS UNATTAINABLE. HE'S
RESEARCH AND OUR MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS EXPERIENCES. AT
NATIONAL AND YEAH GETTING POLICY
DRIVEN SO THE FACT THAT THERE
DEBATED- BEING BORN IN RAISED IN
STOCK I HAVE WITH AND THE RATE
AND THE CREDIT LENDER PRACTICE
HAVE BILL GENERATIONAL POVERTY I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR.
ENOUGH THAT NATIONAL. BOY
DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICE BUT
NATIONAL INSTITUTE NEED TO.
ENSURE THAT THEY PRACTICES AND
PRODUCTS EQUITABLE AND PROVIDE
TANGIBLE BENEFITS TO UNDERSERVED
CALIFORNIANS UNDER S. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX YES YEAH I WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ANALYZE WHETHER
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION CAN
CONDUCT BUSINESS. THAT DOES
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA ARM. OF THE
OBTAINING THIS INFORMATION IS A
CRITICAL STEP TOWARD ADDRESSING
THE RACISM AND DISPARITIES THAT
MAKE IT NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES TO
SURVIVE AND THRIVE ECONOMICALLY
THIS BILL IS LONG OVERDUE AND
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND GET
FOR IT. THANK YOU THANK YOU ARE
. OF MS ROCK ONE. FELLOW HOBBY.
ARAMBULA FUTURE AMBITIONS
MELANIE MORALIS- IN PLACE THE
FOR ONE- ON BEHALF AGREE MONEY
INSTITUTE. ALREADY GO AHEAD. I'M
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- AT ELEVEN THIRTY SIX
THE ART FIRST STEPHANIE
SPEAKING EQUITY IN OUR FINANCIAL
SYSTEM FOR STATE LICENSE WONDERS
AND UNDERSTANDING THE CREDIT YOU
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES IN WHICH
WE OPERATE. NOW THIS IS URGENTLY
NEEDED EXTRADITION- BASIC
RECENTLY CONSOLIDATE INCLUDE
BRANCHES CREATING A LEADING
ACTING THAT IS EASILY FILLED BY
UNDER REGULATED THEY MIGHT
BLUNDERS I THINK THAT ALL
REGULATORS DO NOT HAVE A
FRAMEWORK FOR EVALUATING WHETHER
STATEWIDE WONDERS ARE MEET THE
FINANCIAL NEEDS OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. YEAH LET. THE CREDIT.
WHAT WE DEVELOPING A FRAMEWORK
HOW IN A RESEARCH THE FOUND THAT
BAKER HAVE A GREATER PRESENCE IN
COMMUTER COLOR LONG TO MEET.
COMMUNITY TRADITIONAL BANK
CONCERNING BECAUSE THESE GROUPS
ARE HIGHLY VULNERABLE TO
PREDATORY LENDING AND BECAUSE
NONBANK LENDERS ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO THE FEDERAL THE R. EIGHT
WHICH LEGALLY OBLIGATED HELPING
TO CREATE CREDIT PETER BOEING
KUMBHARIA IF WE CAN RESPONSIBLY
NOW THIS WILL HELP BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS ON IN
OUR CITIES. WONDER PRESSURE
ROLLED ENSURING THAT ALL. A FULL
BLOWN THANK I MEAN AND REDUCE
WHITE RACIAL GAP IT IS RESEARCH
DONE BY THE FEDERAL RESERVE BANK
OF SAN FRANCISCO IT AND OTHERS
ALSO SHOW THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
THE RISK MULTIPLIER THAT
EXAGGERATES RACIAL AND ECONOMIC
INEQUALITY. ELEVEN EXPERIENCE
TODAY THE GREEN LINE INSTITUTE
WOULD AGREE PROVISION
INCORPORATING THE GEOSPATIAL
ANALYSIS IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
OPPORTUNITIES WITH YOUR A
QUALIFYING INVESTMENTS CAN
ADDRESS MANY NEEDS. WHAT WOULD
YOU CAN POLLUTION ENVIRONMENTS
WE BURDEN COMMUNITIES WITH THAT
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE- AND
BEHOLDERS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT. OTHERS SUPPORT
IN THE- HEARING ROOM SEEING
KNOWN APPROACHING MIKE PHONE
LET'S NOW TURN TO THE PHONE
LINES. THOSE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX MODERATE.
THEM THANK YOU AND IF YOU DO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO.
AND WE CAN FIRST FIRST CAROLINA
TWO EIGHT EIGHT. KIDNAPPING
SHARE MEMBERS DANNY CAN'T GO
BECAUSE HER ON BEHALF OF BOTH
THE NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CENTER
AND THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE. HE CAN BE JUST A
MOMENT HERE ONE WHAT A LINE
THREE EIGHTY SIX. JOSH YOU TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CUP CONSUMER
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU. CURRENTLY NONE
FURTHER ALREADY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT LET'S NOT TURN
THE OPPOSITION I HAVE NO WON A
LISTED AS FORMAL APPLE IN- IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IF THEY TO
PUT THE MICROPHONE NO LONGER
PRODUCE LET'S NOW TURN TO THE
PHONE LINE. FOR THOSE IT
POSITION TO S. B. ELEVEN SIX
MODERATE IF YOU QUEUE UP THOSE
ON BONE. THANK YOU A POST PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO THIS TIME AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSE. AND
NINE CURRENTLY HAVE POSING. ALL
RIGHT WITH NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE- IS THERE MOTION SIR
WHY CASKEY MOVES THE BILL-
CEREMONY CRITICAL BILLS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL.
ONE ONE SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR LEE
MARTIN WITH- MOTION BY CENTER
WHITE HOUSE YOU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. I'M I BOUGHT THIS. FOR
JUST NOW CARILLO. THE RUSSELL
THE REST SO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
JONES AIRED ALL RIGHT LAYERED
ICE STERN WAKE HOUSE HE Y.
CASKEY AYE WIENER. YOU HAVE
FORTY ONE SO FAR MEMBERS MISSING
RT THANK YOU- WILL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL I SEE SENATOR MEN HERE
SENATOR MEN S. B. EIGHT SIX
THREE PHYLUM NUMBER NINETEEN. I
THANK YOU DEREK NUMBER THANKS
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THIS CLOSELY ON
THIS BILL I SB EIGHT SIXTY THREE
WOULD ALLOW DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DEATH REVIEW TEAMS TO EXAMINE
YOUR DEATH INCIDENTS OF DOMESTIC
ABUSE BEFORE I BEGIN TO CLARIFY
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES. RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS TODAY. WHILE FEW ARE
FAMILIAR THE WORK OF DEATH
REVIEW TEAMS THEY PLAY A CRUCIAL
ROLE IN CREATING THE DATA AND
RESEARCH ON THE CAUSES. OF
DOMESTIC ABUSE RELATED
FATALITIES WITH THE GOAL OF
PREVENTING FUTURE SUCH
TRAGEDIES. THAT THE REVIEW TEAMS
ARE OPTIONAL FOR COUNTIES AND
ARE COMPRISED OF. TEARS FROM
BILL. ADVOCATE IN JUDICIAL GROUP
. THEY WORK WITH ONE FOR TO
PROVIDE A CONFIDENTIAL FORUM TO
SYSTEMATICALLY REVIEWED DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RELATED DEATHS. HOWEVER
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA LAW
CURRENTLY LIMITS THESE TEAMS TO
ONLY INVESTIGATE AND RESEARCH
SITUATIONS OF DOMESTIC ABUSE
ABUSE THAT ACTUALLY RESULT IN
DEATH- THIS IGNORES A INCREDIBLY
LARGE NUMBER OF INCREDIBLY
SERIOUS. MYSTIC VIOLENCE WHERE
THE- PARTY CAME VERY CLOSE TO
BUT DID NOT ACTUALLY SUCCEED IN
PULLING THE SURVIVOR. ON TO MY
LEVEL OR SEEN MANY STATES
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
INVESTIGATING YOUR DEATH
INCIDENTS AND EXPANDING THE ROLE
OF DEATH REVIEW TEAMS. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FOR A THIRD OF STATE
LEGISLATURE LIVES AROUND THE
COUNTRY HAVE PASSED US UP. THE
RISING ARE THESE TEAMS. L. HELP
USUALLY. IN AREAS LIKE THIS BUT
HE- ARE OUTDATED LAWS ARE
PREVENTING OUR ABILITY TO
CONDUCT COMPREHENSIVE RESEARCH
THAT WILL CLEARLY HELP PREVENT
FUTURE DEBTS. TO SUPPORT THE
ROLE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE DEATH
REVIEW TEAMS PLAY IN PROTECTING
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SB EIGHT SIXTY THREE. WOULD
AUTHORIZE TEAMS TO INVESTIGATE
YOUR DEATH INCIDENTS AND I WANT
TO CLARIFY THAT. BILL IS IT THIS
DOESN'T THINK TO EXPAND OR
CHANGE CRIMINAL LIABILITY.
ASSERTIONS OF OPPOSITION. TO
ACTUALLY DOES NOT CHANGE A LOT
SIMPLY EXPANSIVE BILITY OF-
THESE REVIEW TEAMS TO REVIEW A
BROADER ARRAY OF CASES. BY
BRINGING CALIFORNIA ALIGNMENT
WITH NUMEROUS OTHER STATES THE
BILL WOULD PROMOTE THAT CRUCIAL
WORK OF THE VIEW TEAMS AND SO
FORTH. EFFORTS TO. THIS OF
DRIVERS I HAVE WITH ME TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. MISTER PEDRO
NAVA THE CHAIRMAN OF THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION. THANK YOU
FORMER ASSEMBLYMAN NAVA IT. IF
YOU ARE ON THE PHONE- WE WOULD
AWAIT YOUR COMMENTS. I AM CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU LOUD
AND CLEARLY. WELL IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE ABLE TO JOIN ALL
OF YOU- THIS AFTERNOON- MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'VE
- THEY DON'T ABA. AND I'M
CURRENTLY SERVING AS CHAIR OF
THE LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT SIXTY THREE. THE
COMMISSION IS AN INDEPENDENT
BIPARTISAN OVERSIGHT AGENCY
CHARGED WITH MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE STATE
GOVERNMENT. IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE ISSUED TWO REPORTS
EXAMINING CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE
TO INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
MILLIONS OF CAP. THE BALL BACK.
AND YET AGAIN TO THE- THIS
HORRIFIC FORM OF ABUSE DURING
THEIR LIFETIME. IN OUR ENTITLED
BEYOND THE CRISIS THE LONG TERM
APPROACH TO REDUCE PREVENT AND
RECOVER FROM INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE WE LEARNED THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS MORE ACCURATE
DATA TO SUCCESSFULLY ADDRESSED
THIS HEINOUS CRIME. BAKAL CALON
AND YOU KNOW THE FULL SCOPE AND
IMPACT OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE ON CALIFORNIA NOR DOES
THE STATE KNOW THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THE TWO MAIN PROGRAMS FOR
SURVIVORS TO FACILITATE EVIDENCE
BASED DECISION MAKING THE
COMMISSION RECOMMENDED THAT
CALIFORNIA GREATER FOR WORK FOR
DATA COLLECTION AND ANALYSIS
ONCE CREATED. CAN BE USED TO
EVALUATE THE EFFECT OF THE
MESSAGE THAT IT IS USING TO
COMBAT INTERNET PARTNER BY WE
HAVE EIGHT WOULDN'T RECKON YOU
SHOULD. HELP STATE GALLAGHER
DATA IN A OUR RISK. TO THE
HORRIBLE. WE BELIEVE THE WILL
ALLOW CAL TO BETTER SERVE
SURVIVORS I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MAN FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS CRUCIAL ISSUE AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
TODAY. ON BEHALF THE LITTLE
HOOVER GEN I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALL
RIGHT NEXT TO DR DAVID WELCH.
DOCTOR WELL SHE WILL NOT BE
JOINING US OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT SIX THREE OR HERE IN
THE- HEARING ROOM. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
THOSE MODERATOR IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT SIX THREE. THANK YOU
CAN DO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE CAN GO TO
LINE THREE THIRTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS CUT THE
COLOGNE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AB CUP MORE HERE GIVE
ME JUST A MOMENT. CAN WE GO TO
LINE THREE FIFTY NINE. HI YES
THIS IS CATHERINE CAMPBELL WITH
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
. AND AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO GIVE
ME JUST A MOMENT WE HAVE ONE
MORE HERE WHAT IT TO NINETY NINE
. YES CANNELLA NINE CO FOUNDER
OF CALIFORNIA. ANSYS ADDITION.
AND WHAT AT THE EIGHT SIXTY
THREE THANK YOU. AND THEN
FURTHER AT THIS TIME RT THANK
YOU LET'S NOW TURN TO OPPOSITION
I DON'T SEE ANYONE FORMALIST IS
OPPOSITION OF THIS ANYONE
OPPOSED SB EIGHT SIX THREE IN
THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE SING KNOWN
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE LET'S
NOW TURN TO THE PHONE LINES.
MOTOR IF YOU QUEUE UP THE
OPPOSITION S. B. EIGHT SIX THREE
. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN TO OPPOSE PRESS ONE
ZERO. GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR- TO. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. I'M
SORRY I MISSED THE- SUPPORT THAT
MY NAME IS MEGAN WE FROM EVER
HAVING A SERVICES OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. EIGHT SIXTY THREE THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. NOT HOLDING AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT ONE COMING UP
HERE K. WE JUST A MOMENT.
APOLOGIZE HERE WILL BE WITH YOU
JUST A SECOND HERE. IN THREE
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS SANDY ROTH. AS FOR THE
SENATE I'M IN SUPPORT I'M SORRY
I COULDN'T GET ON THAT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH NUMBER
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
I THINK WE'VE EXHAUSTED THOSE ON
THE PHONE LINE NOW LET'S TURN TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS COMMENTS-
CENTER WHITE HOUSE HE MOVES THE
BILL- SO YOU CAN. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU HAVE A ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MENEM CHIEF
COUNSEL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS SENATE BILL EIGHT SIX
THREE BY SENATOR MAN WITH THE
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GET MOTION IS DUE TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG HI. NUMBER
I BORJAS BRIDGES I GOVERNMENTAL
. DRESSEL DRESSEL AYE GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG JONES LAYERED LAYERED
I STERN MIKE HOUSEKI WHITE HOUSE
HE AYE WIENER. YOU HAVE FIVE TO
ZERO MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PLACE THE BILL ON CALL
NEXT- FILE NUMBER TWENTY S. B.
NINE SEVENTY FIVE CINNAMON THANK
YOU GET RICH AGAIN SHARE ON
BURKE I ALSO WANT TO SAY- GIVE
IT ABOUT HEARING COMMITTEE STAFF
THE CHRISTIAN KRIPO SKI. IT'S
BEEN CLINICALLY TO ME I STEP
THIS BILL FOR THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF I ALSO WANT TO STATE I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMERICANS TODAY SB NINE SEVENTY
FIVE. WHICH WOULD CREATE CAUSE
OF ACTION THROUGH WHICH A DEBTOR
CAN SEEK RELIEF FROM TANK AND
DIRETTE IN CAN. FOR OR LOWER
CASE THE RESEARCH THEIR PERSONAL
AND- FOR PER. GAIN THIS SEEKS TO
ADDRESS A PERVASIVE- FORM OF
ABUSE DEFINED HERE'S ECONOMIC
PORTION WHICH AFFECTS. THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ALL TOO OFTEN.
I AND IS ALSO FREQUENTLY WITH
SENIOR CITIZENS AND FOSTER
YOUTH. THIS ABUSE CAN LOOK LIKE
IN THE FOLLOWING WITHHOLDING
MONEY BEING A PARTNER AN
ALLOWANCE- OF FORCING OR
THREATEN A PARTNER TO FILE
FRAUDULENT LEGAL DOCUMENTS OR
SPEND CERTAIN AMOUNTS OF MONEY
AGAINST THEIR WILL. THREATENING
THIS WILL SAVE YOUR WELL BEING
OF THE SURVIVOR IF THEY DO NOT
AGREE TO MAKE CERTAIN PURPOSE
PURCHASES. ECONOMIC MAYBE A NEW
ASSAULT INCREDIBLY COMMON TACTIC
OF FINANCIAL. AND NINE PER. BUT
SHIPS. IS TO PRIVATE. STICKLE A-
SEEKING TO THESE ABUSIVE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT ACCESS TO
ECONOMIC RESOURCES IS THE MOST
LIKELY PREDICTOR OF WHETHER
SURVIVOR WILL EIGHT- ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY SEPARATE FROM THEIR
ABUSIVE PARTNER IN A TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE STEP OF 85%
VICTIM RETURNED TO THEIR VIEW
PART A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER CITED
AN INABILITY TO ADDRESS THEIR
FINANCES AS THE REASON THEY WENT
BACK. IT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION
L. MEASURE IS SPONSORED
COSPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER
AND ALLOW FOUNDATION OF SILICON
VALLEY IT'S SUPPORTED BY A WIDE
ARRAY OF GROUPS INCLUDING THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA.
AND THE COMMISSION. CAN I HAVE
BEEN IN CLOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH
OPPOSITION OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
REALLY FOR LAST YEAR AND A HALF
AND YOU MAY RECALL THAT I PULLED
THE BILL LAST YEAR BECAUSE I
FELT LIKE IT WAS NOT RIGHT THAT
POINT. SUPP ACTIVELY SOUGHT
DISCUSSED THIS AND FEEDBACK FROM
OPPOSITION GROUPS AND WE'VE
TAKEN A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS
ALONG THE WAY THAT HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM VARIOUS GROUPS-
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE DIALOGUE ON THIS MEASURE-
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS NOT UP.
TO THE MAX ISN'T A GREAT GROUP.
OF THE BUTTE. READ AND
PERNICIOUS. THAT COERCED DEBT
CAN PREVENT PEOPLE KIND
PRIMARILY WOMEN FROM LEAVING
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEY
THAT CAN END UP IN DEATH FOR
THEM. I WILL TRY TO CREATE A
NARROW EXCEPTION THAT ALLOWS THE
SURVIVORS TO SKIP THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY NOT ONE THAT IS RIFE
WITH ABUSE- AND SWEET LOOKING
FOR DESTRUCTIVE FEEDBACK TO TRY
TO MAKE THIS BILL BETTER. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO ALONG THE
WAY YOU HAVE MY WORD ON THAT. I
WITH ME ATTEMPT TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY REMOTELY TODAY IS LEE
FERRAN OF THE PUBLIC LAW
FOUNDATION. AND OPERATED
GUERRERO AND IMMIGRATION
SERVICES MANAGER AT THE WOMEN'S
TRANSITIONAL LIVING CENTER.
ALREADY THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
HAPPENING JERRY MEMBERS OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME IS LISA
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC LAWCENTER WHICH
IS THE LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES FREE
CIVIL LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS OF ORANGE
COUNTY. I'M I IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE CENTS. WHICH WILL PROVIDE
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ELDER ABUSE FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
THE ABILITY TO FIGHT BACK WHEN
THEY ARE BEING HELD RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT THEY WERE COERCED INTO
TAKING OUT. FINANCIAL CONTROL IS
ONE OF THE MAIN ASPECT THAT
WOULD BE THE RELATIONSHIP
WHETHER THAT. AUTHORITIES ARE
CHAPLAIN. NUMBER OF LAWS THAT
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL FACING
COLLECTION AND PROTECT FOR
pHOWEVER WHEN WORKING. YOU HAVE A
NICE WHILE THE THIRTEEN THERE IS
NO LAW THAT DIRECTLY ADDRESSES
THEIR SITUATION. WELL THE
PROVIDER MAY KNOW OF THE
EXISTENCE OF A SPECIFIC THAT. WE
CERTAINLY DID NOT REALLY CONTENT
BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT IN
ALMOST ALL CASES WHERE FINANCIAL
CONTROLS PREENT THE SURVIVOR
HAS NO MEANS BY WHICH TO PAY FOR
THAT. ALL THESE THAT MAY NOT BE
MUCH TOO MANY RELIEVING THAT THE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ARE LIFE CHANGING FOR
SURVIVORS OF ABUSE. FOSTER YOUTH
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO. HELP FINANCIALLY. CREDITORS
YOU OFTEN DO NOT THANK THE- LEE
AND ONE CASE ARE ALL PRACTICE
MULTIPLE LANE LETTER WITH THE
DOCUMENTS. OUTLINING THE OF AND
RESPONSE TO CREDITORS GOOD
ACTORS I AM. COMPLETELY IGNORING
THE ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE. SB
NINE SEVENTY. OF PROCESS. IS.
ACTUALLY REQUEST YOUR EYES OUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS FERRON
ALL RIGHT- IS CARRERO. YOUR NAME
NUMBER AND COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE AND THEN THE QUESTION
AND ANSWER WHATEVER GEOGRAPHY
WHICH IS WITH AT THE COUNTER
AND- ORANGE COUNTY. THEY'RE PART
SUPPORT SB 9405% OF THE MEN'S
FOUR THAT IS OFTEN BIGGEST OFF
FIBERS MOST OF THE PAST. IT I'M
OF THE POP FOR TO MOVE FORWARD
THEY HAVE IT WILL. FOR THE
PAYCHECK TO PAY OFF THAT
INCLUDES ONE. BUT THE BUYER FROM
A THREE HEALTHY FIFTY FACT
FRIDAY EARLY BILLION SECURITY
POP THE HOBBIT. ADVERTISEMENT IS
EITHER UNABLE RECOVER NORMAL
MARGIN. THERE ARE EXAMPLE FROM
LATIN AMERICA SIXTEEN TO HAVE A
- YEAH THE PRIMARY INCOME. MEDIA
WITH. IT IS A MATTER OF THEIR
WORK AND THEIR FAMILIES
APARTMENT TO TRY FINANCES MANAGE
ALL OF MY MONEY UNVEILED A
MILLION NOTICED THAT THERE WERE
A NOTICES ON THE GENERAL BEEN
WITHOUT SHOT NEVER A MISTAKE THE
BILL. BUT IT AT THE WORST POINT
. FIFTY ONE WITH THE OCEAN OFF
BETWEEN NINETEEN AND LEAVING
AFTERNOON TO FAMILY. WHAT I FIND
IN A PEOPLE. THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO WATCHING VIDEO
WITH. CREDIT IN ONLY. HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO FIND STABLE. LEAVING HER
FOR ANOTHER PLACE FOR YOUR ON
HEALTHCARE.
POLICY NEVER REPEAT ANYTHING
NORMAL THE MANY FACEBOOK PICTURE
. WHEN SHE FINALLY ESCAPED
MARRIAGE WAS WITH THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN CREDIT CARD DEBT
WHICH IS STILL PAYING OFF TODAY
IN OTHER WORDS NO SAVINGS OR
SAFETY. NINETY ENGINE EXAMPLE
THE AND BURGER. ON PROVIDERS
THANKS FOR THAT FOR SOME IS THE
ME BACK WHILE OF THE THAT ARE
COULD YOU CALIFORNIA. THE THIRD
TWO VOTE MAJORITY OF HIS CAREER
A FEW IT UP. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
. OTHERS IN SUPPORT S. NINE
FIVE. OTHERS HERE THE HEARING
HIM SING ON APPROACHING
MICROPHONE OTHERS IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. THOSE IN SUPPORT B
NINE SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO SO. WE CAN
GO TO LINE THREE NINETY NINE.
RECKONING HERE NUMBERS JESSICA
SPENDER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK AND
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS IN
COURT. THANK YOU FOR ALL THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS
CRITICAL AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PROBLEM WITH UNFAIR OF
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE
FOUR OH SEVEN. HI EVAN MINTON
WITH THE PROGRESS WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU. AND LINE THREE FIFTY
EIGHT. ACTUALLY HURLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION FROM SUPPORT
THANK YOU. YOU FOUR HUNDRED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CREAM ALLIED WITH
THE CHILDCARE LAWCENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE NINTH OF GAME.
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT. THE ANY OTHER CUSTOMER ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL CONSUMER
LAW CENTER AND THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND
LINE THREE FIFTY NINE. THREE HOW
CAN I HANDLE. DR CAMPBELL
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
THE STATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THREE NINETY SEVEN. B. NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PHOTO
LINE FEDERAL ONE. HI BRING HIM
ON BEHALF OF THREE FRIENDS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINETY THREE
NINETY FOUR. B. NINETY FOUR. WE
CAN GO TO LINE ONE NINETY NINE.
WHEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH WHILE MANAGER TOURNEY
WITH A LAW COMPETITION OF
SILICON VALLEY I AM A PROUD
SPONSOR OF SB NINE FIVE I WORK
EVERY GAVE WITH CURRENTLY
PERFORMING VERY MUCH RICK. LAW
RIGHT I CAN'T IMMENSELY THANK
YOU ARE NEXT IN LINE FOR- TO.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. I'M FROM
NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL SERVICES OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF AND ON I. THIRTY I
THANK YOU. THEN FURTHER AT THE
FINE ALREADY THANK YOU NOW LET'S
TURN TO OPPOSITION- WE HAVE MR
WILSON AND MR GOVERNOR HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IN OPPOSITION
DO SB NINE SEVENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROB WELLS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CREDIT YOU. APPLE OPPOSITION SB
NINE SEVENTY FIVE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT FINANCIAL ABUSES
DESTRUCTIVE WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING REAL
VICTIMS WITH REAL RELIEF IN A
WAY THAT IS NOT RECOUNTED ON THE
FINANCIAL MARKET PLACE.
UNFORTUNATELY NINE SEVENTY FIVE
IS NOT A CALL VOTE THIS AND
INSTEAD SUFFERS FROM NUMEROUS.
MENTAL FIRST THE MEASURE TREATED
PREDATOR WORSEN THE- SB NINE
SEVENTY FIVE RIDGE NEW CAUSE OF
ACTION FOR THE NEW CRIME
ACCORDING TO DEBT. WHERE THE
CLAIM IS NOT THE PERPETRATOR THE
CRIME BUT A PARTY WHO'S
COLLECTING ON THE BALLOT DEBT.
RELIEF TO THE DEBTORS IN THE
FORM OF UNILATERAL CANCELLATION
OF THE DEAD ITS ENTIRETY. YET
ADEQUATE DOCUMENTATION IS MADE.
OUT OF A DRUG ADDITION IS ABSENT
REQUIREMENT EVEN NAME THE
PERPETRATOR EVEN THOUGH THE IN
THE NATURE OF THIS CRIME
INDICATES THAT THE USERS NOW.
WHICH MEANS THAT THE PENALTY
THIS CRIME IS ON THE LENDERS
HAVE NO PATH WOULD BE. MADE
WHOLE. A CREDITOR WOULD NOT AND
SHOULD NOT HAVE INFORMATION
REGARDING REGARDING A DEBTOR'S
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP. NOR THE
NATURE OF THE ABUSE IN ORDER TO
REBUT THE PRESUMPTION. THE
MEASURE STATES THAT ACCREDITORS
NOT PREVENTED FROM ENFORCING A
DEBT HOWEVER MERELY STATING THAT
A CREDITOR. CAN COLLECT IS NOT
GIVEN THE LEGAL AUTHORITY TO DO
SO. MANY GETS A PERPETRATOR AS A
RESPONSIBLE PARTY AS NECESSARY
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL. THE
MEASURE CONTAINS A MULTITUDE OF
OTHER SIGNIFICANT ISSUES WHICH
ARE LETTER EXPANSIVE POINT SUCH
AS DESPITE THE RECENT AMENDMENT
THE SCOPE REMAINS VIRTUALLY
ENDLESS WITHOUT GUARDRAILS IN
THE TYPE OF RELATIONSHIP
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT QUALIFIED
DEBTOR FOR RELIEF. AND THERE'S
LITTLE NO PROTECTIONS FOR
CREDITORS AGAINST COLLUSION AND
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS WHICH MEANS
BAD ACTS HAVE NOTHING TO LOSE BY
MAKING FALSE ALLEGATIONS.
MEMBERS SB NINE SEVENTY FIVE UP
AND SPOTIFY CONTRACTS THE
REVOCATION TO FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS AND THE BILL BE
CREDIT WILL NOT BE SMALL
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS BILLS
HOPING TO HELP. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MUST CONTINUALLY
RIGHT TO OPPOSE SB NINE SEVENTY
FIVE I RESPECTFULLY IMPLORE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE PROPONENT TO
CONSIDER OTHER SUCH AVENUE SUCH
AS RE EXAMINE TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN WHICH JUST BECAME IN
WHICH WE JUST BECAME ACTIVE.
THIS JANUARY STARTING THE
ANALYSIS. LEVERAGING THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION FUND OR EXAM ONLY.
PROBABLY TO THE USER I LOOK
FORWARD HAVING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR AND APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THIS GOVERNOR. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT GOVERNOR
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION. CERTAINLY
THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO HELP RESOLVE-
BUT THIS IS NOT A NARAL BILLS
SUGGESTED BY THE SENATOR. OUR
PARTICULAR CONCERN RELATES TO
PERSONAL PROPERTY THAT IS CARS
MOTORCYCLES THOSE. VEHICLES
GENERALLY- AS THIS BILL IS
DRAFTED UP PEOPLE WOULD BE ABLE
TO KEEP THOSE VEHICLES- BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WAY TO RECOVER THEM.
THE AUTHOR ADDED PROVISION WHICH
SAID YOU CAN FORCE A LEAD. IS
NOT A TERM REFERENCING THE
REPOSSESSION ACTIONS AT ALL.
WHAT IT ALSO MEANS IS THAT AS
THE QUARTER. AFTER A WHILE THE
NOTICE OF INTENT WITH THE DMV GO
THROUGH THE ENTIRE REPOSSESSION
. IT TO RECOVER SOME THAT IS
YOURS WHAT THE BORROWER IS DOING
UNDER THE SITUATION IS
RESCINDING THE AGREEMENT UNDER
RECISION EVERYTHING GOES BACK TO
SQUARE ONE. YOU HAVE THE
CONTRACT CANCELLED THE VEHICLE
THE PROPERTY GOES BACK TO THE
LEGAL OWNER BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT
HAPPENS HERE HERE THE LEGAL
OWNER IS STUCK WITH THE BILL.
WITH VERY LITTLE RECOURSE TO GET
IT BACK BECAUSE AS MR WILSON
MENTIONED THERE ARE NO PENALTIES
ON THE PERPETRATOR HERE. THEY
COULD COLLUDE TERRIBLE THING
WITH THE VICTIM ALLEGED VICTIM
AND JUST KEEP PLAYING HIDE AND
SEEK WITH THAT VEHICLE AND WE
CAN'T GET IT BACK. IT'S ALSO
WORTH NOTING THAT BY ENFORCING
THE LIEN CARE ACTUALLY LEAVING
OUT OTHER FORMS OF PERSONAL
PROPERTY THAT IS. APPLIANCES
FURNITURE THOSE ITEMS WE HAVE A
SECURITY INTO. IN THOSE YES THIS
. SO YOU CANCEL THE CONTRACT AND
YOU KEEP EVERYTHING THAT IS NOT
A RECIPE FOR SUCCESS AGAIN WE GO
BACK TO THE NOTION THAT THE
EXAMPLES ARE REFER TO CREDIT
CARD DEBT OR KIND OF THEFT OF
FUNDS WITH A PERSONAL PROPERTY
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THIS BILL
ENTIRELY AND THAT WAS REALLY GO
A LONG WAY. OUR BURNS SO. THEY
YOU MISTER. ALL RIGHT OTHERS THE
ROOM OTHERS IN THE HEARING ROOM%
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVENTY
FIVE. PLEASE ENTER MEMBERS JAMIE
HAVE WITH THE JACK AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN THE ROOM
SEE NO ONE ELSE APPROACH MIKE
FROM THOSE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE SEVENTY FIVE
. MITCHELL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THERE AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO. YOU CAN GO TO LINE FOR
ALL FIVE. BURKE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSITION ASKING OVER THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE THREE SIXTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THEIR NUMBER IT
WILL BE ALL OVER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY BANKING
NETWORK AND A LOT OF THIS IS A
GIFT. THANK YOU. LINE FOR
THIRTEEN. THE FOURTEENTH I WOULD
BE ABLE TO SPEAK DURING THE
COURSE OF TIME I AM BUT I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE COURT I
AM KIND ENOUGH CONSIDERING IF
YOU I'M HALF OF THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS THANK
YOU BAY AREA LUMINA. OKAY. IF
YOU WERE LINE FOR ALL FOUR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS PUT
COSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREDITORS ARE
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND LAST THREE NINETY SIX. ALL
RIGHT AFTERNOON MISTER BURKE.
NOW YOU CRAVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
INTERGRAPH OPPOSITION FOR THE
RECORD PREVIOUSLY STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING
BACK TO COMMITTEE. SENATE WHITE
HOUSE KEEP. I'M SURE THE
CREDITORS- BAR IN FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS WILL FALL OFF THEIR
SEATS WHEN I'M SYMPATHETIC TO
THE CAUGHT THEIR OBJECTIONS THAT
THEY ARE RAISED- N. AND ALSO
JUST NOTING THAT I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU. PROVE IT WASN'T TO REST
IF. THAT THAT'S THEIR WORK
THAT'S NOT ARCHITECT OUR WORK
BUT THE QUESTION I HAVE IS HOW
DO YOU MARRY. TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN WITH WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE AND IN NINE SEVEN FIVE AND
I GUESS IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A
JOINDER OF PARTIES RIGHT BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE THE CREDITORS
INDEED TV ACTION AT THAT THAT
THAT THAT. AT THE- UNDER
GLORIOUS BILL BUT THEN YOU DON'T
HAVE THE ABUSER IN THIS ACTION
AGAINST THE CREDITORS AND IN THE
DC PARTICIPANTS JOINT LIABILITY
THEN YES YOU CAN GO AFTER CREDIT
BUT IF IT'S JUST I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING AT IS JUST. IT'S
JUST IT'S THE WIFE'S WERE THEY
ABUSED UP CREDIT IT'S NOT THE-
NOT THE ABUSERS HOW DO YOU JOIN
THOSE OTHER THAN. ALLOWING IF
YOU CREATING CAUSE OF ACTION
ALLOWING FOR THE JOINING OF THAT
THIRD. PARTY THAT'S- AGAIN I'M
I'M I'M THINKING AS I'M ASKING
THE QUESTION. IS I JUST AND I'LL
LET MY- MY FITNESS SPEAK AS WELL
BUT- I THINK AS I UNDERSTAND AB. TWO FIVE. THE IT. LEVERAGING
TO STAY THAT SOMEBODY WAS OR FOR
CERTAIN DEBTS THESE WERE THE
RESULT OF ECONOMIC VIEW ABUSE-
THIS IS A SEPARATE PROCESS FROM-
CANCELING THAT DEBT OR REMOVING
ANY KIND OF FINANCIAL LIABILITY-
AND SO THERE IS NO PROCESS IN
PLACE FOR DOING THAT THIS GOES A
STEP BEYOND THAT AND CREATES
THAT PROCESS SO SURVIVORS
ACTUALLY CAN ELIMINATE THAT DATA
AND- THAT FINANCIAL OBLIGATION
BUT I WILL ALLOW- LEE IF YOU
WOULD WILL NOT NECESSARILY BE
LIKE TO TAKE THAT. AS WELL. SURE
I DON'T HAVE A LOT TO ADD GAS
AND THAT ONE IS THAT IT IS A
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN IT WOULD
BE- ADEQUATE DOCUMENTATION THAT
COULD BE USED IN AN ACTION UNDER
AT THE NINE SEVENTY FIVE SO.
THEY WORK TOGETHER AND IN THAT
FAMILY COURT COULD IDENTIFY A
GUY AS BEING THE WORST WHICH
COULD THEN BE USED AS A PIECE OF
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT A CLAIM
UNDER AT THE PROPERTY IDENTIFIED
IN IT YOU NINE SEVENTY FIVE.
OKAY I WE CAN STATE AGAIN I'M
NOT GONNA SPEAK FOR THE
CREDITORS PART BUT I THINK WHAT
THEY WOULD LIKE IT IS YES THE
SURVIVOR HAS PROVEN TO REST BUT
WE HAVE NOW HAVE A JUDGMENT
AGAINST. SOME OTHER PERSON WHO
IS THE REAL. PARTY IN INTEREST
I'M ON THE ISSUE OF RESCISSION
OF THE CONTRACT AND THE
SECURITY- AUTOMOBILES- THE ONLY
THING I.KNOW IS THAT THEY
CAN'T. THEY CAN'T SELL THAT CAR
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T BIG THEY THEY
GOT THE TIGHTLY GOT A BAD TITLE
BUT THEY CAN STILL DRIVE IT
AROUND. AND REGISTER IF THEY
CAN'T SELL TO SOMEBODY ELSE BUT
THEY JUST HAVE INDEFINITELY-
HAVE YOU GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO.
THAT BECAUSE THAT SEEMS LIKE A
YEAH ADJUSTED. NO I AND I
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THAT AND SO
I I'M SYMPATHETIC THE POINTS
RAISED BY MISTER GOVERNOR. I
THINK WITH THESE WERE LAID
AMENDMENTS AND THE GOAL WAS
ESSENTIALLY TO ADOPT A
RECESSIONARY APPROACH TO. THE
CONTRACT FOR THE LOAN OR THE
CREDIT EXTENDED- AND CERTAINLY
YOU KNOW IF YOU. YOU YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE WHETHER IT'S A SECURED
LOAN OR LOAN USED BY PARTICULAR
IDENTIFIABLE OBJECT. I DON'T
JUST GET THE PROPER CREDITS
BASIC CONTRACTS LAW. AND SO THE
GOAL HERE IS TO HAVE A DECISION
B. THE MEASURE AND WE CLEARLY
CAN CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
BANKS THIS IS NOT A PERFECT
BILL. IT IS GETTING CLOSER TO
THAT THOUGH AND I CAN APPRECIATE
ACTUALLY THAT. PERSONALLY WAS.
IN WRESTLING. ACTIONS TO TRY TO
THIS BILL ON THE OTHER THE RIGHT
PLACE. AND WHY DIDN'T THIS
QUESTION REYES ONE OTHER CONCERN
BROUGHT UP BY MR WILSON. WHICH
IS THE IDENTIFICATION OF THE
CREDITOR I MEAN IT DID THE OF
THE USER WE HAVE PUT IN PLACE-
REQUIREMENT THAT- IT IS CERTAIN-
CERTAIN FORMS WERE HAPPY
ATTENDED THE PLEADINGS- BY THE
PERSON. THAT BE SURVIVORS
SEEKING TO HAVE THAT. THAT
CANCELED. ARE THE REASON WE
DON'T ALLOW HAPPENED
SPECIFICALLY CALL FOR IDENTITY
IS BECAUSE THAT. AS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ADVOCATES WILL TELL
YOU. I HE IS A RECIPE FOR
DISASTER THAT POTENTIALLY IT CAN
CAUSE ALL SORTS OF VIOLENT
SCENARIOS- SO WE'RE BEING
MINDFUL OF THE BALANCE HERE
BETWEEN THE SAFETY OF THE
SURVIVOR. AS WELL AS THAT TEN
AND WILL BE. AND FIT OF THIS
PROCESS. ALL RIGHT. COME CERN'S
OF CIRCLE HERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR RIGHT- CAN YOU
CAN YOU ARTICULATE A SITUATION
OTHER THAN A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SITUATION WHERE YOU WOULD YOU
WOULD- YOU COULD SAY THAT- AND
I'M I'M LOOKING AT THAT IT WAS A
COERCED DEBT I. REAL TIME WITH
WITH THAT THAT THE CONCEPT IN IF%
IN ANY OTHER SITUATION OTHER
THAN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND- AND
IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT
THIS IS MORE APPROPRIATELY-
SHOULD APPROPRIATELY BELOCATED
IN A IN A FAMILY LARA TO A
DOMESTIC- IN THE IN THE IN THE
RULES AROUND RELATIONSHIPS AS
OPPOSED TO- BEING APPLIED
BROADLY AND I AM STRUGGLING WITH
THAT AND I BELIEVE. THE FOR
FIVE. TWO IS. LIMITED TO- THREE
SITUATIONS- DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT ABUSE I
GUESS FOR FOSTER YOUTH- THOSE
ARE THE SITUATIONS WE TO SPACE
SO- IN EACH OF THOSE SINNERS
OBVIOUSLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS
THE ONE THAT IS THE PRIMARY
FOCUS OF THIS BUT A SIMILAR SET
OF ABUSIVE OR COERCIVE
CIRCUMSTANCES COULD ARISE IN-
WHO. WHO IN A SUBJECT TO THE
CARE OF AN INDIVIDUAL OR FOSTER
YOUTH- AND JUST AT THAT BAD ON
THIS IS ROOTED IN A DURESS
THEORY OF- CONTRACTS LAW THAT
THAT IS NOT NOVEL. IT'S WELL
ESTABLISHED IN COMMON LAW GOING
BACK TO ENGLAND SO- YOU KNOW WE
THINK THIS IS A NATURAL
EXTENSION THIS WORK WE'RE JUST
CLARIFYING THAT ECONOMIC
COERCION IS A FORM OF DIRECT
ESSENTIALLY. I AM THE IT IN ARE
ALREADY THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT CENTER BOARD JUST. KIND OF
IN LINE WITH CENTER COPY COVER
HEROES QUESTION IS. YOU HAVE
THREE DIFFERENT CATEGORIES HERE-
AND I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS
THERE. IS THERE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE OPTIONS THAT IS
BEING OVERLOOKED IN FAVOR OF THE
COURT A LEGAL CAUSE OF ACTION.
WHAT I MEAN. IS THAT. MIGHT
THERE BE A SITUATION WHERE A CO
WORST DEPENDENT OR SPOUSE-
SUBMIT SOMETHING TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AS A AS A
PRECONDITION FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THIS THE EVIDENCE IS IN EARLY
STAGE. THAT THEY ARE ACTING
UNDER DURESS WITHOUT DISCLOSING
NECESSARILY IN ANOTHER
INFORMATION- THAT COULD PUT THEM
IN HARM'S WAY BECAUSE WHAT WE
HAVE HERE IS WE HAVE LENDERS
THAT THROUGH NO FAULT ON
MODERATOR I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO. CLOSE OUT THE QUEUE-
LET ME SEE IF I CAN FIND LINE
THAT IS YOUR APOLOGIES FOR THAT. IF YOUR LINES ARE OPEN PREVIEW. I THINK WE'RE AND WHERE I'M
GOING IS THAT HAVE WE'VE
EXHAUSTED THE IDEA THAT THERE BE
OTHER REMEDIES AVAILABLE BECAUSE
WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
LENDERS IN GOOD FAITH LAND TO A
PARTY THEY HAVE NO REASON TO
OBTAIN INSIGHT INTO THE DOMESTIC
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THAT HOUSEHOLD
OR WHETHER A HUSBAND OR A WIFE
OR SOME OTHER PARTNERSHIP. IS
TROUBLED THAT WOULD- THAT WOULD
PROHIBIT- THE CONTRACT FROM
BEING FILLED SO HOW DO YOU
BALANCE OUT THE INTERESTS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL WITHOUT HARMING THE-
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE. PLACE
BECAUSE OUR BANKING AND LENDING
SYSTEM. IS ONE OF THE BEDROCK OF
HOW WE FUNCTION IF YOU TAKE IF
YOU INJECT A HIGH DEGREE OF
UNCERTAINTY WHICH A BILL LIKE
THIS COULD DO. AS A MEANS OF
FOLKS BEING ABLE TO GET OUT
SHOULD THEY REPRESENT THAT THEY
WERE UNHAPPY IN THEIR MARRIAGE
OR WERE UNDER YOU KNOW OR OR
WERE UNDER- SOME FORM OF
INTIMIDATION- I'M JUST. MORE OF
A DISCUSSION POINT LIKE HAVE WE
EXHAUSTED ALL IDEAS BEFORE
MOVING IN THIS COURSE OF ACTION-
WE'VE NOT EXHAUSTED ALL IDEAS OR
INPUT I WOULD SAY THAT. THE TO.
CHARACTERIZE THE PROCESS OF THIS
BILL IS MERELY SAYING I'M
UNHAPPY IN MY MARRIAGE OR I WAS
THREATENED IS NOT ACTUALLY AT
THIS BILL DOES YOU NEED SOME
KIND OF DOCUMENTATION WHETHER
POLICE REPORT. REPORT FROM A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSE
COUNSELOR- OR A JUDGE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT YOU HAVE TO
ESTABLISH THAT YOU'RE IN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP OR SOME
MEASURE APPROVED. AND THAT DEBT
INCURRED WAS INCURRED DURING THE
PERIOD THAT ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP
AS A RESULT OF THE ABUSE. SO
THAT IS WHAT CREATES IN ORDER
MEANS THE IN BUT A MEANS- AND
APPROPRIATE TIME. BECAUSE IF MY
WIFE AND I- PURCHASED A CAR IN
WE WERE IN THIS. PARTICULAR CALL
STE. ALL BUT TEN YEARS OR YOU
KNOW FIVE YEARS INTO INTO THE
REPAYMENT. YOU KNOW- IT'S
DISCLOSED THE HARM COULD BE
BORNE BY THE LENDER THROUGH THIS
BILL SO THE IDEA IS AT IN
APPROPRIATE PERIOD OF TIME. IS
THERE IN ADMINISTRATIVE. ACTION
THAT COULD BE TAKEN THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE- I ALSO NOT UNCLEAR
INTERRUPT- CENTER- WHAT DO YOU
MEAN BY THE MINISTRY OF ACTION
IF YOU COULD GIVE ME SOME SENSE
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING OR- SOME OF
SOME OF MORE REALIZATION WHETHER
IT BE. WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT- OR
SOME OTHER ENTITY THAT
IDENTIFIES THAT I'M IN AN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP. AND THIS
INDIVIDUALS CAPITALIZING ON MY
CREDIT AVAILABILITY IS PER
THING. THINGS I DON'T HAVE A
MEANS I DON'T HAVE THE MEANS OF
GETTING OUT OF IT. BUT I HAVE TO
DO NOT TO S. VOTED. OTHER CAR-
WHAT WHAT SO RESEARCH JOHNSON NO
I MEAN A- IT'S MORE OF A IT'S
NOT A ERROR IT'S KIND OF WHAT
WE'RE- PAID. FOR TRYING TO GET
AT IT AGAIN.
ADEQUATE DOCUMENTATION WE'RE
TALKING THE POLICE REPORT
INDICATING THAT DEBT WAS
INCURRED AS A RESULT OF THAT
ARREST OR THREAT AND FTC
IDENTITY THEFT REPORT PLANS
AFTER WORK ORDER ISSUED SO THESE
ARE THE TYPES OF DOCUMENTATION
ON TALKING ABOUT. I SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
DISRUPT THE FINANCIAL SYSTEM-
YOU KNOW LIKE I CUT MY TEETH IN
AN EARLIER LIFE- WORKING ON SOME
OF THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
MORTGAGE MARKETS. AND LANDING
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF SIMILAR
CONCERNS RAISED AROUND ONE OFFS-
YOU KNOW MORTGAGE RELIEF- LOAN
FORGIVENESS. BECAUSE THEY THEY
ALL DISRUPTING OF THE POTENTIAL
SECURITY PARTICULAR SECURITIZED
MARKETS. THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT I DECIDED TO TAKE
OUT REAL PROPERTY- IS CONCERNED-
AND NOT JUST BY SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY. BUT ALSO
ABOUT THE MBS MARKET GLOBALLY
AND I DID HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT- SO WE MOVED AND THAT
REMOVED A LOT OPPOSITION TO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING OUR BEST TO TRY TO
NARROW THIS IN THE WAYS YOU
SUGGEST- AND I THINK THAT
ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE IS BALANCE THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE ACTUALLY LIKE A LOT OF
PEOPLE. WHO WE THINK WILL EITHER
LIVE MUCH BETTER LIVES OR LIVE
AS OPPOSED TO BEING IN ABUSIVE
RELATIONSHIPS OR DYING AS A
RESULT OF THAT THAT THIS BILL
CAN HELP AND WE'RE TRYING IT AND
BALANCE THAT AGAINST THE
CONCERNS RAISED WE DON'T WANT TO
GIVE A FREE PASS WE DON'T CREATE
A HUGE LOOPHOLE I THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE- THIS PROVISION THAT. SAYS
AN ALLEGED DEBTOR WHO FALLS ON
MERITORIOUS MOTIONS PLEADINGS IT
CETERA SHALL BE LIABLE FOR THE
ALLEGED PREDATORS IT TOURNEY'S
FEES AND COSTS NOTHING LAWSUIT
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO OPEN UP
PRIVILEGE LITIGATION WE DON'T
WANT TO CREATE A MASSIVE
LOOPHOLE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOK A CERTAIN SUGGESTIONS AND
FEEDBACK FROM OPPOSITION AND
OTHERS TO HELP US MAKE THIS BILL
BETTER THIS IS NOT A COMPLETED
PRODUCT I AM GOING TO CONTINUE
TO TRY AGAIN I. RECALL THAT I
DID THE BILL HERE WE MADE THE
VOTES BUT WE DIDN'T WANT TO PUSH
THIS BILL THROUGH IN ITS FORM
THEN BECAUSE IF WE FOR LIKE BILL
NOT POINT YOU WANT TO DO. I COME
HERE. I IT'S IN YOUR MEN AND OF
COURSE IS WHAT'S WHAT'S TO
PREVENT FRAUD- I JUST DON'T WANT
TO PAY THIS AND NOW I START
MAKING ALLEGATIONS AND- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR LAST
COMMENT THAT EXPLAINS IT TO ME-
I- EXPECT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING AND ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT- THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND NOT SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY BUT I WILL I WANT TO.
SEE IT- GET BETTER BECAUSE I DO
THINK THAT THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING
AND THIS IS THIS IS IMPORTANT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
NOT A TOOL TO BE ABLE TO AVOID
ON PAYING DEBTS THAT YOU
LEGITIMATELY. THAT YOU. NEED TO
RELEASED YOU DIDN'T OBJECT TO
AND THEN I GOT THIS- THIS BURDEN
ON ON THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY AT
THAT IN IN GOOD FAITH MADE THE
VIDEO. I THINK IT THOSE COMMENTS
AND I AGREE WITH THEM COMPLETELY
CENTER. ALL RIGHT- BILL'S BEEN
MOVED ON IN CENTER MAN I
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS OVER THE LAST. EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF IN A AND I KNOW YOU
ARE IN GOOD FAITH HERE AND
TRYING TO BALANCE THE INTERESTS
OF GOOD FAITH NON CULPABLE
LENDERS. WHO NEITHER KNOW NOR
SHOULD KNOW THAT THERE'S A
COURSE OF RELATIONSHIP AND OF
COURSE THE WORST CASE SCENARIO
IS ILLUSTRATED BY SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS. IS WHERE A ABUSIVE
SPOUSE COURSES THIS MOUSE FOR
EXAMPLE INTO BUYING A
LAMBORGHINI UNDER THEIR NAME
EXCLUSIVELY UNDER THE- ABUSE
SPOUSE'S NAME AND NOT BEING ABLE
TO REPOSSESS IT. I AM CONFIDENT
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO. DO THIS.
LAMBERT IN B. REPROCESSED.
NUMBER ONE. AND NUMBER TWO THIS
MISTER WILSON INDICATE. I UNDER
THE SCENARIO. FORTY THE
PERPETRATOR IS NOT NAMED IF FOR
EXAMPLE THE DEBT IS SOLELY
ANCHORED BY THE VIEWS SPOUSE. I
ALSO UNDERSTAND CENTER MINUTE
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PERPETRATOR IS NOT
SOMEHOW. AVOIDING INSTABILITY OR
LIABILITY. OF COURSE IF IT'S A
JOINT DEBT THE CREDITOR KANAME
BOTH BUT IF IT'S AN EXCLUSIVE
THAT. WE'LL WE'LL FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO MAKE SURE WE DO THAT AND
THEN THIRDLY JUST AS A MATTER OF
DISCLOSURE- ONE OF THE SPOT CO
SPONSORS THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER
WAS FORMALLY A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER IN MY- LAW
PARTNERS HAVE BEEN LONG TIME.
FOR MEMBERS I DON'T THINK THAT
PRECLUDES ME FROM- FROM VOTING
ON THIS BILL- AND- HAVING. THAT
THERE'S A MOTION BY SAID A WHITE
CAL SKI A BY THE WAY MY
CONDOLENCES TO ALL THOSE IN THE
VIEWING AUDIENCE THAT FAINTED
WHEN SEND A WHITE CAL SKI. TOOK
THE VISION OF THE CREDITORS. SO
I HOPE YOU RECOVER ALL RIGHT.
CENTER. RIGHT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ADVICE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THAT THIS IS SB NINE
SEVENTY FIVE BY SENATOR MAN WITH
MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GIVEN MOTION IS D. PATH AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG OCT.
NUMBER I FORGET. GUERRIERO EVERY
AT ALL I THE RUSSELL. THE
RUSSELL I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
JONES JONES KNOWS LAYERED
LAYERED ICE STERN. STERN I WAKE
HOUSEKI WHY CASKEY AYE WIENER.
YOU HAVE SIX TO ONE WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALREADY CINNAMON WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL. I SEE SENATOR
NEWMAN WHO'S HERE BEEN PATIENTLY
WAITING. SENATOR NEWMAN IS
HOBBLING TO THE PODIUM THANK YOU
SIR NEWMAN FOR YOUR PRESENCE
THANK YOU AT THE WESTCHESTER
EVERY MY WANT TO TILT A LITTLE
BIT SO YOUR PARALLEL WITH MY
CRICKET BACK. IF WE COULD MISS
RICHARD I I'D LIKE TO SWITCH THE
ORDER OF TWO BILLS WHEN MY
WITNESSES HAS TO GO SOMEWHERE
FRAZIER. WE DO SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE FIRST SURE SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE WHICH- OF FOR THOSE OF YOU
WATCHING IS FILING NUMBER TWENTY
THREE. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
AFTERNOON YOUR MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE- BEFORE I
BEGIN MY COMMENTS I WANT TO
THANK YOU MISTER. SO HAS WITH
THE MOST READ. BENEFITS ON A
EIGHTEENTH. RIGHT NOW TO THE
BILL AS ENSURE YOU'LL ALL AGREE
FREE AND FAIR ELECTIONS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL CORNERSTONE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY IN RECENT
YEARS HOWEVER. AN INCREASING
NUMBER OF THE DILIGENT AND
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANTS
CHARGED WITH ADMINISTERING
CALIFORNIA SELECTIONS. HAVE BEEN
SUBJECTED TO THREATS
INTIMIDATION AND SOMETIMES
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE AT POLLING
PLACES IN THEIR OFFICES. AND
EVEN AT THEIR HOMES IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTIONS UP TO THE
PRESENT. THE PHENOMENA VIOLENT
THREATS AND HARASSMENT LEFT
WORKERS CONTINUES TO CLIMB TO
ALARMING LEVELS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY A NATIONWIDE SURVEY AS
MANY AS ONE IN THREE. ELECTION
WORKERS SAID THEY FELT UNSAFE IN
THE CONDUCT OF THEIR JOBS. WITH
A STUNNING WANTED SIX LISTING
THREATS TO THEIR LIVES AS A JOB
RELATED CONCERNS. EXCUSE ME.
SADLY THESE CONCERNS TO BEGIN
AFFECT THE ABILITY TO
EFFECTIVELY ADMINISTER ELECTIONS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA SINCE NOT
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY. MORE
THAN 15% OF CALIFORNIA ELECTION
OFFICIALS HAVE LEFT THEIR JOBS.
DUE IN NO SMALL PART TO THE
MARKED INCREASE IN AGGRESSIVE
AND ABUSIVE. STATE BACK TO
MEASURES TO- TO ACCOUNT THOSE
WHO WOULD SEEK TO INTIMIDATE
ELECTION WORKERS THROUGH THREATS
OR ACTUAL VIOLENCE IT IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
SIMILAR PROACTIVE STEPS IN ORDER
TO HELP ELECTION WORKERS FEEL
SAFE AND SECURE SB ELEVEN THIRTY
ONE WILL PROVIDE PROTECTION AND
PEACE OF MIND TO OUR ELECTION
WORKERS BY EXTENDING THE OPTION
OF THEIR ENROLLMENT IN ONE OR
THE OTHER OF THE STATE'S TO
EXISTING ADDRESS PROTECTION
PROGRAMS CALIFORNIA HAS A
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
OFFICE OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE
CALLED SAFE AT HOME. TO FORCE
PROTECTIONS TO SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VILENCE AND THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK AT REPRODUCTIVE CARE
FACILITIES SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
WOULD EXTEND ELIGIBILITY TO
ENROLL AND SAFE AT HOME TO
INDIVIDUALS RACK WITH THE PUBLIC
IN THE COURSE OF THEIR
PERFORMANCE OF ELECTION RELATED
WORK UNDER THE TERMS OF SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE THE ME DRESSES
PEOPLE IN THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
SUBSTITUTED WITH A MAILING
ADDRESS PROVIDED BY THE SIX
STATE OR A LOCAL AGENCY SO THE
LECTURERS HOME ADDRESSES WILL
NOT BE INCLUDED IN PUBLIC RECORD
REQUESTS AND POSSIBLY PUBLICIZED
RESULTS. SB ELEVEN TO ONE ALL TO
EXTEND TO ALL DAVID PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS BY APPLYING THE
SAME HARASSMENT PROTECTION ORDER
TO ELECTION WORKERS REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS AS WELL ALSO
ON PROVISIONS INCLUDE IN SB
ELEVEN ELECTION WORKERS WHO FEEL
THAT THE MECHANICS OF SAVE AT
HOME MAYBE TO. STATE USED TO BE
. I SHOULD PROGRAM THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO PEACE OFFICERS AT
THE COUNTY LEVEL THE INCLUSION
ELECTION WORKERS IN THIS PROGRAM
WILL ALLOW THESE WORKERS TO
OBTAIN A SIMILAR LEVEL OF
CONFIDENTIALITY THEREBY ENABLING
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO
RESPOND TO REQUESTS FOR PUBLIC
RECORDS WITHOUT HAVING TO
DISCLOSE THE PRIVATE ADDRESSES
OF COVERED ELECTION WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS. THIS
LEGISLATION IS SADLYVERY MUCH
NEEDED IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA TO DO THE LARGELY
THANKLESS. BUT ESSENTIALLY
MATURING THEIR LECTURES ARE FREE
FAIR AND EFFECTIVELY
ADMINISTERED. HERE WITH ME TODAY
ARE TO TODAY TO TEST FOR KIM
ALEXANDER FROM CALIFORNIA VOTER
FOUNDATION. AND GALLUP GALLERY
RAMACHANDRAN FROM THE BRENNAN
CENTER FOR JUSTICE IT'S GARY
THAT HAS TO GO SOON I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ALREADY- MISS RAMACHANDRAN
ARE YOU AVAILABLE. YES RIGHT NOW
MY- FIRST ACCOMMODATING ME I
CAN'T REMEMBER THANK YOU FOR
JUST THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS GUY ROBIN
CHANDRAN I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE BRENNAN CENTER FOR
JUSTICE. WERE EMPTYING YOUR
COUNSEL IN THE ELECTIONS AND
GOVERNMENT PROGRAM. IN THE
SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
COMMISSIONED THE SURVEY AND HELD
INTERVIEWS WITH NEARLY THREE
DOZEN ELECTION OFFICIALS AND
OVER THIRTY EXPERTS. IN FEBRUARY
THIS YEAR WE COMMISSIONED AN
ADDITIONAL NATIONAL. SURVEY OF
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS. OUR
RESEARCH THE OFFICIALS WERE
AFFORDED ANONYMITY IF THEY WISH
. FREEING THEM TO SPEAK UP
OPENLY. WHAT THEY TOLD US THAT
HEARTBREAKING. LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS FEEL UNSAFE DUE TO
HARASSMENT AND THREATS IN THE
WAKE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. DOUBLE REPORTED THAT
THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS INCLUDING
ELDERLY PARENTS AND CHILDREN
WERE. THREATENED AND MULTIPLE
OFFICIAL TOLD US THAT THEY WERE
FORCED TO FLEE THEIR HOMES. A
RECENT SURVEY IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FOUND THAT ONE IN FOR LOCAL
AFFECT ALEXION OFFICIALS STILL
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT BEING
ASSAULTED ON THE JOB. WHEN THEY
HAVE BEEN THREATENED AND THREE
AND FIVE WORRIED THAT THE DRAFT
WILL MAKE RECRUITMENT DIFFICULT.
MANY ELECTION OFFICIALS YOUR
EXPRESSED THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
THE TIME OR RESOURCES TO
DETERMINE IF THEY'RE ENTITLED TO
ADDRESS CONFIDENTIALITY PROGRAMS
IN THEIR STATE. ENSURING THAT
ALEXION WORKERS FEEL CONFIDENT
APPLYING FOR THE PROTECTION IT'S
THE KIND OF MEASURE THAT PEOPLE
OF ALL PUBLIC IF YOU CAN GET
BEHIND FOR INSTANCE THE ORGAN IN
COLORADO BOTH RECENTLY PASSED
BILL BROAD BI PARTISAN SUPPORT.
ALLOWING THEM TO HAVE THEIR
PRIVATE INFORMATION MATH IN
GOVERNMENT FILES. HOW CAN BE A
LEADER ON THE FAST AN ATHLETE.
ONE ONE THREE ONE BUT IN SHORT
THE ELECTION WORKERS AND TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE FOURTH THE
FIFTH HOME PROGRAM. OR FIVE WITH
THEIR LOCAL ELECTION NOT FOR AND
GEOLOGY AFTER INFORMATION ON THE
BORDER FILE. THE GENTLEMAN. FOR
DOING THEIR JOB ARE NOT AND MY
FIFTY ITSELF AND THIS BILL AND
THEN. STEP FOR IN PROTECTING THE
WORKERS AND DEMOCRACY THANK YOU
. THEY YOU. ALL RIGHT- MISS- L.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS IS KIM ALEXANDER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA VOTER FOUNDATION
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED WITH THIS
ISSUE OF HARASSMENT AND THREATS
AGAINST ELECTION OFFICIALS SINCE
THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION
UNLESS YOU CAN BE RELEASED A
REPORT CALLED DOCUMENTING AND
ADDRESSING HARASSMENT OF
ELECTION OFFICIALS. IN A LIGHT
ON THIS CRISIS. ONE THING WE CAN
DO TO ADDRESS THESE RISING TAXES
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO ADDRESS
CONFIDENTIALITY PROGRAM
SELECTION MARKERS TO PROTECT
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION STOP
INTERVIEWING TO WORK IN PUBLIC.
ELECTION ADMINISTRATION LOCAL
ELECTION OFFICIALS IN THE US ARE
80% FEMALE AND MANY OF THESE
ATTACKS ARE GENDERED
MISOGYNISTIC ATTACKS. THOSE ARE
ON THE RECEIVING END OF STRIDES
ARE UNDERSTANDABLY RELUCTANT.
CAL PUBLICLY. BECAUSE DOING SO
TRIGGER YOU KNOW MORE TRUST IN
THE TOP AND THEY ALSO DO NOT
WANT TO GIVE THEIR ATTACKERS THE
SATISFACTION OF HAVING AN IMPACT
. THERE IS GROWING CONCERN THAT
IN THIS HOSTILE CLIMATE PEOPLE
WILL NOT WANT TO REMAIN INTHESE
POSITIONS AND ALREADY 17% OF
CALIFORNIA'S. FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
REGISTRARS HAVE LEFT THEIR JOBS
SINCE. TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN THE
INCREASE INCREASE I AGGRESSIVE
AND ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR TARGETED
AT- WHEN PEOPLE HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT WALKING TO THEIR CARS FROM
THEIR OFFICES AT NIGHT FOR OUR
RIGHT. TO WEAR ANY ARMOR. IN POP
. THAT HI. MUCH WORKER. LEADING
JOBS TOGETHER WHEN THEY'RE THREE
WITH DEATH OR THEIR FAMILY ARE
NAMED. TO KEEP IT OUT BY DURING
HIS OR HER IS PICKING. WE ACT.
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION OF THE-
ADVANCED ELECTIONS FOR OVER TWO.
BUT IT WAS NOT UNTIL THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION WHEN WE REALIZED
THE PHYSICAL SAFETY OF THE
PEOPLE WHO RUN OUR ELECTIONS IS
AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT OF
ELECTION SECURITY. CALIFORNIA
VOTING PROCESSES ALREADY AMONG
THE MOST SECURE IN THE COUNTRY
SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE WILL HELP
ENSURE THE PEOPLE ENTRUSTED WITH
ADMINISTERING OUR ELECTIONS ARE
ALSO SECURE. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
QUIRK-SILVA ACTION OFFICIALS. AS
WELL. QUIRK-SILVA ASIAN AND
EARLY VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
ALSO ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. MOM ANY I'M SORRY
ANYONE ELSE HERE. IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED IN SUPPORT OF. S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE. BRENDAN
INSTITUTE- WITH SEIU CALIFORNIA
INSTRUCTS PORT THANK THANK YOU.
OTHERS HERE SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING MIKE FROM THOSE ON
THE PHONE- IN SUPPORT OF SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
TO LINE. FOR TWENTY FOUR. HI
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CAP
AGAIN OFTEN REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN CALIFORNIA IN
PART. THANK YOU. IN ORDER TWENTY
TWO US OPEN. WELL GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SHARING CONDOLENCES ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY CLERK'S
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE. FOR TWENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHE MAIRE WITH THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
REPORTER AT ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND-
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S NOT TURNED
OPPOSITION- I HAVE OF SUSAN ARE
NOW IN OPPOSITION MISS ARNELLE
IF YOU'RE HERE PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF. THE
STAR NOW. ALL RIGHT. NOT NOT
HEARING- MISTER NO IDENTIFYING
HERSELF I SEE NO ONE HERE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
OPPOSITION WISHIN TESTS WERE IN
OPPOSITION WAS TURNED THE PHONE
LINES TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE. GIVEN PRESS
ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSED. AND
CURRENTLY NINE THEN Q. ALL RIGHT
GREAT THANKS BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING NONE ALL RIGHT
SIR BY CAL SKI MOVES THE BILL
SENATE YOU NEWMAN YOU CARE TO
CLOSE. WITNESSES ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT THE BILL'S SPONSORS
AND I WERE CLOSE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION CLERK'S
ELECTION OFFICIALS- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE NEEDS OF ELECTION
WORKERS OR A GUARD BUT TENDED TO
AND I RESPECTFULLY I SHOULD I GO
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. BENSHI
COUNCIL CALL THE ROLL THIS IS SB
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR NEW
MAN WITH THE MOTION BY CENTER
RIGHT HOUSE YOU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AMBERG HI. AMBER I BOARDED.
GUERRIERO I THE RUSSELL. THE
REST SO I CAN SAY. HERTZBERG
JONES AIRED THERE'D AYE STERN
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI CASKEY I
WIENER YOU HAVE SIX ZERO WITH
SOME MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT ON CALL THANK YOU AND
MISTER I'M GONNA HAVE TO GO
DOWNSTAIRS AND SEVERE PAIN IS
GOING TO DO HIS BILL AND I'M
GOING TO COME BACK.
TRANSPORTATION ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU OKAY- NEXT WILL HAVE SENATOR
PAN. CENTER PAN IS HERE ON. S.
B. TEN EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU OF
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND-
SENATORS AND ACTUALLY IT'S QUITE
APPROPRIATE THAT I'M PRESENTING
THIS BILL TEN EIGHTEEN EMILY
AFTER THE PRESENTATION OF THE
BILL YOU JUST HEARD. IS NOTED IN
THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY- ELECTION
WORKERS HAVE BEEN UNDER PERSONAL
THREAT- I KNOW PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS HAVE BEN UNDER PERSONAL
THREATEN WE'VE TRIED TO GET IN
THE SAME PROGRAM- AND SO THE
QUESTION WHY. WHAT'S CHANGED Y.
AS IN THE PAST FEW YEARS. WE
HAVE. PEOPLE SERVING THE PUBLIC
WHETHER IT'S PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
ELECTIONS AND SO FORTH. WHO ARE
NOW SEEKING THE TYPES OF
PROTECTIONS. AND THE TYPES OF
PERSONAL TAXES THEY'RE SUFFERING
FROM AND THAT'S WHY I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT SB TEN EIGHTEEN THE
PLATFORM ACCOUNTABLY CHANCE
PARENTS THE ACT. I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
COUNCIL AND STAKEHOLDERS WORKING
SO DILIGENTLY ON THE PROPOSED
AMOUNT WHICH I AM ACCEPTING
THANK YOU. NO SOCIAL MEDIA
STREAMER WE CHANGE THE WAY WE
SHARE AND CONSUME INFORMATION
AND ACTUALLY INFLUENCES OUR
ACTIONS. AND YET WE KNOW LITTLE
ABOUT THE ALGORITHMS THAT
DETERMINE WHAT INFORMATION IS
PRESENTED. TO US. OR EVEN WHAT
IT MISINFORMATION TO PRESENTED
TO US. IN HER CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY FACEBOOK WHISTLEBLOWER
FRANCIS HOW CAN EPLAIN HOW
FACEBOOK KNOWINGLY LEVERAGE
THEIR ALGORITHMS TO PRIORITIZE
PROFITS AND ENGAGEMENT WHICH
ALSO MEANT PROMOTING
MISINFORMATION- AND ANGER. OVER
CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY IN FACT IN
THE FALL OUT OF THE JANUARY
SIXTH ATTACK ON THE NATION'S
CAPITAL. THOUSANDS OF LEAKED
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS PROVE THAT
FACEBOOK PLAYED A LARGE ROLE IN
SPREADING INFLAMMATORY
MISINFORMATION ABOUT ELECTION
FRAUD AND AIDED COMMUNICATION
EFFORTS OF EXTREMIST MILITIAS.
THE HEAD OF THE RIOTS. SOCIAL
MEDIA ALGORITHMS ARE ALSO KEY
DISTRIBUTOR OF PUBLIC HEALTH
MISINFORMATION AS ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT ONE STUDY FOUND THAT.
A MERE TWELVE PEOPLE. AND THEIR
ASSOCIATION RESPONSIBLE 465%
ALMOST TWO THIRDS OF ALL THE
VACCINE MISINFORMATION. ON
SOCIAL MEDIA TWITTER FACEBOOK
INSTAGRAM- WHICH COURT POSES AN
ENORMOUS DANGER PUBLIC HEALTH
AND IN FACT VERY RECENTLY A-
PAPER WAS PUBLISHED IN THE
SCIENTIFIC JOURNAL NATURE ONE
LEADING SCIENTIFIC JOURNALS IN
THE WORLD. SHOW THAT ONLINE
MISINFORMATION WAS DIRECTLY
LINKED TO KOBE NINETEEN VACCINE
HASN'T SEEN REFUSAL. IT'S CLEAR
THAT THESE ALGORITHMS HAVE A
PROPENSITY TO REINFORCE BIAS IN
THE QUALITY AND MISINFORMATION.
NOW TRANSPARENCY IS ESSENTIAL IN
UNDERSTANDING THE SOCIAL IMPACT
OF THESE ALGORITHMS. THIS BILL
IS ABOUT GIVIG THE PUBLIC THE
TOOLS- WE NEED TO HELP IDENTIFY
HOW THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
ARE IMPACTING OUR LIVES. SB TEN
EIGHTEEN REQUIRES ONLINE SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS TO MAKE ANNUAL
PUBLIC DISCLOSURES REGARDING
THEIR ALGORITHMS TO METRICS AS
WELL AS THE CONTENT MODERATION
EFFORTS. THESE REPORTS WILL
INCLUDE DESCRIPTION OF ALL
PRODUCT FEATURES THAT MAKE USE
OF ALGORITHMS DURING THE
REPORTING PERIOD AND THE SUMMARY
OF METRICS USED BY THE PLATFORM
TO SCORE RANK CONTENT. WITHOUT
DISSEMINATING TRADE SECRETS SO
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR DETAILS
RESTING FOR SUMMARIES. SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS AND MANY OF YOU
PERHAPS OF USE THAT TURN YOUR
FAMILY MEMBERS. HAVE ENORMOUS
POWER TO AFFECT WHAT WE SEE HOW
WE FEEL BUT WE BELIEVE. AND YET
HOW THE OPERATE REMAINS
EXTREMELY OPAQUE. I WOULD ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT ONE OF OUR
LEADING SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES
FACEBOOK IS SUCH A CONTROLLED BY
ONE PERSON. ONE MAN MARK
ZUCKERBERG AND ABOUT TO HAVE
ANOTHER MAJOR SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM TWITTER THAT'S GONNA BE
TAKEN PRIVATE BY AGAIN ANOTHER
SINGLE MAN. BILLIONAIRE SO
THEY'RE NOT EVEN ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PUBLIC THEIR NAME
ACCOUNTABLE TO SHAREHOLDERS.
DURING CONTROLLED BY A SINGLE
PERSON. SO ULTIMATELY SB TEN
EIGHTEEN IS A NECESSARY STEP TO
ENSURE TRANSPARENCY TO WORK WITH
SO MUCH I MEAN I FEEL JUST KNOW
HOW THEY OPERATE RIGHT. THERE'S
AN ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS
POWERFUL BURGEONING INDUSTRY.
AND SO- TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I
HAVE PROFESSOR NATHANIEL PERSILY
PROFESSOR OF LAW AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY AND THE AUTHOR TO
FEDERAL PLATFORM ACCOUNTABILITY
TRANSPARENCY ACT. THE DESKSIDE
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT BUT THANK YOU. ALREADY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO-
PROFESSOR. PERSILY IF YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE PLEASE IDENTIFY. YES
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES WE CAN.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU CENTER COURT
AGREED USELESS LEGISLATION I HAD
NEVER- AND THIS IS- YOU KNOW A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION AT
A CRITICAL TIME. WE CANNOT LIVE
IN A WORLD WHERE FACEBOOK AND
GOOGLE KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT US
AND WE KNOW NEXT TO NOTHING
ABOUT THAT- AS AS INDEPENDENCE
MENTIONED- WE NOW OKAY YOU KNOW
THAT HE COULD BE MORE PRESSING.
ON THE DAY AFTER IT LOOKS LIKE-
THE SINGLE PERSON IS NOW GOING
TO PURCHASE WHAT HE DESCRIBED
THAT THE PUBLIC SQUARE. AND SO
IT'S EVER MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE
GET GREATER TRANSPARENCY IN
ALGORITHMS AND THE CONTENT
MODERATION PRACTICES OF THESE
LARGE FIRMS- AND THERE'S SEVERAL
REASONS FOR THAT THE FIRST. IS
THAT I. VERY DIFFICULT FOR US
RISE AT OTHER KIND OF- PUBLIC.
THE DEAL WITH THE LARGE
PLATFORMS WHETHER IT'S REGULARLY
AND- PRIVACY AND ALLOW. IF WE
HAVE GREATER TRANSPARENCY IT
WILL LEAD TO BETTER INFORM
DECISION MAKING FOR PUBLIC
POLICY MAKERS ARE BOOKING
CALIFORNIA AND AROUND THE WORLD.
I THINK IT WILL ACTUALLY HELP
THE FIRMS THEMSELVES I THINK-
REQUIRED THEIR PRODUCT BECAUSE
THEIR BEHAVIOR WILL CHANGE. IF
THEY KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE BEING
WATCHED. AND THE THIRD IS IT
WILL HELP ALL OF US UNDERSTAND
LIFE ONLINE BECAUSE MORE MORE OF
OUR LIFE REQUIRING ONLINE. AND
SO WHETHER IT'S THE PATHOLOGIES
OF THE ONLINE INFORMATION
ECOSYSTEM. BE A PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT SELECTION DID NOT
CONSPIRACY THEORY. ISSUES OF
CHILD THEY HAVE A LIFE OR DEATH
MORE MUNDANE TOPICS ABOUT- YOU
KNOW SORT OF HOW PEOPLE ARE
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER WE
NEED TO HAVE. BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ONLINE INFORMATION
ECOSYSTEM. THERE ARE LOTS OF
BOOKS. ABOUT THE PREVALENCE DAY
AS HATE SPEECH DISINFORMATION OR
I'LL BUY IT I'M. MORGAN COLIN.
BUT WE CAN KNOW WHETHER THOSE
FOLKS. SURE THAT WE HAVE GREATER
. PLATFORM TO JUMP. OR DISPUTE
OF LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT- ELSE WE SHOULD
IN SO OF S. B. TEN A PRESENT
HEARING SEEING ONE ON THE PHONE
A MATTER MATTER IF YOU WOULD
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TEN EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU TO CHECK
FOR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. CERTAINLY NINE Q. ALL
RIGHT. LET'S TURN NOW TO THE
OPPOSITION- I HAVE TWO WITNESSES
LIST IN OPPOSITION I SEE MISTER
HOFFMAN HERE MR OFTEN. THANK YOU
MR CENTER STILL HOFFMAN ON
BEHALF OF TACK MATCH-
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO THE
VERSION OF THE BILL THAT'S IN
PRINT- BUT WE'RE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS- IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR. AND THIS
COMMITTEE- THAT TO WORK TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS- AS YOU
KNOW SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT THIS COMMITTEE HAS
CONSIDERED FOR THE BETTER PART
OF A YEAR- AND WE AGREE THAT IT
IS A VALUABLE CALL TO ADD
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY- FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE IT HELPS OUR-
CONSUMERS KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
THE- RULES THAT- WE EXPECT OF
THEM AND ALSO TO. HELP THEM
BETTER UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
DOING TO PROTECT THEM FROM
HARMFUL CONTENT- AND WHERE THIS
BILL AND I THINK THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE- THAT IS ACTUALLY AN
IMPROVEMENT UPON OTHER- TRANSFER
TO MEASURE. IS THAT I THINK IT
STRIKES A BETTER BALANCE- IN
WAYNE TRANSPARENCY SIX THREE-
BEFORE. THAT YOU OUR OUR- AND
AUTOMATED SYSTEMS- IDENTIFY
HARMFUL CONTENT AND REMOVE IT-
AND- YOU KNOW BY REQUIRING
SPECIFICS ABOUT HOW THOSE
SYSTEMS WORK- NOT ONLY
JEOPARDIZES PROPRIETY.
INFORMATION BUT CAN ACTUALLY
LEAD TO DECREASED SECURITY AND
MORE HARMFUL CONTENT SO WE THINK
THIS BILL- AS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED- STRIKES A BETTER
BALANCE IN THAT REGARD- AND SO
AS WE CONTINUE TO REVIEW THE
LANGUAGE WE MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUGGESTIONS AND COMMENTS BUT-
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR- AND- COMMITTEE AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU MR
OFTEN- MISS AMY BOSS YOUR
AVAILABLE IN THE FALL. YES YES
THANK GOODNESS YOU MUST REMEMBER
READY. MY NAME IS AMY FIVE FROM
THE TRUCK FOR A STATE AND
FEDERAL AFFAIRS CHOI A TRIP TO
THE TRADE ASSOCIATION DEDICATED
TO FREE ENTERPRISE DISTRICT
ACTION ONLINE. I WANT TO START
OFF BY SAYING WE UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT BEHIND THE LEGISLATION
AND THEY NEED TO BRING ABOUT
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND CONTENT
MODERATION DECISION HOWEVER WE
ARE NOT IN. THE RIGHT PLACE AND
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT THE
FUNDS. ADDRESS WE HAVE. THAT THE
JUST. A PART. IN ASKING TEN
EIGHTEEN OF WOULDN'T AT ACTORS I
THEM DETAILED ESTIMATE. ABOUT
HOW. JUST SCREENING AND HELP
AUTOMATE THIS. IDENTIFY AND
REMOVE HARM CONTENT. DOING SO
WHAT IT SOUNDS GET CHILD. OR
SCAMMER. ROADMAP TO GET AROUND
WITH THE EFFORT. MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO ENSURE THEY DON'T
GET CAUGHT. WE SIMILAR
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS
PRECLUDED FLORIDA'S SOCIAL MEDIA
. AND THEN TO LOG LAST YEAR BY
GOVERNOR THIS FANTASTIC WE ARE
DIRECTLY FROM CHILD PROTECTION
GROUP. THING THAT WOULD MAKE IT
HARDER TO PROTECT CHILDREN FROM
BAD ACTORS- THERE IS A LOT TO
UNPACK IN LIMITED. TIME THANK
YOU WHAT. THAT NEXT WAIT THE
COMMISSION EKOW LAW FOR BUT AND
BRIEFS ARGUING THE BILL DOES
RIGHT SOME CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS NOT JUST THE U. S. TO
BUT THE- CONSTITUTION. THE
BRIEFCASE THAT DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS WHICH WOULD INCLUDE
SOME SENSITIVE INFORMATION AND
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY WOULD
CREATE A AN INFRINGEMENT UPON
THE PRIVACY RIGHT VIOLATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION. AND
I'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE THE BREAK
WITH MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
THAT BEING ADDED ALL RIGHT. HE
WELL. YOU'RE GOING TO PUT DOWN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY- INSTEAD I SEND A PEN USE
MEMBERS RIGHT I DID IT OUR GREAT
OKAY. LET'S NOW TURN TO. OF
THOSE WHO ARE PRESENT HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM DON'T PRESENT
HEARING ROOM THOSE OF THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. TEN
EIGHTEEN AND AGAIN FOR
HOUSEKEEPING PURPOSES AFTER THIS
BILL. WE'RE GONNA OPEN THE ROLE
AS TO ALL MEASURES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY ON CALL- SO. GO AHEAD
MODERATE IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE WHO ARE WAITING. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU AND IF SO PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE PINE. GO FIRST A
LINE OR TWENTY SECOND. I
REGIONAL WITH NICK HOW MAY I
DIRECT YOU FOR FREEDOM AND I
OPPOSE THE SPELL. THANK YOU.
NEXT. FOUR OH NINE. HI EVERYONE
YEAH COUNTY WILL BE A- ALREADY
THANK YOU. NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
HI MY NAME IS DENNIS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. IN LINE FOR TWENTY
SEVEN. YEAH MY NAME IS KAREN
RIGHT NOW THEY I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THE NEW DELHI
OFTEN CURRENTLY NUMBER THANK YOU
. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE%
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY THE
COMMITTEE. THE WHITE HOUSE HE
MOVES THE BILL I SEE NO ONE
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT
CENTER PAN. CLOSURES TO CLOSE
YET ADVERTISEMENT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND HOLDING
HEARING ON DISINFORMATION I
WOULD ALSO HELP CERTAINLY GONNA
BE WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION-
AS WELL AND AGAIN CREATE THE
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE ND THE
AMENDMENTS AND SO EXPECT THE
ASPIRIN I THOUGHT. THANK YOU-
AND SHE COUNTS OF YOU CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL TEN
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR PAN WITH THE
MOTION BY CENTER WHITE HOUSE YOU
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AMBERG AYE.
AMBERG AYE BOARD JUST. GUERRIERO
GUERRIERO I WRESTLE. THE REST SO
I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG- I JONES
JONES NO LAYERED LAYERED ICE
STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI WHAT
KASKY AYE WIENER- YOU HAS SEVEN
TWO ONE WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT PUT ON CALL ALL RIGHT
MA'AM CHIEF COUNSEL LET'S LIFT
THE CALLS ON ALL THE BILLS THAT
HAVE CURRENTLY BEEN HURT OKAY
AND I'M GONNA GO IN FIRST
CONSENT AND THEN IN. ORDER BY
THE BILL NUMBER OKAY SO CONSENT
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I GOT A YELLOW
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES JONES I
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN STERN I
WAKE HEALTHY. WEIGHT CASKEY I
WINNER- ONE MEMBER MISSING. ALL
RIGHT OF THE BILL SO BACK ON
CALL. NEXT WE HAVE A S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR CORTES
SAID. HOME BY SENATOR CORTEZ IT
. S. B. EIGHT THREE ONE I DON'T
KNOW FROM WHICH IS TO GIVE YOU
THE FILE NUMBER AFTER SHE GIVES
OF THE- FIRM NUMBER TEN. CORTEZ
A WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
PORGES MODERATOR IF YOU COULD-
SHUT DOWN THE PHONE LINES FOR
NOW. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES JONES NO
STERN AYE STERN AYE WIENER YOU
STILL HAVE TO MEMBERS MISSING RT
BACK ON CALL. NEXT IS S. B.
EIGHT FOUR SEVEN WHICH IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN. WITH THAT
CHAIR VOTING I S. B. EIGHT FOUR
SEVEN BY SENATOR FOR THE BATTLE
GARY ADULTS CARRIER. CABALLERO I
DO WRESTLE. JONES JONES I
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN STERN I
WAKE HOUSEKI WHITE HOUSE SKI NOT
VOTING WIENR. YOU STILL HAVE
MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT BACK
ON CALL NEXT ITEM IS S. B. EIGHT
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR MANDATE
THAT FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI ABIERTO
. ZERO I GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES JONES I
STERN STERN AYE WIENER. YOU HAVE
NINETIES THERE WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. BACK ON CALL NEXT WE
HAVE S. B. NINE SIX FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN SB NINE SIX FIVE
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I DO RUSSELL. DO I.
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES JONES ICE STERN. STERN
AYE WIENER. YOU HAVE NINETEEN
NINETY ZERO MEMBERS ARE MISSING
. BACK ON CALL NEXT WE HAVE S.
B. NINE SEVEN FIVE BY SENATOR
MAN SB NINE SEVENTY FIVE IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY CHAIR VOTING I
BORGIAS. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE WIENER YOU HAVE TO
MEMBERS STILL MISSING BACK ON
CALL. THE NEXT ITEM IS S. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE. CHAIR
VOTING I BOARD YES GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI JONES.
JONES NO WIENER YOU HAVE TO
MEMBERS ARE THREE MEMBERS STILL
MISSING FROM THIS ONE. ALL
RIGHTY BACK ON CALL NEXT ITEM S.
B. ELEVEN SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
LEE MOM THAT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I. STERN
STERN AYE WIENER- THAT'S- THAT
SEVENTY TWO WOULD MEMBERS
MISSING ALREADY BACK ON CALL THE
NEXT ITEM IS S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX BY SATURDAY MORNING
FILE ITEM TÍNH S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTY SIX BY SENATOR LIMON
FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. HAVE A ZERO.
VERY LITTLE HI GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI JONES.
THIS IS FILE ITEM IT'S AT
EIGHTEEN WITH SB ELEVEN SEVENTY
SIX JONES JONES NO STERN. STERN
AYE WIENER. YOU HAVE SEVEN TWO
TWO WITH MEMBERS MISSING. RIGHT
BACK ON CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS S.
B. ONE TWO TWO SEVEN BY SENATOR
EGGMAN THAT'S S. B. ONE TWO TWO
SEVEN FILE ITEM FIVE. FILE ITEM
FIVE- CHAIR WAS ABSENT DURING
THIS ONE. UMBERG HI I'M BURKE HI
THE RUSSELL. WRESTLE HI GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE LAYERED
LAYERED I WIENER- YOU HAVE NINE
TWO ZERO MEMBERS MISSING BACK ON
CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS S. B.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER. THAT IS FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN FILE ITEM FIFTEEN S. B.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
HI GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
FIVE Y. CASKEY BY CASKEY I
WIENER. GIVE TO MEMBERS MISSING
SO FAR WITH SEVENTY TWO SO FAR
BACK ON CALL THE NEXT BILL IS
SENATOR UMBERG'S BILL THE CHAIRS
BILL S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE CHAIR
VOTING I BORGIAS. IT'LL. FIVE
ZERO HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
JONES JONES I LAYERED LAYERED I
STERN STERN I WHITE HOUSE SKI MY
CASKEY I WIENER YOU HAVE NINE
BACK ON CALL NEXT ITEM BY
SENATOR BRADFORD SB FOURTEEN OH
ONE IS FILE NUMBER NINE S. B.
FOURTEEN OH ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE BY SENATOR BRADFORD CHAIR
WITH ABSENT FOR THIS VOTE AMBERG
I AM BURKE. HI BURGESS. GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JONES
JONES NO STERN. STERN AYE WIENER
. HI YOU HAVE FOR A THIRTY SEVEN
TWO ONE WITH MEMBERS MISSING.
BACK ON CALL THE NEXT FILE ITEM
IS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
BY SENATOR EGGMAN IT'S SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN SIXTEEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
S. B. FOURTEEN SIXTEEN WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI GORGEOUS. THE
RUSSELL. ONCE I LET. THE RUSSELL
. FOURTEEN SIXTEEN S. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN FILE ITEM SIX
BY SENATOR EGGMAN. THE RUSSELL
HI GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES JONES I LAYERED LAYER
I STERN STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE
AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER- HERE
EIGHT ZERO SEVEN ARE WITH
MEMBERS MISSING THANK YOU GLAZER
SENATOR GLAZERS BE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GLAZER WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE IT'S FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE- THE CHAIR VOTING
I DID ALSO. THE BOSTON OPERATING
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I
THERE'D AIRED I STERN. STERN NOT
VOTING Y. CASKEY HI MY CASKET I
WINNER YEAH MEMBERS MISSING
STILL WHAT'S THE VOTE THE VOTE
SO FAR IS. SEVEN TWO ZERO ALL
RIGHT BACK ON CALL. AT THE NEXT
AND FINAL ITEM FOR GOING TO THE
ROLL CALL IS S. C. R. NINETY TWO
BY SENATOR LEYVA THAT'S AS C. R.
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA. A
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE GUERRIERO.
AYE JONES. JONES AT VOTING
LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN AYE
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI AYE AYE
CASKEY AYE WIENER. THERE'S EIGHT
TO ONE SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
MISSING BACK ON CALL. ALL RIGHT
. BACK TO OUR BUSINESS CENTER
RUBIO WHO'S BEEN STANDING AT THE
LECTERN. SO RUBIO- S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
SO HARD WITH ME TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE GOT THIS BILL RIGHT NOW
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT SB TWELVE FIVE
IT'S A BILL THAT BACKS VICTIMS
AND CHILDREN. MEMBERS OUR
CHILDREN NEED US THERE HAVE BEEN
SO MANY CASES WHERE THEY WORK
CLEAR SIGNS OF ESCALATING
VIOLENT BEHAVIOR IS SO MANY
CHILDREN COULD HAVE BEEN SAVED
AND SO MANY VICTIMS COULD HAVE
BEEN SAVED BUT NOTHING IS BEING
DONE FOR VICTIMS WHO HAVE A
PROTECTIVE ORDER. HAVE REPORTED
SIGNS OF ETHICALLY. OR IT HEY
THERE ABUSERS TO THE COURTS I'VE
TALKED TO SEVERAL VICTIMS TO
SEEK. TO THE JUDGE AND REPORTED
THE ABUSER IS EITHER GOING TO
KILL ME OR KILL MY CHILDREN AND
THEY DID NOTHING. ANASTASIUS A
MOTHER MY DISTRICT WHO LOST HER
FIVE YEAR OLD LITTLE BOY TO. HIS
FATHER. KEPT GOING BACK AND
FORTH PLEADING WITH THE COURT TO
DO SOMETHING THAT THE FATHER WAS
DANGEROUS AND WAS HURTING THE
LITTLE BOY. AND THEY WOULD NOT
LISTEN. THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE. WE
JUST HAVE A CASE HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE THREE LITTLE
GIRLS SAMARIA H. TEN SAMANTHA AT
ELEVEN THE MEDIA MARAGA TERRACE
H. THIRTEEN WERE FATALLY SHOT BY
THEIR FATHER. THAT I A PRIME
EXAMPLE EVEN WITH THE
RESTRAINING ORDER HE HAD- GONE.
THE PROTECTED PERSONS HOME EVEN
WITH THE RESTRAINING ORDER HE
HAD BEEN HELD ON INVOLUNTARY
PSYCHIATRIC EVALUATION. AND ON
TOP OF THAT HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
FOR ASSAULTING A POLICE OFFICER
AND HEALTH CARE WORKER ONLY SIX
DAYS BEFORE THE MURDERS. THE
SIGNS WERE THERE THERE WERE
CLEAR SIGNS OF ESCALATING
BEHAVIOR BUT IT DIDN'T MATTER
THERE WAS NOTHING THAT. COULD
HAVE DONE. SNOWLINE IS THAT
REQUIRES TE COURT TO PROTECT
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES I
THAT SITUATION. THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE
AND GIVE THE PARENTS. JUST
BECAUSE THE JUDGE HAS GIVEN
VISITATION RIGHTS TO AN ABUSIVE
PARENT WITH THE RESTRAINING
ORDER DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE
DANGER IS OVER IN FACT THE
DANGER CONTINUES TO BE PRESIDENT
AND ANYTHING CAN SET OFF AN
ABUSER. SO NOW IT IS OUR JOB TO
SEE THAT THERE'S SOMETHING WE
CAN DO. ESCALATING BEHAVIOR IF
THERE IS A SIGN THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE IN DANGER WE NEED
MUST ACT THIS BILL WILL GIVE THE
PAIR WITH THE PROTECTIVE ORDER
THE ABILITY TO PAUSE. GO BACK TO
COURT AND REASSESS THE DANGERS
TO HIM OR HERSELF AND THEIR
CHILDREN IT IS A MODEST WAY TO
GIVE HOPE TO SO MANY OF THESE
CHILDREN THAT ARE DYING AT THE
HANDS OF AN ABUSIVE PARENT WHO
IS OUT. OF DEBT FORGIVEN FOR
REVENGE I'LL TO COSTING WHICH
DISTRESS AND HARM THE VICTIM AND
THEIR CHILDREN WERE SIMPLY
ASKING FOR ANY MEDIUM PROTECTION
UNTIL HEARINGS CONDUCTED. FIFTY
DAYS. NOW IF I MAY I WOULD LIKE
TO INTRODUCE MIGHT WITNESSES
THEN HAVE ACCORDING TO PROFESSOR
AND DOCTORATE OF SOCIOLOGY AND
CRIMINOLOGY. A RESEARCHER ON
HOMICIDE AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
ARE WITH ME ALSO WE HAVE CAM
ROBINSON FAMILY LAW SPECIALIST
IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO-
DOCTOR LYNN HOFF CORTESE IN IF
YOU'RE AVAILABLE. I AM HERE YOU
HEAR ME OK YES YOU PLEASURES.
OKAY GOOD GO AHEAD. OKAY AS THE
DRUG WILL BE OKAY AND DOES NOT
RESIGN AND A FULL PROFESSOR AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CENTRAL
FLORIDA I STUDIED VIOLENCE FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS AND I'VE
FOUGHT FIRST FORCES UNDER THAT
METHOD BY OLYMPIC KANSAS STATE
UNIVERSITY AND DESIGNED THE
COURSES THAT COMPRISE GRADUATE
LEVEL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE TRACK AT
THE. INSTANCE THE ALLERGY IT
USED YEAH. HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW
PLAN OFFENDERS AND VIOLENT
COMMIT. FOR SOME REASON SOME
PEOPLE VIEW VIOLENCE AS A WAY TO
DEAL WITH THEIR PROBLEMS NOT
REALISTIC. THEY DO THE WORLD
BRIEFLY STATED. HEY YOU'RE HIS
THE PREDICTOR OF FUTURE BEHAVIOR
. WE KNOW THAT- IT IS ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS FOR CHILDREN I HAVE
VISIT TO PROVIDE YOUR NOT. AND
THE VIOLENT PERSONS VIOLENCE IS
IT ESCALATING. THANK YOU
THOUSAND EIGHT OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
KILLED DURING THEIR PARENTS
DIVORCE PROCEEDINGS AND OVER A
HUNDRED OF THESE COULD HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED. OVER 70% OF TILE
HOMICIDE BY. A RELATED TO
SEPARATION OR DIVORCE ARE
COMMITTED BY THE FATHER. MOST
CHILD HOMICIDES ARE NOT A
SURPRISE THE CHILDREN AT EITHER
BEEN DIRECTLY THREATENED OR THE
PROTECTIVE CARE ACT CAREGIVER OR
PARENT KNOWS THAT THEIR LIVES
HAVE BEEN THREATENED. IT'S A
MISCONCEPTION TO THINK THAT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ONLY AMONG
THE WELL AS- THE ADULT IN THE
FAMILY. A HISTORY OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THIS EXTREMELY RELEVANT
THE DECISIONS RELATED TO TRIAL
IS THE FACE AND I THOUGHT THEY-
MOST CHILDREN WHO WERE KILLED BY
A PARENT ARMORED MURDER DURING
UNSUPERVISED VISITS FROM THE
VIOLENT ABUSIVE PARENTS HOWEVER
AS WE'VE RECENTLY WITNESSED
HAVING SOMEONE OVERSEE THE
VISITATION DOES NOT ALWAYS MEAN
THAT THE CHILDREN ARE. EIGHT
CHILDREN WILL TELL PROFESSIONAL
INTERVIEWERS THAT OUT FOR
VIOLENT IN THEIR HOME. AND BASED
ON THAT KNOWLEDGE WITHIN THE GAS
SHARING CLIPS FROM VIDEOS THAT
CHILDREN WOULD SHARE WITH THE
FORT. WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
WITH SENATE BILL BOTH SIXTY FIVE
INTERVENE ON THEIR BEHALF. ON
THE BEHALF OF CHILD SAFETY. THAT
IS BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
JUSTICE AND PROFESSIONAL
SPECIALIZED IN THE STUDY OF
QUALITY IS CONSISTENTLY SUPPORT
NEED FOR LAWS TO PROTECT
CHILDREN WITH THEM IN SUPPORT
ONE. HUNDRED STATE. IS AT LOGIC
IS CORRECT. WE'LL PUT IN THE
WORK OF CONSISTENTLY EXPECT
CHILDREN FROM BEING COURT
ORDERED INTO KNOWN HIGH RISK
THAT YOU WAIT. OF ESCALATING
VIOLENCE. THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT RT YOU ARE KIM ROBINSON OF
YOUR OF IT. YES AT THANK YOU-
CARE ON BERGEN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
UNDER EXISTING LAW- RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA THAT IS BASICALLY
HAVE THREE OPTIONS WHEN THEY ARE
PRESENTED. WITH AN EMERGENCY
PUBLIC NEED TO CHANGE THE CAPS
IN VISITATION SCHEDULE IN CASES
WHERE THERE IS A RESTRAINT
PERSON NEEDS THIS BEING A
PROTECTIVE ORDER. OPTION ONE IS
THAT THEY COULD SUSPEND. THE
PERPETRATORS IS THIS- OPTION
NUMBER TWO IS THAT THEY COULD.
BORDER PROFESSIONALLY SUPERVISED
VISITS THAT YOU BOTH OF THESE
OPTIONS WOULD BE PENDING A
NOTICED HEARING- WITHIN FIFTEEN
DAYS. OR ACTUALLY AT TWENTY ONE
DAYS IS EXISTING LAW. WHAT THE
THIRD OPTION ONE THAT'S EXERCISE
OR TOO MUCH IS TO DO NOTHING AND
LEAVE THE- IN PERSON CONTACT
ORDERS IN PLAY. AND THAT IS THE
FIRST PART OF EXISTING LAW IS
TOO MANY JUDGES ARE JUST LETTING
THE VISITS HAPPEN EVEN WITH
PRESENTED WITH AN EMERGENCY
MOTION WHETHER HIS AND- VERY
DISTURBING ON TOP CONNDOT- ALL
BEING. SOLD AS WORST CASE IN
SACRAMENTO- FOR SOMEONE TO STAND
WEAPONS AND MADE THREATS SB
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE WOULD CLOSE
THE PTION THREE FOUR AND WOOD-
HOPEFULLY REQUIRE THAT WHAT WHEN
PRESENTED WITH AN EMERGENCY
APPLICATION ABOUT NEW THREATS
NEW CONDUCT. WOULD EITHER
SUSPENDED VISITS OR THAT- VISITS
DEEPER ESPECIALLY SUPERVISED
UNTIL THEY DO HOLD HEARINGS. AND
FOR A MORE PERMANENT- WHATEVER.
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN A ROOM TWENTY.
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED- IF YOU
APPROACH MICROPHONE SING KNOWN
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE A LET'S
GO TO PHONE LINES MATTER IF YOU
WOULD Q. THOSE UP WHO SUPPORT SB
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE SO THEY GIVE
US THEIR NAME. THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION. THANK YOU
AND- IT ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
YOU. I DIDN'T THINK ABOUT THIS
THE FRESH ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WHEN FIFTY SIX YEAR LINES OPEN
. THANK YOU- FOR KAREN MEMBER WE
WORK ACT THEN WITH THE CENTER
FOR GOOD ACTUAL EXCELLENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB DE TWELVE
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU. NEXT IN
LINE FOR THIRTY THREE. YEAH ALL
RETIRED ARMY VETERAN IN FAMILY
COURT WITH PROTECTIVE ORDER
LOWER I SUPPORT SB TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALL
RIGHT DANTE ROSS LOS ANGELES
COUNTY I WRONGLY FOR THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR. LINE TO NINETY
NINE. THIS IS CONNIE VALENTINE
VOEPEL CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE
PARENTS THE FUSION WE URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON SB. TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE EIGHT CHILDREN FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANKS FOR THIRTY
FIVE. THIS IS THE ANDREA RAND
TELL THEM INTO SURVIVORS YOUR
GIRL CALL CALIFORNIA RESPOND THE
BILL THANK YOU. NINE FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN. I'M PART OF THE GULF
ITSELF THANK YOU. IN LINE THREE
FIFTY NINE. NOTHING CAMPBELL
WITH CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE
PARENTS ASSOCIATION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
THANK YOU. AND THEN FURTHER IN
Q. ALREADY THANK YOU LET'S NOW
TURN THE OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
ONE LISTED INFORMAL APPOSITION
IS ANYONE OPPOSITION TO S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THEY PRODUCE A
MICROPHONE SEEING KNOWN APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE MR THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION
TO. SB TWELVE SIXTY FIVE. AND IF
SO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TWO A
POLLS ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO.
WE GOT A LINE UP FOR THIRTY ONE
IS GO AHEAD- REPORTER
MOLYBDENITE FIND LEGISLATIVE
CODES AND TO PREVENT CHILD ABUSE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
FIVE THANK YOU. AND THEN FURTHER
IN Q. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE OF
QUESTIONS BY THE COMMITTEE.
SERVER ALSO- JUST- ONE.
REGARDLESS OF MY QUESTIONS JUST
THANK THE AUTHOR BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT YOUR INTENTION HERE IS TO-
PROTECT THE CHILDREN AND THE
FAMILIES THOSE WHO COULD B IN
DANGER- WE ALSO KNOW THAT- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR CHILDREN
GOING THROUGH THAT KIND OF
TRAUMA TO ALSO STAY IN TOUCH
WITH THEIR PARENTS FOR A
DIFFICULT ENOUGH OF WHAT THEY'RE
GOING. SO ONE QUESTION I HAD IS
ABOUT THE FIFTEEN DAY HEARING OR
NOT I MAY HAVE. NOT- READ ANY
KIND OF AMENDMENT RIGHT BUT- THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS I UNDERSTAND
IT- AGREES THAT- A FIFTEEN THE
CURRENT CASELOAD IN THE COURTS-
DOES NOT IS UNREALISTIC TO ALLOW
A HEARING WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS-
SO I'M WONDERING IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT. THANK YOU I KNOW
HOW IT'S A CONCERN THAT UP I
FEELS LIKE THE COURT IS
OVERWHELMED BUT- YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW WE ARE WORKING ON A SEPARATE
BILL TO OBJECT TO PROVIDE
FUNDING TO FOR NOT ONLY JUDGES
BUT COURTS TO EXPEDITE THESE
KIND OF BILLS AND DIE. AND
CONTINUE TO PRESS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE AND I KNOW
THAT. YOU KNOW IT. THE CHILDREN
END UP PAYING THE PRICE FOR
THAT. FOR THE DEFICIENCIES IN
OUR COURT SYSTEM SO YOU KNOW I
JUST ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER THE
FACT THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CHILDREN'S LIVES BUT I
WILL. DEFINITELY CONTINUE TO
PRESS ON THE ISSUE I DO WANT
THESE COURT CASES TO BE HEARD WE
NEED HIM TO BE EXPEDITED AND- IN
ALL THE LIVES OF OUR CHILDREN
ARE AT STAKE BY PRESSING FOR
FUNDING ON THAT. REGARD YEAH THE
NIGHT I MENTION THAT BECAUSE- IN
MY BUDGET SUB FIVE THAT WE GO
THROUGH THE- BUDGET FOR THE
COURT SYSTEM. THERE IS. A
PRESSURE I JUST WANT. THAT IF WE
GO DOWN THE LINE OF- EXPECTING
THAT WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS IS
GOING TO BE A HEARING. OF THAT
WE REALLY. THAT'S AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF MAKING THIS. CHANGE-
VALID AND JUSTIFIABLE NO
ABSOLUTELY I MEAN WE WANTED TO
BE A EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT SO
BOB YOU KNOW I WILL CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE THAT YOUR QUESTION RIGHT
NOW BUT YOU'RE RIGHT- YOU KNOW
THERE IS- DEFICIENCIES CURRENTLY
IN THE SYSTEM AND SO I WILL
CONTINUE TO OP POSSIBLY SIT DOWN
WITH YOU AND SEE TO MAKE SURE
HOW DO WE MAKE THIS- I READ
BLOODY BITE. AGAIN I KNOW THAT
WE CANNOT JUST LEAVE OUR
CHILDREN OUT TO DRIVE WHEN THE
DANGEROUS SO PRESENT AND- AND I
WILL LIKE I SAID CONTINUE TO
PUSH AND SIT DOWN WITH WHOEVER I
NEED TO SIT DOWN TO IT TO. MAKE
THIS YOU KNOW HAPPEN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE COURT HEARINGS
ARE HEARD WITHIN FIFTEEN DAYS.
ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS THAT ARE CABALLERO.
WELL I WANNA- THANK YOU FOR ALL
THREE NISPEL IF I'M NOT A CO
AUTHOR I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED- ONE
OF THE I'M SENSITIVE TO THE
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED BY A
CENTER GARAGE SO AND I AGREE
WITH YOU CENTER RUBIO- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET. THE
ISSUE IN FRONT OF A JUDGE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND IN THE
EVENT THAT THE FIFTEEN DAYS IS
NOT POSSIBLE THEN- TO. ISSUE A
TEMPORARY ORDER THAT THERE BE NO
VISITATION AND TELL THAT COURT
CAN HOLD A HEARING I THINK WOULD
BE TOTALLY APPROPRIATE BECAUSE-
THE CHILDREN THAT ARE GETTING
INJURED AWFUL MURDER R. THIS
CONTROL. TROLL OVER THE FAMILY
AND OVER THAT THE CPOPS AND SO
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT- IF
THERE IS THAT. FEAR BASED ON
IDENTIFIABLE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTECT THAT FAMILY AND THOSE
CHILDREN UNTIL THE COURT CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE A HEARING ON IT
SO- I THINK THAT- I THINK
FIFTEEN DAYS IS REASONABLE AND
IF IT CAN'T HAPPEN BECAUSE OF
THE COURT SCHEDULE THEN I THINK
THEY A TEMPORARY ORDER SHOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AND YOU MIGHT THINK
OF ADDING AT THAT KIND OF A BUT
I'VE EVER RELEASED IT PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COURT TO
MAKE A FINDING THAT THEY JUST
CAN'T DO IT WITH AND THAT.
INTEREST A SET. THAT'S IS REALLY
THE ISSUE THAT YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT SOME- THANK YOU. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL MOVE
ABOUT. ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS SEEING NONE OF CENTER
RUBIO A FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU
FOR BEING A CHAMPION WITH
RESPECT TO THE VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BOTH SPOUSES
OR PARTNERS AS WELL AS THE
CHILDREN NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TW
THANKYOU FOR WORKING SO HARD ON
THIS BILL AND I KNOW THAT YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS BILL- IS
BOTH EFFECTIVE AS WELL AS PASSES
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER. THERE IS
AN ISSUE THERE'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT FOR A
PARENT TO HAVE VISITATION AND-
YOU'VE DIRECTED AND ASKED US TO
HELP. BASICALLY STRUCTURE A BILL
THAT WOULD PASS CONSTITUTIONAL
MUSTER THINK WE WILL ON A NIGHT
I KNOW YOU AGREED TO CERTAIN
AMENDMENTS. AS TWO OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS ALL ALL MENTION THOSE
THE SECOND AND THE FOLLOWING TO
CENTER THERE ALSO INCIDENT
CARILLO. IF THE COURTS CAN'T
ACCOMMODATE A HEARING IF THEY
CAN'T ACCOMMODATE THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT IN ORDER TO
PROTECT CHILDREN. THEN WE NEED
TO PROVIDE THE RESOURCES TO THE
COURT IT CANNOT BE THEY WERE
GONNA LEAVE CHILDREN IN
JEOPARDY. BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THE COURTS SO
THAT'S OUR- OF MUTUAL OBLIGATION
TO DO THAT. LASTLY AND- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS THIS IS A
BIT TECHNICAL BUT THAT- THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
REFERRED TO MODIFYING A
PROTECTIVE ORDER. BUT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD YOU'RE GOING TO AMEND-
THIS TO REFER TO REQUEST FOR AN
ORDER TO MODIFY. YOUR VISITATION
ORDER AS OPPOSED PROTECT ORDER.
THAT'S RIGHT THAT'S CORRECT IN
ORDER TO GET THEM. OKAY AND THEN
ALSO OF THE MEMBERS REQUIRE
PERSON SEEKING THE ORDER THE
STATE THAT THEY FEAR THE
RESTRAINT PERSONAL HARM
CHILDREN. HEADQUARTERED
VISITATION OR CUSTODY. FOR IN
THAT THE RESTRAINT PERSON
THREATEN HARM OR KILL THE
CHILDREN THAT THAT'S CORRECT AS
WELL THAT'S CORRECT OKAY IN AND
THEN LASTLY THE MET. REQUIRE THE
PERSON SEEKING ORDER OUT TO.
YOUR MOBILE BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
OR WHATEVER OR SYSTEM FORTY A BI
. NEXTPART YEAH. DO SO. THEY CAN
EITHER. BACK OUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT- LEAVE IT BEEN A
MOTION BY CABALLERO- MADAM TO
KELSEY CALL THE ROLL. YES THIS
IS SENATE BILL TWELVE SIXTY FIVE
BY SENATOR RUBIO WITH- IF YOU
CLOSE HELLO I'M SORRY WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE HEY YESTERDAY SO I YES
AND I WANT TO JUST GO BACK TO
OUR DISCUSSION A CHAIR AND I HAD
A CONVERSATION ABOUT JUST MAKING
SURE THAT IT WAS. YOU KNOW NOT-
LIKE YOU PUT IT THAT THAT IT'S-
YOU KNOW PARENTS HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SEE
THEIR CHILDREN BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE AND HE
HELPED ME. OUT FRAME IT IN A WAY
THAT THAT IT DID SO I JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES FOR
LISTENING BUT- YOU KNOW IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABUSE AND THAT
CHILD CUSTODY CASES INTERSECT.
IT'S VERY DANGEROUS UNFORTUNATE
CHILDREN ARE ALWAYS THE ONES
THAT ARE PLACED IN THE CENTER
AND USED AS WEAPONS. TERKENAL
EACH OTHER TO BE THE ADULT
PARTIES AND SO I JUST WANT TO
ASK THAT. YOU KNOW YOU SUPPORTED
AND I THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
LISTENING WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR RIFLE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
A MAN SHE KILLS YOU CULTURAL.
YES THIS IS SENATE BILL TWELVE
THE MOTION BY. SENATOR KERRY AT
ALL- AND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI NUMBER AYE BURGESS
BURGESS I CABALLERO EVERY AT ALL
I'D RUSSELL THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG JONES JONES
I LAYERED LAYERED I STERN.
WIECKOWSKI WIENER WIENER I- THAT
SEVEN TWO ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING ALL RIGHT PUT IT BACK ON
CALL. NEXT WE HAVE WHOEVER SHOWS
UP- SENATOR LAYERED IS HERE AND
READY TO GO. THAT'S. THAT'S
PHYLUM NUMBER THIRTY ONE-
SENATOR BOARD SENATOR LAYERED.
AT NINE FIFTY SEVEN I PROJECTED
AT THIS LATE HOUR YOU CONFUSE ME
WITH SENATE REPORTERS. YEAH HE
SAID HE LOOKED AT ME AS ALWAYS
INSULTED THOSE. SO WE'LL SEE IF
I CHANGES RIGHT VOTE RIGHT ARM
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT US SENATE BILL NINE
FIFTY SEVEN IT PLACES TO SANTA
CRUZ METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
DISTRICTS SANTA CRUZ METRO UNDER
THE JURISDICTION OF THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT. RELATIONS BOARD TO
GIUDICATO LODGE COMPLAINTS OF
LABOR VIOLATIONS OF THIS WOULD
GIVE EMPLOYEES. ACCESS TO A TIME
WHERE MORE COST EFFECTIVE
PROCESS TO SETTLE DISPUTES IT
SUPPORTED BY VARIOUS UNIONS SEIU
SMART LOCAL TWENTY THREE. ENJOYS
THE SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION TIPSTERS AND A
HANDFUL OF OTHER LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS I'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE SANTA CRUZ
METRO MANAGEMENT AND THEY WILL
CONSIDER THEIR OFFICIAL POSITION
DURING THE SUMMER THIS BILL
PASSED OUT OF SENATE LABOR AND
PURSE UNANIMOUSLY ON A FIVE VOTE
VOTE AND WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. TESTIFYING TODAY OR
TERRY BRENNAN- FROM SEIU AND
JAMES SANDOVAL THE ORGANIZER AND
GENERAL PERSON- THE CHAIRPERSON
OF SMART TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
AND HE WINS AN AWARD HE HAS BEEN
SITTING HERE ALL DAY LONG
WAITING FOR THIS BILL AND SO-
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ON- SENATORS TERRY BRENNER
BEHALF LAST YEAR YOU CALIFORNIA
ALSO BEEN HERE SINCE TEN O'CLOCK
K. SHOULD NOTICE- HE'S
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT THIS BILL WAS IN THE-
PRESS. ANY SYSTEM OF THANK THE
STAFF FOR DOING A GREAT JOB ON
THAT THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD
IS THIS IS ABOUT ROUND FIVE OF
TRANSIT DISTRICTS WERE INCLUDING
UNDER PERMANENT LIMITED WAY IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE- STRIKES AND
WORK STOPPAGES NECK I THINK IT'S
JUST A WAY TO ADJUDICATE- THE
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICES OR-
CHOOSE BETWEEN MANAGEMENT AND
LABOR THAT. DON'T REALLY RISE TO
A FULL JUDICATA AND IN THE
SPIRIT COURTS SO SAVING MONEY
MORE EFFICIENT. WE APPRECIATE-
THE OFFSHORE KINDNESS THANK YOU. HELLO COMMITTEE MILLER. HELLO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JAMES ANIMAL ON THE GENERAL
CHAIRPERSON OF SMART LOCAL
TWENTY THREE. WHO REPRESENTS ALL
OF THE BUS IMPAIR BUT-
PARATRANSIT DRIVERS AT SANTA
CRUZ METRO ON ALL I'M ALSO A BUS
DRIVER AND SENECA'S METRO ON
BEHALF OF SMART LOCAL TWENTY
THREE I SPEAK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL. SB NINE FIVE
SEVEN THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES OF SANTA
CRUZ METROPOLITAN TRACT. AND THE
DISTRICT. TO ADJUDICATE
COMPLAINTS OF SPECIFIED LABOR
VIOLATIONS BEFORE THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RELATIONS BOARD. HERB
AS AN UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE.
UNLIKE UNLIKE ON OTHER
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
EMPLOYEES AT CMPD AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES HAVE NO RECOURSE TO
PER. INSTEAD THEY MUST RELY UPON
COURTS TO REMEDY ANY FOR ALLEGE
VIOLATION. TO SETTLE AN UNFAIR
LABOR PRACTICE YOU ALL P. CHARGE
. SEM CITY AND THEIR EMPLOYEES
MUST FILE A WRITTEN SUPERIOR
COURT WHICH IS TIME CONSUMING
AND VERY EXPENSIVE FOR ALL
PARTIES. HERBISON ESTABLISHED
AND TRUSTED AGENCY THAT
SPECIALIZES. IN PUBLIC EMPLOYER
EMPLOYEE CONFLICT RESOLUTION.
MOVING JUDICATA JURISDICTION
OVER YOU A PIECE TO PER WELL ASTHE ENTITY AND ITS EMPLOYEES TO
ACCESS A TIMELIER AND MUCH MORE
COST EFFECTIVE PROCESS TO SETTLE
DISPUTES AS WELL AS INCREASED
CONFIDENCE THAT A DISPUTE WILL
BE ADJUDICATED BY A BODY WITH
EXTENSIVE KNOWLEDGE OF LABOR LAW
. THIS BILL NINE FIVE SEVEN WILL
NOT ESTABLISH NEW STATUTORY
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
FRAMEWORKS. FOR THE S. SEEM TO
BE IN ITS EMPLOYEES IT'S SIMPLY
PLACES CERTAIN MATTERS GOVERNING
THESE. RELATIONS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF PER FOR EASIER.
ADJUDICATION PROCESS. THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD LIKE
THE NATIONAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD FOR ALL PRIVATE SECTOR
UNIONS WAS CREATED DECADES AGO.
TO HELP IMPROVE THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES MANY OTHER UNIONS AND
EMPLOYERS HAVE THIS VERY
EFFECTIVE TOOL AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO HAVING IT AT SANTA
CRUZ METRO TO. THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU BEFORE YOU TODAY
AND I WANT TO THANK SENATOR JOHN
LAYERED. AND HIS STAFF FOR
HELPING BRING THIS VERY MUCH
NEEDED LEGISLATION. FORWARD FOR
THESE REASONS AND AMONG OTHERS.
OUR ORGANIZATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
WE'RE RESEARCH RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT OTHERS HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. OF TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE FIVE SEVEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS MONICA AND MY
HUSBAND WORKS AS A BUS DRIVER
FOR SANTA CRUZ METRO ALSO STAY
HOME MOM AND I HAVE TWO CHILDREN
AND I SUPPORT S. B. NINE FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LOW ACOSTA
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SHEET METAL AIR
RAIL AND TRANSPORTATION WORKERS
SMART. TRANSPORTATION DIVISION
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT OTHERS HEARING HEARING
ROOM IN SUPPORT SEEING KNOWN
APPROACHING MICROPHONE. ALL
RIGHT LET'S GO THE PHONE LINES
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND TO WORK PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN THEY'RE ALL.
WE CAN GO TO LINE FOR THIRTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE BOARD MY NAME IS
SURELY MARSHALL I AM A LONG TIME
TRANSIT THAT'S RIGHT AND I
SUPPORT S. B. NINE FIVE SEVEN
THANK YOU. OUR LINE FOR FORTY
EIGHT. YEAH MY NAME IS MICHAEL
RICHARDS- AND I SUPPORT- SB NINE
FIVE SEVEN- I AM A PROPER EITHER
FOR SANTA CRUZ METRO LOCAL.
LOCAL TO CREATE. ALREADY THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. NINETY FOUR
FORTY FOUR. MY NAME IS HOT FIFTY
ON THE OPERATOR WITH SANTA CRUZ
METRO MARC LOCAL TWENTY THREE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU. IN LINE
OR TWELVE. TURN EVERYTHING DOWN. KAYLA HELL WITH ARE YOU LOCAL
TWENTY ONE FLORIDA SB NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. IN LINE FOR
FORTY THREE. MY NAME IS ALLEN
HAMMER NUMBER OF MARK LOCAL
TWENTY THREE TRANSIT OPERATORS
AND IN SUPPORT OF AT THE NINE
FIVE F. YEAH YOU DIDN'T. THANK
YOU. EXPAND BLIND OR FORTY THANK. OR FORTY SIX. THE LINE OR
FORTY ONE. YES THANK YOU THIS IS
BONNIE BAR LABOR REPRESENTATIVE
OTHER. AND I WRONG AND WRONG WAY
IN ORDER TO FEED NINE FIFTY
SEVEN THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU JOHN
LAYERED THANK YOU LOCAL TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU. AND LASTLY WHAT
ONLINE OR FORTY SEVEN. FOUR
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WITH NO RESPONSE FROM FOUR
FORTY SEVEN THERE'S NONE THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- OPPOSITION OF.
THOSE WISHING TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. MISTER LOOKS LIKE
YOU DON'T HAVE OPPOSITION BUT
I'M JOSH SHAW REPRESENTING THE
SENATORS MET FALLING TRANSIT
DISTRICT AND OUR STAFF ASKED ME
TO LET THIS COMMITTEE KNOW AS
SENATOR LAYERED SAID THAT THE
BOARD DOES NOT YET HAVE A
POSITION THEY'VE TALKED ABOUT IT
A COUPLE TO IN PUBLIC. BUT
BECAUSE FOR LACK OF A SEAT BUT
WE LOST OUR CEO SEVERAL MONTHS
AGO A COUPLE WEEKS AGO THE BOARD
ANNOUNCED HIRING A NEW CEO HE
STARTED YESTERDAY THE BOARD
WANTED ITS FINAL FORMAL DECISION
TO REFLECT THE INPUT FROM THAT A
CEO WHO IS GOING TO BE ME CENTER
CHARLIE THE BORDER INTO ACCOUNT
OTHER INPUT TO AND THEY WILL BE
MEETING AT- THEY DID ASK THE
STAFF TO BRING THE BILL TO THEIR
BOARD ON THEIR JUNE. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO MEETING AND THAT'S
WHEN THEY WILL ACT FORMALLY
THANK YOU SO YOU'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION ZERO POSITION ARE
FROM SENATORS MET FUNDRAISER
DOES OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ANYONE ELSE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
. NO ONE UP. HEARING STERN TO
THE PHONE. SO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. WE'RE LINE FOR FORTY TWO.
ONE OR FORTY TWO WHEN HE STOLE
THE CEDA AND DINE WITH SMART
LOCAL OPERATOR LOOK TWENTY THREE
YEAH I IN THE QUARTER SB NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU-
MODERATE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND WE HAVE
ONE AND AFTER GIVE ME JUST A
MOMENT HERE. AND OUT FOR FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
NOEL MORALIS. MY CONCERN THAT IS
IN NINETEEN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
FIVE SEVEN ALREADY THANK YOU
THANK YOU MODERATE ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE FIVE
SEVEN. I KNOW BEING CUTE AND ARE
COMING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SEEING SENATOR CAFIERO THE BILL
SIR CABALLERO MOVES THE BILL ALL
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS NO
QUESTIONS. CENTER LAYERED YOU
MAY CLOSE I JUST THANK EVERYBODY
THAT WAITED ON THE LINE FOR EVER
WAITED IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FOREVER- AND APPRECIATE THEIR
TESTIMONY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ON. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED MEDICI COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
SENATE BILL NINE FIVE SEVEN BY
SENATOR LAYERED WITH MOSHE MY
CENTER GOT IT ALL THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
I'M BURKE AYE. NUMBER I BOARD
YES. FOR JUST NOW CARRIER TO GO
YET- I DID ALSO THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG JONES. JONES
NO LAYERED. LAYERED I STERN.
WHITE HOUSE SKI BY CASKEY I WE-
WINNER I THAT SIXTY TWO SO FAR
WITH MEMBERS MISSING ALL RIGHT
BACK ON CALL SENATOR NEWMAN HAS
BEEN WAITING BOTH PAINFULLY AND
PATIENTLY IF HE'S STILL HERE
HERE IS. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO. HOW MANY PEOPLE GO THROUGH
THIS. FOR SAFETY OF THE S. B.
NINE TWENTY ONE FILE NUMBER
TWENTY TWO SEVEN NEWMAN
PLEASURES IN MY LAST MISTER
CHAIRMAN NO YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
LIST FOCUS LIPSTICK AND- GOOD.
OKAY I WILL. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THOSE WERE
LISTENING. AT BEFORE I BEGIN LET
ME FIRST THANK COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
AND NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
THE MOST RECENT SET OF
COMMITMENTS WHICH ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE. HAVING SAID THAT I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BLL
NINE TWENTY ONE THE DIGITAL
ADVERTISING TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY BACK TOWARD DATA
ACT WHICH WOULD CREATE A
PUBLICLY MANAGE DIGITAL
ADVERTISING REPOSITORY TO BETTER
AND MORE TRANSPARENTLY PROVIDE
ACCESS TO. AND OVERSIGHT OF
DIGITAL POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENTS
AS YOU KNOW DIGITAL ADVERTISING
HAS BECOME A POWERFUL TOOL.
CHECK TO NOT MAKE A IN THE
CONDUCT OF POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS
THE EPHEMERAL NATURE OF DIGITAL
ADS OVER MAKES AND MAKES
LOCATING THEM. AND ADDRESSING
AND CORRECTING FALSE STATEMENTS
A TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE FOR THE
MEDIA RESEARCHERS GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES AND WATCHDOG GROUPS NOT
TO MENTION THE VOTING PUBLIC
IT'S HARD TO OVERSTATE THE
DEGREE TO WHICH POLITICAL
ADVERTISING. EXPLODED IN RAGE
AND RUN NUMBER TERMS COMPARED TO
THE ROUGHLY EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION SPENT NATIONALLY ON
CAMPAIGNS OVERALL IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ELECTION. CYCLE BY TWENTY TWENTY
MORE THAN ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS WAS BEING SPENT ON
DIGITAL ADVERTISING ALONE. IN
THE FACE OF THESE TECTONIC
CHANGES REGULATORS SUCH AS THE
FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION AND OTHER WATCHDOG
ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN FACE
DAUNTING CHALLENGES IN POLICING
DIGITAL CAMPAIGN ADVERTISEMENT
TO BOTH THEIR TRANSITORY NATURE.
WELL AS CAMPAIGNS ABILITY TO
PERSONALIZE MESSAGES AND TARGET
SPECIFIC AUDIENCES. THIS HAS
CREATED REGULATORY GAPS AS NEW
TECHNOLOGIES ARE DEVELOPED AND
DEPLOYED SUCH AS REPLICATING AS
WAS SMALL BUT DELIBERATE CHANGES
FOR MICROTARGETING TO SPECIFIC
AUDIENCE. WERE USED ON SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS WHILE SOME
ONLINE PLATFORMS RETAINING MAKE
A BILLS FOR NATION OF POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENTS ON THEIR
RESPECTIVE PLATFORMS. THE
CURRENT REQUIREMENTS WITH
RESPECT TO POLITICAL ADVERTISING
ON THESE PLATFORMS DO NOT
CAPTURE ALL DIGITAL ADS RUN ON
THOSE PLATFORMS THE DATE IT WILL
CREATE A PUBLIC REPOSITORY. THAT
WILL AFFORD VOTERS THE MEDIA
RESEARCHERS THE F. B. AS ACCESS
TO EVERYDAY OPALA ADAM. BY
CAMPAIGN OR- FOR AT LEAST FOUR
YEARS UNDER THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS ONLINE PLATFORMS THAT
ALREADY COLLECT DATA SUCH AS A
DIGITAL COPY OF THE
ADVERTISEMENT. THE APPROXIMATE
NUMBER OF VIEWS GENERATED FOR
THE ADVERTISING AND THE NAME AND
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER THE
COMMITTEE THAT PAY FOR THE OTHER
DOESN'T. WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT THIS INFORMATION TO THE
F. B. PC ON A STANDARDIZED CYCLE
ON THE FIFTH DAY OF EACH MONTH.
THIS EASILY ACCESS FULLY INDEXED
ADVERTISEMENT ARCHIVAL APPLY
ONLY TO STATE LEVEL BALLOT
MEASURES AND STATE LEVEL
CANDIDATES AS CAMPAIGNS CONTINUE
TO INCORPORATE DIGITAL MODES OF
COMMUNICATION ADVERTISING.
FACILITATING TRANSPARENCY AND
CREATING AND FORCING MECHANISMS
THAT ENSURE THAT VOTERS HAVE
CLEAR VISIBILITY INTO CAMPING
FUNDING BECOMES EVER MORE
IMPERATIVE HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS LIVES IN A
CONDO SENIOR LEGAL COUNSEL. FOR
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THIS EVENING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE YOU TO MISS
THE CONDO IS THAT CORRECT IS NO
FORMAL OPPOSITION THE BILL. TO
MY KNOWLEDGE THERE'S NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION RIGHT ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS NEEDS TO GO TO PUBLIC
SAFETY THEN COME BACK SO- GOOD.
WELL OKAY SO I CALCIUM WAS THE
BILL BUT LET'S LISTEN TO MISS.
MCCONNELL GO AHEAD MISS THE.
KANO RECOGNIZES NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU CONCERT CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS BRITTANY. AND SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
PRACTICAL PRACTICES MISSION.
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED THE SPONSOR
THIS BILL SB NINETY ONE I
RELATING TO THE CREATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF PUBLIC RECORDS
THE DIGITAL CAMPAIGN AD. THIS
BILL ORIGINATED WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
COMMISSION DIGITAL TRANSPARENCY
TASK FORCE WHICH WAS CONVENED TO
STUDY THE EFFECT OF THE
CONTINUOUSLY EVOLVING DIGITAL
LANDSCAPE. ON CAMPAIGN
ADVERTISEMENT TRANSPARENCY AND
DISCLOSURE. BUT IT'LL COMMITTEE
FOR SPENDING INCREASING AMOUNTS
OF MONEY ON DIGITAL CAMPAIGN AD
TO AFFECT VOTER CHOICE. BECAUSE
OF THEIR IMPERMANENT NATURE IT
CAN BE DIFFICULT SOMETIMES
IMPOSSIBLE. FOR VOTERS TO TRACK
DOWN A DIGITAL AD THEY SAW
ONLINE PREVIOUSLY. FIND OUT MORE
ABOUT THE FUNDING OR IF YOU WITH
MESSAGING. OR TO FIND OTHER
DIGITAL ASSETS ASSOCIATED WITH A
PARTICULAR CAMPAIGN OR ELECTION.
UNDERSTANDING WHO AND WHAT
INTERESTED BEHIND DIGITAL
CAMPAIGN AD. HOC VOTERS AFFECT
THE VALUE AND VERACITY OF THE
ASK MESSAGE. COMPARING THEM TO
MAKE INFORMED VOTING DECISIONS.
THE ABILITY TO REVIEW ALL ADD
THAT ALSO ENABLES THE PUBLIC TO
HOLD POLITICAL COMMITTEES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR MESSAGING.
I CREATING A PUBLIC. PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE AND SEARCHABLE RECORD
OF DIGITAL ADS IN THE
CENTRALIZED LOCATION. SB NINETY
ONE WHAT EFFECTIVELY INTERESTED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY. ISSUES THE WITH A MECHANISM DO
YOU ADS AS THE- WITH THE PROJECT
CAMPAIGN OR- ACROSS MULTIPLE
ONLINE AT. THANK YOU SENATOR
NEWMAN CLEARLY ON THIS ISSUE AND
MAKE. TRAINING BUT I THINK ARE
TYPICALLY AT WE ARE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT-
HERE THAT ROOM IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE TWENTY ONE SAYING NO ONE OF
THE HEARING ROOM ABOUT MY REVIEW
TWO OF THOSE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
NINE TWENTY ONE BEARING IN MIND
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION. AND JUST
SUPPORT TO REPRESS WOMAN THERE
ARE FINE. BUT A LINE FOR THIRTY
NINETIES BUT HAD. KILEY FIFTY
SOUTH OUT. COOL OKAY HERE WE GO
BACK HERE TO FOUR THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FONG HI MY
NAME IS MIGUEL MALDONADO. AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE. AT NINE
TWENTY ONE TWO SEVEN. I AM NOT A
BUS DRIVER FOR SENATE MITCHELL
KNOW WHAT TWENTY THREE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. JOHN. ALL RIGHT EARLY
NOBODY IN Q. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE OPPOSITION YES WE ARE GOING
TO OPPOSITION OPPOSITION SEEING
NO ONE OPPOSITION I THOUGHT WE
DID THAT SEEING KNOWN OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
APPROACH IN MY PHONE MODERATOR
IF WE GO TO THE PHONE AS TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
NINE TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU OF
COURSE SB NINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
B. AND Q. S. ALL RIGHT GREAT
BRING IT BACK THE HEARING ROOM
SEEING NO ONE WITH QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SENATOR LAYERED IS
MOVE THE BILL- SIR NEWMAN YOU
HAVE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT YOU GET A CLOSE. WORLD
CHANGES QUICKLY WE SHOULD CHANGE
PARTLY ALONG WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OF A MAN CHIEF
COUNSEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL.
MEASURE MOTION BY ROOM. ITS
MOTION BY SENATOR. CENTER LATER
IN Q. THIS IS SB NINE TWENTY ONE
BY SENATOR NEW MEN BUT THE
MOTION BY SENATOR LEHRER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE AYE. NUMBER AYE BORJAS.
WE'RE JUST I'D GUERRIERO. AREA
I'D WRESTLE. WRESTLE I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG JONES. JONES NO
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN
WIECKOWSKI WHITE HOUSE HE AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE YAY YOU HAVE
SEVEN TWO ONE RIGHT NOW WITH
MEMBERS MISS ALL RIGHT PUT IT
BACK ON CALL THIS IS OUR LAST
BILL OF THIS EVENING THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN SENATOR WIENER
SENATOR WIENER YOU ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS IS
THAT RIGHT. SIR WIENER ACCEPTS
THE COMMITTEES ROPOSED
AMENDMENT SENATOR WIENER S. B.
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. I THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN- SB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
WILL UPDATE AND MODERNIZE-
PENALTIES FOR- HEALTH PLANS OF
VIOLATE STATE LAW IN TERMS OF
DENYING COVERAGE THAT THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE WITHIN A LOT
OF WORK IN RECENT YEARS. TO
ENSURE THAT HEALTH PLANS ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING FULL COVERAGE
WHETHER IT'S AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH OR OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS
AND THESE REQUIREMENTS OF LAW
NEED TO HAVE A MEETING. ON THE
ONLY A MEETING IF THERE IS
ACCOUNTABILITY WHEN THE PLANS
VIOLATE- THOSE- REQUIREMENTS
CURRENTLY- THE MAXIMUM PENALTY.
THAT CAN BE- APPLIED OR OR
IMPOSE ON A PLAN PER VIOLATION
IS TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
THAT WAS ADOPTED DECADES AGO IT
HAS NOT BEEN ADJUSTED AT ALL AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS EFFECTIVELY
A COST OF DOING BUSINESS AND I
CAN BE CHEAPER SIMPLY TO VIOLATE
THE LAW- DAN- TO- TO FIND- I'M
SORRY. SHE PREPARED LEVINE IN
THE FALL OF THE LAW- SERVICE
THIS LEGISLATION WELL IT'S BEEN
A LONG DAY- THIS LEGISLATION.
WILL ADJUST- THE PENALTIES SO
THAT WE HAVE A MINIMUM OF TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IT WILL
CREATE A STRONG INCENTIVE TO
FOLLOW THE LAW AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WITH ME TODAY I TESTIFIED
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE JASMINE
HICKS AND DIANA DOUGLAS FROM
HALIFAX ALL RIGHT- MISTAKES OR
MISSED DOUBLE SO YOU HEAR. YES
HI THANK YOU MY NAME IS JASMINE
HAKES AND I'M THE MOTHER OF TWO
DAUGHTERS IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN MY- THIS WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH MULTIPLE SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES KAISER OFFERED US A
FEW PAMPHLETS INCENTIVES HOME
THAT SAME YEAR THE D. M. H. C.
CITED KAISER FOR SYSTEMIC
VIOLATIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT AND
OTHER LAWS THEY WERE FINED FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS A DROP IN THE
BUCKET COMPARED TO THE REPORTED
PROFITS THAT YEAR OF TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN MY DAUGHTER SUICIDAL
IDEATIONS GREW ALARMING WE BEGAN
PLEADING WITH KAISER FOR THERAPY
AND HELP. WE WERE TOLD THERE
WERE NO THERAPIST AVAILABLE.
SINCE THEN SHE HAS TRIED TO KILL
HERSELF TWICE. TWICE ON LIFE
SUPPORT IN THE ICU. IN THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS SHE'S BEEN
HOSPITALIZED SIX TIMES. AND
EVERY TIME SHE'S BEEN DISCHARGED
BUT NO FOLLOW UP SERVICES OR
AFTER CARE. IN SPITE OF THE
SEVERITY OF HER MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES AND REPEATED APPEALS
FOR SERVICE KIZER HAS INFORMED
US THAT THEY HAVE NO AVAILABLE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ON
STAFF. AND THEY'RE CONTRACTED
THERAPISTS ARE BOOKED SOLID
THEIR TREATMENT PROGRAMS HAVE
STAGNANT WAITLIST AND HER KAISER
PSYCHIATRIST ONLY COMES IN ON
MONDAYS SO IT TAKES MONTHS FOR
US TO GET AN APPOINTMENT. THIS
IS NOT PARITY. BUT WE'VE BEEN
LUCKY MY DAUGHTER IS ALIVE I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG I'LL BE ABLE
TO SAY THAT SHE STILL NEEDS
HELP. AND WE STILL CAN'T GET IT.
MUCH LIKE THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS FOR DID WAS DEVELOPING
THE DEADLY PENDO WITH THE
PENALTIES AS THEY STAND IS
CHEAPER FOR KAISER TO PAY
ANTIQUATED FINDS. THEM TO DO
WHAT THEY ARE LEGALLY REQUIRED
TO DO. ASA'S TELL ME TO GET HELP
IF I NEED IT. AND WE'RE TRYING
WE HAVE BEEN FOR YEARS WITH THIS
BILL YOU'LL BE TELLING KAISER
THAT BUSINESSES USUAL IS NO
LONGER OKAY. INCREASED FINES
WON'T FIX EVERYTHING BUT IT
MIGHT GIVE MY DAUGHTER AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS. THE CARE
NEEDED TO HAVE A HAPPY HEALTHY
FUTURE INSTEAD OF ENDING UP
ASIDE IN ALL TOO COMMON
STATISTIC. I URGE YOU TO APPROVE
THIS LONG OVERDUE REFORM. FOR
STATES IN PERSON SYSTEM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MISTAKES- THANK YOU FOR
SHARING- YOUR STORE YOUR
DAUGHTER'S STORY. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DIANA
DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA THE STATEWIDE
CONSUMER ADVOCACY COALITION WE
ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WILL ENSURE
HEALTH PLANS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
CALIFORNIANS RELY UPON THESE
PROTECTIONS INCLUDE ACCESS TO
BASIC HEALTH CARE SERVICES
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE LANGUAGE
ACCESS INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW AND PROCESSES FOR PLACING
GRIEVANCES. DAMAGE THESE
PROTECTIONS RYAN A STRONG
FRAMEWORK OF BOTH CIVIL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
CORRECTION AND CORRECTION ACTION
EXCUSE ME CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLANS TO HOLD PLANS ACCOUNTABLE
HOWEVER WATER STANDARDS HAVE
BEEN UPDATED MANY TIMES OVER THE
YEARS THE PENALTY TO RARELY IF
EVER BEEN UPDATED. THE BASICS OF
A CIVIL FINE MAXIMUM OF TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE MANY ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES WHICH REPRESENT THE
VAST MAJORITY MAJORITY OF
PENALTIES IMPOSED HAVE REMAINED
FIXED FOR DECADES HEALTH PLANS
HAVE BEEN ACCUSTOMED TO TREATING
FINDS IS JUST ANOTHER COST. WHAT
IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE TO PAY
VIOLATIONS WHEN THEY GET CAUGHT
RATHER THAN TO IMPROVE SERVICE
CONSUMERS PAY THE PRICE WITH
DELAYED CARE DENIED SERVICES AND
GRIEVANCES GONE UNRESOLVED. SB A
FIFTY IT WILL UPDATE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES BY
MULTIPLYING THE KERN AMOUNTS BY
FOR. MOST MHC PENALTIES ARE
ADMINISTRATIVE IN THESE AMOUNTS
TO REMAIN THE SAME FOR DECADES
CIVIL PENALTIES WHICH HAVE BEEN
CAPPED AT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR ALMOST FIFTY YEARS.
WOULD BE INCREASED TO A MINIMUM
OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND. THIS
REPRESENTS INCREASES IN
INFLATION AND ALSO IN HEALTH
CARE PREMIUMS AND COSTS. AND
FINALLY SB EIGHT FIFTY IT WILL
ALSO ENSURE THAT HEALTHCARE
PREMIUMS IN OUT OF POCKET COSTS
INCREASED PENALTIES WILL
INCREASE COMMENSURATELY. WE
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK ON AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT THE FOUR TIMES MULTIPLIER
WILL ONLY APPLY TO PENALTIES
WITH A SPECIFIC AMOUNT. AND
KEEPS THE MINIMUM FOR CIVIL
PENALTIES AT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND AND COMMIT TO TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS RELATED TO HOW.
PENALTY INCREASES WOULD BE TIED
TO INCREASES IN HEALTH PLAN
COSTS IN APPROPRIATIONS AND
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK HERE.
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
SB FIFTY EIGHT RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MISTER DOUGLAS ALL RIGHT. OF
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT TO COME FORWARD
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS JANICE- ALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. OTHERS HERE
IN THE HEARING ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SINGH KNOWN APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE- MATTER IF WE GO
TO THE PHONE. FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT.
IF YOU'D LIKE CHAU Y'ALL GO
AHEAD OF YOU TO PRODUCE A
MICROPHONE. SERVICE WHO- GOOD
EVENING LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
PHENOMENON POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT.
NOW BACK TO THOSE ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU AND IT'S ONE ZERO. I
WANTED TO HEAR ABOUT A LINE OR
FIFTY TWO. RIGHT YOUR LINE IS
PRETTY GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD EVENING THOUGH I THOUGHT OF
ALL THE CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FIFTY TWO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT THANK YOU. I THINK THAT.
AND THEN IN Q. AT THIS TIME NO
WAS IN Q. ARE AT LET'S GO
OPPOSITION I HAVE NICK OF THE WE
CELLS IN IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
NICKEL RESOURCE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS- IN OPPOSITION TO EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT. WHICH RAISES HEALTH
CARE COSTS BY CREATING A
PUNITIVE IN COMPLICATED NEW
PENALTY STRUCTURE ON HEALTH
PLANS MASSIVELY INCREASING
PENALTIES ON HEALTH PLANS DOES
NOT SOLVE PROBLEMS AND DOES NOT
IMPROVE OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
WHAT IT DOES IT DIRECTS
RESOURCES AWAY FROM DIRECT
PATIENT CARE AND UNDERMINES IT
NATURE OF REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT- WE DISAGREE WITH
THE PREMISE OF THIS BILL WHICH
IS BASED ON THE LOGIC THAT
MAKING PENALTIES MORE MORE
PUNITIVE WORSE WILL SOMEHOW
IMPROVE OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
NOW YOU KNOW- REFERENCING THE I.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT TODAY YOU
KNOW LOOK WE'RE ALL MADE OUT OF
THE SAME STUFF WE'VE HAD FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT HAVE INTERACTED
WITH THE SYSTEM AND SOMETIMES IT
WORKS OUT SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
GREAT YOU KNOW SPEAKING DIRECTLY
TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WE
ARGUED LAST YEAR WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF SENATOR WIENER'S SB
TWO TWENTY ONE THAT IT IS A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT ISSUE- AND
THERE ARE LACK OF PROVIDERS IN
THIS AREA PARTICULARLY ONES.
THAT ARE WILLING TO CONTRACT
WITH PLANS SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO WORK ON AND I
THINK SENATOR WIENER HAS ONE
THAT- THIS YEAR BUT- YOU KNOW I
WILL SAY CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
PLANS ARE HEAVILY REGULATED
CURRENTLY UNDER THE KNOX KEEN
ACT- THERE ARE THERE IS A
PENALTY STRUCTURE THAT INCLUDES
BOTH ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
AND CIVIL PENALTIES. ON THE
GRANTS THE DIRECTOR OF GMAC THE
DEPARTMENT MATTERS HEALTH CARE
WHY TO FORTY TO LEVY PENALTIES
ON HEALTH PLANS- AND EVEN REVOKE
LICENSES OF PLANS- THAT ARE IN
VIOLATION OF THE ACT. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE CURRENT LAW ALREADY
GRANTS SUFFICIENT FORSMAN
AUTHORITY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE WHICH HAS
ALLOWED ITSELF PRETTY
CONSIDERABLE LATITUDE I'M IN
ASSESSING PENALTIES AND AS
RECENTLY DEMONSTRATED ITS
SIGNIFICANT BIRDS- IN
ADDITION TO PENALTIES THE TEAM
YOU SEE ALSO ISSUES CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLANS WHICH REQUIRE
HEALTH PLANS TO REMEDY PROBLEMS
ARE FACE EVEN FURTHER SANCTIONS
. WHAT IS SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
DO. SO I THINK SOMETIMES BILLS
CHARACTERIZE MERELY UPDATING ON
THE AMOUNTS THAT WERE
ESTABLISHED IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. AND YOU KNOW IF THAT
WAS THE CONVERSATION I THINK
THAT WOULD BE ONE THING WHAT
THIS BILL DOES THOUGH. IT
DELETES THE LIMITATIONS SO
THERE'S NO LIMITATION ON CIVIL
PENALTIES- IT IN THE LAW IT
ANYMORE IF THIS BILL WOULD SPEAK
WERE TO BE ENACTED. SO IT
DELETES THE CEILING. AND
REPLACES IT WITH A FLOOR THAT IS
TEN TIMES THE AMOUNT OF THE
CEILING- AND YOU KNOW WE BELIEVE
THAT. IT IS PRETTY EXCESSIVE-
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE- SO IF YOU
KNOW REPRESENTS A WHOPPING
INCREASE IN SINGLE CIVIL
PENALTIES BY A FACTOR OF TEN
MISTER LOUISE ALSO YEAH. GO
AHEAD AND WRAP IT UP YEAH GREAT.
WE THINK THE GOAL OF REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT IS TO- YOU MAKE
THINGS BETTER- YOU KNOW. YOU
KNOW WHEN THERE ARE PROBLEMS. WE
THINK A- BILL LIKE THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY PAY OUR MEMBERS AGAINST
THE DEPARTMENT AND CREATE A
MORE. KIND OF NEGATIVE.
ATMOSPHERE AND TRY TO RESOLVE
THINGS ALREADY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. TO S.
B. EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. SINGH
KNOWING HEARING ROOM. MODERATE
IF LET'S GO THE PHONES FOR THOSE
IN OPPOSITION SB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT. THANK YOU AND COMPOSED
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. CURRENTLY
NOBODY IN Q. OKAY BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE OF QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NOT SEEING ANY
QUESTIONS IS THERE A MOTION.
SENATE WHITE HOUSE HE MOVES THE
BILL SIR WIENER DO CARE CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT MAN CHIEF COUNSEL IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
US SENATE BILL EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
BY SENATOR WIENER WITH THAT-MOTION BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
AMBERJACK AMBERJACK I BOARD YES
. BARRIO EVERY YEAR I DID A SONG
. THERE ARE SO I GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG JONES LAYERED LAYERED
I STERN WAKE HOUSEKI WAKE
HOUSEKI I WINNER WINNER I SO FAR
YOU HAVE SIX ZERO WITH MEMBERS
MISSING I WILL PUT ON CALL SO
HERE'S A WE'RE GONNA DO- WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND- WE'RE WILL
RECESS FOR FIVE MINUTES. UNTIL
SIX. WELL LET'S LET'S RECESSED
UNTIL SIX FIFTY FIVE TO GIVE
OTHER MEMBERS A CHANCE TO RETURN
TO THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
AND THAT WE'RE GONNA LIFT THE
CALLS ON ALL THE BILLS THAT ARE
PENDING. OKAY YOU WILL BE. ALL
RIGHT. RIGHT YEAH I CAN DO THE
RECORD FIFTH. RIGHT LET'S OPEN
THE ROLE RIGHT NOW- SO THAT
THOSE WHO ARE HERE CAN CAN GO IN
THE MIDDLE WEIGHT OTHERS WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE THE RETURN OKAY
I'M DOING THIS AND FILE ORDER
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT OKAY CONSENT
CALENDAR. WIENER WIENER AYE
THAT'S ELEVEN TWO ZERO THE
CONSENT COUNTERS ADOPTED. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SENATOR UMBERG
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
CHAIR VOTING I PORTIS WIENER.
WIENER AYE THAT- TEND TO ZERO
THE BILLS OUT. YEAH. I THINK SO
MOMMY I DON'T KNOW BUT IT'S OUT
. NEXT BILL IS S. IS S. B. NINE
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR EGGMAN
CHAIR VOTING I. GONZALEZ WIENER. THIS IS S. B. NINE SIXTY FIVE
FILE ITEM TO WIENER AYE- YOU
HAVE ELEVEN SORRY TEN TWO ZERO
WITH CENTER GONZALEZ MISSING I
WILL PUT IT BACK ON CALL. NEXT
BILL IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN S. B. TWELVE
. WIENER
THEIR WITH CENTER GONZALEZ
MISSING PUT IT BACK ON CALL
CENTER EGGMAN FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN SURE
VOTING I. OR JESS GONZALEZ
WINNER WINNER I. THAT'S NINE TWO
ZERO WITH TWO MEMBERS MISSING
THE BACK ON CALL SENATOR
BRADFORD TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE S. B. FOURTEEN OH ONE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING HI BORJAS.
GONZALEZ WINNER WINNER I- THAT
IS. THAT'S EIGHT TO ONE WITH
MEMBERS MISSING. AT EIGHTY ONE
WITH CENTER GONZALEZ MISSING
FROM CALL UNCLE. NEXT IS M. S.
B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR
CORTEZ SAY. A FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE
TRIGGERING AYE BORJAS GONZALEZ
WIENER WIENER AYE SECOND CALL.
NEXT FILE ITEM TWELVE BY SENATOR
GLAZERS SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
CHAIR VOTING I DID ALSO NOT
VOTING- GONZALEZ STERN WIENER
WIENER I. THAT'S EIGHT ZERO SO
FAR WITH CENTER GONZALEZ MISSING
BACK ON CALL. NEXT FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN CENTER OR BATTLES SB
EIGHT FORTY SEVEN WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I- DO NOT SO IT'S NOT
VOTING ON THIS ONE. OH I'M SORRY
. THE REST SO NO- WAKE HOUSEKI
YOU COULD NOT VOTING. NOT VOTING
WIENER. WIENER I- THAT'S NINE
TWO ZERO ALL MEMBERS HAVING
VOTED FOR DECIDED TO NOT VOTE
ALL RIGHT BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS SB TWELVE FORTY FIVE
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE GONZALEZ. WIENER WIENER AYE-%
EVERYONE'S VOTED EXCEPT FOR
GONZALEZ NEXT S. C. R. NINETY
TWO BY SENATOR LEYVA FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN. JONES WINNER WINNER I
AM. THAT'S NINETY ONE EVERYONE
WHO'S GONNA BE HERS VOTED BILLS
OUT. NEXT FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR LIMON S. B. ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO. GONZALEZ WIENER WIENER AYE
CENTER GONZALEZ STILL MISSING ON
CALL. NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR LIMON SB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX TRAVELING I
GONZALEZ WIENER WIENER I CAN
CALL. NEXT BOTH SENATOR MEN'S-
S. B. EIGHT SIXTY THREE FILE
ITEM NINETEEN. GONZALEZ WINNER
WINNER I MISSING GONZALEZ BACK
ON CALL NEXT ITEM FILE ITEM
TWENTY BY SENATOR MAN SB NINE
SEVENTY FIVE TO READING AYE
FORTUS WIENER. I'M SORRY CAN I
WIENER AYE IN GONZALEZ. IT'S
ALSO NOT HERE RATE CUT BACK ON
CALL OKAY THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
NEWMAN SB NINE TWENTY ONE CHAIR
VOTING I. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG.
STERN AT STERN- BACK ON CALL.
NEXT SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE VOTING AYE BORJAS GONZALEZ
WIENER. SECOND CALL WINNER I.
NEXT ITEM S. B. TEN EIGHTEEN BY
SENATOR PANFILO ITEM TWENTY FOUR
GERMANY I FORGES GONZALEZ WINNER
WINNER I THANK ON CALL FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE S. B. 1265% OF RUBIO
. YOU'RE READING I GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG STERN WHITE HOUSE SKI
WHAT KASKY I STILL WANT CENTER
BACK AWFUL FOR MISSING NEXT IF
ITEM THIRTY ONE BY CENTER
LAYERED SB NINE FIVE SEVEN-
GONZALEZ. HERTZBERG STERN. BACK
ON CALL NEXT ITEM S. B. EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO BORDERS
GONZALEZ HERTZBERG JONES STERN-
BACK ON CALL. THANK YOU VOTE ON
EVERYTHING.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR CENTER
CONSOLES- WHY DON'T WE RECESS
HERE TILL- SEVEN O'CLOCK THE
LISTENER GONZALEZ PEERS LOOKED
EARLIER BUT WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL SEVEN O'CLOCK.
WE NEED TO
QUEUE THEM UP ALL RIGHT THIS
QUEUE THEM UP YES FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO- SB NINE SIXTY FIVE
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI THAT'S
ELEVEN TWO ZERO BILLS OUT. NEXT
BILL FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B.
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN PROVIDING
AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI THAT'S
ELEVEN TO ZERO THOSE OUT NEXT
PROVIDE FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
YOUR VOTING I FORTIS GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I THAT'S TENTH ZERO
CENTER OR DISMISSING. THE NEXT
BILL FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
FOURTEEN OH ONE. VOTING I FOR
JUST GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI YOU
HAVE BILLS OUT. THE BILL OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN. THE VOTE-
HERE'S CENTER BOARD JUST WE'VE
BEEN SKIPPING YOU DID YOU WANT
TO SHOOT. LET'S START OVER AGAIN
I'M SORRY I THOUGHT CENTER
BOARDS WITH YOU ON YOUR- WE
CAN'T. R. OKAY BUT WELL IN. OKAY
WHOA JUST COMMENCE WE WERE OKAY
AND THAT ONE WAS SB FOURTEEN OH
ONE RIGHT. THAT'S NINETY ONE DAY
BILLS OUT THE NEXT BILL FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN SB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE BY SENATOR CORTEZ SAY.
VOTING I. GORGEOUS FILE ITEM TEN
. GORGEOUS NO THAT'S NINE OH
SORRY GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI
THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT SENATOR GLAZERS. FILE ITEM
EIGHT. THE RUSSELL GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I STERN ALL RIGHT STERN
BY BILLS OUT. THAT'S TEN TWO
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN SB
TWELVE FORTY FIVE BY CENTER
KAMLAGER PROVIDING HI GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI THAT'S NINETY TWO
BILLS OUT. EXPEL FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN IS AN EARLY
MORNING SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO TO
REDDING I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ HI
THAT'S NINETY TWO IS OUT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SENATOR
LIMON S. B. ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX
YOUR VOTING I GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HI NINETY TWO BILLS UP NEXT BOAT
S. B. EIGHT SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR MEN CHAIR VOTING I FILE
ITEM NINETEEN GONZALEZ GONZALEZ
HI THAT'S ELEVEN ZERO BILLS OUT
NEXT BOTH FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY SB NINE SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MEANT. AS CHAIR VOTING I
THAT'S NUMBER TWENTY BORDERS.
BORDERS NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ AYE
THAT'S NINETY TWO BILLS OUT.
NEXT BILL FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
SB NINE TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR
NEWMAN WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
STERN STERN AYE THAT'S. THAT'S
MY TWIN WITH CENTER HERTZBERG
MISSING HIS BILLS OUT. SB
THIRTEEN ELEVEN BY SENATOR
NEWMAN AT FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
TO REVERTING HI GORGEOUS. THIRTY
THIRTY ELEVEN THIRTY ONE FILE
ITEM TWENTY THREE NEWMAN FORTIS
. WE'RE JUST NO BORDERS NO
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HI NINETY TWO
BILLS OUT FILE I'M TWENTY FOUR
SB TEN EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR PAN
CHAIR VOTING I BORDERS. GORGEOUS
NO GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I THAT'S
NINETY TWO BILLS OUT S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR
RUBIO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG STERN
STERN AYE THAT'S TEN TWO ZERO
THOSE OUT. SB NINE FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LAYERED FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE SURE VOTING I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
THAT'S. EIGHT SIX TWO TWO
HERTZBERG NOT VOTING BILLS OUT.
SENATOR WIENER'S SB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT CHAIR VOTING I NUMBER
THIRTY TWO GORGEOUS. PORTIS NOW
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
JONES. STERN HI STERN I. THAT'S
EIGHT TO ONE I BILLS OUT
COMMINGLED IS VERY- I'M SORRY
ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE IS
THAT THE BILL OUT. FOR SELF
CARE. RIGHT CONSENT CALENDAR.
YEAH OKAY ALL OF THEM- SB NUMBER
ONE CAN WE CAN'T CALL IT BACK.
BECAUSE IT'S OUT WELL HEAD TO
HEAD CENTER BOARD JUST BEEN HERE
WE WOULD HOW WOULD YOU VOTED
CENTER BOARD JUST. OKAY THERE IS
WELL WE WILL NOTE THAT THANK YOU
CENTER GORGEOUS ALL RIGHT YEAH%
SO MUCH FROM VICE CHAIR COURTESY
YOU'VE COME ON MAN MY BAD SO ALL
RIGHT WE ARE ADJOURNED UNTIL MAY
THREE- AT. THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
THIRTY THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. WE DONT.
WE'RE SORRY YOUR CONFERENCE IS
ENDING NOW PLEASE HANG UP.